in this react course you'll not only
learn the nuances of react and its
internal workings but also immerse
yourself in building a variety of
projects to understand the Practical
applications of react features this
course uniquely balances a project
focused approach with Comprehensive
theoretical knowledge ensuring a
thorough understanding of each concept
pest childre created this course he's a
popular instructor with 850,000
subscribers on his YouTube channel by
the the end of the course you'll not
only have a bunch of projects for your
portfolio but you'll also gain hands-on
experience in creating a fullstack
application using aite integrating
Advanced tools like redex toolkit and
Tailwind to craft production grade
applications hey there everyone Hees
here back again with another video and
welcome to this brand new series so I
was trying to record a series on react
on the other channel that's when I
realized hey why can't I record this on
this main Channel as well the English
Channel so welcome to this brand new
series on react this is a very focused
series on focusing on absolute beginners
who want to just get started with the
react and there are lots of tutorials on
react but all of them are a little bit
some things which carry the baggage of
you should know this you should know
that not this one this one is purely
entirely beginner friendly if somebody
wants to get started to learn react in
2023 what are the options available how
to read the documentation what is the
process of getting started with the
react along with projects and what
should be the approach this is going to
be whole about it you're going to
absolutely love this series and let's
get started so we're going to get
started this video with a road map how
one should be learning react when should
be learning the common questions that
should be answered what should be the
prerequisites of learning that so we'll
be answering all of that in this very
first video I have prepared a few notes
for you and we're going to get started
with that so first let me go ahead and
share my screen with you so this is my
iPad where we'll be walking through with
the react road map and this is where
we're going to get started first and
foremost let's not jump directly into
how should I learn react let's first
answer a couple of questions first why
to learn react most important question
if you really ask yourself that why am I
learning react or why I need react on
the first place then you'll be a better
engineer in designing react application
just because you want to learn because
there's a hypee around it uh there's a
lot of jobs available for it or it's in
the trend probably not right because
most of the cases of the react can be
handled via just the JavaScript or just
the JavaScript Dom manipulation please
don't learn react if you're are just in
the hype or you just think that hey
there is plenty of jobs and I can be a
react developer yes that case is
somewhat true but I think that's not a
great reason to learn it is trendy yes a
lot of people are talking all the time
about react and if you think I want to
just build UI with the react then of
course you are not correct my friend
because building UI is not something
which is a Core superp Power of react
those uis were getting built in the PHP
as well in the era of gquery as well so
there's nothing which is super important
that is being offered by the reactor
cell you should be learning really react
because it makes easy to manage and
build complex front ends there are
applications in which you just click one
button and things gets update on five
different places 10 different places or
20 different places these places are
really difficult to manipulate while
your ordinary Dom which you manipulate
by the JavaScript so if your application
is pretty complex like an e-commerce app
or something like Facebook or something
uh at that places it really makes sense
to have a react application the better
you become in understanding the react
need the better react engineer you will
become then the second thing when should
I learn it because now that you know
that okay I can build complex app but
when you should really learn react I
always say don't jump into the
Frameworks of JavaScript just because
you enjoy them or you watch a lot of
YouTube videos no that's not a good idea
learn react only after mastering the
JavaScript JavaScript is something which
is core to the react and there are a lot
of problems and debugging issues which
are actually JavaScript issues and not
the react issues if you understand
JavaScript if you understand how the
single thread works if you understand
how the execution environment comes into
the picture how the global execution
context the function execution context
work how JavaScript is able to
manipulate the Dom then is the right
time to jump into react otherwise no you
are making it in a hurry not a good idea
you should stick to the uh JavaScript
still okay assuming that you know your
JavaScript then also please understand
that most of the projects don't need
react it seems like this is a video
where I'm actually pushing you away from
the react but that's not the case I'm
just putting up an honest picture that
do you really need react once you truly
are satisfied that I really need react
then you'll be becoming a good good
engineer of the react so most project
honestly don't need react in the initial
phase as the app gets complex as the
pages are increased as there is more and
more functionality which is on the front
endend part then injecting the react or
having an application totally on the
react makes sense if your application is
just one page which is having a contact
form and is just displaying some
pictures just one or two page I think
you'll do far better in just HTML CSS
and core JavaScript so assume that hey
there's a case now that you are
convinced that okay no matter what I
really want to learn a react so in that
case uh why react was created on its own
in the first place there's a great story
behind it I would love to share that so
this green box yes I tried to mimic
Facebook with this one so in this
Facebook if you remember the old time
there used to be a problem of the ghost
message problem uh in some of the
Internal Documentation of Facebook and
some some of the conferences you'll find
this as a phantom problem I called it as
ghost for no reason but there was a
problem so here was the chat icon here
was the chat that was written like this
and there are a couple of ways if you
click on the notification itself uh then
it opens up a pop-up box here at the
bottom if you click on the chat it opens
up the entire box here but if you have
opened this from the notification
sometimes what happened is not all the
times sometimes this icon here which
says one or maybe that says three
because there are three messages is this
doesn't get go away I have read the
message here so this should go away
there should not be any notification
symbol here if I directly read it in the
chat sometimes it just appears here and
it doesn't go away that was the problem
there was no consistency in the UI and
this was a common problem which was
getting a feedback feedback again and
again in the Facebook that hey why this
message is being shown here I have read
the message I'm aware of it it's still
not gone so this is the common problem
that Facebook was facing and in order to
solve that problem a team was engaged
especially Dan uh that I really want to
solve this problem and that is how the
react was born at the first time the
react was not taken well by the
community but eventually eventually
people adopted a react and even started
to loving it instead of hating it now
the problem that we are facing here is
actually a two coupled problem the first
is the state by the term State I mean
all the variables in JavaScript uh all
these variables like should I show the
notification or not or should the number
should say one or the number should say
five all these things are actually
maintained in the JavaScript world and
all the updation of the UI is actually
handled by Dom so UI is updated via the
Dom while all of your variables are
actually in the state in the JavaScript
so the problem that it was there was
actually the problem of syncing there
was no sync between JavaScript and the
Dom so react came into the picture which
actually gave a consistent way of
updating your Dom elements and that is
the only superpower of react it gives
you consistency in the UI and that is
why people loved react when the react
came in the first early adopter outside
of the Facebook was Khan Academy a very
well-known name if you are in the
education domain it's a very well-known
name so they adopted it and uh couple of
talks uh were there and in that KH
Academy Tech Team said that hey uh react
is not an amazing Library which it was
not at that time but hey it gives so
much amazing consistency in building the
application that we kind of love it and
that's when after this unsplash or
picked it up a couple of other big
corporate Giants picked up the library
and say it's it's fun to actually work
in the react and of course react was not
perfect at that time uh there was a lot
of class-based component eventually it
got updated a lot of things happened
which we are going to see but this is
how it learned again one more time I
would say Do not learn react if you
don't know how the JavaScript works all
those Basics and again again also don't
learn it if you don't know how the Dom
works or the document object model by
the way I do have a video on my YouTube
channel about how the browser inner
working works I do have a playlist of
inner working which will help you to
understand how the browser actually
works how the do Dom is being painted
HTML CSS JavaScript and whatnot at least
watch that video it will be very
fruitful for you so moving that assuming
now that now that you know about how to
learn react and you're confident about
it there are a couple of ways how you
can learn the react there are two
processes of learning that is in fact
this pedagogy applies for almost
everything that I teach there are two
ways you can go directly in depth or you
can just start building the projects you
might be thinking I need both I want to
go in depth I want to see the project as
well yes you do both but actually you
need to start somewhere and you can
start either by directly going in depth
or by directly making the projects so
when you go directly in depth you come
to the words like Babel or you come to
the words like react fiber virtual Dom a
diffing algorithm hydration uh tree
shaking all these Concepts and you first
understand the concept and then you try
to make projects uh like to-do and
calculators and background Changers and
whatnot and you apply these concept
another approach is let's just directly
build the projects let's just say we
build a background changer or a
calculator and while this we learn each
topic for example in to-do we'll learn
about the virtual Dom maybe or
calculator maybe theing algorithm so
each project teaches you one or the
other concept and then the same thing
happens the project the approach that
I'm taking in this entire series is
actually by making directly the project
first I'll make the project and then
I'll take you into the behind the scene
hey what just happened how we did that
how we didn't do that how it worked how
it didn't work and all of that I think
that's a much more fun project uh based
approach a much more fun approach
because it actually keeps you engaged
and then that hey we're building
something and something is working on
the screen and now let's see that how it
actually worked so I'll be using this
this approach uh but again there is no
right and wrong here if you're learning
somebody who's teaching you directly in
depth that's also good no problem in
there one thing that you're going to
commonly see is react as a library so I
do have a common words for them uh
you'll also hear that some things are
Frameworks some things are Library I
call framework as something which is
military and Library as something like
uh who is somebody a cool dude what do I
mean by that by the term framework and
by the term military it means the rules
are very strict in the framework rules
are very stract the naming convention
the way how the file name should be the
way the file should be placed in a
particular folder the way how the data
is going to coming in and going out all
of this are very very strict in the
framework in the
library it's like cool dude you wear the
cap front side it's good you wear the
cap uh behind the side it's all good so
the cool but again it's not like they
don't have any rules Library also do
have certain rules but they're not that
strict of a framework so yes react is a
library and that makes it really easy
because it's not really that much
difficult it's not a big Library you can
finish it up pretty quickly and easily
once you understand the basic core
concept the topics that you're going to
learn in the react first are core of
react you really want to understand how
the react Works how the file structure
works the core concept behind it how the
state or the UI manipulation Works in
this what is GSX in the first place what
does it mean by that uh what does it do
beneficial for us and all of these
concept once you done this then you jump
into the component reusability concept
and again it's not a proprietary concept
of the react itself react component
reusability was there in the early days
of PHP as well it still is in other
places as well but react makes it easy
and once you understand the component
reusability concept you automatically
are introduced to the props which is a
short for properties yeah the same
JavaScript object uh the same key value
yep those exactly same so we understand
about those props also we learn how the
changes are propagated so in the react
what we want to do is we don't want to
use the classic JavaScript like get
element by ID query selector and whatnot
we just want to manipulate the variable
automatically react will think on its
own and will update my UI on the web
page for this you learn about the hooks
that how these hooks are responsible for
updating my UI or my dom on the web page
I'll just update the variables I don't
care about how the UI is being updated
that's where you are actually introduced
to the hooks that's the basics of it at
least uh this is it this is it this is
your react but hey T uh we haven't
talked about the URLs we haven't talked
about the routers we haven't talked
about the State Management the truth is
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be
although we are covering that in the
series but you shouldn't be because till
this part this is only your react
nothing else if you really want to have
a additional feature then comes other
libraries for example react has no
built-in router but if you really want
to use router you have to use something
known as uh react router Dom so yes we
install another package since you're
learning about another package that
cannot be called as core react knowledge
you are going a little outside of your
realm and thus I call it as additional
addon to reacts very close to the react
but they are add-ons they are not react
similarly we do have a state management
thing uh react didn't used to have any
State Management in the earlier days yes
it was introduced later on but in the
early days we just had the Redux Redux
again separate package separate Library
Redux can be used with the react Redux
can be used with view can be used with
SW so it's a standalone library but yes
we still focus and learn a lot about
Redux and these days we learn about the
another abstraction of the Redux which
is known as Redux toolkit which is cool
uh so yes we'll be going through with
with that another such similar State
Management library is zustand quite
popular I do have a series on my channel
on the zustand as well uh so quite
amazing uh so you can learn that but
eventually react realize of course they
realized it before the S stand actually
uh that hey we need to do something
about this State Management it's getting
out of the hand so they introduced
something known as context API which is
again kind of a hooks when we'll learn
about the hooks you'll automatically get
and understand that part so you'll get
to know that so only context API is
something that is not additional but it
was introduced later again some people
also tends to learn about the class
based approach when the react was
introduced in the very early days
everything was class-based uh they got
inspired a lot by the Swift not Swift I
would say purely by iOS development so
they used a lot of things like component
did Mount component unmount component
about to mount component will Mount I
don't think so there was about Mount but
component will Mount you get the idea so
a lot of things were there and this is
known as Legacy code so if some
companies still using it hey why are you
using class based component these days
it's been so gone so long gone but I'll
still give you some brief idea about
that not really that important but yeah
if you wish you can spend some time in
learning about that these days
everything is functional in react the
documentation says that hey just drop
the class-based approach use the
functional approach that's how we are
going and it's not like they started
just a couple of years ago it's it's
long gone it's long on and on top of
that one more additional part of it is
bass apps bass apps like back end as a
service one prominent name which I'm a
big fan these days is actually aight
there are a couple of others as well but
being aight being open source amazing it
provides you entire backend so you can
build your social media apps e-commerce
apps tw Twitter clone threads clone
whatever you wish in just react but
technically it's not pure just react
react is just handling the API calls and
sending data receiving data the majority
of the heavy lifting is done by these
bass back end as a service you might
have heard other names as well so let me
know if you know some of these names uh
so again once you're done with the react
then what about after react see if you
think that hey react is not for me I'm
not enjoying the front end part or the
front end engineering you could have
directly jumped from the JavaScript to
the backend part but since you're
already here I assume that you might be
interested in learning the react as well
so what should I learn after mastering
the react I have handled a good amount
of apis and now I want to build some
complex apps and whatnot so in that case
uh you can also go ahead and try one of
my open source project which is known as
uh free api. apppp it's a fantastic
Library if you want to push yourself to
handle some of the complex react changes
or complex react full-blown application
what we did is we wrote the entire
backend for these application complex
e-commerce complex social media complex
chat app handle just the react part of
it just the front end part of it so
check out the free api. apppp in there
but again react has some of the drawback
that's why people actually switched from
react as a library to a full-blown
framework what are these problems react
don't have seos I'll walk you through
that why the seos are problematic in
react uh it also allows browser to do a
lot of rendering browser does so much of
lifting react ships the entire
JavaScript to your browser now it
executes in the browser then it Paints
the entire picture of HTML CSS so
there's a lot of work with the
JavaScript and your browser does so
obviously in some cases it's not really
ideal uh that's one of the drawback what
we want is some things which actually
renders react on the server itself and
send the browser only HTML CSS part of
it and that's what a lot of things even
this is coming to the core react of it
the server side rendering but we'll talk
about it later on also there's no
routing in the react so we can either
use react router Dom or other option is
use a full-blown framework there's no
shortage of these framework in fact I
would not hesitate to say every a new
framework in the JavaScript drops every
week some people would say every day but
I'll I'll still uh be saying every week
so there is the nextjs I do have a lot
of content on my channel on free code
camp on the nextjs I created them I
loved it uh but there's it's not like
nextjs there's other options Like getsb
Remix a lot of options are there so this
is basic so this is your entire road map
of how you should be learning react or
how you should be introduced to it or at
least you now know the basics of okay am
I ready for this react or should I focus
more on JavaScript or can I go just back
into this one uh after this we'll be
directly jumping into the code part and
we'll be starting our react Journey so
this is pretty amazing and I think
you'll be enjoying this series quite a
lot uh I'm definitely going to enjoy
teaching this entire react to you so get
ready buckle up a lot of projects are
about to come we'll be going dive into
the lot of react fun stuff and subscribe
hit that subscribe and in case you are
enjoying this series please please
please do share it on the LinkedIn tag
me that's one of the only motivation
that I need right now uh I would be
really really happy with that so that's
it for this video let's catch up in the
next
one hey there everyone hes here back
again with another video and welcome to
this react Series this probably would be
your second or maybe third video in the
react itself and this video is much more
crucial than the last one in the last
one we saw that how we can have a basic
road map to understand and learn react
in this one we'll be actually getting
some hands down yes I walked you through
the we'll be walking through with the
project approach but it's not going to
be just the project approach I'll be
walking you through with time to time
in-depth how react works so that you can
develop a mindset of how to work with
the react ecosystem that's really the
crucial part of it in this video I will
walk you through with all the tools that
are required how you can create a react
project how does a react project looks
like because by default a react project
is a little bit clumsy there is too many
files involved in it once we understand
that what files does basically what job
it will be much much easier for us so
this is going to be your official first
start journey and all the tools all the
sets that we required to work with the
react don't worry it's going to be a
Hands-On Journey it's going to be a
handholding journey you're going to be
enjoying this for sure that's that's my
promise so the first thing that we're
going to do is share my screen so let me
go ahead and share my screen so that I
can walk you through with the stuff uh
we'll come back onto the GitHub a little
bit later first of all let's just
explore all the things that we're going
to require the first one being nodejs we
are not going to move anywhere forward
without the nodejs it's a little
surprising that even the front end
doesn't move without the nodejs these
days so you can pick up any version
version 18 or version 20 that's totally
fine it's not really a difficult process
get it for Windows Mac Linux doesn't
really matter you just need to install
it the specific version also is not that
much important you can have the LTS
version long-term support for the
version 18 or you can have the latest
and the bleeding edge version which is
20 that is also fine in my case if I
open up my console and I show you that I
do have once you actually install it uh
you'll be having a node DV as option to
find out what version of node is
installed in your system mine happens to
be in between of 18 and 20 but I'll
update it very soon it's as I told you
it's it really doesn't matter as long as
something above 18 is there even 17 is
above there but it's totally fine it's
not going to bother you it's not a
course on nodejs but it is required to
actually learn react so that's the first
piece of the puzzle the second piece of
the puzzle is any code editor these days
uh everybody seems to be on the vs code
but if you happen to have any other
choice of the code editor that's also
totally fine maybe you are a Wim fan
that's totally okay maybe still you are
rocking the Sublime Text that's also
fine but I'll be using the vs code I use
it with my own custom theme with the
purchased font you don't need to do all
of this that's just a fancy Shenanigans
you don't need to worry about that uh
but this is something basic what we have
now another crucial thing that we need
for this is actually react. Dev you
don't need to download anything from it
it's just a reference point from where
we'll be Consulting the documentation to
understand the parts of it uh there's
another portion of it I'll walk you
through with that but first let's set up
the things so that you can actually grab
all the stuff and things like that so
what I'll be doing is uh let's first go
onto this so I do have a folder here uh
actually going to create this one is for
my English Channel so I'll be saying
that hey this is going to be a react uh
react course for 20123 so I'll be saying
react
2023 uh basically or probably react
course react course yeah that's that's
it react course I'll be giving you the
entire description where you can
download on the code files and
everything that you are having so no
worries on that part and the next thing
that we'll be having is just open this
up into any code editor so I happen to
have uh a code editor with me which is
vs code this is how it looks like when
you install this all you have to do is
drag and drop this react up here that's
it that's the step one once we have this
let's go ahead and keep it up there
we'll be creating a new folder into this
one let's just call this one as
readme.md MD is a markdown syntax which
has a special way if you just create
a.txt file that's totally okay as well
uh no need to worry at all in this case
now I'll be just putting up a simple uh
hash that means a heading and I'll be
saying uh simply start off start off
reactjs on Main Channel I do have couple
of other channel not couple of but one
other channel which is in the local
language so I'll be just saving this and
I can just click on this button which
gives me a preview that this is how it
looks like so as I told you it's nothing
it's just a text file nothing more than
that uh why we are creating this is
because I want to push all of the code
onto the GitHub as well uh so I'll be
just going up here on the GitHub INE in
case you know GitHub that's great if you
don't know this is where you need to
download all the code files that I'm
creating along with you you can download
all of them and check out how the course
progressed and everything from here
right just click on this I want to
create a new
repository and I'll be I'll be calling
this one as react Das
English and it's really really uh funny
to see that we have a react and dash
English after this U because you know
that's how it is I have a couple of
other channels so I'll be calling this
as public that's fine and we'll be
calling this one as uh a fun uh react
series series yeah just uh in
future yeah maybe I don't know why why
we kept it I don't want to add any read
me or something just keep it as public
or you can keep it as private as well I
need to keep it public so that I can
give it to you uh create the repository
and then the repository will allow you
to actually a few set of commands uh
that you can you can initialize the git
you can add the readme you can make a
commit change the branch and basically
you have to add a remote origin and push
it so that all the code can get onto the
GitHub and later on anybody can see that
let's run all these commands so I can
just open up my inbu terminal by the way
I can just click on the terminal new
terminal or I can just click on view and
uh somewhere here the terminal is I
don't know where yeah here it is
terminal or you can use the shortcut uh
control till day whatever is your
shortcut that's the one you you can use
I'll just go ahead and say uh get in it
that initialize a g repository and then
I'll just go ahead and say get add I
want to add everything there's just one
file or I can name the file as read me I
just add this one after that you can
again consult to the documentation
because all the commands are have are
here then next step is get commit so
I'll just commit with a message that
says start off uh react Series so that
later on I can push all the code up
there uh also I would love to change the
branch also there's a mention there's a
big big GitHub Thread about why we
should call it as main not as a master
and slave uh but again we are not going
to go into that much of the story but
I'll just say I'll just say get
Branch Das capital M I'll call this one
as main so the branch is changed then I
don't remember this so I'll just copy
and paste this this is basically a link
to repository since my GitHub is already
configured with my account and all the
SSH keys that are required to talk to
GitHub that's why this command will run
otherwise this will not run for you so
the remote uh origin is being added all
I have to do is now push all of my code
here so as I'll be creating the content
I'll be pushing it onto this one so now
everything is gone up there now if I
come back and refresh onto this link
which I'll be giving you in the
description as you can see all the code
actually get pushed to the GitHub that's
really important for us so that I can
share all the code files with you also
you can check out the commits as well so
that you can find out okay this section
of the code was added at that time and
this was first this was second just like
that okay so this is Basics but now we
need to go back and see that how we can
actually create a react project that's
the crucial information and all the
crucial information comes from the
documentation I want to learn it
obviously so there is a quick start and
there is an installation guide how can I
quick start before installation so I'll
just click on the installation and see
that how can I start a new project uh so
as I go into start a new project it says
if you want to build a new app or
website fully with react we recommend
picking one of the react powered
Frameworks powerful in the community so
these are updated documents and the
documentation says that hey you know
react is a very barebone Library as I
mentioned in the road map as well it
doesn't do offer too much of the things
to you it doesn't have routing it
doesn't have advantages like incremental
builds there are so many of these things
so react team recommend that if you
really want to build a full-blown
application just use some of the uh
Frameworks like Gatsby nexj or any
Frameworks remix whatever you like to
choose so they actually mention all of
this that hey we are not biased towards
just react which is a lot of people are
making confusion on the YouTube no they
says hey you can use nextjs you can use
remix or you can use gby whatever you
like it's your choice uh but they are
saying that hey this is for a full-blown
application in the production but if you
just want to understand what the
reaction is it's not going anywhere it
is still a rock solid library but the
way they mention it is little bit
controversial that why this was actually
mentioned in the Deep dive if you really
want to have a deep dive understanding
of those Frameworks as well as of the
react you need to have react knowledge
and you can use it without a framework
you can check the details there are a
couple of ways how you can actually go
ahead and take advantage of this they
mention that hey uh you can actually use
react and react Dom directly I'll walk
you through how you can do that as well
not walk you through but I'll give you a
brief reference of it and you can use
some of the bundlers as well now what
what on the God's green earth are these
bundlers uh you can use vat or parcel
let's try out and taste out what is this
vat so vat actually allows you to have
uh you can click on the get started
guide and it will allow you to have an
application preconfigured with the react
and all you have to do is npm create V
at latest that's all okay uh this is not
the perfect ideal guide of getting
started so I'll walk you through with
both the guides so that you can be in
the sync of it now first and foremost
we'll come back here uh as you have
installed uh node couple of other
packages are also installed on the
system one of them being npm and another
being npx npm being node package manager
it helps you to install all the
libraries which are JavaScript friendly
Library uh node package manager another
is node package executor which helps you
to directly execute these packages so
we'll be using one of them which is npx
and we'll be saying
create-react-app what is this create
react app this is a utility which was
really famous nowadays people look
little bit down onto this library
because it's little bulky it takes a
little bit more time to get downloaded
it literally takes more time because
it's bundled up with more things which
are required for any beginner to get
started for example even the testing
Library ships in this package which
probably you don't need it's too much
configured for you so we'll check out
both the applic ations both the ways
that how a package is being created with
the classic create react app and we'll
also analyze the application which is uh
build by the V or same thing goes for
parcel or any other uh similar package
or bundler uh that we have so once we
have this create react app we'll be
calling this one as 01 and we'll call
this one as uh basic react because
that's what it is basic react
application as I click on this uh notice
that it's going to go on to GitHub
basically and actually uh yeah basically
it's called a CRA create react app
template it's fetching all the things
for me not only fetching it it's
actually installing the things for me if
I open up this directory right now the
first step is to just get the
package.json which has a lot of things
I'll come back onto this one right now I
don't want to touch it uh so basically
that's what happening I'll come back
onto this project because this actually
takes painstakingly long time that's why
I just want to show you this is the only
time I'll show you that yes this
although I have a beast of a machine I
have a Mac Studio maxed out and my
internet connection is decent with a 300
Mbps and still it took this much of the
time not very long to for a beginner to
get started and we can see that there is
so much that comes into this one there
is so much Source uh I'll walk you
through how you can read these kinds of
applications don't you worry but now we
have this application next thing that I
want to do is not to dive into this one
I would love to learn how these
application are being processed and how
can make it up and running but I want to
explore another option that okay I can
create my react application with CRA
create react app but I can do the same
thing with the vit as well in fact the
documentation says that you can actually
use another bundler which is parcel so
what are these bundlers we will explore
them later on but I can actually do that
all I have to do for this is just to
copy this command which is npm not the
npx create then the V at latest at
latest is optional but we'll still use
the as ittis command I'll just paste
this command and this is a little
different of operation in the create
react app I don't have to even think it
just brings everything installs that's
it done when I click on the create V app
V is a bundler which has more options if
you just get a scroll onto the top it
says I don't just support react I
support pre- react I support SW I
support vanilla I I support a lot of
things so you have to tell it explicitly
what that what do you really want to
build with this V or what should I
bundle together for you so if I run this
command it says first thing what should
I name your project I'll say 01 and I'll
call this one as basic V yeah that's
basically it so I've got this basic vat
application but it says Hey how do you
want to actually build this application
select your framework Library it's a
loose term that we use here vanilla view
react pre- react whatever you can use
arrow keys to uh just go go up and down
and I'll use react obviously inside the
react it also gives you two options that
you want to use typescript JavaScript
whatever I'll keep this as accessible
for more audience although I do have a
typescript course both on the free code
cam on my channel as well but I'll in
this entire course I'll choose the
classic JavaScript but no worries we can
talk on typescript some another day I'll
just click on this and that's it it's
done as you can see how fast the V was
compared to the create react app but
there are a couple of things you should
be aware of vit just brought in these
files for me uh it never installed
things for me so I have to go ahead and
install this while on the other hand the
create react app not only brought in the
files but actually installed those files
I can see the node modules here so in
this one I have to go inside this folder
and install it now this brings a very
interesting option anytime you're going
to see any react application this is how
the react applications are brought in
there is never a node module folder so
what you have to do is go ahead CD into
your 01 uh basic uh V app app or
whatever the app you're going in and you
have to say LS or Dr if you on Windows
and you should be able to see this
package.json this should be in your path
directory once this is there then based
on this file you can actually run the
command npm install whatever the
packages are mentioned inside this
package.json will be installed once I do
this now you'll see a folder being
created live in front of us which is
node modules this is the file which will
actually allow us to install all the
packages and now we can run now we are
onto the same packages level that I can
run my vtab or the react app but before
I go there I should really learn to
understand that how these files are
actually structured that we'll do in the
next video uh but we should actually
really see that how can I run this
actually bare minimum projects and what
all the things are there so uh I'll just
go ahead and delete my terminal itself
so that we can go into the basic project
route one thing you'll notice that the F
structure looks a little bit similar but
the way how you should read these
application is always jump into
package.json this is a centralized index
of the entire application that what all
the files are what all the dependencies
are what all the dependencies for
development are what do I support what's
my name and everything you can see name
version the dependency list the scripts
that I have linting configuration what
browsers list do I support everything is
mentioned in the package.json as you can
see with the create react app it doesn't
really just uh brought in react and
react Dom it actually brings this couple
of things now before we move there I
would like to bring you back onto uh our
another eraser yeah
eraser eraser yeah I can I can go there
just give me a second I'll be going up
there I want to walk you through with a
couple of interesting thing about the
reactjs so we'll just go back there it's
just exactly scal draw so what you need
to understand a couple of things about
the react is that react is a main
application or the main package which
does all the magic but react actually
alone doesn't work we need to tell it
that where I want to run my application
so react has a couple of versions that
you have to go through with this so
there is one known as react Dom which is
a version or the connector of the react
which talks to my dom in the browser
it's a web application similarly we have
just like this I can talk to the web I
can go ahead and talk to mobile apps as
well there's a react native for that uh
the core foundation will always remain
react so they will it will always be
there but it will also have the react
Dom if I want to work with the mobile in
the web if I want to work with the
mobile it's react native even there is a
version of connector of the react with
the 3D applications like a 3js and all
of that so there's a lot of hooks that
you can uh actually wire up the react
with other application so now you can
see that the important libraries for us
are just react and react Dom but
actually installed react script some web
vitals to check out how your web is
doing what's the performance it actually
installs some of the test libraries
without even asking that whether I want
to use the jest as a library or maybe I
want to use Cyprus or mocha or any other
Library it just installed it it's very
opiniated in that case so this is the
first thing that we have learned now
let's go back onto the vit yes I know
this looks like very repetitive that why
are you comparing the CRA and the vat
it's very important for you right now to
understand this because you'll be
creating applications with a lot of
bundlers right now let's just let's just
nail it off here in the basic vat if if
I go and nail down into package.json
again you'll see that this is not very
opiniated it just gave me dependency
list of react and react Dom you need
some testing libraries you install it I
don't care about this this Dev
dependencies you don't need to worry
because this doesn't ship it these are
for helping the developers only so as
you can see there is no even react
scripts so that means that's not an
essential library that is given to us so
now this is the basic the next thing
that we'll be doing is just to learn and
understand that how we can run these
applications that is it that is it
understanding the file structure that's
for the next video or the next section
of the video if you're watching it all
one go I don't mind that okay so open up
your terminal and how you run this
application is actually again mentioned
in the package.json so if I go up check
out this notice here there's a start
script so all you have to do is somehow
you need to learn that how can I invoke
the start script similarly you can
invoke the build script test script
whatever the script if I go into the V
application same application uh same
procedure there uh there are scripts
like in this there is no start script so
there is a Dev script so all I have to
know is how can I invoke these uh keys
so that I can run the application that's
all that's all I have to do so open up
your terminal and let's go into one
folder uh which is 01 basic react once
I'm in into this and I'm able to see my
package.json file then I can go ahead
and simply just say npm run and then
invoke the script start script Dev
script build script whatever that is
just invoke that so I'll just say npm
start that's that's what is mentioned in
the create react app so if I go ahead
and run this it will say that hey I'll
open this up and it opens up a bare
minimum bare bone react application cool
okay uh I'll just close this one because
hey it's it's all done and then kill the
terminal as well now I want to run the
VAP so as we just saw that VAB don't
have a start script but it actually
gives me another script which is the dev
so I'll just invoke the dev and how
simple it is once I know the basics of
it npm run and the dev and can I run
this here notice here the error if I
click on this one it says hey there's
too much of the error why the errors are
there it ran into that so there's is
there a problem in the v no you missed
the step that I actually taught you that
hey if I do an LS I should be able to
see my package.json I couldn't so uh I'm
pretty sure now you'll take care of the
Errors By this way so I'll just go into
basic vat and I do a LS and I'm able to
see my package.json somewhere give me a
time okay package.json okay once I have
this package.json now I can say npm run
and the script name it's a build
whatever the script name is in my case
it's Dev so I'll just say Dev it doesn't
automatically open this up so I'll just
go ahead and control click or if you're
on the Mac command click it will ask you
to navigate navigate there and this is
your V application this was my react
application V application so yeah very
similar very similar but there are
certain differences between each each
one of them so I think that's the wrapup
uh I'll call this one as the wrap-up of
this video because it's already quite
decently long but at least we have moved
on to one point that we can actually
create applications without even being
dependent on nextjs or remakes or
anything so we're going into the core
Foundation of react within just few
minutes or seconds or in the next video
we'll be exploring the file structure so
that you have absolute uh confidence
about that hey I can build any react app
or I can inject react Wherever You Are
me to do so so that's all uh let's go
ahead and meet up in the next video and
explore the file structure of the react
application and the Ved application as
well let's catch up in the next
one hey there everyone Hees here back
again with another video and welcome to
the react series let's continue further
down the road in our react Series so we
have built a couple of applications in
fact two precisely of the applications
one was built using the create react app
another was built using the vit which is
another bundler and there are many other
such bundlers so it is very crucial for
us now that we dissect each one of these
application yes there is a way that we
can directly jump into the application
can build some project like uh to-dos or
maybe some password generator or
something we will surely do that but it
is utterly important here at this point
that we dissect the application once you
understand each of these because they
are like a critical example of how the
bundlers actually work and how the
default react crra Works once you
understand the working and the file
structure of both of them you will be
able to understand react much better and
you will be able to inject react in any
pre-built applications as well of course
you'll be able to create them fresh as
well so this video is only and only
focused on each and every bit that is
going behind the scene and is running in
the react applications so let's go ahead
and just dive into that one so let me
share the screen so this is our
application that we have and the first
project that we have is 01 basic this is
being built by the CRA the second one is
being built by the VAB we will of course
do the comparison between the two uh but
first let's jump into the react
application we have already seen that in
order to read any such application the
first point is to go into package.json
this is kind of a index order directory
for your application it shows you the
name the version and most importantly
the dependencies and the scripts that
are available as we can see the react
application with the CRA create react
app it's little bit opiniated it gives
us some of the T testing Library it
never asked me that whether I want to
use just or not maybe I'm a big fan of
Cypress or maybe mocha these are also
testing libraries so it doesn't ask me
just directly give me these testing
libraries on top of that react and react
Dom as I mentioned these are the two
vital things which is react react is
core react and in order to talk to the
Dom there's a separate package known as
react Dom similarly to talk to mobile
apps we have react native so these kinds
of things happen also on top of that it
actually includes some of the react
scripts I'll walk you through what it is
doing behind the scene for you and some
web vitals to check the performance or
application so it never asked me that
whether I want to use this package to
track the performance or not so little
bit opiniated of a library then on top
of that it actually uh runs some of the
script so when I say npm runs start it
actually runs a script which is known as
react scripts and then it starts so even
starting of the application is dependent
on these react scripts so I cannot just
go ahead and uninstall this similarly we
have some of the build scripts test the
script and eject the script maybe you
want to eject the entire react
application from the react configuration
now the way how we start the react
application is actually in the
development mode this is what you have
been using but once it actually goes on
production something known as varel
netlify Amazon there are lots of options
to deploy your application you simply go
ahead and run the build project of it
and once you actually do this uh you run
the script of build it actually gives
you the production version of how your
application will be deployed and there
is no rocket science behind it we can go
ahead and just simply run this so we
will go into uh 01 Basics probably I am
in Basics I'll close this one delete
this one actually I'll start with the
new one uh 01
Basics uh my bad 01 basic react okay uh
now we are in the correct folder and I
can run this script and simple way to
run it is npm run and instead of start
which will run the basic development
server I can actually run the build
servers which your um netlify and versal
actually run to actually run your
application because when you run it in
the start mode uh actually your browser
doesn't understand that there needs to
be just one Javascript file what it does
is in the react building or the
development phase we build lots of react
application they need to be combined and
come at to one place and this is not a
easy operation that's why there's a
separate build script for that and each
one of the packages gives you that so
we'll be running this npm run build as I
done this you can see there's a build
folder which is available for me and
this build folder has the final uh
JavaScript version of everything that's
required to run this application as you
can see uh HTML CSS JavaScript that's it
and this these are your minified
versions and mapping of your JavaScript
uh so end of the day it's just HTML CSS
and JavaScript no rocket science there
all right so this is how your build
applications are being built as we can
see react scripts are actually
responsible for doing this we'll come
back and compare this exact thing with
the vit as well but right now just to
summarize yes there are lots of
dependencies we have react scripts as
well and we have the start now let's
compare the exact same thing of package
or Json with the V application and see
and figure out that why people love V so
much let's open the package.json of the
V and as we can see uh name private
version very basic nothing to be worried
there uh we have the dev script we have
the build script okay I agree that part
needs to be there in the dependencies we
have just the react and react on so no
testing libraries uh no react script and
how does it is working we without the
react scripts that's an important
question but rest of the dev
dependencies I'm not much worried
because they are only there for the
development purpose as you run the build
command Dev dependencies never goes into
your project or your files all right so
that's the one thing so that's why
people love the vat no opinions about
the testing framework or any react
scripts just the core minimum bare
minimum Essentials to run the react app
that's pretty nice okay uh further down
the road as we can see this is much more
easier and cleaner and we already
understand that Dev is for development
environment when I run NP M run build
this is how it's going to run the build
command so very basic and bare minimum
again uh closing this and this kind of a
comparison in necessary uh for
understanding the application now going
uh into this one we have this public
folder where we have this HTML
index.html of course uh this is where
everything gets injected I'll walk you
through and majority of the time you'll
be spending inside the source folder
rest of things are pretty basic we have
node modules which installs all your
packages we have get ignore to ignore
some of the files which are not
interested uh there's a page. lock
folders as well which has a specified
version of all the packages that you are
installing pretty much the same but it's
a locked version of it and we have the
source now how does your react
application works so for that let's
first go into public folder and open up
index.html rest of your logo manifest
these are not much to be worried robots
for your uh Google indexing manifest for
the mobile indexing so all those mobile
icons and stuff are very basic but if I
go into
index.html and as you can see there is a
lot of things that is being written here
and you will be able to understand it
more if I remove the comments first of
all in the head part we have some of the
meta tags so really not much worried
about it the linking of the icons not
much worried about it and then it
mentions some about some things about
the Manifest that hey it's a metadata
used for your app when installed on the
user mobile not much wor it so I'll just
clean this one all right similarly I
will also just clean up this uh public
URL and basic that how we can link up
the static assets so so not much worri
it now further down the road I'll also
go ahead and clean up these uh comments
as well so there we go let's remove that
and if I go ahead and save it now and
close the head tag where the all the
crucial information is there in the body
there is nothing much going on first a
script that says that hey if you want to
run this application you need to be
having JavaScript enabled because some
browsers can optionally disable that and
we have just one thing which is known as
div which has an ID of fruit and that's
why we call the react app as Spa single
page application because there's not any
other page it's just a index and what
react does it actually takes your web
application and in every web application
or website we have these Dom nodes of
HTML react basically does is remove the
nodes and inject the nodes at the place
so that we don't have a full page reload
that's what we call it as Spa single
page application so if there is a div ID
route there might be someone who is
grabbing this if you understand the
Foundation of Dom there needs to be a
script in this page which actually go
ahead and say hey document. get element
by ID or query selector something
because ultimately react is the
foundational of like JavaScript is the
foundation of react so uh this needs to
be there without this it's not going to
be working so right now I can see there
is no script tag in my HTML so from
where this is script tag might be coming
up because otherwise how your HTML page
loads your JavaScript that's important
question here so if I go ahead and try
to run this application let's see what
happens uh so let's run this into the
and you don't need to run it into build
mode npm Run start is all good npm run
start and try to evaluate this and there
we go our page runs nicely and fine if I
right click and click on inspect uh
let's go ahead and see so as we can see
uh there's a lot of things which got
injected in my application so this is my
uh ID route and in this I can see app
was injected then the app header all
these things not much with it I'll
understand that but not only that some
things like style ID uh this dash lane
is mine because that's my password
manager this always gets injected but
apart from this couple of other things
also got injected into this one which uh
I'm not sure from where this actually
comes up and you you also will see that
couple of more things actually get
injected onto this one uh you can
analyze it more by just uh clicking and
view page source and you might be
noticing that previously there was just
this app but now if I go ahead and open
and look onto this one there is a script
which says static JS bundle JS so from
where this script is getting injected in
my application very interesting question
if you just look at this and in order to
answer this question uh there is inside
the package.json there is this uh
something known as react script so this
is doing behind the scene Magic that uh
while running the application or
building the application since the
application is being run by react script
it automatically finds your index.html
and inject its JavaScript there before
uh publishing it or pushing it onto the
server or our local server so this is
the magic that's happening but as we saw
in the v application this magic is not
going on there so what is making sure
that our app is running because similar
kind of a thing might be happening there
let's go ahead and analyze that as well
this kind of comparison analysis I'm
pretty sure a lot of people are not
going to like it but this is very
crucial to understand react after this
this is just uh packages and just fun
stuff okay as I can see there is no
public folder like there is a public
folder but my index.html is just outside
if I look at this this is much more of a
cleaner version of it there is a head
tag okay I understand that part there is
a div ID root so they're using the same
uh analogy there but I can see that the
script tag is automatically there so
they are not using any react scripts to
inject your script rather they are
injecting it manually here and that's it
that's what your react scripts are
actually doing so that's exactly where
it is happening now everything is coming
up inside the source and inside this
index. jsx we'll talk about that one by
one but now that we understand how the
working part of there and how the
JavaScript of react is getting injected
into the application now further down
the road if I open up the source and uh
there's a lot of things in here so we
obviously need to remove that otherwise
it's it would be really difficult to
understand that so setup test I'm not
interested in test go ahead and delete
that move to trash report web vitals I'm
not interested in you I'll just go ahead
and delete that all right uh logo not
interested in this VG logos just delete
that uh yep index.js yes I'm interested
index. CSS I'm not going to talk about
CSS as of this moment later on WE surely
will uh app test no no testing this time
I'll just go ahead and remove this and
app.css nope not interested in this one
so I'll go ahead and delete this so
ultimately we have just two files here
index.js and app.js as I can predict
from here that the first entry point of
my JavaScript would be index.js if you
have guess that that's correct uh I'll
just go up here and as you can see
there's again too many of the things so
I'll just go ahead and first remove all
of this so that's one I don't have web
vitals so I'll just go ahead and remove
this I don't have index. CSS remove that
react Dom and react these are packages
and app is my file there so if I look at
the index. index.js there's not too much
things going on
there is somebody who is actually
referencing document. getet element ID
by root so it's referencing my
index.html and is bringing up the rout
and react behind the scene we have a
react Dom so there is a browser Dom and
there's a react Dom known as virtual Dom
it tries to mimic the original Dom as
well and then whatever the updates you
make you actually first goes into your
virtual Dom or react Dom uh calling it
as a Dom right now it's not a great idea
because now it's not a virtual Dom it's
fiber but we'll talk about that later so
we go ahead and just have our own
virtual Dom and that's what this react
Dom is known as this is actually the
virtual Dom and any update that happens
here in the virtual Dom actually gets
pushed into the original Dom and only
those pieces are pushed so as we can see
it's just creating a root here and then
this root is actually rendering I'll
definitely talk in one other the video
about these rendering process in much
more detail in fact we'll be creating
our own render uh method just similar to
this one and as I can see this is just a
react strict mode and react and by the
way I can just remove this strict mode
as well in order to make sure that you
understand it much better this is also
an optional code so we have just an app
which is just running in here all right
that seems good if I go into app.js it
looks there is so much going on but I
can just go ahead and technically remove
everything and in fact if I just close
this header I don't want this header
entirely I'll just go ahead and say Hey
There is a div app no I'm not interested
in that I'll just go ahead and write in
simple H1 which is like a html text so
I'll just go ahead and say H1 or to
whatever feels good to you and I'll say
custom not custom it's a vanilla or
classic classic react app I'll save this
and if my application is running which
it is not uh I'm in the basic react so I
can actually go ahead and run this npm
Run start and technically my application
should still be running but in the
barebone version so now we can see that
classic react apps so as we can see a
lot of things were coming in just from
the CSS and stuff and and if you look at
from the JavaScript perspective what
we're doing here in the app.js we have
just created a function that is an app
that's it and we are returning some HTML
from it all right we'll just go into the
details in the upcoming videos but as of
now just a function which Returns the
HTML further down the road if I just go
up into the
index we're importing this app from the
file and we are rendering this here so
how cool this is and how basic this is
now further down the road we have this
app so that is cool and we are running
this and there's a special syntax of
running this into this this is known as
jsx we'll definitely go into much more
depth but if this is bothering you a
little bit since this is a method that
you imported uh it shouldn't be done but
since this is a method you can actually
run the method like this and if I save
this yep if I can go back onto my react
app yeah this is exactly it's a method
you can execute a method like this but
again not a good practice it's supposed
to be GSX we'll talk about about that
but yeah that's that's the basics of it
all right so this was somehow the
classic version of dissecting react app
which was built and now we understand
that it's not that bad it's just some
rendering that is happening behind the
scenes so react is doing some magic of
optimizing The Thing by just selecting
an element from the route now I
dissected it I know that I can change
anytime route to bees or maybe something
else I can do that totally do it and app
it's not really that fancy it looked
fancy at the first go but now it's just
a method which returns an HTML that's it
and now it's time that we dive and
dissect the vtap as well that hey what's
happening at your side index we know
that you are injecting my root here and
there's a script cool I accept that I
understand that in the source again we
have a lot of things going on so let's
just go ahead and delete one by one
main. jsx I think that's equivalent of
our uh index.js so exactly same uh again
we can do the same magic here we will do
that but first let's go ahead and remove
index. CSS not interested in the CSS
part so I'll just go ahead and delete
not rename I'll delete that just to give
you an idea of how the barebone version
looks like app.css not interested in
that either move to trash assets uh not
even tiny bit interested in that part so
I'll delete that now if I go ahead I
have just app.jsx and main.js and you
might have noticed that it calls it at
jsx and we call it as main.js so here's
a convention rule if you're returning
any HTML from your JavaScript that's
known as jsx because technically it is
jsx uh but it's just a rule you can
avoid that in some of the cases but I
recommend that you don't do that also
another convention is if you're creating
any component yes we call them as
component in the react World otherwise
it's just a basic function we actually
use a capitalized letter in the file
name in the component name as well I'll
definitely walk you through with that as
well so in the main. jsx now I can go
ahead and do the same thing I don't have
CSS let's remove that uh app yes we have
that and react react on that's cool
react strict mode we don't need that
right now so we'll just go ahead and
remove that we have just the app being
returned save that in the app.jsx we
don't have any CSS remove that we don't
have v logo remove that uh react logo
not interested in that you state in fact
we don't need that we'll just remove
everything remove all of this which you
don't understand right now and let's
just go ahead and have this div uh this
needs to go away and this whole thing
needs to go away away and again we'll be
doing the same thing everything goes
away we just have an H1 tag and it says
uh V react app so that's it that's the
basic of how it goes in the main. jsx we
are importing it and showing that up
that's it told you it's super super easy
let's stop that and run the vtap to
actually verify that we have a vtap
running with the bare minimum Basics so
CD and this one is 01 basic V and this
one is npm run
Dev and this should also be running
without any issues vtap and we have a
create react app so classic so now that
we understand each bit of it that how it
is happening why it is happening we can
actually do a lot more since we are in
the vtap itself uh if we actually
understand the basics of it that hey
it's just a file and I can just go ahead
and create a function inside it can I do
it one more time yes you can actually
let's just do that so let's go ahead and
remove all of this into my the same
folder V inside the source I'll create a
new file and show you a couple of errors
as well so we'll just go ahead and call
this one as youtube. JS and in here
we'll be just going with the classic we
have a function whose name is YouTube
and that's how it looks like and it goes
ahead and says I want to return there's
a parenthesis here and I'll be returning
an
H1 H1 just like
this and
H1 and I'll say YouTube app because I
teach a lot on YouTube okay uh we have
to export as well so we're going to say
export default and we'll be saying
YouTube so now that I have exported this
YouTube can I use this YouTube inside
the main or in the app yes you can you
can uh there is only one rule you have
to follow in the jsx there's a rule that
you can only return one element so what
if I have to return two H1 like this no
it's not allowed so there's a cool hack
of it that hey just go ahead and wrap
everything inside the div and
technically you returning just one
element uh but the error is gone this is
so much of a common practice that
eventually react guy realized that hey
this is this is such a basic thing in
the GSX it's kind of a a backdrop of a
of a GSX that we don't want it So
eventually they removed it and they
simply said hey now we can return empty
parenthesis which doesn't create any
extra de on the HTML and keep everything
just awesome uh in one of the mid
version of the react uh we were supposed
to actually bring it as fragment from
the react but now we don't need to have
this even the import statement it it
just works fine so if I go back here
it's a vtab VAB there we go now
similarly if you understand that how in
the main. jsx you have imported app from
app.jsx you can do same thing in the app
as well you can just go ahead and say
Hey I want to uh
import
YouTube and YouTube and now you can use
the same syntax of that just like we
have used in the app just same syntax
yep you can go ahead and use this uh but
this will be throwing us some errors
don't worry we'll be removing that so if
I go back it says Hey failed to pass the
source code of import analysis because
the file contains valid invalid JS
syntax if you're using jsx make sure the
name of should be jsx so this is one of
the V uh you can say rule that hey your
file was actually uh a jsx but you
actually called this as just a YouTube
you should shouldn't be doing that it's
again a vit specific issue maybe some
bundlers also do that but now that you
understand this uh you can just go ahead
and rename this and you can call this as
jsx because you're throwing out some of
the JS but this is also not going to do
it if I save this go back it technically
runs that but where is my YouTube Hey
there should be a YouTube because
there's a text inside the YouTube I'm
returning a YouTube app uh why is this
not going on right click inspect and
just look at the console now some
warning in the console the tag YouTube
is unrecognized in the browser if you
want to render react component start its
name with an uppercase letter so yeah
again one more error so let's just go
ahead and remove that so I'll just go
ahead and say hey this is a YouTube with
a capital u export that as a YouTube
with a capital u in the app obviously I
have to export that as YouTube and now I
can just call this component as a
YouTube so that is much better version
of it and now we can see the YouTube app
now there is no such hard requirement of
naming the file as capital but this is a
convention and I don't want to break
that so I'll just go ahead and say that
hey that's a YouTube and the moment I do
this this needs to be updating with the
import just the file name will be
importing and sometimes you'll see the
errors like this that's okay just go
ahead and command shift p and reload
reload the window and the errors will be
gone so yeah really basic I've been
teaching this for years and years now in
all of the boot camps so yeah this is a
classic way of now you have learned how
you can create your own component
basically which which is just a method
this is just a method so that's basic
part of it now let's try to do the same
thing I know this is boring but it's
very very important for you to
understand that why and how we are
having the bundlers and how does they
behave and all of that we need to do all
of this in the basic react app as well I
know I'm sorry uh but this is crucial
information we cannot avoid that so
let's go into the source we know this
index.js we know app.js let's go ahead
and create another one and let's call
this one as YouTube and we'll be
following the convention this time
because there's no point of learning
them again and again so we know that
YouTube uh in this I can actually use JS
there is no hard and fast requirement to
call it as jsx because the rules were
actually coming up from the V not the
CRA so every bundler has their own rules
but I'll I actually like this GSX it
actually gives me that hey there's some
GSX getting returned from it so I like
that so I'll be following that in the
function I'll be calling this one as
YouTube there we go really basic and in
this one we'll be just going ahead and
saying return and inside the return
we'll be returning a jsx probably just
an H1 uh which says YouTube react app
and end of the day we'll be just saying
export
default YouTube if I can write that not
like that YouTube so once we have
actually created and exported that in
the app.js I can actually go ahead and
import that I can just go ahead and say
import YouTube from YouTube we know that
this needs to be uppercase if if I go
ahead and directly write this as a
YouTube and just like that it will
bother me now we know that the basics
behind it that hey this needs to wrap
inside this which is a fragment very
basic not too much to be worried I can
save this and now I can run this so as
you can see once you understand the
concept at one places moving them into
another place is not a big deal uh we'll
just go ahead and say npm run and uh
start I think that's the start script no
that's not a start script because I'm
actually in the wrong folder I need to
go inside uh 01 basic react and from
here I can run npm run
start and yes these errors are really
really important uh for you to see and
actually walk through and just make sure
never be afraid of going into the
console to see if there is any error or
something like that and that's how we
all debug the application now we have
actually dissected the application in
such a way that uh we just know every
inch every piece of how the react
application is working from where the
reacts are getting injected in the HTML
both in the v how the build process
works uh both in the CRA create react
app and the v as well it actually gives
us a great Foundation of how things
actually are being done inside this
again some of this I understand was
boring was repetitive but it is
essential for you to understand how the
dissecting is done so that when we later
on create the react apps you just see
them as just a Javascript app and that's
my goal not to see react as some fancy
library but something which is an
addition in your JavaScript writing
capabilities that's what my goal is I
hope you're enjoying this if you're
enjoying this do let me know in the
comment section that is very very
important for me to get a feedback to
get some appreciation everybody works
for some motivation this is my
motivation so that's it for this video
we'll surely catch up in the next
one hey there everyone here back again
with another video and Welcome to our
react series I hope you are constantly
watching this series and also sharing
this series so that helps me a little
bit uh to spread the word around that
hey there is a remarkable series and yes
one thing is sure this series is going
to compete with all of the paid courses
that you have seen around on the
internet so with that let's go ahead and
get started in this video we are going
to focus on one very basic concept of
how can I create my own react now this
sounds very fancy but it is not a lot of
people just believe that react is some
kind of a magic that happens behind the
scene but it is not it is just a ton of
JavaScript which has been written by
somebody else and a lot of algorithms
which makes the manipulation in the Dom
much more easier and consistent that is
it nothing more than that once you get
the mindset that react is doing nothing
apart from helping me in manipulating
the UI you will become an amazing react
engineer or as a front-end engineer
that's debatable so in this video I'll
walk you through that how we can create
a really basic HTML file and a
Javascript file and can kind of a mimic
what react is trying to do in the back
end of course react uses tons of
algorithms we are not going to write
that but still this video is very
valuable and we give you a whole lot of
idea about that I hope that makes you
excited and uh in case you're watching
it on my channel then definitely we have
a Target setting practice so uh go ahead
and keep on learning the things and post
in the comment section we are targeting
around not higher but just 100 comments
on this channel I hope you can help me
in achieving that Target uh let's go
back and I'll First share the screen so
there we go uh so this is my VSS code by
the way you can find all the code files
in the in on my GitHub account post a
star there as well I'm asking too much
that's really required okay moving
further uh let's create a new folder and
we're going to call this one as simply
just custom react so let's go ahead and
create a custom react where does that
folder go oh anywhere Uh custom react or
we're going to call this one as custom I
I really like this color but anyways
custom react Uh custom react will get
just the two files very basic just like
how we do in the classic vanilla HTML so
index.html what else uh we're going to
get some JavaScript so uh let's call
this one as custom react or whatever you
like custom react.js should I uppercase
this yeah I I really think a lot about
that okay what goes into the index. HTML
nothing much we'll be using EMT to
generate the boiler plate code hit that
two hits and after that two tabs and
after that you can just write Uh
custom
react now the idea is uh in the react
what you might have seen is we have
already explored that in the last video
that it has just a div which has an ID
of root that is it if I go ahead and Jog
your memory again either I go in the v
or wherever you want me to go I can just
open this and this is exactly how it
looks like in the vat we we saw that
there is a custom script that is
included and in the react we saw that
there are some react scripts which helps
me to inject this inside this so if I go
ahead and look into my public index HTML
nothing and that is only and only one
reason because in my package.json there
are some react scripts which actually
inject that so we're going to not going
to do that we will inject our script
manually and there are a couple of ways
how you can inject this we'll not talk
much about it but right now I'll just
say say script and all I want is to have
a source and the source is in the
current directory custom react uh by the
way we can talk also about that how the
type of the loading of the script can be
commonjs module but not for this series
not going to be too much into the
JavaScript but wherever it is required
I'll discuss that okay now coming up on
to the react how does react works and
how does react is able to just generate
everything inside this route and how
would I do this if I had to just do
really basic of it now the first thing
is that we need an element so what is
the element that you want to inject here
now you might say that hey I want to
inject let's just say an H1 tag uh
simple and inside the H1 tag we'll have
some laurum great but this is not how
react looks at the picture react looks
at the picture uh that everything is an
object and inside this object you'll
give me that what should I create uh
first give me a tag name then give me
what should I insert into that give me
what attributes should I add to those
HTML that kind of a basing so we can
just try that let's just go ahead and do
that first of all let me say that hey
this is a type what the element type
should be it could be H1 it could be a
tag whatever you like that is exactly
the type now after that uh what are the
props that you want to insert into this
uh by by the term props you can just use
attributes no problem there my video I
chose to props your video you or your
code you can choose absolutely to have
this now this props since we know that
the attributes can be many so that's why
I'll use a prop as an object which can
further be drilled down to multiple
things like for example I want an HF uh
which goes to uh Google so Google if I
can write that that would be great uh
HTTP colon google.com so that's the
first thing that I have here and apart
from this what else do I want maybe a
Target okay Target will be underscore of
course in the string underscore blank
now right now it's giving us couple of
Errors don't worry we'll fix them up in
a minute uh but this is my basic what
else do you want to have now let's just
say I want to have a some text inside it
and I'm going to call these text as
children and I'm pretty sure you might
be wondering how you are able to come up
with the things that we are going to
call this as props or children no Need
No need no need to call it anything feel
free to call it whatever you like I'll
just go ahead and say and I'll say uh
click me to visit Google and I know this
is bothering you so I'll just fix this
okay since this is an object let's go
ahead and store that into a variable so
we'll just call this one as react
element feel free to call it whatever
you like there's just nothing more than
naming so now we have an element uh
which we want to inject inside our Dom
or root in this case root so I want to
inject here okay how can I do that uh
that's pretty easy first and foremost
get me the reference of this root that's
easy if you have studied your JavaScript
that's easy easy all I have to do is say
document hey document I want to have a a
get element by ID will also work uh we
can have a query selector that will also
work whatever you like it's your choice
so I'll just go ahead and say give me a
root there we go now you might have
noticed that if we go and check out the
vit especially this is exactly what they
are also doing so in case they are
you're looking forward for this one if I
go ahead and open up Source main. jsx
exactly like that get element by ID
query selector whatever that is exactly
same okay since we have a reference of
this let's call this one as main
container uh there we go feel free to
name it whatever you like now once I
have this reference I am thinking that
there should be a method just like react
has its own method if I have a custom
render method which takes two parameter
that where do you want to inject and
what do you want to inject that is it
that is it I'm done with my job so first
thing is I want to inject react element
where do do you want to inject it uh I
want to inject it into
container uh main container yeah that's
whatever name okay so this is good now
the whole Magic lies that how does the
main container work it's a function
that's for sure so let's go ahead and
create a function why to worry about
that and let's just call this one as
main container and there we go there we
go magic function that's it tutorial
done no not like that okay uh main
container takes a react element let's
call it as react element and whatever
the container you want to inject so in
my case it's main container but we'll
just differentiate it like this okay
step number one is uh create an element
so how do I create an element it's
pretty simple document. create no
suggestions create element there we go
we have suggestion create element what
element do you want to create I want to
create an element which is an a tag
great but I want to utilize the
parameters which are passed to me so I
can use a react element parameter and I
can say hey take the name of the
parameter from react element. type okay
so that I can reuse this code and not
only just with the a I can actually
inject H1 and H2 and whatnot all these
values let's store that into a variable
so let's just call this one as Dom
element whatever the name of the element
it's up to you so we have a Dom element
that can be injected uh but right now it
just created it doesn't have anything
inside it so let's put something inside
it so this Dom element we're going to go
ahead and set up inner HTML inner HTML
that's always something which I mess up
and then we can use this react element
and I can just go ahead and use the
children so inside the inner HTML this
children will be added and now we have
an a tag and whose text is inside the
inner HTML or you can say inner text as
well that's changeable and I have this
access but I have set no attributes in
inside it so how do I set the attributes
uh that's also easy I can just go ahead
and say hey Dom element uh I want to set
an attribute set at no
suggestions that's that's mean at oh my
bad I'm writing wrong at three still no
suggestion I I don't like that okay I'll
say attribute what attribute do you want
to add now I want to add an attribute
which is going to be first
href and where will I get the value of
href I'll I'll get it from react element
do props do href so this is my first
attribute that I'm setting now what is
the next attribute you would love to set
I would love to set this target so I'll
just say hey now let's set the Target
and the target you'll be getting from
Target that's it okay once this is done
then I need to utilize this container
because this is where I'm going to
append the things so I'm going to go
ahead and say hey container let's go
ahead and say append child and in the
pen child let's inject the Dom element
that is it now so far we haven't
utilized anything react or reactors like
that we have just gone through with the
basic JavaScript to jog your memory of
JavaScript in the early days of react
okay this looks good and we were able to
do all of this but this code is not
optimized we can actually optimize it so
I'm going to go ahead and put some
comments onto this one so that this is
there for you and by the way I've been
doing this for a really really long time
in lots of boot camps
okay there we go we keep this now let's
try to do this again it will be a good
revision for you A lot of people are not
going to like it but this revision is
necessary so let's do it one more time
uh this time we'll write a little bit
faster so we'll just go ahead and say
document do uh create element and we
know what's going to happen inside this
one we'll take the react element do
types types or type and we're going to
hold that into a variable let's call
this one again as Dom element and there
we go now we know that this part of the
code is absolutely okay and Dom element
will also get the inner HTML so we'll
just say inner HTML and we have the
inner HTML which is going to come to me
vi react element. so far exactly same
code no big deal but what I want to do
now is I want to Loop through this prop
so that no matter how many elements are
coming in I can just set them up so
let's just utilize a loop here to write
a better code and we're going to use a
for in Loop that makes sense and we're
going to say for prop in and again we
have to go inside this props to Loop
through and I can just go ahead and say
hey react element dot props there is an
S there so all of this element needs to
go through with that I'll just remove
this if part this is our classic basic
code now let's just say first of all uh
this is also uh something which happens
in the react as well by the way you can
just go ahead and set these elements so
we can just go ahead and do something
like this access this Dom element and
just keep on looping through and set the
attribute
attribute and that attribute uh the key
of the attribute is obviously this this
thing which is actually looping through
in the prop so I can just go ahead and
say prop and what should be the value
the value is going to be react element
and we also know that objects uh can
also be accessed other ways then just
the dot notation there is a square
brackets in this case that square
bracket makes sense so inside this go
into the props now we are inside this
what property do you want to access
whatever there is in the prop this same
so I'll just use a square bracket and
I'll say prop that is it now this is how
like obviously it will work but there
are also cases that somebody might
inject accidentally a children here uh
just like this and might add a children
here as well if there is a children here
we are expecting that the children will
come outside now remember this I am
setting the rules I am react okay uh but
still I want to avoid that case so just
taking care of the corner case I can
just go ahead and say hey if the prop is
equals to a literal string of
children and if that is the case I just
want to return so I'll just I'll just
sneak it out I'll just say
continue I cannot return here otherwise
this will close the entire thing I just
want to skip that one iteration again if
this is something too much for you just
go ahead and skip that now I have
improved the code and I can just go
ahead and say hey take the container and
append nope no suggestions hate that
append child and in the append child I
can just use the Dom element so it's a
better approach definitely 100% a lot
better approach uh but can we say that
this was far better and this is how
exactly the react Works absolutely 100%
this is how things Works let's go ahead
and open this up into a live server so
that we can actually see that in action
okay we got some of the stuff wrong so
let's just go ahead and uh fix that okay
object and we have back
limiting okay so some things are not
loading up properly let me go ahead and
quickly check that all right so after
staring the code a little bit staring
the warnings a little bit I found the
bug and it was pretty easy and not
really that big of a deal so what we see
here is that inside this I accidentally
named it as main container shouldn't
have done that this should be uh named
as custom render probably bad suggestion
there you might have already noticed
that uh so once we do this save this and
when we go back onto the code part we
see that click may visit Google although
very very painful for your eyes uh but
it's good it's good it's actually
working and I can just go ahead and fix
it so that you can at least see that
properly so inside the body I can just
go ahead and add a style and can say
background color is going to be uh
probably Ash and we're going to go
uh better all right so although the link
and the text and everything is little
less visible but we can see it is there
it is there it is now much visible for
you I can zoom this for you and we can
see it is visible for me so there are a
couple of things that we need to discuss
now that how these all things are going
on it's not really that bad of a deal so
we have concluded so far that yes we are
perfectly capable of Designing our own
react and this is what react actually
does on the surface level where react
shines is there are definitely the
capability of creating uh things inside
inside it like for example there is
right now just an a tag but what about
when there's a div tag then there is a
span tag then there's a a tag we
obviously need to Loop through values
and smartly design our component so we
can do that no problem surely take time
take some time but with enough of the
time it can be done also react uses some
of the algorithms behind the scene that
makes this entire process easier so now
can we relate this our Custom Design
thing with the react itself so that it
makes sense or it start to make sense a
little bit uh yes turns out yes we can
actually go ahead and try that so now
let me go back onto the code part this
is the code that we have written now
technically if this is whole the theory
which is correct I can actually bring
whole of this into the vit and should be
able to run this and that is where the
challenge begins so I'll just go into
the source main. jsx and I'll just say
hey I have this react element and I just
want to run this react element uh can
you do this for me
I think yes you can uh because what we
noticed if I just close it and Jog your
memory again in the app.jsx this is just
a function that is it you are exporting
a function if I come back and for a
minute if I just forget about my react
element I can just go ahead and declare
my own function and I just can call this
one as my
app and that's my app and literally
whatever exactly we are doing in the app
we can do here we are just returning
this so let's just return this so I can
just go ahead and say Hey I want to
return what do you want to return a
simple div which says Uh custom app
maybe like this so I'll just say hey
this is my div not like that uh didn't
intention so one more time a div yep
just like that and we will have an H1
and this app H1 will say
custom react app so we should be able to
run this technically and we will be we
will be I can just go ahead and remove
instead of the app I can just go ahead
and say my app
just like this and even I can do all the
fancy stuff since this is a function I
can do this literally and let's try to
run this and I'll open this up and let's
just clean this up and I'll go inside uh
basic and probably we are already in the
basic react so I'll kill the terminal
start it again cd01 basic V and the way
to run it is npm run Dev we have already
seen that and are we not able to run it
let's just do an LS package.json uh
probably we are missing let me just
check oh I probably deleted the node
modules folder npm install shouldn't
take much time
npm run Dev and now yep we are able to
see that so now we can see custom react
app this is exactly what is what we
intended to do but this is not a correct
way uh this is not a recommended way in
the react although there is nothing
which is stopping you to do so but it
might hinder some of the optimization so
rather better way is to load it as a
component Custom Design uh element HTML
element that would be a better name so I
just go back and say hey still it works
custom react app so hey that is exactly
now if this is the exact process that is
happening of looping through the
elements uh can we reach to the point
where I can just Loop through this
element uh let's just try this so how
can I if I I can render this whole thing
with a function I should be able to
render things if I directly pass it on
as an element so what about if I go
ahead and say hey I want to give you a
const which is going to be named as
another element whatever you want to
name it and this another element is
directly not a function it just doesn't
return but it directly gives you an a
tag uh which actually goes
to
google.com and have a Target get of
underscore
blank and we can just go ahead and say
visit
Google visit Google this should also
work because this is exactly what is
happening this is what is getting
returned if I can get it as a return can
I render my element directly like that
uh yeah you can actually if I can just
go ahead and remove this uh I can just
say another element directly and this
should technically work in theory so if
I go ahead and move this this is not
working I'll tell you the reason if I go
ahead and inspect and say console it
says Hey warning another element is
using incorrect casing that's is the
only problem with the V is because it
wants me to actually make it capital and
this one also has capital and this is
all happy this is all happy if I go
ahead and redirect it reload it now
notice here it says in the console uh
that hey uh react. GSX is invalid
expecting a string ah you are expecting
a string but let's try the same thing
because this is actually a warning or
some of the issues that are given to me
uh in the v itself can I go ahead and
just change it like this uh yes you can
and by the way I'll just go ahead and
show you how the things are actually
being done in this exact way now the
most important thing is that if this is
an element which is already generating
an element do I actually use this it
like this or do I use it like this
syntax and this is weird or this syntax
but this is not a function this is just
something I don't know what this is even
I have never seen anybody returning like
that but one thing I can surely say that
this whole thing is going to be looped
through just like here we have Loop
through so I don't need to do any of
this and can I just go ahead and pass it
like a variable will it accept it like
this if I go ahead and save it and go
back onto my browser ah we can see that
it accepted it like this oh that's
interesting never seen react like this
so if I go go back I have concluded a
few things that okay uh it's totally
possible to just declare a function and
return an HTML from it that is your jsx
technically and I can also go ahead and
do some things like that which is very
very weird but it technically works now
if technically this whole thing works
can I just render react element like
this and you might be very very curious
to see it like working like this but you
go to the web and it doesn't if I go
back onto the Chrome and I go ahead and
reload and you say that hey it doesn't
work now again you are excited that
probably this needs to work somehow so I
can use a syntax like this or maybe
another angular bracket syntax no it
doesn't work sadly like that and you
might want me to answer this why it
doesn't work the reason for that is
react doesn't know what is this type
react doesn't know these are props react
doesn't know these are children this is
something that is I designed it my
custom react I made it up so whenever
you made it up how can I react actually
understand your language so there is no
way react actually understands your
language if you want to create an
element like this you have to understand
the react language and have to give it a
react language so what is this react
element uh so I'll just go ahead and say
const and actual uh react element or I
can just say a react element the reason
for saying this is because we already
have this react element as V variable so
I'll just call this one as react element
in order to properly actually convert
this thing this whole a thing or
whatever the div thing is you have to
actually convert this whole thing using
the react language and how do you
understand the react Language by
importing react that is it and use a
method that says create element this is
exactly how it does just like we created
our render element this is how react
actually create element so whatever you
return back this whole GSX actually goes
through the react element and then it is
converted into an object and how does it
look like uh we saw that we gave this
type and everything no react don't use
it react actually directly gave it as a
tag this is how literally you convert
that after that you go ahead and inject
an object this object second thing is
always and always an object the order
here is also important and then it
actually Loop through and say that all
the attributes that you want to go
through you go ahead and inject those
attribute for example
google.com I should have used my own
website but anyways Target and we used a
target of unders in the strings of
course underscore
Blank That's the uh second thing and
finally the last thing that comes up is
whatever needs to inject as a children
and that is where you actually says
click to
visit Google and that is why I named
them specifically as childrens and props
and everything yeah this is exactly what
happens the first thing is your element
the second thing is all the attributes
and the third thing is all the children
that you actually inject this is how
literally reacts actually break it down
once you have this one as a react
element let's go ahead and place it up
here that hey I now have a react element
let's go back and we can see that now
there is no problem in saying that hey
this is not uppercase lowercase because
we are not using those elements now
nothing is getting uh extracted from the
another element another element this is
literal HTML this is what the react
expects while rendering because it is
the object version of it ah quite a lot
of stuff uh which is fun stuff now
another thing which you might have seen
is uh actually fun stuff so let me just
go ahead and say let's roll back to
app.js so we already have this one so
we'll just inject this and I'll say hey
let's render app with a self closing tag
and there we go we have number of times
V tab you might have noticed that uh
what happens into this one is sometimes
you go ahead and inject those variables
that is also super super important uh
the way how we render the the variables
is not really too different from how we
render anything in the JavaScript you
want to render an element this is how
you go ahead do that now here I can just
go ahead and say 2+ 2 go back and it
gives me four so it is actually
converting everything whatever I have as
like this now not only this I can
declare my own variables if I go back
onto the code part I can go up here and
say Hey I want to have uh a username and
that username name is literally my name
I can instead of 2+ 2 or in another
variable I can just go ahead and say
that hey now I have this user name so
this is oh by the way wrong place this
is where it should be going up so inside
the function why is it bothering
me okay too many bothers no
corresponding closing tag you have a
closing
tag okay probably some place I messed it
up CST username closing it return just
like that okay I'll hit command Z couple
of
times oh my bad we actually messed it up
here and this should be all happy now
now we can place it back so this is how
we get our username uh whatever the
variable is funny and I go back and see
I have this variable so how does that
actually works and a lot of people
wonder that why cannot I just go ahead
and uh use something like this
if uh
username equal equal equal maybe one
more equal and I go ahead and Sayes uh
then can I use my other stuff like uh
trary operators here just like that
there is a string and you can see it
it's not working out and it says no and
this one says yes so why does this
doesn't work and this works uh because
the reason behind that is whatever you
write react actually goes inside each of
your element each of your element HTML
element and extract these curly braces
out of it and whatever it extracts these
curly braces it actually puts one more
object property here and whatever you
place it there it actually literally
moves it there so for example when you
go ahead and say 2+ 2 that 2+2 goes here
and since this is evaluated as
JavaScript that 2 + 2 gets converted uh
into actual value which is four but if
you go ahead and write it like this if
and let just let's just bring it so that
we can see that why it doesn't make
sense I copy this and instead of 2+2 if
I go ahead and and use this this is this
cannot be evaluated so the only thing
which I recommend everybody to
understand is whatever the expression
you write is this is evaluated
expression it could be it should be
evaluated to something so this something
here is 2+ 2 4 so that can be evaluated
and that is literally being taken and is
being placed so that JavaScript engine
can just take it as it is when
JavaScript takes it this is expression
which needs to be evaluated this is not
already evaluated and this is I know
this is too much uh but this is
literally how it place it as another
property and that's why you are able to
see your username here so it just refers
to that as a variable I'm just good in
referencing the variable or doing some
JavaScript is calculation not your whole
logic should be written here because it
doesn't make sense property should not
have Logics like this uh this is
literally just a property list of
properties and that is one thing you
need to understand so this whole thing
doesn't work so you should not be be
doing it like that uh if you go ahead
and place it as empty that is also okay
uh sometimes you'll see there are empty
lines and stuff like for example if you
want some spacing or something uh
between them or maybe at some places
you'll see people literally just use it
like this and then put an empty string
here just like that with spaces because
this is literally being taken up here
and this space actually is taken like
this so yes this is valid and you'll see
a lot of bugs and things uh being
reduced if you understand this part of
GSX that is it you understand a lot of
react uh this is a lot I know and I can
totally understand and relate to you but
this portion of the code is really
important for you to understand that how
the GSX is actually evaluated how react
sees the thing and never never Fascinate
react as something which is magical we
already tried to building something of
course we didn't spend that much amount
of time with the algorithms and the uh
chaining of these elements but hey we
did a fantastic fantastic job in
actually doing a lot of stuff so this is
where actually your foundation begins of
the react that hey and now I understand
JavaScript now I understand jsx now I
understand react it's nothing more than
that all these H1 and H2 tags are
converted into object react. create
element helps me to do that and later on
I'll walk you through with the even the
source code of the react on the Facebook
GitHub page yes we'll do that as well
later on but I think this video gave you
a lot of insight of how the custom react
is being designed and I know whenever I
teach this even in the early days of the
react in any offline online boot camp
people just go oh man this is too much
but we loved it so if you have enjoyed
this please do support me hit that
Target in the comment section I would be
super super happy to have this kind of
support from you and again videos will
be coming soon as constantly as they
have been coming for years and years now
let's go ahead and catch up in another
video hey there everyone haes here and
welcome back to another video in the
series of reactj yes so we are taking
our time absorbing the react as much as
possible and now let's start the
fundamental Foundation of react itself
the one of the core foundation of the
react is State not the State Management
that's a separate topic we'll cover that
but the state what do you mean by state
and to be honest you don't need state in
the react so state is the way uh we
first need to understand that where does
the state comes into the picture should
I learn it should I or can I skip that
and right now I would say yes you can
skip that but as you will see the need
automatically you'll understand that oh
this is why I should learn the state
state in the react so let's go ahead and
try to build a project very basic
project and let's do the stuff with that
and I think Hands-On practice is always
the good idea uh by the way if you're
watching it on my YouTube channel I am
expecting just 100 comments under the
comment section itself uh just to
provide support and to set a target for
you if you complete that that's awesome
if not hey I need some support I need
some uh encouragement from your side as
well it's really difficult to just talk
to camera and sit here all day on the in
the room itself so I deserve that
hopefully if I okay let's go ahead and
start with that so first of all we are
on to uh vs code uh just like always and
I'll just start I'll just actually C
close this one I'll start another
terminal and we'll be creating a fresh
new project by the way all the projects
are available on my GitHub repository
you can just search for react English
somewhat repository it will be in the
description so it will be available
there so let's go ahead and try to have
this one at latest and this is just how
you create the vtap and by the way we
have discussed quite a lot vtap react
app doesn't really matter whatever like
suits you you like that you just go
ahead and get started with that I'll
name this one as this is second project
so I'll just call this one as 02 counter
to keep a track of how many projects we
are building uh in this one whether
small or big that doesn't really matter
so I'll just go ahead work with react I
want to go with JavaScript I know a lot
of you want to go into typescript
especially after seeing my entire
playlist on this channel or free code
cam wherever you have seen that entire
playlist on types scrip I want to keep
this entire react series much more
accessible to everyone uh I don't want
too much of the prerequisite because
already there is too much prerequisite
of JavaScript in the react Series so I
would just say that hey we are not using
typescript at least in the initial level
I will keep couple of videos at the very
last of the series to just give you an
idea of how you can use typescript with
react but for majority of the part my
goal is to make you familiar
with the concept and Foundation of react
and not to just bog you down with the
typescript that's that's the idea so uh
let's go ahead into 02 and I can just go
ahead and say npm install that is all
what we need and then we'll simply fire
npm run Dev to start this if my internet
is decently fast I hope so uh there's
not too much of dependencies that's a
good thing uh something something has
happened to my Internet it's usually not
this slow anyways uh let's let go ahead
and say npm run Dev and by the way we
have already seen that how we can
actually see that which command runs all
of that via the package.json this is how
it looks like which is good which is
good going back into 02 counter and
we'll see inside the source that we have
app.jsx this is the file where we are
interested in mostly and we'll try to
build something of our own into this
entire application so let's just remove
everything we'll just keep the bare
minimum basic and let let's see that can
we build something of our own so let's
just go ahead and have an simple H1 it
says react course
with hes and that's it and probably
there is another H1 here or probably H2
and I'll say uh counter value and then
nothing yes this is exactly what we want
to do and then I'll probably have a
button and that button does nothing it
just says add add value and there's
another button which just says remove
value and for some reason I don't know I
want to inject some values in these
buttons as well and there's one more
I'll just go ahead and say hey there's a
paragraph which says footer which will
also get some value can we first go
ahead and just remove everything from
this file just like we did in the last
one that hey I'm not interested in any
one of that I just want to see how my
app looks like so there we go uh right
now we can add some more values to it or
probably we can inject some of the
spacing as well by the way here's a fun
thing I can just go ahead and add like
this and notice here it adds a space if
you know how the GSX are being converted
this shouldn't really bother you but
right now there are buttons they do
nothing footer nothing and what I want
to do is I want to have a variable and
that variable should be shown all the
places no big deal I can come here and I
can declare a variable uh let's just say
we will have a counter since this will
change I'll start with the value 15 20
whatever you like this is my counter and
I know already that I can just use these
curly braces to have my counter this is
known as variable injection no fancy
thing and I also want to inject it here
so I'll just go ahead and say
counter and I'll also come here in
footer and I'll inject it here and I'll
say counter so this is a common thing
which I sh shared you in the story of
react how it actually got up so you can
see it's 15 it's 15 it's 15 everywhere
so first of all notice and even
appreciate that you don't have to say
document. getet element by ID and then
inject that append that add value append
HTML nothing nothing like that I can
just use literally variabl so I'm more
focused on the programming side of it
than just uh attaching things to the
node list in my in my document so that's
one advantage here now next thing is I
want to have a method that when I click
on the button it adds the value cool you
can have that pretty simple there is
nothing reacti in that it's just simple
JavaScript so I can just go ahead and
say here I'll use an on click this on
click will say add a value since this is
a method this needs to be declared so we
can just go ahead use classic function
or Arrow function totally up to you not
going to crash your app so I'll just say
add value and add value will be an arrow
function in my case and what it does it
takes the counter and it adds the Val to
it so I'll just go ahead and say plus
one that is all now on top of this let's
go ahead and try to do a console log of
the counter whenever I add a value U
I'll just go ahead and say let's console
log here itself I'll say console log and
I want to have the value of counter that
is it so I'll save this go back and I'll
open up my inspect and console so that I
can see what's happening there so the
value is 15 and I simply click on add
value and it says 15 I again click on
this and it says two time it's 15 H very
interesting so if I go back I see that
the counter + one doesn't increase it
why because I didn't saved it anywhere
so it should be something like this
counter is equals to counter plus one so
I'm updating the value of counter by
adding one to the existing value H
that's good let's go ahead and just
facilitate it again refresh and remove
everything and I say add value I get 16
add value 17 add value 18 okay so I'm
able to do almost everything in so far
whatever is required in the javascrip
TSH world I have my variable I can add
value to it I can similarly remove the
values whatever everything that
JavaScript is telling me I can do that
except from this what's coming up next
now the next Target in front of us is
that hey you have this great good we
appreciate that but now we want this new
value to be updated here as well now
this brings something to your mind that
hey how does this work because
technically if we are updating this
variable this should be updated here as
well and here as well and here as well
why is it not working because I'm pretty
sure on 100% that the value is getting
updated I'm seeing this and I can add
the value 19 but this is not getting
updated here and this is my friends
where it comes to the react react this
is exactly where react comes into the
picture react is a library which
actually takes the control from you and
gives you that hey this is now the
mechanism of how you're going to update
your UI remember that is why we call
react as a react as a UI Library majorly
because it controls how you're going to
take care of the UI itself not your
JavaScript not how you're going to take
the data from the database but how
you're going to display the things on
the website and how things are going to
be getting updated and this is exactly
where react actually tells you that you
know what you cannot go ahead and just
update things like that I will provide
you a mechanism you're going to follow
that mechanism and by which you are
going to update everything and anything
that you want and exactly we have to
follow the things react came up with a
concept known as state and state is a
unique thing in the react which actually
simply just is getting constantly
monitored and any change in the state
reenders the UI on the web and this is
what the state is being designed for any
change in the state will reender the web
page that's it told you it's really
really simple so we cannot just go ahead
and say hey let counter equals to 15
there is a way how you do it in the
react and once you understand this way
once and that's it you will be able to
do it every single time we have we can
already see that in the v there is
already an import statement of user stat
user state from the react and this is
exactly the state that comes up now
let's just go ahead and say const and we
want to use this state so the way how
you say it is simply say use State and
the parenthesis I'll tell you later on
these are known as Hooks and how you can
design your own custom hooks as well yes
we'll be designing a full-fledged but
the whole idea is this is a method what
does this method returns to you and it's
pretty simple to extract value from it
it returns you something in the format
of array the first thing is actually the
variable whatever you want to call it
it's up to you and the second is a
method and there is no hard and fast
rule that you always should call it as
counter then set counter number then set
number it just is a Convention feel free
to call it as Superman and this one as
Spider-Man nobody's going to stop you
and your code is not going to go Bonkers
uh really basic now just introducing
this and saying it as counter by the way
I could have called this one as count or
I could have called this one as hes it
would have still worked again different
hes and set counter they are also linked
uh always remember the one thing that
the first value that you see here it's
actually a variable and the second value
that you you see here is a function yes
you can call it method as well I won't
harm you for for that I won't be failing
you in the interviews as well but hey
remember this is a variable this is a
method okay moving further just because
the name is counter I cannot just go
ahead and say counter equals + one this
is not going to work still I can save
this show you that hey this is all good
refresh it and all refresh good and I
can just say add value and now even this
thing is gone so what happened what just
happened how can this value actually go
away uh let's look at the code see the
error so it says Hey const variable and
stuff so what is happening what is
happening uh simply because this is a
const you might be thinking hey this is
a constant that's why it's not able to
add the value okay let's just go ahead
and try this if that works let and there
we go if I go back again and hit a
refresh I still don't see the numbers it
says hey that const error is gone now
even we don't have any error uh so the
problem is not with the let or const you
can still keep it const because every
time you update the value a new state is
given to you okay uh how do I update
this whole thing so this whole thing
updation is pretty simple all you do in
this one is just whatever you want to
update you update it via the method so
once you have the method for example I
remove everything from here in the add
value you call this method set counter
this set counter method is responsible
for updating its nearby or I know nearby
is not a good word but in the array
there is only one nearby which is a
counter so it's it's brother the brother
is a good word it's brother here and how
do you do that you just pass the updated
value so in this case I can just go
ahead and say Hey I want to say counter
and I want to add one to it okay you
just do that now what happens when I do
this if I go back and hit a refresh now
notice here it says uh react the counter
value is gone nothing nothing if I go
ahead and say add value it says None why
is that because there is one more
portion of the thing which you need to
learn notice here the user state right
now has these parenthesis these
parentheses Define what should be the
initial value because it's a variable
you are defining a variable something
needs to go into it so obviously when
there's nothing so it's undefined and
undefined you add one to it you don't
get the desired result so you can start
it with the zero or in this case we
started our variable with 15 it's up to
you whatever you want to start I'll
start with 15 and now I see the 15 again
here Again by the way in case just for
the info it doesn't need to be variable
like con like numbers here you can just
go ahead start with true you can start
with nmt array a field array an object
you can even put methods into it which
is not a good idea but hey you can
nobody's stopping you from that I'll
start with 15 okay now things look are
looking like a little bit better I can
see react course with hes 15 15 15
everywhere and if I even add value to it
it gets updated here so goal achieved so
we have learned here that there is a way
there is a mechanism there is a flow of
data that react is controlling and what
we can appreciate here is I can just
click on one button and it updates the
value all at all the three places I
don't have to worry at all so that is
what your state is there is only a
single source of Truth there is a single
state and everybody is Consulting and is
looking forward to this state only
that's why everybody gets updated and
hence react solved the problem of the
ghost messages in uh the Facebook yeah
that that is it this is the whole gist
of it but this actually although the
next portion of this section I usually
uh first let's cover up let's cover up
the decrease value part as well because
there's a button here as well so it
would be fun uh to actually go ahead and
work on with it so I'll just say click
and I'll say hey there will be a new
method which will be remove a value and
that need to be a method as well and by
the way you can use the classic
functions as well and this will be
remove value which will be in our case
and arrow functions so there we go and
we can use the same state so same method
because I cannot just go ahead and say
counter plus one or minus one this
method will be responsible for having
this uh by the way you can also do
something like this hey counter uh is
going to be equal to counter minus one
oops counter minus one uh inconsistency
and then I can go ahead and pass up the
updated value of counter you can name
this one as uh new counter as well and
you can pass on that as well uh no big
deal just style of writing the code and
we can just go ahead and say counter
minus one the reason for writing this is
because there's something interesting I
want to show you I go back and I say
remove value it removes the value at all
places it adds the value so there's this
great now this next portion of uh the
video I usually go ahead and take this
as kind of exercise for interviews and
stuff but I'll just throw it away okay I
go ahead and duplicate this line a
couple of times what do you think is the
expected output here uh this is a
classic interview react question uh
which says hey now since it is getting
started on 15 I'm running the function
add value so it should be after 15 it
should be 16 17 18 and 19 but when you
actually go ahead and see add value it
just adds 16 and 17 and 18 uh this is uh
something which has to do with the
concept of batching react doesn't
actually uh send the things immediately
when you actually perform an action or
state it actually bundles everything
together we'll go through into the
algorithm behind this uh known as
reconciliation how that's being done but
these are fancy words we'll throw them
around a little bit later uh so what
react is doing it's actually taking all
this batch and it's seeing that hey
there's only one method you're firing up
and it has just one operation to be done
as counter which is increaing so this
batching actually gives you a problem if
you want to avoid the batching that hey
this is not the exactly same value I'm
taking and I'm updating one because this
is right now just the same value you are
taking it uh there is a way how you can
actually avoid that or actually maybe
this is the this is the situation you
want to do that I want to click it I
want to update just four to it but
instead of adding four to it I want to
do it iteration and there will be
situations not exactly like this but
there will be situation in that case
what you can do is there is a call back
given to you in this uh method so since
this is a method this actually accepts a
call back and this is how your call back
looks like and in this you automatically
get the access of the previous counter
so I'll just for the understanding
purpose I'll call this one as previous
counter and now either you can return it
or if if it's just one liner you can
just go ahead and say hey now my prev
counter will add a value of one to it
yeah this is now a game changer because
now since you're using a call back that
means there is a guarantee the call back
needs to finish your state will be
returning the values and whatever you
call it here prev counter counter
doesn't really matter it's just a call
back here you just get the access of the
updated State value that is it so I can
literally go ahead and copy this and I
can just have a multiple cursors here I
can just go back here and paste it now
you have just changed how things will be
now these cannot be batched because they
are dependent on the previous value so
you have to extract the previous value
now if I go ahead and add the value
notice here now they are jumping up in
the ratio in the update steps of four so
this is really sometimes is given to you
sometimes interor say just create a a
counter for me you do that quickly and
he does some something like this or
something tricky sneaky like that and if
you don't know the foundation of the
react you obviously will get into the
trouble but not after watching my video
for sure so go ahead and try to uh get
the similar situation and scenario in
this one and I am pretty sure that now
at this point of time you truly truly
understand that why we have state what
advantage State gives us and do is there
any real world use case of the state or
not are we just learning it for the
stuff of for the sake of fanciness no
it's not we are actually learning it
because it's important for us so now
that you understand State told you it's
not really uh difficult when you're with
me react is just a breeze let's go ahead
and move on to the next video where I'll
walk you through with another project
another fun another concept so again uh
just go ahead if you're watching it on
my channel itself uh go ahead and share
this video and the comments uh one just
hurt or like uh motivates me a lot so
let's catch up in the next
video this is a theoretical video and I
know a lot of people don't like
theoretical videos but this is an
essential part part of understanding the
react and to explore things on your own
so I'm pretty sure those who really
appreciate the under the hood working of
the things and they want to really go in
the engineering side of thing they will
appreciate it uh those who just want to
learn superficially H they will not
appreciate so the target for this video
is just 200 comments I'm pretty sure you
will help me in achieving a confidence
as well as engagement uh that yes we are
actually watching the videos you are not
just literally talking to camera in a
old room uh we are actually with you
learn learning together so if you have
any issues by the way just look at uh
post it in the comment section I'm
pretty active there all right so in this
video I'll walk you through with a few
concepts of virtual Dom
reconciliation uh bunch of fiber and all
those stuffs before that let me set the
stage for you so the idea behind the
react is pretty simple that once you
actually are in the JavaScript you
always have to go get element by ID and
what not and whenever there is any
change what your browser does it
actually reenders the entire page so
your painting of the page is entirely
being repainted uh your Dom cssom
everything is reconstructed this is a
painful process especially for the large
scale application what react does behind
the scene it actually creates its own
virtual mimic of the Dom so however the
Dom looks like it actually tries to
mimic it all those nodes everything and
whenever there's a slight change in the
in the node it actually then tries to
compare with the original Dom and only
the thing which needs an update it just
gives an update of that
so it's really a great remarkable
thing of how things are done in the
react but this mimicking of the virtual
Dom of the real Dom this mimicking part
is known as virtual Dom but how good it
is and how good it is right now that can
be understood by the latest version of
the react so a lot of things okay by the
way uh before we get started let me
share the screen so by the way this is
the Facebook GitHub repository and this
is where they have the react so by the
way you can go into the Facebook of
course there uh pinned repositories
react obviously what else it would be uh
you can go into the react and then you
can actually go into the packages and
see everything which is there listed in
the react I'll just move it a little bit
here uh so that you can see it nicely
and I'll actually Zoom this a tiny bit
so that you can see what's happening and
where it is happening so on the left
hand side you'll see that there's so
much that is given to even your react
Dom is here and if you'll click on this
uh you'll be actually taken into the
source by the way I'll just zoom out a
little bit yeah now it's better so you
can go into this one where is where we
are here is the react Dom and inside the
source I can check out that let's just
say I want to study the client side how
does the react behave uh there's a Dom
Legacy which we don't want to use react
root how does it work react Dom how does
it work so you can just go ahead even if
you don't understand much you will get
introduced to the new terminologies like
there is a container there is something
known as hydrate root options there is a
create root options and maybe eventually
as you'll go through you will understand
a lot of this code and this is how
people contribute in the open source as
well which I am very active in the
community so hydrate root and all these
things or at least you can ask chat GPT
like what these are I want to understand
them okay uh moving on let me just get
this a little bit uh don't want to go
like
this okay let's go back onto the source
okay I want it not to be like this okay
not like that I wanted the entire full
view yeah there we go a little difficult
so I'll probably move my entire thing
here so that's actually better invisible
it's it's really small but um videos are
in 4k by the way you can change it okay
one more package I would like to
introduce you a little bit not too much
is react core package so this is the
react core you can expand this and see
there's a source expand this and this is
where you can find a lot of things how
does the react work how does the cach
works childrens's and whatnot and even
there are some of the things things like
Hooks and stuff that you can find like
react hooks we talk about that and here
you can actually see that how does a
hook work so whenever it says uh
something like use State you'll find
that you'll find that I'll show you
there is a use context here and uh there
will be uh use
context and then there is a use effect
hook here there's a use ref here uh use
insertion effect probably you have never
heard about it use layout effect call
back use memo we'll use some of them so
as you can see there is almost every
hook we'll be also using use ID once in
the entire Series so as you got you got
the idea that there is everything
written here probably right now we don't
understand it but it's a good idea to at
least see that okay things exist there
uh I'm not the only one uh who's just
mimicking here things stuff also you can
go into the GSX the things which we
studied in the GSX actually comes from
here this part here in the GSX element
if you go into this one you'll see that
everything which I talked about actually
comes from here so if you scroll a
little bit you'll find that here are all
the things so let me Zoom this so when I
say the react element to you this
element actually takes these parameters
of type key ref and props uh all of
these things so I was not making up
things in the thin air they actually do
exist all right so this is the first
portion of the theory that I wanted to
introduce you a little bit with the uh
core react itself uh how does that looks
like so I'll just go on to the 100% back
again but there is one more thing if
you'll search for the the react fiber on
the Google this is usually for me is the
first one here uh because I don't think
so I have actually recommended in any
boot camp uh anything more than this uh
so this is a big shout out to uh uh
acadly I don't know how to spell it but
he wrote it so well that I don't even
want to Fork it or something and this is
so long it's seven years ago I'm still
using this this was constantly updated
obviously uh but here's something so
this is the portion where we dive into
the react architecture how does it work
so it's a react fiber previously not
previously but yeah react core algorithm
got changed and this is the whole study
we'll be doing uh some of the things
it's really important that you pay
attention onto this one so I'll just go
through with that I'll Zoom it even a
tiny bit more yeah tiny bit more now
it's much more understandable let's go
up here so all it says is the react
fiber is an ongoing implementation of
react scoree algorithm uh spoiler alert
it's not an ongoing uh it it was already
introduced in couple of version ago uh
but you saw it first time uh again the
goal of the react fiber is to increase
the suitability for area like animation
so what's the problem with animation
animation happens back to back and we
saw it just there in the user state that
it's not possible for us to do back
toback updates you react uses something
known as batching and once the batch is
gone it's gone I cannot do anything in
the core algorithm but now we can see
its headline feature is incremental
rendering so animations smooth
animations uh the ability to split the
rendering work into chunks and spread it
out over multiple frames so it's not
like uh previously react used to just do
things instantaneously but now they
actually wait for algorithm time by the
term algorithm time I mean uh they
actually decided for our c that I'm not
going to do update right now I'll send
the batch eventually to do multiple
updates at the same time so it gives us
the ability to pause abort and reuse the
work as new updates come in or not to
just give that so it's a concurrency uh
primitive so this is best here okay this
is the first part uh this is the
introduction of why the core algorithm
got changed now fiber introduces several
novel concept we will talk about them
some of them I'll give you a brief
overview of that uh but again this is
again big shout out to the this one so
for this uh you need to have a basic
understanding of the react which you
have now you have seen the videos so it
says uh react core components element
instances we have seen that already
reconciliation this is something really
nice but they cover it in this
documentation itself so I'll walk you
through with that react basic Theory
concept and react design principle uh so
I'll I'll walk you through with that so
first of all what is reconciliation
being asked in interview quite a lot the
algorithm react uses to diff one tree
with another and by the term diff one
tree with another means original Dom my
virtual Dom are they same and if this
Dom gets updated is this Dom is
following the principle so that's your
diffing algorithm known as if one tree
with so we are comparing two trees of
the node list uh to determine which part
needs to be changed yeah literally what
I just said uh so update a change in the
data used to render a react app uh
usually the result of set State
eventually uh results are in render so
as it says if you want to reender the
app usually it's the set state which
governs the thing uh so that's why we
use use State because ultimately the
method which actually does all of this
is use State we just saw that the
central idea of the react API is to
think of the updates as they cause to
app rerender so whole picture is all
about rendering so how can we get into
from state of a to B then B to C and C
to a and so on so how can we move into
different transition of all of that okay
uh actually rendering the entire app on
each change only works for the most
trivial apps in real world apps it's uh
so again uh we can actually skip this
part because it's all it's saying is we
don't want to render the entire app we
want the performance we want to cost to
be coming up and that whole this process
is known as Recon ilation so it's kind
of a a rewalk through of the Recon I
have gone through with this one probably
20 30 times so I know every inch of it
so so sorry if I'm jumping something
some places around okay so by the way
this whole thing is again reconciliation
and different things uh reconciliation
versus rendering uh so again this is an
interesting paragraph the Dom is just
one of the rendering environment react
can render to the other major Target
being a native IOS and Android I told
you in the earlier as well that react is
one implementation on the web is known
as react Dom but more thing exist like
react native and react for 3D renderings
so stuff like that the reason it can
support so many Target because react is
designed so that reconciliation and
renderings are separate phases uh so
yeah that is why I hope now if anybody's
ask you I think you have great
information here okay moving on uh now
what we have is we don't want to go into
the react design principles and key
points uh here is where we want to study
more what is fiber uh we are about to
discuss the heart of react fibers
architecture fibers are much uh lower
level abstraction than application
development typically think about it uh
if you find yourself frustrated in your
attempts to understand it don't feel
discouraged so if this best article on
the internet says discouraged uh don't
you don't need to fail that I also
understood it after going repetition and
repetition after it keep trying it
eventually makes sense yeah same
happened with me okay here we go so here
are the key points I'll just give you a
brief summary of it and then that's it
we'll call it a day uh pause work and
come back later to it so one of the
advantage of this is uh sometimes you
are back toback firing the updates so
sometimes let's just say you updated A
to B and same variable to C there was no
point of updating it to B because
eventually it just supposed to become
the C so if you pause your work come
back here without updating it probably
we can sa save some of our time in
updating it to B we can directly update
it to C so that's what it says pause
your work and come back to it later so
uh yeah literally uh assign priorities
to different type of works so we can
just say that hey uh maybe this
animation is going on but this button
also needs an update but this button
might take few micro milliseconds later
on as well but this animation needs to
be constantly re-rendering so that's why
it says we can assign priorities to
different Works uh reuse the previously
completed works so we can actually take
States and stuff like that abort work if
no longer needed so again example if a
gets converted to B and B finally gets
converted to back into a within
fractions of second then there's no
point of updating it to the user user
don't want to see that user want to see
the ultimate truth so there is no point
of showing him the state if you want to
do so uh so again now it comes up is uh
structure of the fiber fiber always
treat them like fiber just like your
muscles have fibers everything is
attached to each other that's like the
fiber everything is getting controlled
and stuff like that U it's almost like
everything is in the fiber is term in
the world of react okay uh it uh further
goes into the return statement how it
does and all of that you don't want to
go into that uh future section you can
just try that but again there's no need
of it if you want to watch uh you can
just watch this one 2016 pretty old uh
but again this is whole thing uh which I
wanted to share I know this is little
bit probably boring part of the entire
series but these are some foundational
algorithm which I wanted you to learn
from the direct resources and repository
of react not from me not from anybody
else just go dive into that so at least
you are not afraid of that one okay a
few things we now know reconciliation we
now know a lot about the react uh
virtual Dom we also know a lot about the
react fiber and we also know a lot about
the batching of the update and all these
things these will be foundational and
very helpful when you'll be learning
nextjs as well on which I also have a
course happen to be I'm producing a lot
of them uh so I think now you have a
core foundational understanding of it
and later on we'll definitely talk more
about these documentation but I think
that is enough that is enough for you in
the next video we'll jump into the code
part and the course part itself and
you'll learn more on that that okay
that's it for this video and let's catch
up in the next
one hey there folks how are you doing I
am pretty sure you're doing good hey
there everyone my name is hes and let's
go ahead and get started and continue
with our react Series so we have done
with the we done already with a couple
of topics and especially the response
that you have given me on the videos
like State what is a state how does we
work it and some topics that we
discussed about like virtual da
reconciliation fiber pretty interesting
topic little bit theoretical but very
important and interesting one in this
video we'll take down one another such
topic uh which I always begin with why
do you need it you don't need it at the
very first place until unless you
understand the possible need of the
subject then only you should learn so
that's the props for us and we'll go
through and understand that apart from
that there is kind of industry Trend
these days to use something known as
Tailwind CSS uh this is not going to be
a dedicated class about the Tailwind CSS
but still we need to learn to configure
it with the react so that we can utilize
it and it's not really that heavy it's
uh quite understandable and we will be
doing that on the go as well so without
a further Ado let's go ahead and get
started and let's understand what is the
need of the prop and why the props are
there uh by the way we will also learn a
little bit about components and building
components in the react in this video
and let me just announce this first that
components are no proprietary of the
react itself they used to exist in other
programming languages like PHP long
before when react came into the picture
so it's not something which is new to
react or new to the industry it's a very
common thing we used to divide uh the
the chunks of the web like headers and
Footers into separate file a common
practice being done in the PHP and other
programming languages as well same we
are going to learn how we do that in the
react it will make your life a little
bit easier as a web developer uh things
are just at one place you make a change
at one place it propagates to every
single page it's pretty easy life is
easy with that so let's go ahead and let
me first uh share the screen and we'll
go through with that so this is uh our
application we have been working on this
one uh so we will be now creating our
third is app actually the third one
itself so uh we'll be just going through
with the third so let me just go ahead
and open up the terminal and we'll be
going with the same npm I know a lot of
you want to go with the bun we don't
have bun as as of now I do have it on my
system but I won't be using them uh so
we'll be saying just simply create atate
vat sorry vat at the rate latest uh so
this gives us a v project and we'll be
naming our project as uh 03 because it's
a third pro project and we'll be calling
it as tailwind and we also are going to
be using props Tailwind props components
yeah I think that's a good name uh we'll
be using react for this we'll be going
with JavaScript I know you want me to
switch into typescript but no I want
this videos the entire series to be Mass
reachable more and more people should be
able to learn it without the hindrance
of additional typescript yes I do have a
typescript series and playlist on my
channel uh but this time we're going
just with a JavaScript probably at the
end of the series I'll introduce you
briefly with the typescript as well all
right so let's go into this one and it's
03 and let's go ahead and run npm
install uh that's the basic of how you
get started with this one
okay uh by the time we get started the
first thing that we are going to take
down is how we can actually install and
configure Tailwind CSS uh there is a
process to it and we all need to learn
that so first of all let's go ahead and
work with Tailwind css.com this is the
official website and every single time
I'll need to configure the Tailwind CSS
I always go with the docs you should
also go with the docs this is how we
actually learn and install it so in the
docs there is a section here in the
installation so there's a tailent CSS
CLI
post CSS we actually are going to be
working with framework guides uh yes you
can say react is a library but this is
how it is being mentioned uh we are
working with the v in case you are
working with CRA create react app
there's a guidance for that and almost
similar looking guidance we'll be going
with the V we don't need to work with
these first two steps because we are
already done with that uh we'll be going
with the Second Step so go ahead and
copy this these are the two commands
that we need to work through so let's
just go ahead and clean this make sure
you do an LS uh the most important thing
is you should be in the same folder
where this package.json file is so make
sure you take care of that I'm pretty
sure you will uh go ahead and paste the
commands uh this command will install
couple of Dev dependencies the DHD is
for development dependencies they don't
get shipped to the production itself
most interestingly it creates a file
known as Tailwind config.js this is your
Tailwind configuration because Tailwind
is kind of a pre-processor you can say
uh because whatever the Tailwind you
write it actually generates that CSS on
the go not everything is being shipped
only the CSS that you need is generated
and for that generation you need to
actually Define it that where should I
find my content so the next step is
actually go ahead and find and Define
where my content is so in the v the
content is actually index.html and your
some Source folder so everything uh
components every file app.js everything
will be inside the source so this line
actually is a Rex regular expression to
find all the files that's related to
JavaScript or typescript jsx or TSX and
also we are also listing our index.html
so go ahead and copy this entire content
thing go back up here and we want to
replace it uh make sure you take care of
the additional comma at the end usually
this is a common mistake which a lot of
programmers in the initial days while
learning the react they do this uh
things are not done yet we also need to
mention that hey in the index.css file
we'll be using this as directives uh
these directives are must to have
without this things don't work so go
back inside the source this is where my
index. CSS file is there now there are
two options in front of you you can just
keep everything there and just paste it
at the top or you can remove everything
and just keep it up here but in case you
have some additional CSS which usually
you will not have uh you can go ahead
and write them still it is not going to
bother you but you still have all of
this so that's it these are the two
steps three steps technically uh this
command uh the tail config and this
thing and after that it's all npm run
death so that is all what we have now
let's go ahead and try to run it first
so that we can see are we good or not
npm runev and we just run it hopefully
it looks good and right now we have no
idea is it working or not so uh what we
can do is let's go into app.
GSX and minimize the things which we
don't need let's just remove everything
and go ahead and grab an ah1 uh which
says
wheat with
Tailwind Tailwind there we go in the H1
we'll be using a class name which is a
keyword since we are in the JavaScript
world or JavaScript Paradigm we cannot
use the word class itself it's a
reserved keyword for the JavaScript so
we use class name only handful of the
thing in the HTML are changed like uh
there is also an HTML
4 uh HTML 4 which is also changed uh in
the other input field especially you'll
find that so if there is an input field
it's usually in the label actually so in
the label you'll see the HTML 4 so in
the regular HTML we just write it four
uh but again four is a reserved keyword
so only a handful of places are there
where you have these kinds of things
otherwise it's not so let's just say we
want to have it so we can have the text
Dash uh 3XL suggestions 3XL by the way
these suggestions comes from a plugin
which I have installed in my VSS code
known as is a Tailwind intellisense yep
and we'll go with the BG green and we'll
go with this one and we'll add a padding
of three maybe just for fun if I go back
all these things are here that means hey
everything is looking good by the way
there are some fun classes as well like
I can go rounded MD it looks good so
this is our basic Tailwind uh
configuration so Step One is done now we
are almost a master of uh configuring
the Tailwind in our application that's
that's the basic that we have uh Next
Step let's go ahead and understand the
things about the props do we need a prop
right now we don't need any prop now one
thing to understand here is that this is
a function so if this is a function and
this whole function is imported in the
main.js uh x main.js x can I write more
such function and in those function can
I return some GSX which we have already
studied quite a lot during our custom
preparation of the react can I go ahead
and do this kind of a thing I don't know
let's try it uh I'll create a new folder
uh you don't need to create a folder I'm
just organizing the things better I'll
just call this one as components and
inside the components let's create a new
file and call this one as uh card and of
course since this will be returning some
jsx I'll be calling it as obviously doj
jsx now there's a shortcut that you can
use if you have installed the react or
not react there are some intellisense
plugins available as well so there is
some let me just show you so there is
some plugin known as react Snippets yeah
this is the one that I have so you can
actually go ahead and install this this
makes life a little bit easier once you
have installed this one what this will
allow you to do is you can type things
like RFC which will give you a react
functional component you can go ahead
and say react a r afce uh for example I
can go ahead and say r a c which gives
me a react Arrow function component I
can go ahead and say RFC which gives me
a react functional component so
whichever the one you like you can go
ahead go with that now uh what I'll do
inside this uh since I know there is a
div here I'll go ahead and say that Hey
I what I want to know is uh let's just
say I'll import an image here and I'll
give you a source as well in a minute
I'll also give you an H1 uh in the H1
I'll just say this is going to have a
some class uh text D D
2XL and we'll be having a BG D
green uh this one padding of three maybe
rounded rounded and this will
say a card for photos I don't know and
we'll also have some paragraph with a LM
of 10 words I I don't know this this is
my card that we have uh let's give it an
image source as well I'll obviously pick
from some of my images that I donated to
pixels I think this one looks good I'll
just right click copy image address go
back and just paste it up there now I
have this image and this is looking good
but this is a function there's nothing
more to it and again don't ever
overestimate react it's just JavaScript
always think it from the JavaScript
perspective uh now we have this card can
I import this card in app.jsx or main.
jsx even yes you can import it wherever
you like
uh let's go ahead and say that I want to
import a card and that card will come
from do/ component uh so I'm going into
one directory and then I have this card
you don't need to write this like card.
jsx it's Auto imported so you can just
avoid that how can we use it just like
we used app so it's going to be simply
like card and a self-closing one just
like that that's it now let's see uh if
it works so we'll go up here and we see
that okay uh we have this this is a
pretty big card uh but there's nothing
which is stopping us it's looking pretty
nice and we have this one all right so
we have this card now let's go back onto
the tailwind and see if what they can
offer us on the homepage so on the
homepage also they are offering us some
of this card and let's go ahead and copy
this entirety and see if we can actually
somebody what happens if somebody gives
us the components like this uh I'll just
go ahead and replace my card with this
card and obviously you can see there are
a lot of places where things are going
wrong and whatnot so let's just figure
out so this is a common mistake or
common error that you will also be
facing so let's not uh run away from
them instead let's deal with them so
first one it says Hey figure so what is
this problem it says figure has no
corresponding closing tag another GSX
requirement that if something is getting
started it needs to close as well uh so
notice here this is where the figure is
ending so what's the issue uh you can
see that at some of the places uh this
needs to close so that now it goes now
you can see some of the errors are gone
just with that it's not always about hey
figure was missing or something like
that but we can see things are going not
that great in this case so for example
we have some of the errors here as well
why these errors are here uh it should
be all supported like this uh yes the
reason for them is let me go ahead and
hit command Z couple of times uh we were
supposed to enter this all here but if I
go ahead and copy this you can see it's
not properly being written or it's not
properly being organized so I need to
actually grab it properly right click
and copy this uh but again you will face
some of the issues with this because
things are not great things are not
great at this moment so let's just paste
this and probably this time they have
come back in a better situation but the
issue is I have this a lot of Errors so
I'll first indent this because this is
bothering me a little bit so
okay now uh these things these curly
braces and uh these closing brackets
they are good but the problem is that
first of all our image is having no
ending tag when the image is not having
any ending tag you can actually provide
a self-closing tag that will remove at
least one of the error now let's see
what's the other error the other error
is uh we have these quotes inside it
which is obviously giving us these
commas and errors uh intellisense is
helping me to figure this out and I'll
have a lot of 10 words maybe something
like this this will work better and now
we can see some of the errors are gone
okay some of the errors are gone but I'm
pretty sure the image is not going to
work why so uh because the source the
source of the image I don't have it
easiest way is to fix it just stay calm
and fix the stuff that's how the
programming Works let's say copy image
address go back and we'll just replace
this whole image with this okay now that
our designer has given us a better card
by Design designing that this is looking
good and since it's a Tailwind it should
be optimized as well decently optimized
not the best uh but okay now I
understand that yes this is a common
thing which I can say that hey
eventually I can keep all of my
components separate like this for
example header could be its own own file
navigation menu could be in its own file
footer could be in its own file and can
be rendered on every single page and if
I have to make any change I can go ahead
and make a change in one place and
that's it it will serve at every single
page now this is exactly known as
component building and there's a word
for it we call it as Dum component yeah
very rude uh but we call it as dumb
component the reason being this
component doesn't take any parameter
it's not modifiable it just works like
this so how can we make it a little bit
more intelligent of a component now
couple of ways how you can do it the
first way is that hey I want to pass on
some text uh for example in our card as
we can see uh this is the name of a
person and then the post maybe software
engineer staff engineer so these things
probably I want to assign that hey maybe
multiple cards should be there and I
want to pass on this argument right now
there is nothing which is stopping me to
actually display this card because I've
imported that I can display two times
three times however I like but the
information is exactly same so the first
step actually is whenever you want to
make a card to accept any parameter is
go up here and accept it the way how we
accept it actually with every single of
these component there is a react magic
that goes on onto it which is known as
props now what does prop is doing right
now if I go ahead and hit a Reload
there's nothing inside it it even broke
my application so if I go ahead and
check out the console it says uh props
is not defined okay so if the prop is
not defined how the things are going to
go ahead and work notice here props is
not defined everywhere and you are
saying that react actually gives me a
prop like this uh yes react actually
gives you a prop like this uh but why I
cannot even access this you cannot
access this because first you have to
actually accept that there is a props uh
once I go ahead and save it back you can
see at least our application is loading
if I go ahead and hit a Reload uh but I
can see all empty yes it should be empty
and by the way there is a class eror let
me just fix that uh the class should
be and let me just go ahead and do
command D to find all the instances of
this so that I can actually rename
this okay so this would be class name
okay now it should be all happy yeah
hopefully and let's hit a Reload there
we go at least that error is gone okay
so we can see that now there is nothing
inside this there is this uh square
bracket square bracket prop prototype
which is again a hidden scope we won't
talk about this this is not a JavaScript
class but I can see at least that okay
uh so far we are correct that at least
in the card there is something which is
known as props and I can console log
this okay so far good but how can I use
this props we just saw that this is an
object so if it is an object we can add
value to it all right that's good so how
can I add value to it wherever you are
calling this card go ahead and pass on
value for example I'll just call this
one as a username and the value of
username is here he is going to be hes
okay now how can I utilize this
everything that you pass here in this
format it's actually a key value thing
key and value so you can actually have
this props here and now I can change the
name here I can inject my JavaScript
just like this and I can say props since
this was an object and I can go ahead
and say do username and this technically
will render my name so I can see that uh
this is hes now rest of all the things
they are gone because they never passed
me anything but this is an issue what
happens if the user doesn't pass on this
props uh common case so in this case
what we can do is we can actually just
provide some default value if the value
doesn't exist use this valuee one more
thing if I'm going to pass you these
values like prop. username prop do uh
your post whatever that is every time
you have to say prop dot prop dot so one
common thing that you're going to see is
just destructuring this object directly
and whatever the field you need you just
simply go ahead and say Hey I want to
extract username out of it or whatever
you want in this case you don't have to
say props like this and everything still
works now there's a good thing that if
uh this value is not available uh then
there are a couple of ways actually you
can uh go ahead and work on with this
for example uh I can go ahead and say
username or if username is not there go
ahead and print hes uh so it works uh
but there's a problem there's a problem
with this case uh this is not scalable
the reason why how many times your other
fellow coders are going to come and look
into this much of the pieces of the code
and will'll say hey this is where you
have used the conditional this works a
lot of people use that I've seen that in
the production code even but not a good
approach so technically it is correct
but it's not scalable solution so the
better approach could be that hey you
should actually give some values here as
well like hes so or maybe h
or I'll just use an H oops command Z
couple of time I'll just go ahead and
say instead of this HC just like that
save
this and now if I go back notice here it
says HC so the logic is still same the
so if you'll give me the value which you
have given me here uh I'll use that
value if you are not going to give me
any value in any component call I'll
just use this default value so this is a
far more better approach because at the
very start of the function you get all
the usernames and what the values you
want to extract and you can work on with
that similarly we can just put a comma
separated values I can just say post and
I can just simply say equals and then
instead of Staff engineer we'll be using
something else uh not assigned yet uh so
we can see that uh right now it says
still because we haven't used it so in
here I can just go ahead and enable my
JavaScript and I can just go ahead and
say uh I don't have to say uh props dot
I can just directly say post so there we
go now it says not assigned yet not
assigned yet so every single time you
call any component or a piece of code
you can just go ahead and provide hey I
want to make it more reusable this time
it was ites this time it's going to be
uh Jason and then I want to also provide
a post which is an optional parameter by
the way there's no comma here uh post
and the post value is going to be
stuff stuff and engineer so just like
that and we can see that this changes a
lot of stuff so instead of making a dumb
component we can go ahead and make it
much more smarter similarly you can go
ahead and provide a URL of the image
here as well and instead of getting this
whole big thing you can just go ahead
and make it as an optional that hey this
is optional and you can inject your
JavaScript just same curly braces add a
string and that is it uh that's your
assignment uh by the way a really easy
one go ahead and make this component a
little bit better so that you can make
it more
reusable uh but one more thing will I
always be passing a strings like that
can't I just pass something more uh
something like hey in this first card I
want to provide an array so I'll just go
ahead and say my error and that is going
to be an array like this and that's
going to be 1 2 3 4 we can see obviously
that's an error that's an error the
reason for this error is if you have
studied my jsx uh chapter in this entire
Series this whole thing will be taken up
as it is and will be placed in the jsx
line L by line passing of it so this is
obviously not a great idea yes you can
pass arrays you can pass on objects but
there is a way of doing that and that is
where you have to inject your JavaScript
in here and that's how you pass it and
one of the better way even actually to
do this if you really want to pass on
something like this uh the best way is
to create an object uh first object
create a variable first that would be
better name uh so for example you go
ahead and pass on my object just like
this and in this we will have couple of
values oh that's too much of the values
I don't know how he came up with that
address I don't even Liv in this I'll
I'll just I live in the pink
City okay just for fun just for fun and
I'll just say new
array and some values into that so it's
always a better idea if you want to pass
on any values or like this go ahead and
pass on this variable that's usually a
better approach so I can just go ahead
and say new array and oops my bad my bad
in syntax there we go now I can go ahead
and say new array this is a far more
better approach than just writing the
things so if you want to pass on
anything uh your arrays object strings
anything else maybe you have called some
values from the database you want to
pass it on as it is you can go ahead and
do that uh maybe you want to pass on
each of these element you can spread
these values and can pass on but it's up
to you that how you are accepting these
values here as well that is the most
important thing here we are expecting
that they will be an object having a
string into that so optional string if
you expect that the values will be
spreaded array go ahead and handle and
deal it with that way that is the most
important thing and that is why you need
props uh so in this video now we have
learned so let me just summarize this
first of all we G we gone through with
the we went through with the Tailwind
configuration absolute basic nothing to
be worried about we just gone went
through with a step-by-step instruction
from the documentation then we studied a
little bit about why props are necessary
uh by the way this whole thing this
username hes this is the prop that is it
it's a short form for properties and the
reason why we call this one here as a
props that is again a short form for
properties we saw in the console log
there is a object yeah that object is
called as property and that's why hence
the short name of props so coming back
so we studied about how we can make dumb
components component is like uh
shortening D your code and make it more
modularize so that you can have indiv
ual control on each component like cards
eventually we can Loop through the cards
generate hundreds of cards a navigation
bar Footers and all of this so that we
can keep them separate this is how the
production code is being written on top
of that we studied a little bit how we
can actually grab the entire props or we
can destructure them at the very top and
if we are interested in destructuring
then it's much better we also studied
the concept that if you don't pass on
any default value what are the
consequences we also studied there is a
non-scalable approach that could be have
taken taken but you can improve your
codee with this scalable approach of
providing the default value up here
itself that is always a great idea uh
this is all this is all that you want to
study in this particular video about
props now you have a great idea about
what are the states why they are being
used you also have the idea about
modularizing your code using the props
we created a card component go ahead and
create another component like header or
footer or something and try this out
this is all this is all that we have uh
for this particular video if you're
enjoying this video it gives me an
immense boost in confidence if you leave
a comment drop down a comment any thank
note heart emoji whatever that is I'm
expecting at least 100 comments on this
video just to give me a moral boost
that's it uh let's go ahead and catch up
in next
video hey there everyone hes here back
again with another video and Welcome to
our react Series so we are on to our
react Journey going pretty good and now
is the time that we learned the things
on the go while building the
applications and of course we're going
to start with absolute Basics and let me
break this here a lot of time when I
bring this kind of application at the
start of the things people just say hey
T that's too basic that's too basic we
really don't want to build this one uh
show us something cool build an Amazon
clone or a Spotify clone or a Blog
application uh but the reality is that
if you directly jump into these
applications especially at this level
because somebody who's is learning react
has just gone through with JavaScript
trying their hands on some Front End
Library
this is where you can make a lot of
mistakes so please don't do that
building these kinds of smaller
application will get confidence in you
as well as you'll understand a lot of
workflow as we go through so let me show
you what we are about to build and then
I'll walk you through that how we are
going to actually build it uh we'll be
using a lot of Tailwind for this one so
this is how we are going to get started
so this is absolute basic this is how we
are going to get started at the bottom
we will have a few buttons of course we
will not focus too much on the Tailwind
side of it but still these are going to
be button and as you click on these
buttons they will actually change the
color so it will turn it into red uh
green and blue and then if you hit the
refresh it again comes back to the olm
so this is all that we are going to
build together uh we'll be using again
classic wheat for this we'll be using
Tailwind for this and just the basic
state management this will give you a
thorough confidence of how states are
being used and how you can actually
utilize them what are the impacts of
using the state and eventually gradually
we are going to level up the difficult
here I hope you're all excited we're
going to get started absolutely from
scratch so let's go up there so this is
my application let's go back onto this
one so this is how we are going to get
started we'll be creating our very
fourth app that we have right now uh so
let me go ahead and fire this up there
we go we need to close this again fire
this up and this will be our fourth app
so I'll be just saying uh npm create uh
vat and we'll be going with the latest I
think that's it's the best approach that
we can have and then it requires to name
this will be our fourth app technically
so we'll be saying 04 and this will be a
BG changer uh feel free to name it
something else if this doesn't suits to
you works great with me so I'll be just
using this one and package name is
exactly same for me I'll be using react
for this one I wish they could have
asked me for a library of CSS as well
but sadly they don't do again we'll be
going with classic JavaScript so that we
can have more people using this Library
so let's go on to 04 and there we go now
the first thing that I have to do is npm
install in case you are already on bun
you can go ahead and use bun install as
well uh no problem there it's usually a
comparatively fast install that we have
but by the time it does all of this
let's go back here and work on the
Tailwind CSS again classic go back to
docks it might look repetitive to you
but this repetion is necessary so that
you feel absolutely comfortable in doing
all these things I want this to be a
muscle memory in use so let's go back
and let's go ahead and clean this up and
paste these two things so that we can
have background changer and we get a new
file which file yep a configuration file
for Tailwind exactly this one a Tailwind
config in this we have to change some
configuration so we are using V so
that's why we'll mention that our index
file is actually outside I'll just
replace this and rest of the files will
be inside the source so this is exactly
for that after that we have to get the
decorators uh directives there are a lot
of Nam for that uh different language
depends on what language you're coming
up for and I'll be just changing that
into index. CSS just replace everything
we don't need much of the CSS just save
this and there we go just save this and
now technically you should be able to
run npm run Dev which hopefully we will
be so we'll be saying npm run Dev and
things should be up and running before
we go there let's go into app.jsx and
actually just clean the things so we'll
be saying hey let's clean this this
let's clean this uh from here to here
we'll be just putting up a simple
H1 and what we're going to write a BG
Changer app with wheat looks
good and we'll be having a simple class
name and that says we need a BG Das
green suggestions please I'll be using
500 variant of it and we'll be saying
text of 3 XL so we'll be saying
three XL
why is it not suggesting me yeah it is
suggesting me okay let's see if the
application is working or not let's go
up here and there we go I'm not really
the nicest coolest of the all but it is
what it is it is decently good that we
have okay going back now how we are
going to deal with this one uh nothing
too much let me just give you a brief
overview of how we are going to take
down this application main.js we are not
going to be taking it down because our
app is being served inside it so let's
just uh close this uh totally I'll close
everything okay then we'll go into
app.jsx this is the file which is
serving entirety of my content so in
fact all of my content is going to go
inside this for this I need to go ahead
and create a simple full page width
inside that at the bottom we'll be
creating few buttons it's not really
compulsory that you keep the buttons at
the bottom top left right it's totally
up to you uh but we need a full page of
the screen itself so let's go ahead and
do this uh what we're going to do is
remove all of this the easiest way of
doing this is to have a simple div we'll
be putting some content inside this but
first let me add a few classes these
classes comes from the Tailwind itself
uh first of all I want the WID to be
full so that's the shortcut for this one
H screen actually gives you a viewport
height screen if you hover your mouse
onto this one it says give me height of
100% viewport again this is not a series
about Tailwind but still want to give
you a brief overview of how things are
actually going ahead and we'll do it uh
we'll also go ahead ahead and add a
duration of this so that whenever
there's a change it actually does it
slowly now uh next thing uh we are going
to just keep it as it is uh this is how
the basic looks like now once we have
this I'll just not use these suggestions
here uh we'll be using a simple flexbox
class here so that we can have all these
buttons and everything so let's go ahead
and have a div inside this div let's
have a class name first of all we want
it to be fixed so that it's always fixed
from the bottom fixed there we go and
we'll be using a flex we'll be using a
flex
wrap flex-wrap there we go and again
justify Center and we will be fixing it
up from bottom so we can use a bottom of
uh how much you want to have it 12 maybe
13 totally depends on you uh no big deal
uh we'll be also using one of the
another property which gives you inser
as well and by the way you can provide
an inser on xaxis and y-axis again not a
class for CSS but we'll be going with
that you can just copy and paste uh
these ones so this is what we have as a
basic and now once we have this then we
can just go ahead and simply have uh
this suggestions we can actually go
ahead and take this one uh this gives us
nice suggestions for this there we go
now we'll not be using everything we
need Flex we definitely need a flex wrap
justify Center uh we'll be using some
Gap and some the shadows as well so let
me just go ahead and give you the CSS
directly again from my notes with be not
using a withd full and all of that again
it doesn't really matter what CSS and
anything you're using I'll be just using
a simple button and let's just say test
again if this UI doesn't make sense only
UI that should make sense for you is the
width should be full the height should
be screen and after that just add button
wherever you like let's go back and see
how does it looks like so we can see at
the bottom we have a button in fact what
we can do temporarily we can use a
background color of uh let's just say a
black so that you can properly see this
this is what the screen is right now uh
again we don't have a full width as of
now because our application is loading
only in this much we'll see and figure
out how we can actually manipulate that
uh not a big deal we can just change out
the things so we can see this is what we
have test is one button but if we add
more buttons uh we can just go ahead and
do this and these are the buttons that
we have uh we'll be manipulating these
button with a little bit more of these
glasses so just don't worry we'll be
getting through them as well all right
let me just remove this okay uh the
first thing that we have is oops uh in
the button is the class name you can add
more properties to this one but I do
have some uh button classes as well in
my notes so I'll be just directly giving
it to you all right you can just go
ahead and use them from the GitHub notes
we are using an outline none we are
giving some padding on x-axis padding on
y AIS rounded full text is white and the
shadow is large so this makes the button
looks like this obviously we don't have
any text colors and all of that so we'll
be providing them as as well uh no
worries this is right now text as white
by the way this was just to show you
that yeah something BG was there okay
now we have a button like this but our
text is missing so let's go ahead and
add a text what kind of text you want to
have I'll just saying text as black and
there we go a decent button that we have
oops text white text black no we want a
text black that will make
sense okay looking good already uh now
similarly we can have more buttons and
we can call this one as test
two two there we go okay so the
functionality is there now coming up on
to how does this actually work so we
have already learned about the
functionality I hope you remember that
the most important part of this
application is the functionality in the
functionality we have already seen that
if you want to render any changes in the
UI those changes cannot be directly
propagated we need to use some kind of
State Management for this and in the
react we have a hook for that known as
user State and this exactly uh this
exact project is actually based on that
so we'll be using that one uh let me
just walk you through with that it's
super super easy for using the state
just like we have a count here let's go
ahead and remove the count we want to
have some kind of a state management for
the color so I'll be using a const and
let's just say we'll be using a color
and that actually uses set color and we
use some user State and what color you
want to have in this one I'll be just
writing Olive as base one always
remember this first part in the array is
your variable the second part is a
method which is responsible for changing
this variable no other thing cannot
change this variable this is the guy
which is responsible for changing this
color whatever you put inside the U
States that's the default value now how
can I use this default value you can go
up here and can actually add this as a
property for example you can add your
own styling not the styling from the
Tailwind but actually a style property
just like this and by the way I need to
go outside of this string so there we go
we have this a style property inside
this I can go ahead and say I want a
background color and what should be the
background color value just like this
you can go ahead and say Hey I want to
have this uh olive color into this one
and that color will obviously get
propagated up here so all the way up
here uh why is it not going all the way
left and right I'll need to debug a
little bit we'll do that at the end of
it no big deal there uh we can just have
some manipulation there okay uh apart
from this now since this is Olive how
can I actually replace this string with
some variable it's pretty simple you're
already in the double curly braces all
you have to do is simply go ahead and
say color now I'm using now a state
variable and that's why we get a olive
here but if I go ahead and change it to
Red since the default value of the state
is red I get the red but I'm happy with
the olive as a default starting color
okay uh that part is good but now I need
to work on sub method uh by which I can
change this and again remember change
can only be done when you change this
color as a variable and this variable
can only be manipulated and changed by
this set color cool you get it this okay
uh so what can I do is on this button if
I know my JavaScript I can just go ahead
and add an event which is on click now
this on click uh is pretty nice it can
take a reference of a variable maybe you
are defining a method here which is
something like this function and change
color something like this and there we
go let's just assume this changed the
color you can go ahead and pass on a
reference of this change color now once
you pass on this reference this method
alone cannot work it needs some
parameter to be passed on for example if
you give it something like this let's
just say a parameter of color whatever
the color string you are passing me
inside in here I can go ahead and use
the set color which is a method to
change this color this is my ideal way
but again the problem is the change
color needs to pass this color as a
variable now right now I cannot just go
ahead and do like this because it will
immediately execute it and if you
remember your JavaScript onclick doesn't
change the value which is returned from
a function it needs a function itself
and this is not a react this is
Javascript in itself so there is no way
you can you can do this because this
will execute in whatever the return
value will go in on click on click
doesn't accept that you need to pass on
a function into this that's the only way
how you do do it so the another way of
handling this situation whenever you
have to pass on some parameter is just
go like this use a call back and then
you can actually use a change color
because now on click satisfies the
condition that hey I'm passing you a
call back which is also a method and on
the way I'm actually changing this color
so this will be going as a red so if I
go ahead and test this out this actually
changes that so that's really nice that
I can go ahead and work on with this one
uh by the way I'll change this to Red
this one to blue or green whatever you
like okay uh but the problem is I need
to actually do exactly same thing so I
can just go ahead and copy this and
paste it up here and there we go instead
of this let's go ahead and pass on this
green so technically this actually
solves my purpose that hey this is red
this is green and I can go ahead and
change these values I can add more
buttons uh but there could be a better
way of doing this this is no problem at
all you can also have a different take
on this one in this entire series I'll
walk you through with the different
perspective of the code so that you you
feel better where you see the other
people's code I'll just comment this out
uh we don't want this one what you can
do is if I know that this change color
is a method I need to call and pass on a
value I can actually do this with the
set color as well can I do this directly
Yes actually you can you can just
directly set the color into this color
because this is responsible for that so
instead of using the change color I can
just go ahead and use the set color and
pass on any parameter to this whatever
you pass on parameter into this whether
that's number string whatever that value
is the new updated value in this
variable and that variable automatically
is monitored by react to propagate the
changes that's cool so I don't need to
use this extra function that I Define I
can just go ahead and use uh the set
color of a method and this still works
so it saves me some time by not
declaring extra functions here a good
approach good approach uh so now I can
say red green it still works there is
still a bug in the application which
actually uh prevents me from going uh
all the way up here so really don't want
that uh so let me quickly go ahead and
fix this that how it is not going it's a
really minor CSS issue not much bothered
about
it all right so found it it was pretty
easy uh there was already a CSS which
was overwriting our CSS it was in the
app.css index we have already cleared in
the app.css so just go ahead and remove
everything if you don't need anything at
all and this actually flushes out
everything that we don't need so really
basic fix uh now we have a red button we
have a green button it changes the
things uh so this is really nice that
how we are actually able to do this uh
in couple of ways and again saying that
this is correct or this is much more
better it's just an opinion and I
respect your opinion as well in case you
want to go with further like hey no this
is my preference or something like that
now one last thing that we are going to
go ahead and work on with this one is uh
just let let's add some of the colors
onto this one because I think that's
also pretty good so let's just go ahead
and add a style to this
one and we'll be saying background color
and the background color that will be
using is going to be red yeah we can
actually hardcode this and we can see
this looks good text could be changed
but again not really bother too much and
we'll be hardcoding the value here as
well on the green again it's totally
your choice just visual aesthetic the
whole idea is to understand different
perspective of how the things are being
changed uh so your role is really simple
just add a few more colors maybe uh red
green blue orange red pink purple violet
and put up a a straight bar all you have
to do is copy paste the buttons and
again remember this is really important
part of the 9010 or 8010 teaching where
initially I'll be giving you small
assignments if if you'll think that hey
this is too easy I won't be doing that
you will be lagging behind eventually
for the bigger assignments so do this
assignment tag me on Twitter Instagram
LinkedIn whever you like if you don't
like that's okay too but at least do the
assignment this will help you in
improving your skills as well so uh that
is it that is it what we'll be doing
we'll be starting with absolute basic
this is the first project that we have
done uh let's take down another project
in the next
video all right it's been while uh yes
finally I'm back on this channel as well
hey there everyone H here back again
with another video and in this video we
will continue our series on reactjs I'll
walk you through and we'll be building
one project although at a first glance
this project might look absolute basic
there is nothing too much but I'll walk
you through with some scenarios some of
the experiences that I had and together
we'll be crafting this project like an
expert will do you will understand the
good practices bad practices of the
react and how even a smaller thing can
change the entire overview of how the
project should be built up so uh welcome
on board and I expect uh just a minimum
of 100 comments under the under this uh
video so that I can get some moral boost
that hey you are interested in this
series and I should focus more of my
attention here all right so first let me
share uh simple my screen and this is
the project that we'll be building up
and you might be thinking hey this this
is absolutely a simple beginner project
but trust me there can be a lot of
intricacies in this project and together
we can learn some of the good practices
and how to approach this kind of project
what is the mental model required so
first let's go through so this project
obviously is a simple password generator
of a project and in these kinds of
password generator as a project we can
see uh we have some default length in
our slider we do have a slider here of
course and based on the slider it
generates a random password for me which
includes the upper and the lowercase
letters now as I moved my and first of
all if I refresh this it actually gives
me One initial password so I need to
learn that how can I actually run some
code which as soon as this component
loads or this web page loads up it
executes my code that's the step one
when I touch any component and change
its value it actually reruns my code the
code that is responsible for generating
the password and gets me that code on
top of that when I have this number
being clicked it again reruns my code
with all the previous values and the new
values and generates me a password for
that if I include it again as a
character it actually generates all of
this again runs the code and gives me
the password on top of that I can copy
this and it gives me that hey this was
being copied now here comes some of the
ux and UI elements now for copying
anything you don't need to highlight
anything that is the step one but still
we gave the user an a feel that yes this
entire thing was copied uh this is kind
of a user experience and we need to
learn about some of the hooks in react
to give the user this experience you can
just click on the button and say hey
this was copied you might have seen in a
lot of website it just says copied and a
tick mark that could also have been done
but we went extra step and we simply say
when you click on copy and we have
copied it already but on another line of
code we were able to highlight all of
this piece that hey this piece was
selected automatically it came to your
mind that hey I I was able to do this
now the way how this project is going to
be taken down of course we'll be using
Tailwind CSS in that we are not worried
about the Tailwind we'll not talk about
the CSS much but if there would be a
button here which says generate password
then approach of uh taking down this
project would be completely completely
different because when I have a manual
button which says generate a password
that means I am controlling the event
and the event will be controlled and
executed only when I'm ready and only at
one time so in that case my function is
not going to be keep on running and keep
on run running here the exact same
function is keep on running keep on
running on just every single event so
there is a potential use case that we
can optimize the things and that's
exactly what we are going to learn how
we can optimize uh when we have a
similar kind of method executing again
again with just minor changes uh this is
known as memorization concept which in
which we can keep most of the execution
of the methods in the memory which saves
us and ultimately our react app performs
well so this is uh quite a classy
project that we'll be taking down but if
this would be a project where some ux gu
says hey just add a button here that
would be better user experience I have
to actually rewrite the entire project
uh with a different approach of
optimizing it if he says no we don't
need a button just remove the button and
generate the password like this then
there would be a completely different
approach so when next time in your uh
group meeting or your agile meeting
something somebody says hey this is a ux
design get this straight that it is
going to take some time all right so
this is the basic that we have uh let's
go ahead and generate a new project and
install CSS and whatnot onto this one uh
this is our technically fifth project so
we'll be just going forward with that so
let me just generate that uh pretty
simple we are going to say npm uh create
V and we'll be going with the latest and
we'll be saying this is our 05 project
so we'll be naming it as 05 and we'll be
calling it as password
generator uh of course react uh would
love to but not typescript this time
we'll be going with classic Javas
uh by the way if you haven't checked out
my typescript series it's pretty awesome
well renowned well accepted by Twitter
and free code camp and whatnot so check
it out it's pretty nice but in this case
we'll go with the JavaScript uh let's go
into uh 05 actually what I can do here
is a quick neat little trick I can just
right click and open this as an
integrated terminal so that uh by
default I'm always into this
folder and we can say npm
install and this will install all the
packages hopefully pretty quickly and we
can just say npm in run npm run Dev okay
till it's okay not taking much time okay
npm run uh Dev that's how we get there
and let's see how our project looks like
default pretty classic and we'll also go
on to Tailwind CSS to get our Tailwind
uh we won't be discussing Tailwind too
much but at least we need a Tailwind
framework guides wheat I always go with
the documentation and I highly highly
recommend commend to you also do the
same because there might be some steps
who might have changed eventually we
don't want to go get into that one so
simply go ahead and oh we need to
install it my bad uh stop this one paste
it up here and this should generate a
new file for us which will be Tailwind
config that's exactly what we need and
let's go back we need this exact set of
instruction to be copied and let's go
into this one let's copy and paste so
now my content is aware that I'll be
writing my uh Tailwind CSS in either the
index file or in the source uh all the
gsts might include some of the
typescript Tailwind not
typescript and we'll be copying this one
all right so this needs to go into a CSS
your code CSS open up this we'll be
opening up main index. CSS remove
everything else and paste it up here
that's all what we need uh we won't be
needing anything inside the app CSS as
well we can actually go ahead and
probably can remove this one as well uh
it will give us unnecessary pain later
on so we'll just remove this one all
right now technically our uh CSS should
be all okay we should be able to run it
uh let's go ahead and run the command
first npm run
Dev all right uh so it says nothing as
of now but let's go ahead and try out if
we can have some of the CSS and
everything up and running uh let's go
into index.html and what what I'll do is
I'll add some of the class here as well
I'll say BG Das
gray gray okay suggestion okay this one
gray uh let's go with 800 uh yep okay so
at least our CSS is up and running so no
problem there at least one of the task
is all done that we have this whole
thing now next thing what we're going to
do is let's go into app.jsx and take
down this project by first removing all
the unnecessary stuff it's NE NE but
we'll remove that uh let's have a basic
H1 that
says uh setup ready I don't like to skip
any steps so that you can also follow
along pause me in the meantime and can
just set up your steps as well I don't
like to bring in any code from the
GitHub initially at at least that uh it
feels like a magic is happening no it's
not like that so we'll go this uh time
BG Das
red suggestions red 400 to just check it
out yep it's it's looking good things
are all done and all good now first of
all how we're going to take down this
project now we will be needing a couple
of States so that we can manipulate
Things based on whatever the values are
getting changed and it's pretty obvious
to check out from the previous ones uh
it actually refreshed all of the pages
but uh we still have a picture and a
photo that hey this is what we are about
to build so the first thing that we're
going to need is we need a length so
that we can monitor how much the input
box is being uh scratched and you want
10 characters 15 characters how much you
need uh we need something as is numbers
allowed we also need is special
characters allowed and we need a state
of password as well because if you
notice in the input field the password
was being displayed so we need a state
for that also to maintain so couple of
States we need that so let's go ahead
and work on with this so first of all
let's go ahead and have a simple length
so we'll just go ahead and say that hey
we need a length uh this will help us to
monitor the length uh by default we
won't be going 20 that's too much we'll
be going just with the eight feel free
to change it no problem at all uh this
is my password length uh now I'll be
needing is number allowed or is
character allowed that will be just a
Boolean value to figure out whether our
allowed or by default they are set or
not so we're going to say const and
we're going to say number
allowed allowed and suggestions yep
numbers Allowed by default no not true
I'll be getting false by default they
are not allowed uh similarly we'll be
having our symbols allowed so we'll be
calling as uh characters special
characters care allowed it's totally up
to you how you want to rename that set
character allowed we'll be getting a
false and these three are my States
based on which things will be changing
but once the password is generated I
need an input box where I'll be setting
all this one so I'll call this one as
password the actual password that will
be generating so I'll be saying password
and that will be set password initially
that will be empty all right so now that
I have all these I'm not worried about
error case and all of that uh this is
all good what we have right now let's
take care about how we are actually
returning the value because there's a
lot of CSS I'll be copying and pasting
them this is not a CSS or a Tailwind
class so I'll be directly just putting
things up and we'll be just directly
enjoying the CSS that I have here okay
so let's remove all of this we'll be
having a simple div in this div I have
some of the classes that I'll be
directly uh grabbing and pasting from my
notes again reminding you that we are
not here about the Tailwind this is just
a boiler plate for us uh you can have
your password generator with completely
different look completely different
theme we don't really care after this we
will be having a simple H1 which says
password generator but I do have my uh
classes for this one as well to make it
look almost similar to what we have so
we'll be just pasting this one now once
we have this password generator as here
we'll be having uh a div section uh
which will be responsible for holding
our input box as well as the button the
copy button that we have uh so let's
have first this div uh up here and
obviously we'll be having some of the
classes here let me grab the classes
again these are just the flex boxes
classes that we have nothing too much
fancy so Flex Shadow and all of that so
that button can be on the left side
input box can be on the left side button
could be on the right side uh that's all
what we have now what's interesting here
is the first thing is going to be an
input box so let's go ahead and grab an
input it can be of type text so no
problem there let me just move it on to
the next line now what next comes up is
very interesting we should really
discuss that first of all value the
default value is going to be password as
of now it's a default empty state so
we'll be keeping at that as it is no
problem it will be having some of the
classes as well nothing too much we do
have just couple of ones outline is
going to be none uh no not that much let
me just grab the other ones as well from
the
notes all right that's it again classes
are not to be discussed they are very
basic uh CSS kind of a stuff let's also
place a placeholder which says password
great this will be a readon field so
that nobody can actually come into it
and keep on writing we'll be keeping it
as read only we'll be filling it from
the programmatical aspect only and we'll
be keeping it that much at now one more
thing I'll be passing it on here which
will be used later on this is known as
ref and this reference is going to be
some kind of a password reference that
will be variable we will be discussing
about this later on but just to keep an
idea that what's coming up in the future
yes we'll be talking about reference but
not right now it it is there in the uh
in the process as well okay after this
we'll be having a simple button so let's
go ahead and have a button this button
is going to just say uh copy now of
course not just copy we do have CSS for
this one as well so let's just go have
some class name as well and the class
names uh copy that and paste it up there
okay so this is the button that we have
so you can see that yes we are first
generating all of this don't you worry
eventually as we move on to the complex
project I'll be giving you these uh
notes file so that you can directly copy
and paste them and you don't have to
worry uh painfully sit here watch me
just writing the
CSS we are here to enjoy react not these
uh Button making designs and stuff all
right so this is the first part of my
div the second part or the second div
that I have also have some of the
classes as well so not to forget
there and we'll be having
class name all right uh let's add more
of these classes in here as well so
first of all let's go ahead and copy and
paste this inside this also we do have
some more divs uh okay what can I do uh
we have to go through with this at least
once here uh let's add the class
names and then we'll be having this is
how we designed it what can I say and
then once I'm inside this then comes the
important part which we need to discuss
which is the input field so this input
field is going to be of type range
because that's the first one we actually
worked on with so this range is very
interesting we can actually decide how
much the range can go and all of these
things we can decide the name and IDs
and whatnot uh let me just move them
onto the next line so that we can have a
discussion okay so first of all we have
type we can Define the Min and the
maximum into this one so minimum let's
just say we need six characters of the
password to be uh generated and the max
that user can actually drag and drop
it's totally up to you you want 20
characters you want 100 characters
that's totally Liberty on your own uh
this requires a value property as well
the value is going to be uh governed by
the length itself so that anytime I can
go ahead and grab the length of the
value itself then obviously uh we'll be
having some class here as well uh what
can I say classes are
there uh we'll be having cursor pointer
on top of this we'll be having an on
change because as soon as something
change into this one we need to fire up
an event the event is going to be simple
set length to the new values so set
length is a method which governs or
which regulates how you can enter data
into the length so we are using that
based on an event and whatever the
event. target. value is we are actually
setting that value into the length uh
pretty clear explanation uh once we have
this input then after that we just have
a simple label which actually says hey
this is length or something like that so
we'll be having a
label and this one is for HTML 4 for
label I guess
length and we'll be putting up
length not only that we'll be actually
uh passing a value of length as well so
that user know that how much the value
exactly is so if I go ahead save this up
here uh notice here so that the length
actually is here and changes that so
this thing is actually going into my
state as well that's the one thing which
we are pretty interested about uh once
we have this one this entire thing as
the labels and stuff uh we'll be having
one more of the div actually we are
actually copy pasting this div now copy
and paste this div again this time we
don't have any uh input field like
this okay so this one looks
good and what we need is just an input
box which is going to have a check box
so I can actually remove all of this we
don't need a label for this one or do we
need we'll check we will be needing a
label yeah okay so this one is input of
type
checkbox and again we don't need to
worry about names and whatnot just give
me a second I'll just fix this
quickly all right okay now this is the
input box which is a check box so what
is the default value first of all so the
default checked is a parameter and we
can just simply govern it by our state
which is number allowed now on this we
can put up IDs and on whatnot but most
important part is what happens when
something changes so we need to actually
have this on change uh so so we'll be
having on change this is a simple event
that is triggering and this is how it
works and we'll be firing up a callback
onto this one uh and then inside the
call back we'll be saying that hey I am
going to take care of this one this
input box is going to be governing the
number itself the checkbox for the
number so I'll be using set number
allowed through this and here's the most
important part uh I'll be using a call
back here so in each of these State you
actually receive a call back you can
directly manipulate the value but if you
use a call back in here uh that's a
guarantee that you are you can actually
use the previous value and all the
changes properly propagate we actually
discussed that briefly in the last video
as well so we'll be using the same thing
we'll be using a call back here so that
whatever the previous value is we can
call this one as prev or you can use
call this value whatever you like to
call this this is just a placeholder so
previous value whatever that is true or
false we want to just reverse it so
we'll be just reversing it now we could
have directly just send uh here true or
false but that doesn't serve our purpose
we want to pick up the previous value
that is being there and then we want to
do this now these changes could be
really quickly a user can just keep on
clicking there click click click and
sometimes react might not react that
fast and it might think that hey that
was the previous value so in order to
make sure that react actually react we
are using a call back here so this is
really good practice here and kind of a
high level code that we have uh we
probably don't need name and all these
IDs but it doesn't really harm anything
so we'll be just keeping them uh we'll
be having a label this one is for number
so we'll be just saying
number and this one will be a label for
numbers okay so we have numbers just
like that if I can write that better
numbers so there we go now you got this
you understand the proper use case and
everything for this uh rest of these
elements are just one I'll be just
copying and pasting this uh so that we
don't have to talk about the things
again and again exactly same thing uh
probably uh we have got some we need to
actually write this manually because it
might give us some of the issues uh this
one is character for input and let's hit
a
refresh okay so looks like we need to
hit a command Z couple of times uh
probably this is having an issue with us
so let's just minimize
this minimize this and actually just
copy and paste this one so that copying
and pasting sometimes gives you error
and okay now it's back now it's back uh
but we have this numbers here so we need
to actually write the code ourself okay
checkbox your default value is going to
be character allowed on change I'll be
changing the set character allowed and
I'll be taking the previous value
reversing it Name ID that's okay HTML
this one is for
character cat input and this one is
for character now this should be
okay okay at least our UI part is all
done and we are happy with this one
hopefully whatever happy we could be uh
okay so the UI part is all done now
let's go ahead and see that how we can
work on the logic part of it this one
now logic part is actually fairly
straightforward there shouldn't be too
much worried about this let's first
assume that there is a button and on
this click of a button we will be
generating a password all right so in
that case I'll be simply writing
something like this const a generate
password this is my generate password
method and I'll be generating a password
and in here I'll write the logic for it
uh we'll discuss about the logic part as
well but what I really want to bring
your attention in here is this same
thing is actually being done again and
again and again and if some kind of in
if similar kind of a situation is there
in your project as well then go ahead
and do study this uh one hook which is
used uh known as use call back react uh
this is one great uh hook which you can
utilize and notice here use call back is
a react hook that lets you cache a
function definition between re-renders
that's exactly what we are doing we we
are rendering but not only re-rendering
the majority portion of our function is
exactly same yes there are some values
which are getting changed true false and
all of that but majority of the function
uh is exactly that so it uses under the
hood some techniques known as
memorization uh that's a great technique
almost all of the programmers knows
about it if you're not aware of it uh
then please go ahead uh learn about it
it's a fun technique uh especially
helpful in DSA data structures and
algorithm uh so we'll be using this one
uh using this is exactly like this you
use a use callback just like this and
that's it you passed on your uh things
as a call back just like that so pretty
easy to work on with this one so let's
go ahead and apart from use State we'll
be using use call back just like that
now previously I was about to create a
function which was generate password
this looks like a regular function How
can I convert this regular function into
a use callback hook uh you don't have to
do anything there and what I want to do
is just simply use use callback and this
use call back works just like this this
is your regular use call back now inside
this use a simple call back that is it
that's it all the rest of memorization
and optimization is done by the react
itself now you might be wondering that
why we are actually holding the
reference into a variable of this method
yes great question because only and only
one reason as soon as my page renders I
want something to generate my password
so as soon as the component loads or the
page loads I want another hook to
execute this method if I don't have a
reference of this how will I pass it and
say that hey run this method so that's
exactly what we are doing here all right
so let's go ahead and first uh take care
of this one so in here here what we're
going to do is first let's use the pass
for password short and we'll be taking
it as an empty string later on we will
use this exact variable and push it into
this password state so that State
updates all right uh let's also go ahead
and say this is my string and what does
the string has uh nice suggestion there
uh but we'll be removing some of the
elements into it our string is composed
of only the numbers uh alphabets
technically all uppercase and lowercase
that's our string now conditionally we
have to append this string whether to
include numbers or not so let's just do
a quick check on this one so we'll be
checking if uh whatever the state if
numbers allowed is true then what we're
going to do is we can just use a
oneliner we can just append this with
all the numbers similarly if uh
characters are allowed we can just
append our string with all the
characters that you think I want to
include in my password very simple based
on if F else case our string is getting
updated a string is consisting of all
the uppercase and lowercase letters
that's the default if somebody check
marks the number allowed we will be
adding numbers to the string appending
it if the characters are allowed uh then
we will be appending these characters
totally depends on us now the next thing
is we have to Loop through all of this
string now assume that this all numbers
and everything are inserted here we just
need a loop and this Loop will be
running as many times as the character
length is being set and based on this
based on those random numbers I'll be
picking up the characters from the
string and we'll be inserting into the
pass this password that I've added so
pretty simple uh let's go ahead and use
a simple for Loop for that and thank you
so much but I'll be writing that again
because I think that will help a lot of
us to understand what's going on in here
okay first of all we just simply had a
for Loop which starts with i equals 0 uh
we will not start with zero because I
think I'll start with one as a character
uh the length will be exactly length
this length is actually coming up from
our state this length so that's good
that's nice and we are just increasing
this now once I'm into this I want to
generate a random character so I'll be
just saying that hey I want to generate
it so math. Random uh generates this
random string and the string that I want
to generate is going to be string.
length the character I want to generate
is based on how much my string length is
string character length once I have this
obviously I want to add one to it
because it might generate a random
number between zero and to the number I
don't want zero so I'll just shift it to
one so that is how we are working in uh
but this actually sometimes generate the
number which is not in the round uh
digits so we want a natural number we'll
be wrapping this up and we'll be saying
math. floor this is a classic technique
of generating uh numbers between a range
a range X and Y when you'll be building
examples like uh dice rollers or
something like that or gambling app
maybe uh then in that all those cases
you'll be using using this quite a lot
let's hold the
reference so we'll be saying const
care this is just a random number so far
we haven't done anything we have just
generated a random number and that
number we are storing at a car a
variable simply you can call this one as
index as well no problem there now we'll
be taking this pass and we will be
appending that plus equals and in that
string we have a method known as
character at which gives me I can find a
character at a position so this SC here
is acting as an index so index we are
actually having that pretty good now we
can actually pick let just eight comes
of five so we can start with zero and we
can get a five here so pretty simple
pretty easy now once we are done with
this once we are out of the loop make
sure you are out of the loop then we can
just use a method known as Set uh
password and this is governing the
password so I can pass my password to
this one and this will be changing this
state here and now we have a fresh
password Here
uh that's great that's so far fantastic
and now we are working everything but
there is one more thing uh attached to
this one if you study this used call
back hook a little bit you'll notice
that this used call back has two parts
of it first is this call back which we
have studied and this is a dependency
array uh these dependencies uh should
not change too much uh but based on if
you want to rerun the methods or
something uh you can actually go ahead
and just have this so that all the
optimization are done in this one so
we'll be providing some of the
dependencies array that based on this
make sure all the dependencies are there
so obviously if the length is changed
make sure the optimization is done with
that uh numbers allowed characters
allowed So based on all of this almost
kind of a similar you can memorize that
and work on with that uh we don't really
get into the nties of the this
dependency array we'll talk about again
in this in a use effect hook but again
remember this is really simple as long
as these dependencies don't change too
often they can change once or twice
twice but they're always exactly same so
once you say number is there or number
is not there there are only two cases if
it keeps on changing the states like
that crazily then obviously your code
will absolutely burst I'll show you that
case as well but the whole idea is as
long as they don't change too frequently
that is the keyword here okay uh notice
here there are a couple of that shipping
will receive the same props and can skip
rendering and all of that so this is all
what is happening okay so now that our
method is all done that okay uh things
are great now what we want to do uh
based on a sum of the factors I want
this method to run okay what are those
factors first of all if somebody go
ahead and touch this length I want to
rerun the method as soon as the page
loads I want to run this method as soon
as somebody touched this number I want
it to rerun as as soon as somebody
clicks on the characters I want it to
rerun in these
cases a hook that we can use here and
react is all about hooks uh another hook
that we have is use effect this is one
of the most used hooks in the entire
react project and this allows you to
actually run a piece of code based on
variety of scenarios like as soon as the
component is loading there's offloading
as well but right now we'll not go into
that much but as soon as you want
something to happen as soon as component
is loading or mounting then this effect
use effect Hook is being used using the
use effect Hook is pretty simple you
just simply go ahead and say use effect
we have imported that that is it that is
your use effect now inside the use
effect you get two thing again a call
back so we get a call back like this and
the second part is the dependency array
this time we don't want things this is
opposite of use call back in use call
back we says Hey as long as things don't
change too frequently we actually use
that but in the use effect you want to
run the method intentionally as soon as
something changes so all the methods
that you want to give uh you should give
that in the dependency array that hey if
anything changes in these particular
things we would like to rerun our entire
password generator so what are those
things if the length changes yes please
redun this if uh the numbers allowed
changes uh yes I want to run this if
character allowed changes yes I want to
run this and as well as if there is any
change in uh password generator code or
something you can rerun that the good
thing is I don't have to say a single
thing as soon as the page loads
automatically 100% use effect runs even
if you pass nothing inside that at least
one time all the code that you're
mentioning in the use effect hook it
runs that's why it is used so we'll say
password generator where is our password
generator generate password and we'll
just execute that so that is how you
actually run this now let's go back as
soon as I run this notice here on the
reload it actually generates a password
for me as soon as I change this and keep
on changing it reruns the code if I run
this it still reruns the code and best
part is this project is optimized but
the statement here which says as long as
these dependencies don't change what
happens in that case uh I know that
there is one dependency which is going
to change like like crazy uh for example
uh this password is changing this is
changing too frequently and there is no
way of you're storing these state in
this because every time it's random uh
so if you somehow give this password
here because this is changing quite a
lot notice here if you give this
password uh it will just get all crazy
and this is not a way how it should be
done so you you should not be actually
using this one as a password in
parameter that would not be a great
thing so that's why we actually don't
use this password here and that's why we
omitted that it is not going to help you
uh to actually generate all these things
so yeah not a good idea to add a
password here because that's always
changing and that's why we actually
didn't gave it there okay almost our job
is done but there is one more thing this
button is not yet working uh this button
is not working so how we can make this
button working uh pretty simple just go
to your button if I can find that give
me a second yes I'll find
it and yep here we go found it found it
so on this I want to have a simple
onclick event and on this on click I'll
just say copy password to
clipboard clipboard there we go now in
order to just copy the password there is
not too much of the code that I have to
write a simple uh copy password to
clipboard just like that we have and in
order to copy the password all I have to
do is window.
Navigator do
clipboard. write text and password so
it's going to just grab the clipboard
and write text and we'll be grabbing the
password just like that so as you can
see there is nothing uh too much going
on with this one but hey uh what is this
right text and how you can actually go
ahead and find this yeah that that's an
interesting question so let let me
answer this one
first so technically what we are doing
in this one is there is no access that
we are taking from the UI or this
browser itself so if you go into the
browser if I refresh okay what happened
there and there should be some errors uh
oh let me just quickly check that right
click inspect and console okay uh copy
password to clipboard is not defined I
defined it copy password to clipboard
probably I'm making a mistake here let's
go
back and paste it save it yeah there we
go hopefully everything is resolved and
yep now we can uh maybe minor mistake
okay uh so as I was saying uh notice
here in this particular method what
we're doing is we are not taking access
to any of this element we know that our
final password is actually in our state
password so why why don't just grab it
from there that makes more sense so
we're using a window object in which we
always have a navigator and this is your
clipboard uh through the browser you are
actually accessing what's there in your
clipboard this is exactly how you do
copy and paste in all of the application
it has couple of methods if you go ahead
and uh just check out the clipboard it
has a lot of methods to write and read
and whatnot uh there is even a read uh
method as well uh read text read read
only there's a lot of methods I don't go
into too much detail of that there's a
read method yeah there's a read you can
read the text as well but what I want to
do is I want to use the right text and
inside when I use right text I'm
basically writing in your clipboard so
that whenever you paste that the text is
available so if I can just go ahead and
use this and if I copy this and I change
this again let's just say really long
string it has numbers as well and I copy
this and I come onto this new tab and I
paste this hey this copies so that means
my job is done that means my job is done
but uh you will also find that majority
of the time some of the uiu guys comes
to you that hey although it was copied
but user needs feedback the feedbacks
totally depending on you maybe once the
C copy is done you might want to change
the text uh you might want to store the
button text into some State itself and
want to manipulate that based on whether
the copy text was copied and after some
time you want to rechange it there's a
lot of ways how it is done what we have
decided in this case is we are going to
actually select this whole thing so that
user gets okay this was copied now it's
not easy to do this that's why we have
chosen this in order to do so we
actually need uh somehow a reference of
this input field and that's why I told
you earlier that we'll be using
something known as reference so for this
there is another hook that we are going
to learn in this one which is use ref
this used ref is a crazy powerful hook
if you want to grab anything from the
windows not only just this I'll talk
probably at the end of the series that
how crazy this hook can be and we'll go
into this one the user usage is pretty
easy uh there are multiple users by the
way uh you can do a lot of things you
can even find out how many times your
page was loaded reloaded there's a lot
of things that can be done so what we're
going to do is in this one we'll be just
passing on a simple password password
ref you can name this anything and just
use it like this now in this you can
pass on any variable uh null 01 in this
case we are not much worried about this
because we have nothing to do with what
is the value inside here we just need a
password reference here uh why so simply
to just go into my HTML which is
generating and provide a ref tag known
as password reference now once I
actually provide a ref here with the
password reference now in anywhere in my
application I can grab a reference of
this input field there are multiple
input Fields I need to Define which one
I'm grabbing or which one I'm actually
talking I need to find the context of it
but now that I have this one I can
actually use this in my code as soon as
you user has done the copied uh let's do
some of the fun stuff with him so we'll
just take this password reference and I
can just go ahead and find out that hey
what do we want to select so I can just
go ahead and say Hey I want to have a
current and not the focus in this case
but if I have the access to this
reference I can by the way directly go
ahead and say I want to select this
there we go select this is going to do
majority of work if I copy this notice
here it selects uh but it is recommended
that sometimes you might not have the
properly hydration might have not done
and there are a couple of cases so if
you have the current value there then
optionally go ahead and select this this
is just a safety net if you put this
great if you don't put it no worries
there at all now not only this uh
actually does our job our job is
actually finished but if you want to
learn more about it then you can just
learn more about how to select the
ranges and all of that you can by the
way work on something like this I have a
password reference and I can have a set
selection range as well from zero to all
the values or maybe you want to have a
selection range of 0 to 4 for some
reasons I don't know why uh but maybe
that's your use case so you copy that
and only four of the values will be
selected uh no not the set selection
range uh 0 to 99 and all of that uh so
should be all done okay so somehow it
works like that we are not interested in
those selection set selection range as
of now we want to select everything so
we'll be just going back and we'll be
working on with this one so this
actually uh gets the job done majority
of majority of our work that we are
working on and now we can actually have
any characters and stuff like that I
think 100 is too much uh but we can just
copy this it not only copies but gives a
user a feedback and the only guy which
helped us to set this feedback is
actually this password reference here uh
the use effect use ref hook so in this
just one basic project which which
looked so much easy we actually talked
about the use call back we talked about
use effect we talked about us ref and
probably we can talk about couple of
more more of these uh elements as well
so yes uh things can be really really uh
complex even when they looks very uh
basic it's all about the mindset and the
approach that you are taking to finalize
or finish up a project within just what
uh 40 minutes-ish uh we were able to
finish this entire project but we
learned so much but your job doesn't
finish just right here you need to go on
your own and study about a little bit
more about use f hook use a state hook I
use effect hook call back hook yeah too
many use but at least you got an
introduction to this so spend next two
to 3 days in exploring more about this
one and definitely I'll be coming back
in the next video with the next project
and we'll be having so much more
discussion if you haven't hit that
subscribe on my channel uh go ahead hit
that subscribe and I'll be bringing more
content to this uh show some love in the
comment section as well that's right now
really really am in the need of that uh
that's it for this one let's catch up in
the next
video it pretty much amazes me that how
much much we are going to learn within
just one project that we are going to
finish up in this video this is going to
be a longer one hey there everyone my
name is Ates and let's get started and
continue our react Journey we are into
the world of react Journey we are trying
to master react Concepts one at a time
in each of the project this helps us in
building our portfolio project so that
this shows a constant Learning Journey
that we have we have amount ample amount
of projects so that we can showcase them
as well as can learn them in one go when
you build a kind of a big project of
course there is a learning there as well
but I believe that as a beginner getting
started building multiple smaller
projects which focuses on each concept
one at a time is rather a better
approach so this is exactly what we'll
be doing in this video so let me first
walk you through uh what we're going to
build and this will help you to
understand a customized hook you will be
able to build your own hooks just like
we were able to use use State use effect
use call back and whatnot we will be
able to design our own own custom hooks
this will give you so much of confidence
that hey hooks are not that much complex
I can design my own hooks for that as a
matter of fact we will learn how we can
make the API request and get some data
from the apis and can utilize this in
our application and we will also see
that how a component is being designed a
reusable component so far we haven't
much focused on reusability of the
component which is one of the core
principle and core strength of the react
itself so we'll be focusing on that part
as well so with without a further Ado
let me go ahead and give you an overview
now that you have a list of what we are
about to see let's see that what we are
going to learn in this project so this
is the project that we'll be building of
course it's on Tailwind so we will not
be again much focused on how this corner
radius works on that's not our case uh
the goal is to understand the concept of
the component
reusability the first thing that you can
see here is that this component uses the
stop input component which is exactly
same only the data is getting changed
like from gets changed to two the the
value here might changed here as well
then the currency type this is exactly
same the drop- down list this is exactly
same here and this is obviously same
here as well so uh no much big deal if
we design this component it makes sense
so that we can reutilize it later on as
well uh we won't be making any component
for the button or the swap uh this is
exactly same these are just used to
change the two and frow values so very
simple basic swapping of the variables
that we have what's interesting about is
if you choose like how much is the value
for the 10 USD and you convert it it
actually gets you the value and the
value that it is bringing up is actually
coming up from a URL itself and that is
very very interesting of a URL let me
show you what URL we are actually using
so this is a URL by the way you can get
this URL from the project description so
all the projects are available on my
GitHub account you can just get into uh
that repository that file which I'll
actually give you and can grab this URL
the good thing about this URL is is the
end portion of this URL at the end of it
you can write something like USD do Json
and once you write USD do Json it gives
you a key of USD and appropriate
conversion of each values like I am from
India so INR conversion of each of this
is actually available but not only that
I can make the conversion for for
example INR so all the currencies you
can pass on in the URL itself and it
gives you like INR conversion so how
much one INR will be in each of these
currency that conversion a automatically
happens uh not a big deal it actually
converts a simple API which does the
multiplication but this is a little bit
complex of an API than rather hitting
the basic apis like for example uh there
is this api. GitHub where you get the
data this data never changes you get the
data arrange this data into some uh
cards some photos or something like that
and you get happy with that uh for
example we have another one which is
very famous project which is random a
user random user me this is also exactly
almost same what you see on the data
here this is exactly the data only the
data changes the format never changes no
such things so this is exactly kind of a
same API that we are handling here we
are handling a tiny bit more uh than the
previous one because the INR changes
here we need to make a request here we
have to modify the URL and then they get
the appropriate things and then the key
value pairs we need to actually get all
the keys so that we can show these Keys
all up here so there's a little bit more
involved in this one so that will be
taken care by the hooks itself very fun
project initially you thought it would
be very basic but now you're realizing
ah there's a lot of work that we need to
do and of course Tailwind is going to be
our friend for this one so let's go
ahead and get started with this one so
here's my source code I'll just kill
this one so okay that's still running
I'll destroy this and we have the fifth
project being done now let's go ahead
and take down the sixth project of this
series again same npm create vat and
we'll be using the latest just go for
that we'll be going with the very Basics
so this is 06 I guess and this will be
currency all lowercase would be good
converter and we'll be of course react
and JavaScript and I love how easy it is
to actually go ahead and work on with
this one uh let's go ahead and open this
up into integrated terminal that's much
more easier for me npm install and we
need to go ahead and install the tail as
well so we can just come up here the
same guide of the Tailwind I always come
up here because anyways I have to do it
there is no point of doing it behind the
scene and I don't really prefer that so
I'll just copy this go back up here wait
for a few seconds till it loads all the
things uh please don't mind me sipping
some lemon
water uh missing my tea today uh but
there's so much of these long videos
that I need to grab something to
drink okay so the Tailwind is here and
Hope hopefully this will give us the
Tailwind file there we go Tailwind
config and just like the previous one
we'll be just copying and pasting the
content part since we are in the v
content part is done uh next up is we
need these uh
directives okay and this needs to go
into Source our main index.css remove
everything paste it up here there we go
uh we also don't need anything from the
app.css so we'll be just selecting and
removing all of this we don't need it uh
close all of this close this and save
this and close this now technically in
theory we should have the Tailwind but
again the only way to verify is VI
writing some of the custom
CSS let's go ahead and remove this and
simply have an
H1 and we'll say test for
Tailwind all right let's go up here and
we'll be saying class name BG D
red- 200 should be good enough and let's
go back we haven't run
this npm
run
Dev and let's see okay uh this is
working uh let's go ahead and work on
with this one uh this is not really that
much of a complex data or a complex
project we'll be working with this uh so
let's go ahead and work with this let's
close this one and the first thing that
we'll be doing is let's just cut out all
of this we'll cut this one out remove
this one instead of this we'll be having
a basic div let's have an H1 now inside
this we'll be having some of the classes
so again the classes will come up from
our code files that I already have uh
when we build the project so we'll not
be talking about the code files at all
uh the only thing that we are going to
worry about after this is actually one
more thing I want to add a style into
this one now after the style we would
love to have a simple background image
just like this but instead of the
background image going like react logo
or something we will be actually getting
the background image from you can grab
it from asset as well but you can
directly inject the URL in my case I'll
be just directly pasting a URL and let's
go ahead and remove this from where you
can grab the URLs of the images I'll
show you Resource as well one of the
resource that I prefer to use a lot is
pixels yes I do contribute myself on
pixels quite a lot these are all photos
that I click uh feel free to choose any
photo out of these which makes sense to
you and we'll be searching for a photo
that actually represents money or
something like
that okay which one this one looks good
I'll just copy the image address and
paste it up here and let's see how does
that look in the v project there we go
so decent not the perfect uh we can
definitely change the backgrounds and
colors and whatnot but I think this is
is good enough for us as of now uh we'll
be having couple of more CSS and all
these stuffs but first let's talk about
the functionality part this is more than
enough for us as of now okay first of
all uh we need an input box so the
designing of input box is not really
something which should bother us this is
how the input box looks like but how to
design the components which are reusable
what are the things we need to take care
that is what we are going to discuss so
inside the source just right click and
create a new folder we're going to call
this one as compon
component or components however you like
and the only component that we have as
of now is input box so let's create a
new
file input
box. jsx of course and
RFC uh R AFC yeah that that actually
makes sense or I'll go for
RFC okay RFC there we go finally we have
an input box and we are exporting this
now with the input box how many of the
things you want to accept uh that's
totally up to you I want to accept this
label I will be accepting an amount as
well because I'll be using it uh from
different perspective uh in some of them
user will give the amount in some of
them I'll be adjusting the amount so
obviously I need an amount what happens
when the amount Chang so I need a method
uh which will be responsible for
changing the amount and that method will
be state so how we'll be doing that
we'll actually keep this method as it is
but in our app.jsx there we'll be
designing some of these classes itself
so that we can have all these Basics
amounts and how the amounts are being
set currency converter and all of that
but in order to have that amount we need
to have something which can set the
amount as well so that's my number one
goal what happens when the currency is
Chang so this is something we need to
take care of that what happens when the
currency Chang so there needs to be
something which is keeping a track of
all these states at least there should
be a method all the currency options I
will obviously be taking this one so
this is a input box itself it doesn't do
anything on its own the whole idea and
the whole job is just take the values
and display them that is what we have
and uh there might be cases in this case
this is an input box or the input value
which is disabled so which currency like
you will be obviously reusing this so
which one you can enter the data and
which one you want the component to be
disabled so you have to check for that
one is amount enabled or disabled into
that one uh currency disable like here
you can see the currency is disabled in
this one and of course if any additional
classes that you want to give me so
there's a lot of data that we are
getting through this one and you don't
know this data entirely at the first go
eventually as you want to make your
components more reusable you add this
one so let's go ahead and work on with
this one so first of all we have this
label that we'll be taking as a prop
into this one we obviously needs to take
amount these are obvious one now next
what we need to take is on amount change
what happen happens when the amount
change so something State needs to be
there some method needs to be there
which keeps a track of that and what
happens on the on currency change so
this on Currency Change is what happens
when the user changed the currency how
to utilize them I'll walk you through
with that as well but these are some of
the basics then obviously you need a
currency
option currency options and we'll be
setting up some of the default values
because it will be an array we expect
that how we get the array that is not
our concern as of now I want to get all
these currency as in in the format of
array so that I can just Loop through
them and provide the values there now
obviously by default we need to show
some currency so that also needs to be
taken care of that so we'll be saying we
need a selected currency and by default
we'll be going with the
USD and no suggestion there okay this is
my by default currency and do you want
this amount to be enabled or disabled
that somebody needs to tell to us so
we'll be saying amount disabled and by
default we'll be getting a false value
because we don't want to disable it by
default if the user ask us we will
disable that and we'll be also checking
the currency disabled so if the currency
is enabled disabled user is allowed to
change the currency or not it's totally
up to you uh you want to have it have it
if you don't want to have it that's okay
as well so we'll be saying uh currency
disabled by default that's false we'll
also take some of the class name as well
uh this is a very common pattern that
you'll be taking a lot of class name of
course you'll be designing your
component but you'll also give the user
a chance that hey I'll be allowing you
so that you can actually get all of
these values all right so now let's go
ahead and Design This input box itself
first of all we'll be having some of the
classes as well classes I'll be copying
and pasting from here itself now we
won't be putting the classes just like
the strings because we'll be taking some
of the classes as the props so we need
to keep a safe area where I can inject
the classes which are injected by
somebody who is using our component so
we'll be just removing this one here
we'll be injecting our JavaScript here
now in the JavaScript of course we can
use the back ticks now the advantage of
this backtick is since I've taken the
prop I can just use my fillers here and
can add the class name here now this is
something which user is passing but
since this is just a string I can just
go ahead and copy my CSS classes that we
have so there we go really basic
absolute nice okay uh let's go ahead and
remove this so this is our basic card
that it it was designed uh let's go
ahead and design this class uh div this
is also going to have some of the class
names let me grab the class name it's
simple width we want uh to be half of it
so we'll be saying 1 by two very basic
then we'll be having some of the labels
and input so let's first grab a
label and label HTML 4 we will be
injecting some of the JavaScript here in
a minute uh just wait for it right now
we don't want to have it uh or let's
just remove the entire HTML for uh for a
minute then we'll talk about the
usability and how we can actually um
make it more accessible okay uh we have
some classes here as well so let's go
ahead and add a class name I'll be
adding the class name from my
notes copy and paste classes we won't be
talking even a tiny bit we'll be always
getting it like this and this will be
adding as a label remember we don't want
to hardcore it because user will be
using it this label for multiple purpose
maybe from maybe to okay this part is
all good now once we have this label
inside this we want to have an input
field so we'll be having an input field
just like this and let me just break it
onto a next
line there we go now this input field uh
will have a type of number because
that's what we want number there we go
now what else do you want to have into
this one there are multiple fields that
you want to have first of all let's take
down the obvious ones which is the class
names and again the class names goes as
it is whatever we have in notes don't
really care about it don't want to even
talk about it then we have the type then
obviously let's grab a placeholder value
you can grab the placeholder value as
whatever you like we'll be just saying
it as amount depends if you want to take
this input as well from the user uh you
can take it right now if I don't enter
anything into this one it is this one is
zero uh this one actually doesn't do
anything so it's always zero totally up
to you if you want to put this
placeholder any value or something like
that okay uh next up is is the field
disabled or not uh that depends on
amount disabled or not whatever the
value you have given by using this one
uh the value the value is going to be
amount whoever is using it is going to
give me but the most important thing is
if you just keep it as it is then
obviously you'll be having some amount
but there is nothing which is helping
you to change these values so what you
have to do is this method on amount
change will be responsible for changing
the amount so obviously we have to
listen for an event which is on
change on change and we have to use this
on amount change but we cannot just use
it like this otherwise we are never
using the method we have no idea about
the functionality or anything of that so
just cut this out here we want to use a
call back let's go with this and
obviously we'll be tracking an EV so
let's just call this one as e for an
event and then we have to first make
sure that we have the presence of this
on amount change this could actually
make or break your application so for
the standard practices such uh values
are being checked first so we'll be
checking on amount change if this on
amount change exists then we go ahead
and say that use this on amount change
and get an e. target. Val but again
there is a problem into this one uh
whenever you grab the values like this
you'll be be grabbing a string and we
don't want a string we want actually a
number out of it so before we actually
grab it we'll cut this out and we'll be
casting this one as a number and then e.
target. value these are just additional
safety checks nothing to be worri too
much we are just trying to make sure
that our code is as standard as possible
and these are only only safety check if
you directly come up here and say e and
then simply say on amount change e.
Target value U maybe your appc ation
might work and eventually you might have
to debug but this is a good standard
practice that we have all right so this
is all good now we have to go ahead and
work on with this one so this is a part
of only having this part the currency
the numbers and everything we have to
work on this currency type as well so
this is the second portion where we'll
be working on so let's just go below
this div we need to have another div
this one obviously we'll have first the
class
names and let me just grab all the
classes so this is the right right
portion that we are working on notice
here the currency type and USD so this
is why we have flex and all of that so
the next part is all about it let me go
up here first of all a simple paragraph
that says currency type so nothing
extraordinary currency type it always is
currency type so we we are done with
that now comes up the interesting part
is how we are going to take care of this
USD and all these input values now this
is a select field so let's go ahead and
grab a first of all a select field there
we go
now in this select field first and
foremost let me just grab onto the next
lines and here also you go away okay
first of all class name because there is
a styling involved into this one not
worried about styling even in case I
highly recommend you in fact you change
the styling at least you'll be
contributing something in the project
your hands will work onto the keyboard
and that's always a good thing now what
should be the value the value should be
uh based on the select currency that we
have uh selected currency notice here uh
we have the selected currency as of now
we are taking this as USD by default but
user should be able to allow and change
this one but we'll we are happy with
this selected currency as of now uh what
happens with the on
change there we go now again you might
have noticed the exact same pattern that
we are following we will be following
this one as well here we chose an event
we set that whether this uh on Currency
Change method is available to us or not
and based on that we'll work so very
repeatable pattern so yes we'll be
seeing very standardized code in this
entire Series so we have this event
after that we go ahead and check do we
have this on currency change if we have
this then we go ahead and uh use the
second part of it which is on currency
change and we simply go ahead and grab
the e. target. value here we don't need
any number casting or anything because
these are just strings all right okay
next up uh is this field enabled or
disabled uh that maybe you want to
design an applic ation which is uh
disabled having these field disabled but
in our case disabled currency disabled
is mostly false but maybe maybe you
don't want user to change this type it's
always USD to INR or INR to USD maybe
that's the case so we are just taking
care of that okay uh select field alone
doesn't work so we need to have these
options getting inside this one uh for
these options we obviously have to Loop
through the values so we'll be using our
JavaScript here and inside this we'll be
saying hey all the currency options that
you are providing to us remember
currency options is an array in case you
forget this is the currency option which
is an array I want to Loop through this
value looping is pretty simple I just
have to say do map and there we go this
is my map inside the map I'll get a call
back so let's go ahead and grab a call
back no problem at all and in each of
this you will get a currency uh so let's
just call this one
as currency now with each of the
currency what we'll be doing instead of
using curly braces I'll be using
parenthesis so that I don't have to
return anything I'll just go inside this
and we'll say that I'll get an option so
option and thank you uh the key is going
to be currency because we know that our
API actually gives us these uh values
and each of these values are actually in
itself unique so we don't have to worry
about it uh all the options that we get
into the array we will be crafting and
designing the array in such a way that
each of the currency is unique in itself
the value is going to be currency and
this one is also going to be currency
too many currency but this is how
exactly options and everything works
remember a lot of people did the mistake
uh when I was teaching it earlier a lot
of people just use the curly Braes here
so make sure you don't do the
mistake all
right so this seems like a very nice
approach that we have taken of designing
an input uh one more feature I would
like to discuss not a feature but a
standard practice that is used quite a
lot is once you have designed these
components you actually have these uh
index file into these components not
necessarily but usually you have all you
do in these files is actually you go
ahead and import these input boxes like
this and just go ahead and Export uh
like this input box uh the advantage of
this is I don't have to actually go
individually in each of the component
all I have to do is import the
components this index file and I can
bring in any component from this in this
one maybe later on when we'll be
designing of course we'll be designing
uh there might be 5 10 15 components in
each one of them having all of them
listed in index is actually a better
thing so that's what we'll be using
nothing too much to be worried but yeah
these kinds of things do exist all right
uh moving on let's take care of the URL
part so we have this URL we'll be
working on with this one but the way how
we are going to take care of this one is
why designing our own custom hook you
can of course do all of this into your
use effect hook into the app.jsx as well
but there's so much of the things that
we actually require from this that I
don't want to do all of this mess into
app.js rather I prefer to do all of this
into a separate customized Hook by using
that hook I will return the data
whatever is required all right so let's
go ahead right click create a folder and
we'll be calling this one as hooks it's
totally up to you how and what you want
to name this one uh the only uh kind of
a standard practice is to use use before
hooks too many use uh use use effect use
call back whatever that is in this case
we will be using uh use currency info
that is our hook use currency info. JS
and now what we have is we'll be we just
write simple this Hook is actually
nothing more than a function so use your
classic react use your classic
JavaScript uh fetch the API get the data
and return the value that is it that is
in that is literally your hook so we'll
be needing some of the stuff obviously
we'll be needing use effect uh and we'll
be needing user state of course all
right now let's just go ahead and simply
say hey we'll be having a function that
function will be uh use currency info uh
nice all of this is provided to me uh
but I'll be writing that anyways so use
currency info is my hook and after that
we'll be saying export default use
currency info that is all good now how
we are going to go ahead and work on
with this first of all whatever the data
is I'm getting retrieving from the API
call I need to store that so for that
I'll be saying that let's call this one
as data set data and by default uh this
is not an array that is a wrong
suggestion here if you notice this is an
object notice here this whole thing is
an object and I want to store this
object up here so we'll be working on
with that okay now how can I go ahead
and fire this up as soon as somebody
uses this hook so as soon as this hook
will Mount so again uh this Hook is
nothing more than just a function just
like your appjs is a component it mounts
this hook will also Mount so I can go
ahead and use a use effect here and we
use a use effect Snippets uh right now
on which you are dependent uh you are
dependent on couple of values but oh one
more thing whenever whoever is using
this used currency info he needs to
provide me the
currency otherwise How Will I Know That
in what currency you are looking for
data because my API looks for INR as
well it looks for the USD as well so you
need to provide me at least one data
that based on this I want to call the
API so once you have this currency I'll
first remove all of this part it's not
it's a boiler plate code and I'll also
remove this third which is boiler plate
code now anytime anything changes INR to
let's just say USD I obviously want to
refetch the request so the dependency of
this use effect is obviously the
currency any change in the currency I
want to refire this one for here I can
use xos as well I would prefer to use
xos but in this case I'll be using uh
just the fetch so I'll be saying fetch
just like this you can await use however
you like I'll be using back Tex in this
one now just go ahead and copy this data
and I'll paste this one the only thing
that I have to do is just change this U
USD that's exactly what I was changing
in the URL as well so let's just inject
our variable just like this absolute
basic and just add a currency whoever is
calling this Hook is actually passing me
this variable so no problem at all now
once we have this then obviously based
on this we'll be having a then or catch
whatever so we'll be using a Den inside
the dot Den we will be having a call
back so just like this there we go and
we will have a response this response
needs to be converted into Json because
sadly I'm not using an xos I'll walk you
through with the xos as well that's much
much better I don't have to do this Json
conversion and everything uh after this
chaining we need to further chain on one
more because that's where we actually
get our data so we can call it with any
other name as well I'll call this one
again as a response and once we have
this response we'll be fetching this
entire response into the set data the
data the state that we have designed and
inside this one most importantly uh I
cannot just go ahead and say set data
like this of course this is a method but
what data if you notice here uh this is
exactly I don't want to fetch it
entirely because this also includes this
date component I want to insert only one
key there whose value is USD so I want
to insert the data from the key of USD
and this whole thing I want to inject
not the date so for this I can actually
go ahead and access all this response
this whole response is so from this
response whatever that is I want to just
go ahead and provide this USD so there
we go USD but this USD changes based on
INR if we have INR this changes so this
is exactly the currency I can go ahead
and paste this currency cool okay so
this one is
nice all right so all we have got this
one now now now what we want to do is
whoever is using this hook we actually
need to return the data to him and what
we are returning back if you notice it
closely we are returning all of this
this guy here so this is again an object
but in this object we have key values so
0 0 uh Lynch whatever that currency is I
haven't been to most of these countries
and trust me I have traveled around 40
countries a lot of them I don't know
okay so this is what we have so as you
might have noticed the designing the
custom hook is not that much bad it's
actually pretty easy this is just a
basic function we could have done this
all into app.js as well but this would
have unnecessarily just complicated the
stuff into the same file and segregating
your logic is always a good idea and by
the way in case you want to have this
there is absolutely no shame in just
console logging the data in fact when
you are learning the things it's a good
idea to loging every single thing
finding its data type finding its value
I encourage that quite a lot
okay so so far all good uh now let's go
back into the app.jsx finally we are in
here and now let's take care of a lot of
things because all the things are
actually dependent on lot of the things
that we are doing for example this input
box from where you're going to give me
this label amount all of that some some
place you need to give it to me and that
place is basically your app. CH so this
is where we'll be going through okay
let's design a lot of States so we'll be
getting an amount
and set amount uh okay we'll be getting
a US state okay cool uh we also need to
get a from so we'll be saying
from and this one is going to be set
from by default it will be USD we also
need to have a two so set two set two is
no not Euro not Euro that's very
expensive I'll go with din of course I
live in India I'll go with the INR uh
then we also need to give the converted
amount as well and this will be
converted amount and that will be set
converted amount by default it will be
Zuri zero not
Zuri okay so this is the converted
amount this is what we will be filling
the data up here okay and uh couple of
more things actually I forgot one thing
to actually discuss with you I should
have discussed that earlier but let's go
back onto the input box now this is
something which is not really necessary
but still I'll discuss this I'll talk a
tiny bit about it there is one more
thing that we can do is make it little
bit more accessible although it is not
required but we can actually do a tiny
bit more now we know that we have a lot
of options that are going on into this
one and for all of these options uh
notice here we are having this label as
well so this label if I click on the
form it highlights this input field so
how can I go ahead and take this one
because right now that's not working in
our case in this case we have a label
but it doesn't have an HTML 4 and in
this this we also don't have anything
now there are a couple of ways how we
can do it first of all we can just go
ahead and say
html4 okay no suggestions and we can
just go ahead and design a simple
variable or we can just give it a name
itself html4
is currency like this of course in
double
Cotes there we go and similarly in the
input also we can give that hey what's
the id of this one so HTML 4 and this
one his ID because these are actually
interrelated we can give a currency uh
this will do most of our job we don't
need to actually worry too much about it
but you will notice in a lot of
production grade code especially the
Fang companies and big shots they
actually use something known as use ID
yes there is another hook the whole idea
behind use ID is to generate unique IDs
yes that is by default in now in react
and you'll see a lot of people use it in
this format so once I go back and before
the turn I can just go ahead and say
const ID as use ID now it generates
unique ID for me and all I have to do is
just inject this ID here instead of
currency I could have done that with the
currency as well but hey this is how a
lot of people does so I just want to
show you that yes this is also a good
practice uh how much value does it add I
don't know you decided but yes this is a
common thing so just wanted to have it
we have it in the notes to be discussed
in this entire uh boot camp uh but yeah
pretty good pretty good okay moving back
uh coming onto this one so we have a lot
of converted and all of this now coming
back onto uh this use currency info we
have designed a hook for this one this
hook returns me a data so how can I go
ahead and use the value of it okay let
me show you almost all of the hooks that
you have seen is just a function and it
returns some values and we stored that
value into some variables arrays objects
whatever that is exactly like this we'll
be having these things so so what we'll
be saying is I want to have this used
currency info uh by by the way please
import this uh however you like I like
this one so this is my used currency
info this hook requires a default value
so I can just go ahead and pass on a USD
but why to pass a USD like this when we
have all of this being set in this from
so let's go ahead and remove this
instead of hardcoding let's go ahead and
do
from uh no suggestions thank you wrong
suggestions now just hold the entire
thing into a variable and we'll be
calling this one
as currency data or currency info would
be good that's it you have designed a
hook and you have stored all the
information always remember what
information is coming up to your data
see most of the errors actually come up
even in production grade still it's been
12 years still most of the errors that I
do is wrongfully judging what type of
data that is coming up here it looks
like that US state is an object and
stuff but you need to be 100% sure that
the data this data data when it comes to
here and is being called as currency
info what is this this is an object this
is an array this is a number whatever
that is be 100% sure about it and that
is why a lot of people prefer to use
typescript just to be S safe that what
kind of data is coming into the picture
all right enough of the site talks uh
these are experienced talks I think
these talks actually add value okay now
we need to grab options why options why
are you grabbing options because if you
remember I have this USD as a long list
and I need to extract this just a second
I need to extract all these keys from it
so this keys are important for me and
these keys are actually option in my
input box yeah that's why I'm pulling
out all these options and turns out
pulling out this one is actually piece
of cake if you have studied JavaScript
so object has a method of do keys and
inside this keys I can just go ahead and
say hey I'll grab the keys from currency
info uh no need to add rates or anything
like that that is I have my keys all
right pretty good now I have my options
and all these values being designed
nicely added and all of that now what
happens when you actually go ahead and
actually click on convert actually to be
honest nothing happens uh you already
have all the information with you you
have your amount uh you have your
currency info as well and in whatever
the currency you want to convert you can
just grab it now you have all the
options available for you so from this
entire currency in you want to find out
INR how you will find INR from here just
by searching for uh INR so if I search
for INR that's available to me similarly
if I have to write a function for this
it's super super easy uh let's just go
ahead and call this one as convert there
we go how do I do the conversion it's
super simple use first of all set
converted amount because that's what
this is converted amount and all you
have to do is take this amount whatever
the user has given to you and multiply
it by the currency info which holds all
of these keys and multiply by it
whenever we say uh square brackets true
and by the way you can access objects
with the dot notation as well as with
the square notation just giving you too
much of information and in this I'm just
setting it two to INR so I'll just find
this value and this number and I'll
multiply it by that so that is it told
you super super simple by the way we
have this also method let's Design This
which is swap which just swaps the value
and you might have already guessed that
how that actually works super super
simple we are just exchanging the value
of from and to that is it that is it
what we are doing let's go ahead and
design this we'll be having a Swap and
this swap is going to look like this so
notice here how we are swipping it SW
set from to two and set two to from uh
but we also want to change one more
thing once we actually go ahead and say
uh let's just say there is uh one here
when we swap these these numbers also
get exchanged so notice here the numbers
also get exchanged uh that is nothing uh
it's just the set converted amount uh
getting changed with the sent amount
that is it if you want to do that
otherwise you'll just reset them so
we'll go ahead and say that hey I'll
have the set converted amount to be
changed as simply just the
amount
amount yeah that amount no no
suggestions thank you and we'll also set
amount is going to go ahead and
change with the converted amount there
we go that's it now all the
functionality of this swap is all done
all right now that majority of our task
is done let's go ahead and add more of
the values that we have so we have this
uh test for Tailwind we don't need this
uh let me go ahead and add couple of
divs up
here let's remove this again this is the
most boring part but we have to go
through with this one as well uh in the
later on projects and application I'll
give you uh this code file which is
helper file which actually gets all
these components so they can just copy
and paste for rest of them I have that
don't worry so width is going to be full
uh okay once I have this inside this div
we will have another div this div also
have a class name let me grab all the
classes that we
have copy that paste it up here there we
go looks decent after this
and finally uh we'll be having a form
because this form is actually a submit
form so that's what we are using let's
get a form this form has no action but
it has some things known as
onsubmit and what does this on submit
does of course fires an event that's
what all form does and we'll be taking
this event and couple of things first of
all stop prevent this form from
submitting to some URLs so that's pretty
easy event. prevent default that's
classic and then run our simple convert
method that does all of the magic for us
now inside this form uh we need to add
the input box and all of these things so
first of all we have a div here that div
also has some classes super
boring uh not too much not too much like
this okay and once I'm inside this div
uh we have the first input box so let's
grab the input box let's bring this and
let's see how it has brought the input
box so it has brought the input box from
component input box I would rather
prefer it to actually grab it from index
itself index. jsx did I mention no it's
JS so I would prefer to get it uh JS uh
not not it's not like wrong to get it
from input box but it's better to
actually grab it because eventually when
we'll be having 510 on all of this it's
better to actually grab it from here and
again once we are grabbing it from here
the reason why we actually need to
change this because we have exported it
like this this is not export default so
we need to actually grab this that's it
and then if we have more we can just set
set the comma and just have it so very
common but just wanted to show you all
the good practices are there in
incorporated into this
application self closing now it's time
to provide the data to this one so first
of all label this label is just the from
so we don't need to do like this we'll
be just saying this is a from uh amount
amount obviously will be taken care from
the amount the state that we have
designed then we have to provide the
currency options and currency options
are in options if you forgot uh these
are options we derived from all the keys
so that's what we are passing uh then we
have to provide the options of what
happens on Currency Change on amount
change and all of that so we'll be first
changing on Currency Change what happens
when the currency is being changed uh
when the currency is being changed
obviously we are tracking the currency
uh into this from so this is a from so
we are Tech tracking the currency from
so let's go ahead and fire an event and
update the states based on that so we'll
be going like this and first of all this
one is going to take on the Currency
Change it's having a default value of
currency currency why there is no
suggestion currency it should be having
a currency let's call this one as
currency whatever the currency right now
it's USD so as soon as somebody changes
the currency we can come up here and we
can actually remove this and can have
the
set set amount
change set from yep set from and inside
that currency will be changed so
automatically the new string value of
the currency comes to us so that's first
part next up is on amount change what
happens on the amount change uh we'll be
taking the amount and we will be let's
just use this one
better uh on amount change first of all
grab the amount okay I grabbed the
amount then after that we can actually
change the amount uh so on amount change
will be setting up the amount oops my
bad on amount change yeah there we go
we'll be setting the amount to the newer
amount whatever the amount is being
changed so on amount change handles that
part and we will also be needing a
select currency whatever the select
currency is so selected currency is we
are going to grab it from so there we go
all right so this is what we have as of
now let's see if our V application so
notice here we have this all from USD
all the values are being properly passed
but uh this is not enough we need to
have uh one more here uh we'll be having
a button here so just outside of this
div actually we added another div yeah
too many divs and class name very
boring and have this currency name copy
this paste it inside this there is a
button which has a ton of classes and
this one is say
swap okay the easiest part I know which
is on click and this will work as it is
if you just go ahead and do a swap uh
save this and yeah it it works but we
don't want it to look like this so we'll
be just adding some
classes okay I could have done this
entire Project without the CSS but again
a lot of people just appreciate the
content if it looks good
that's why we spend extra time uh in
working with this one all right so
button is all good now we have this div
let's go ahead and just grab all of
this copy this and paste it up here so
we have the same input box but we need
to change the values very carefully in
fact so much carefully that when I
actually did it on my other channel yes
I do have other channel as well I
actually made a mistake on this so this
time I want to do it more cautiously so
that I don't do the mistake okay
first of all label this time I know the
label is going to be two all right what
are the currency options easy peasy I
can give the options all to it then
whatever the amount is amount will be
derived from the converted amount this
is a readon input field so I will be
giving it as uh amount disabled as true
I can give it like this or if you just
pass it on like this as well that is
also considered as true all right so
that part is being taken care okay now
let's go up here uh first of all what I
want to do here is on Currency Change
what happens when the currency changes
so when the currency changes I need to
First grab the currency whatever the
currency is so I'll just grab it okay
and then I'll this time change the set
two currency and I'll change it to
whatever the currency is so set currency
set two and currency I think that should
be all now we also need to provide a
selected currency whatever the selected
currency C is and in the selected
currency I can just go ahead and give an
INR but that would be bad because that's
hardcoded so let's drive the value from
the state itself we're tracking this
into a state known as two and that's why
we actually created this two here it is
two and from so this is what we have now
hopefully uh in the previous we did
mistake now this is working previously
if I change one state it changes another
state probably I did some mistake or
something like that okay anyways let's
go ahead and finally add the last button
that we have uh very long video but it's
fun it's fun I hope I hope it is just
let me know in the comment section I
desperately read all the comment section
and feedback from the students uh that's
my fun okay uh we'll be saying convert
and the button needs an onclick
obviously we don't need on click
actually we need uh on we don't need on
we need just the type of submit that's
submit so it automatically submits and
obviously we don't want to convert to
look like this so you get that we'll be
adding the classes our classic classes
copy that and paste it hopefully it
looks good there we go looks good and we
can actually go ahead and try this so
let's just go ahead and USD how much is
5 USD and we'll convert this it's good
amount it's good amount in India okay uh
you can go ahead and remove this long
string so when the conversion is being
done you can actually use your
JavaScript skills and stop this to just
two numbers uh I'll keep this one as up
to you uh but if you'll notice into our
original app we actually say it convert
USD to INR and when we change something
to in or something it changes so how we
can do that super easy peasy nothing
just start your JavaScript and then just
say that hey uh I want to use from and
to and start your JavaScript and we'll
be just saying to and that's it so if I
go back here it says USD to INR uh maybe
you won't have to all uppercase so it's
also super easy because I know these are
are strings I can go ahead and use to
uppercase it's a method and similarly
here to upper case this is also a method
and there we go easy peasy JavaScript
there is absolutely nothing but if you
look at this code base let me give you a
summary of this that all what we have
done because there's so much into this
video and I know this is a long video
how long almost hour 40 50 minutes so we
started by building our components we
studied the component and there is no
way that you'll be designing a component
this perfect when you'll be designing
eventually you'll be keep on adding the
data to the component maybe initially
you start with label amount that's it
then eventually you add a currency
options that I want to make my component
more use reusable so it's not like on
the day one we designed it like that
eventually we upgraded it and that's a
thing with the tutorial because you
don't want me to sit here for 6 hours
for building this kind of application so
obviously tutorials are more polished uh
So eventually you'll be building all
these things don't worry then you'll be
designing the comp components you'll be
not designing this as perfect then we
studied that how we can actually just
simply take the values and ultimately
what we did is just have an input field
and here we just had a select option
field so we just studied about how we
can add an options field just like this
that's all what we did optionally we
studied a little bit about the use ID
hook not very much used not very highly
implemented but a lot of people use it
so I just thought to have a discussion
over it then we studied a little bit
about the index way of importing the
component again there is nothing nothing
wrong in importing the component from
the component file itself but eventually
in the long run this will make your code
more uh scalable that is always a good
idea and then we went into learning
about the customized hook this
customized hook as we learned is nothing
absolutely ignore these x4x These are
coming up from one of my plug-in that I
have sorry uh this helps me to design
the application faster so we learned
about the hooks as well in the hooks we
saw that it's just a function nothing
else at all this function requires a
currency and as soon as this function
loads whenever you call it then it will
fire a use effect so at that point of
time a hook is automatically being
called this Hook is fetching onto a URL
this URL you can grab from my GitHub
account onto the react I'm actually
pushing this all the code on the GitHub
as well you can grab this URL the only
thing that's we are changing is the
currency so we crafted the URL according
to us then we simply taken the response
into Json and then we simply extracted
some values out of it we studied a
little bit about uh properly looking at
the URL and what the data we are
receiving so we studied that in this
data we don't want everything we just
need this INR and this whole thing so we
actually derived that value out of it so
we simply said hey I don't want all of
this I want just the currency part so
that currency part is obviously this
whole thing so this whole thing we
extracted very basic data nitpicking
you'll be doing this quite a lot and
then uh we console log this and we
actually return the data that's said
that's our hook now inside this app.jsx
we used the state to track all the
values that were required for us and in
this portion we use the hooks as well
our own custom designed hook this hook
gives us the entire object out of this
object we extracted the keys because
that is something we want to pass on
classic JavaScript nothing reacti about
it then we studied how we can do the
swap absolutely basic function converted
was absolutely basic this is just one
lineer code and that's why a lot of
people hate I don't want to build a
currency converter just one liner uh but
ours is not ours is way more complex and
way more scalable as well then we simply
did all here here it was all boring the
input field but hey uh cautiously add
your data because I did a mistake when I
was teaching it on on my other channel
but it's good it's good you learn your
from your mistake it's no big deal it
takes just a couple of hours of
debugging nothing more than that uh so
that is all what we have as of now and I
think uh this video has helped you a lot
in understanding how the react Works how
the big scalable projects are being
taken up and how we constantly move on
further concepts are pretty easy when
you're with me of course uh leave down a
comment it really really helps me if
you're watching the content I know a lot
of people are watching and when they
don't leave just a thank note in the
comment section uh I'm always somebody
who's looking in the comment section and
finds it empty it's disheartening so
please leave the comment and I'll be
thankful to you as well that's it for
this video and let's go ahead and catch
up in next another such
project all right moving our journey
further into the react ecosystem hey
there everyone my name is AES and
welcome back to another video this one
is also going to be a bit relaxed chill
out enjoyable uh slower guide on
exploring another Concept in the react
World now what the concept in the react
is single page application that means
there is no pages in these application
it's just one page and the whole idea of
the react is I'll take take the
component unmounted in place of this
I'll Mount this one so the whole idea is
to manipulate the Dom as much as
possible when you actually say I want to
go into register page react never goes
anywhere it's a single page application
it removes some of the elements from
your homepage and inject some of the
react uh register page on there it
removes the register page and injects
the login component and once you are
successfully logged in then it removes
that and gives you a dashboard just
right there and your page never ever
refresh but this
is not ideal for a regular user regular
user doesn't really understand and we
cannot train the entire world population
how to reuse the internet just because
we have designed a new framework or a
library so the concept of moving users
onto different URL like register page
login is so common that if you don't do
this people might think that it's very
suspicious and it's not really a great
thing for the URLs and the safety
precautions and that is why we need to
figure out a way that how we can
artificially inject the routing so that
the URL looks great and user feels like
they are moving onto Different Page
although it's just react at the behind
the scene it's just a single page
application and yes everything happens
artificially that is just a simulation
being done that you are onto different
URLs your page will never refresh still
the react Concepts bringing in the
components injecting the components and
all of that uh so we'll be learning one
such way of doing that by the way this
is a core react course that is why we
are discussing about the routings uh by
the way on my channel uh you will find
there's a nextjs playlist separately
available so in that we don't discuss
too much of routing that routing is
different and by the way in case you are
just interested I do have a separate
video on my channel in which I have
showed you that how the next year's
routing can be designed customized yep
pure JavaScript how the react router
works uh anyways let's move by so in
this video first let me show you what we
are going to build and then I'll give
you some of the con concept of how to
study the documentation and and figure
out things on your own with the react
router Dom that is the library which
we'll be studying so let me first take
you onto the screen there we go sorry we
don't have any dark mod for this one but
this is the application that we'll be
building uh luckily you don't have to
worry about CSS I'll be giving you some
of the files I'll show you that as well
so this is our homepage and I recommend
you to notice the URL this is the
homepage when I go on to about page this
is slab so this is simulating that you
are moving on to the next page but end
of the day this is just react our
navigation bar never changes our footer
also never changes they stay exactly the
same so if I go back to the home
navigation bar remains exactly same but
our URL changes a little bit so we have
a homepage about page and a contact page
that we have and similarly we will be
having a GitHub page but the GitHub page
additionally will do something different
the GitHub page will show my photo as
well as my GitHub count and we'll see
that how we can optimize it through the
react router Dom which is Library we are
using and for every single time we have
these application going on like this
GitHub and about we'll also see how we
can grab some of the URLs and whatnot
there's there's a lot more that we'll be
studying than just being shown on the
website itself all right and the package
that we'll be studying is react router
domom it's available on react router.com
it's by the remix team made by remix and
what we'll be doing is there are a lot
of ways how router actually evolves and
especially the version six which we are
at the time of the recording video this
is the newest one we'll be using that
one only but I'll walk you through how
you can actually explore the
documentation otherwise my channel is
always available for you to help uh but
we'll be seeing that how we can use the
six version we won't be talking about
the five at all uh we'll be seeing that
how we can pick up different variations
of the router we'll be using the create
browser router and the whole idea is to
study this piece of code so that we can
load things on our own and can design
the routing for this application this
sample application which will give us
the entire idea of how the applic ation
is built or should be built and all of
that we'll see some of the optimization
task and techniques and whatnot so
everything will be pretty nice up there
all right uh enough of the talk uh let's
go back onto this one and by the way one
more thing uh if you'll go onto this one
so I have a repo on my GitHub account
github.com Shri you can find a repo with
the name of react English uh because
these videos are in English and you can
see that there is a react router no
notes. MD the file is available for you
this is a markdown file which will help
you to actually grab the components like
for example for the header part or the
navigation bar uh this is all the code
which has nothing to do with the react
routing majorly it's just a CSS uh
similarly in the footer if you check out
the footer this is just a static footer
we just need it to understand few
concept it could be just one liner but
nobody gets impressed with the one liner
text that's why we are actually giving
it to you so you can find the footer
component just copy and paste paste it
and then similarly we can have home
component and contact us page that's it
I geta we'll be designing on our own so
that's the basic part of
it so let's go ahead and create a fresh
new
project and work with it okay uh let's
grab and there we go okay so first of
all let's kill this we don't need you
and let's go ahead and work on with
this just give me a second I'll align
the
things and remove this one let's start a
fresh one and we'll say npm create V not
react and this one is going to be an
introduction to just the routing so
we'll be calling this one I guess the
seventh application that we have so
07 and we'll be saying react router
package name is same we'll go with react
and
JavaScript all right so this seems
good now we need to go inside the folder
but as you know I prefer to actually
right click and open the integrated
terminal that way I'm always into the
root so I can just run
npmi to install the
application and we can actually go ahead
and move on to uh the browser itself let
me go ahead and get into the
browser and how we can actually install
this so there are main concept migrating
all of this let's go on to getting
started
and there should be getting started
guide
tutorials uh yep the project install
just get me the npm install command or
I'll do it
myself okay no examples FAQ main concept
okay I understand the main concept just
give me that
path okay uh probably it's not going to
be it's nothing it's a react router Dom
so I'll just install it so npm install
it's react somewhere it is I'm not able
to found it react router Dom the very
famous package if you are anytime
working on the react this is the package
you'll be dealing up with that now in
this package entirely all you have to do
is go with the main concept this is
really the essence of how to understand
the react router Dom what happens how it
happens and a lot of essential things
are mentioned in this one so how you
track the URL how you track the location
forceful although we'll be studying a
lot of it especially the router inside
when we'll be building a mega project
finally in this series so all these
things like client side rout routing the
location State and all of that will be
taken care there but if you have time go
ahead and go with the main concept some
of them we'll be studying here like the
path patterns what this is how to grab
the URL pams Dynamic routing we will be
studying in this one but definitely uh
this is a very rich guide uh these kind
of concept these all will be taking care
of this uh but it is always a good idea
to actually go with the main concept
documentation this is the part where you
study and you read out the stuff okay
moving back so now everything is
installed let's first go ahead uh we'll
be needing Tailwind as well uh because
if you look out the classes and all of
that yes there's a lot of Tailwind so
let's go ahead and install the tail as
well one more time in fact a a lot more
time will be coming up in the future as
well okay so this is what we have as a
tailwind and we need to actually copy
the content I'm pretty sure you might be
just kind of memorizing this at this
point of time okay the content will be
replaced save that and go
into uh main. jsx no index. CSS remove
everything and we'll be grabbing these
ones copy them and and paste them up
here save that we don't need anything
into the app. CSS as well just remove
everything we won't be needing we won't
be using actually the app itself okay
further uh let's go ahead and run npm
install npn run
Dev npm
run Dev and that should be up and
running on my system there we go basic
uh since the app.jsx is anyways getting
loaded let's go ahead and at least grab
some of the values out of it so we'll be
saying H1 U react
router react router
Dom and we'll be saying let's add a
class name and we'll be saying BG Das uh
what H
green suggestions yes BG green 300 let's
see yeah at least our Tailwind is
working all right we won't be touching
this thing here uh we'll be getting
started with couple couple of routes and
folders and uh basically trying to get a
feel of how the entire thing actually
works so first thing that we are going
to do is there's always components or
some people call it as Pages totally
depends on you how you want to call it
we'll start by calling this one as
component eventually as we go into the
mega projects we'll be designing
components and Pages as well but these
are just file names nothing really uh
bothers us so we'll be calling this one
as
components and this is just a directory
structure each one each instructor is
going to give you their best or their
practices which is being used in their
company uh we'll be creating a couple of
folders first and then we'll be going
through with that first of all let's go
ahead and call this one as header inside
the header I will have a new file and
I'll call this one obviously as a
header. jsx now nothing much in this
file I'll just say this is a div which
says header that is it absolutely that
nothing more than that now similarly in
the component there will be a new folder
and will be calling this one as footer
inside the footer we'll be having a new
file which we are going to call footer.
jsx there we go RFC we have just footer
this will help us to understand some of
the main concepts of how things are
actually being done or how things are
being laid out all right now the next
thing that we are going to do is once we
have these headers and Footers we will
be replacing them with the notes that we
have because if you remember uh this is
where actually our component comes up
this is where the header goes this is
where the footer component goes and
we'll be talking about them as well but
right now this is all what we have now
after this what we're going to do is uh
this component we'll be closing it down
in our main directory what we're going
to do is we won't be using this app.jsx
although you can no big deal there but
I'll be creating one more file inside
this which will be directly known as
layout and this is a common practice the
reason for creating this file is in our
application you'll see
uh that especially in this one that the
header always remains same the footer
always remains same only the inner
content changes from home to about and
all of that so we need to figure out a
way that we don't have to repeat ourself
that often we just want to grab a header
should always be there footer should
always be there and we'll be just
injecting the content in between that is
a common practice uh you'll find this
exactly same pattern being used in the
next JS and lot more stuff so we'll be
using that practice exactly here so
again RFC
react functional component which gives
me a layout exported that's it but what
additionally we can actually go ahead
and use the first concept about this uh
which you'll be using is known as Outlet
this Outlet is a special thing which is
uh coming up from react router Dom
remember so far we have been using just
the react or the react Dom but this
actually comes from react router Dom the
advantage of this is that I can go ahead
and return some special things first of
all let me import them I'll go ahead and
say say I need a header let's just say
header comes up like this I also need
footer footer also comes up like this uh
by the way we can export these
components into index file as well
that's totally your uh your call you can
go ahead and do this now here what I'll
do is I'll remove this I'll inject just
the fragments just like this and I'll
say there should always be a header all
right and there should always be a
footer so there we go and now what I'll
do is I'll inject a special element that
is given to me by the react router Dom
and call this one as Outlet uh it needs
to be always called as Outlet there is
no other name for it and this is
something which actually gives us this
capability that hey this will always be
on all the pages this one will be in all
the pages this is designing the layout
of the application now what's inside the
header what's inside the footer that's
not our call but they will always be
there and whatever the information that
you're using uh you can actually go
ahead and use that but the main question
that we have is that how it will know
that we are actually doing this because
right now if I just open the application
and I run this this is not going to work
so it's already running we don't need to
worry on that part if I go ahead and
open this up in the vit uh it doesn't
take place it doesn't actually does
anything uh the reason for that is in
the main. jsx or whatever your file is
in your case whatever you're using uh
you actually still serving app it
doesn't have the configuration which is
required to actually have this router
and this router has couple of ways of
how you can actually do the things I'll
show you both the ways which are
actually mentioned in the documentation
so the first thing that we are going to
do is keep this as it is we don't want
to touch it initially but we want to
create a router and this is the router
which I showed you initially that comes
up from this create browser router there
are multiple types of router that you
can use but we'll be using this create
browser router and we'll try to create a
path like this I'll show you this syntax
and there's another syntax as as well
I'll show you the both uh you can pick
up whichever you like so we can go ahead
and create a router so router and that
router will be created by create browser
router so again create browser router
comes from the react router Dom it's
nothing it's a function but this is a
function which doesn't work alone if you
look at the documentation this function
actually needs a route provider as well
but it's not just the route provider you
can see there are lots of ways of how
you can actually have the route provider
static route provider uh create a static
Handler there are a lot of ways browser
router so this documentation is quite in
depth and there are multiple use cases
for each one of them I'll show you the
most easiest one that what accompanied
you need to create this uh one and what
we'll be doing is uh simply we'll come
here and we'll take this one as
create browser router oops create
browser router is already there here and
we
need create route
elements yeah create route from elements
yep uh it's a little bit difficult to
remember this one but as you'll do a
couple of more projects you will be uh
familiar with that so once we have this
create browser router then inside this
you can go ahead and use this which is
create
browser create routes my bad create
routes from element this is again a
method this is again a method no big
deal there now inside this uh there's a
syntax that you have to follow so I'll
come back here you need a special
element uh known as route and this route
is obviously going to come from the
react router Dom and this route actually
works like component itself so just like
we saw that our empty components can
have headers and Footers and we also saw
that headers could wrap up inside
Footers and all these elements so just
like this route is nothing it's just a
component so notice like this is how it
works works so just a basic element
nothing more than that a component but
this route actually takes couple of
parameters and based on this how it
works it works on this kind of a
sandwich model that we have so we'll
first of all say that hey everything
will go inside the path of a slash and
what is the element that you want to
load every single time you have to
follow the same syntax you have to tell
it a path and what element to load in
that path element simply means what
components you want to load in my case
I'll just say hey element that I want to
load in this one I'll give it like this
I want to load an element known as
layout and there we go self closing of
course there we go now once I've have
done this now things will actually take
place and instead of having this app we
want to use this router inside one here
so there's again a syntax a little bit
Syntax for this one as well uh we now
don't want to use this app we want to
use our layout and want to load
everything inside it in fact if if we
have the app we want to load this inside
the layout itself so that the header and
footer always remains so we have to
remove this here uh this one goes away
this one doesn't load directly in fact
we go ahead and use a router provider
here again router provider comes up from
the react router and the whole idea
behind that it's a self closing element
you don't need to just have the ending
one and inside this you provide just one
Pam uh router which is the router Router
is the property and is the router which
we are creating uh make sure the router
provider is getting a operated and is
being taken care once we have this now
what you'll notice is we have this
header and footer since we haven't
provided any Outlet to this one that's
why only thing that's loading is header
and footer now in in this one you can
add as much as you like now let's take
care of this one here a little bit since
we have a couple of path to work on with
this one so we have this route element
and I told you this is like an element
like a sandwich that we have we saw the
sandwich kind of a thing here as well
and we can actually use that you might
have have seen that this is a opening
this is a closing one inside this you
can add as many as you like similar to
this we have this one but right now the
path that we are serving is this one so
inside this you can have as many routes
As You Wish further so these route uh
these route could be self closing or
could be the sandwiching one like this
one or you can have these ones as like
this self closing now here's the
interesting path first of all what path
do you want to load in this case I want
to load a path I'll tell you in a minute
what path to load single codes double
codes whatever but I don't have an
element in this one to load so what I'll
do is I'll quickly go ahead and create
another component in this one so right
click and we'll be creating a new folder
let's call this one as home doesn't
really matter we'll be using the
boilerplate code and we'll be saying
home. jsx and again RFC that's it all
what we have is a home text being
literally written now inside this I I
don't say anything I don't say a slash
or anything further because everything
now happening is after the slash that's
what the meaning of this first route at
line number 10 is now what element do
you want to load I want to load an
element which is home so I'll just go
ahead and say hey uh give me an element
which is home and self closing now when
I go back notice here the home element
gets loaded so that is the advantage of
this one in the basic layout notice here
I'm actually at the slash so this is
technically slash which is where I'm
home is loading now let's just say for
an example sake you want to have a
router which says about so again first
create that component itself so we'll
create a new folder we'll call this one
as about and right click and create a
new file let's call this one as about
about GSX of course and RFC nothing it
just says about literally nothing else
you guessed it right now after the slash
on the Home Route this works but I want
slash about to load that compter
component again go back here and simply
say route again this will be a component
so route self closing could be fine here
and then simply we will have a path
which is going to be like this this one
is going to be saying at this time we
need to change it as about remember we
are saying about here but this about is
after the slash because it is
sandwiching that one so sandwiching
concept comes up here so on the homepage
we have given a a uh a a layout a layout
a route here too too much difficult to
spell uh here we are saying that on the
same level on the same hierarchies after
the slash if I write about remember I
don't say slash about otherwise it will
be twice I just say about what element
do you want to load the element that I
want to load is going to be like this
and this one is definitely going to be
about and there we go self closing so
now technically I can go on to
slash and I can just go ahead and say
about notice here header and fo remains
same but my about changes so I can go
back this is home so this is the whole
idea whole concept if you want to go
further into this that I want about and
then after that uh some slash or
something like that uh then obviously
you can go ahead and say that hey this
is my about and slash this is where I'll
be loading this one so notice here I can
still go on to slash about and it still
works if you want to have it like this
again use the sandwiching concept so in
this case I'll just go ahead and say uh
route there we go and we'll end this one
oops my bad this one needs to go like
this and we don't need this one my
bad there we go so now we have a closing
one closing uh partner of this one now I
can go back and again start writing the
elements whatever that element is uh
this could be about and this could be
company and I can load any element
whatever I want so just remember the
concept of these sandwiching so one
thing can be inside it whenever you need
a further drill down path you can do
this if you don't want to do this just
use a self closing one that's also the
same so you get the idea how the concept
actually works all right so now we know
the basic principle of how the things
are there there are couple of more
principle that we need to actually go
ahead and work on with this and we need
to have a small discussion on this one
let's go on to the home not home header
header this is where we'll be working on
so again we need to copy paste on the Cs
for this one uh so we'll be grabbing
although we can just go ahead and grab
directly all of this we have the header
at the very top we'll be doing that but
there are some elements which actually
requires your attention into this part
so let's go ahead and grab remove this
one and we'll be having a simple header
just like this it will have a class name
and I'll obviously copy and paste the
class names this is the part where it's
little boring but don't worry there are
some interesting features here which we
want to discuss then we have a nav which
which we are writing again class
name and again the class name will
remain the same so copy and paste that
so now that we have nav inside the nav
we will be writing variety of links now
your first intention would be just to
use a tag this is where things can go
actually wrong so I'll just have a div
another one here because that's how we
laid out while designing this so I'll
just have the class names copy that
paste that up here and inside this div
we have all the links what you saw
earlier on on the web page uh like here
home about and all of that so they are
just obviously they are just uh links
all inside this one so we'll be using
that now the first intention is uh
always go and use the a tag and just
write this remember the a tag the whole
idea behind using the anchor tag is to
move on to different resources when you
use a tag the page actually reloads it
remounts because the control is given to
the browser and the Dom which is in the
browser itself we don't want that
because page should not not reloaded
it's a single page application and that
is why every single router no matter
it's in NEX shs or react or wherever it
is it is giving you some ways of
navigating things because remember this
is all a facade this is not real this is
just a simulation of moving to slash
about and wherever it actually never
goes there so that is why in every
single time you'll find something known
as link or somewhat similar to that
which is actually coming up from as you
noticed here a react router remember it
always comes from from react autodom or
somewhat like that and we work through
that so in this case we'll be just
saying that hey uh we'll be having uh a
link and again this could be a self
closing one or you can just go ahead and
close it like this so I can just go
ahead and say SL link like this again it
could be self closing it could be like
this totally up to you now in this link
what do you want to have uh we have just
an image with the logo or something like
this so in the image part we are not
talking that much but yeah we just added
an image or something like this but
notice here this link is pretty
interesting this is not your a tag it
doesn't have an href it has rather a tag
of known as two and this two will take
you wherever you like to go so this is
the interesting part where you should
pay attention so if I go back up here
notice here this logo uh comes up here
so simply go ahead and works on with
that we just found a random logo on the
internet and we worked on with that now
similar to this you can actually have
more of this in fact now I can go ahead
and bring all of this header component
up here so if I just go back here
here copy this exactly same thing so I
can just now replace and talk about it
paste this and we have exported default
all of this but the only thing that is
still required is to import the links
and all of that otherwise it will yell
at you so go ahead and import uh react
do we need react I don't think so we
need react but still if it is saying
I'll just grab it uh we need link
definitely because we discussed about it
and the link is going to come from react
router and not only link uh let me show
you a couple of more stuff so the link
is actually one way of navigating from
one place to another place so notice
here mostly the link is used but there
is also a nav link being used so nav
link is also a part like that so
navigation link uh right now we are just
using it as a basic but nav link
actually gives you a couple of more
features like on what page you are and
what values you can actually use so
we'll see some of the variations and
versions of that as well but right now
we'll just import that and leave it
remember link is not the only way of
navigating we have the nav link as well
and we can read about the documentation
of this one if they have any Global
search I don't think
so uh let's just say components you can
see the nav link here and what you'll
see in the nav link uh you can find out
pretty easily what class is active and
what ends and all of that so notice here
uh it says two messages so the link and
nav link almost same the two section and
everything is uh almost same the only
thing additional with the nav link is
you actually get this is active and is
pending and all of that so why using
this is active which whenever you use
any class name or any Arrow functions
like this it is available to you
directly uh notice here they also say
this a nav link is a special kind of
link that knows whether it is active or
not so when you go up onto the
applications like this and when you say
that hey uh this page is active or this
page is active just like that that whole
functionality can be done via the nav
link so that's why we have this nav link
uh all right uh by the way notice here
this is exactly what we are doing uh
whatever the values are active and all
of that uh we'll talk about that uh
later on in the some sections where
we'll be having in fact we can actually
talk about this into about whatnot so
this is get started then we have couple
of nav links on the home actually we
have just one on the home we can design
it right now itself so let's just say on
the home uh what you can do is you can
just add a couple of more practices and
what the text you want so for example
now we are in the nav Link in the class
name itself since we are using a call
back this is the syntax exactly they are
also mentioning it so we are not doing
anything special in the class name
property we have the access of this call
back and then we can write all this so
this is exactly what we'll be also doing
so in this one we have the access to
this is active remember this needs to be
exactly as is active or is pending so we
don't decide the variable name in here
so we have this is active and by by the
way uh one more thing which usually I
also forget this is active needs to be
extracted as a property like this so
yeah I also make sometimes this mistake
so let's go ahead and keep it up like
this and now you have access to is
active now based on is active we can
decide whether the color is going to be
gray or this one so we'll just actually
cut this out we want to cut this one out
and once we are cutting this out we can
inject the JavaScript again and
by the
way dollar sign is missing yeah now we
are happy okay now based on is active we
can do a question mark and aary operator
here if it is active uh then we can go
ahead and use a text of uh not this one
text orange so we'll just say text Dash
orange we'll be probably using 700
version of it that's what we used and
here we can use a text- gray 700
gray 700 no
suggestions there we
go no suggestions strange uh anyways we
can just find it out later on if we are
doing any mistake and by the way this
needs to be wrapped inside the quotes
because it's a class not a variable
class I mean to say uh types Tailwind
class so that is all what we have and
based on this we can have a nav link
which can provide you whether you are
active or not onto this one
so nav link should be refined so now we
have on home but if I go on to
about so we have the
home and if I go on to slash
about uh this should be technically
going away we shouldn't be having this
link as if it is true then it's 700 if
it is false it goes like this but gray
we'll we'll see that how this actually
works and how we can actually have more
links onto this one uh this one is nav
link we haven't mentioned the two we
have to mention that otherwise how it
will work and we'll be saying that hey
you will be on slash so now it will keep
a track of there we go now if I go back
to home it's orange but if I go back to
slash about we are not active there we
go told you simple okay now we can have
multiple of these allies and can Define
home about whatever you wish so I'll
just copy and paste from lii I'll just
duplicate this
and this one is going to be slash
about and there we go now forgot to
change the
text about save that now we can travel
to home we can travel to about and
similarly we can have more of these uh
so if I remember we have home about and
we will also have the contact so I'll
just duplicate this one I hope you
remember the shortcut for duplicating in
vs code if not right now is the good
time to find it out about okay uh home
Conta
contact this one is going to
be
contact uh we also will have probably
GitHub as well uh we'll be having some
fun with GitHub as well all right copy
and paste
that this one will say I'll go to GitHub
component wherever that
is all right so now we have home uh we
have about although there is nothing
inside the contact so this route doesn't
uh is there so we need to actually
Define our 404 route as well we can work
on with that but at least our home and
about component are there and we now
know about the nav link which is a
special kind of a link and we are aware
of how things are there now with this we
can actually go ahead and move on and
work with the footer which is super easy
now you can go onto my notes and this is
the footer just scroll it on the all the
way to the right and you'll find this
copy button or you can manually copy and
paste that and all we have to do is
paste this all here since we have link
uh in this one so just go ahead and fix
the errors let's first import the
react import react and then we'll be
importing the
link and that link is from react router
Dom technically we should be all good
now so we can see at least home and
about but our footer is coming so it's
looking nice as well uh apart from this
there is no big deal and no facade about
it similarly we have a home component as
well we can go back and replace it with
the home so again it will look just a
little bit beautiful nothing more than
that and
home select all replace it I don't think
so we have anything in this required uh
let's just try this save this and go
back and do we have some links yep we
have some links in the home as well so
let's import that no big deal in fact we
can actually copy paste footer yeah
let's just copy and paste all right
let's come
here and there we go should be all okay
now there we go so we have homepage so
we have learned how we can design that
home about uh and whatnot so I'm leaving
this contact page to you as a simple
exercise all you have to do is go up
here uh we have the contact us page as
well and go ahead and work on with the
contact us page about us page about I
can I can do this fun for you okay so
about is here uh we'll be replacing it
with here and we'll be importing the
link link if we have I don't think so we
have link from react rodom let's see if
we have about yep home is looking good
about is looking good contact is uh for
your exercise maybe maybe I don't know
uh we'll try to have some of the work
with the contact and user and whatnot
okay uh one more thing that we'll be
doing is we'll be creating another
component uh let's go back onto the code
side of
it and we'll be creating another
component let's call this one as user
because I want to show you some more uh
ideas that you'll be using let's call
this one as simple
user and we'll be having a simple layout
here new file that will be user.
jsx and just the basic RFC so we have a
user now in order to make sure that this
component loads somewhere we have too
many files opened up I would love to
close that in order to make sure that I
have a really huge code base into the
user in order to load this I need to go
into main. jsx and how can I load a
route which actually loads this one so I
can just go ahead and say that hey I
want to have a route and this route will
be on going to whatever the path you ask
me to do so I'll just say hey go on to
user and the component or the element
that I'll be loading here is going to be
a
user
user it doesn't suggest me user okay
I'll write that again I want
suggestions okay there we go and in here
we'll be saying hey give me user it
doesn't give me user save that and
probably this will give us
issues uh it surely will I will just
first remove this about because we don't
want that the element should be user H
it should be Auto importing that and
we'll be saying import user from
component user user jsx okay all happy
now can we have another link for the
user itself uh probably yes let's go
into the header header and can we have
another
Li for the user itself let's try this
link go ahead copy and duplicate that
this will be going to uh user and we'll
be calling this one as user how easy
that was okay now if I go back to the
user okay I get the user now in this
user first of all let's just uh
centraline some of the stuff we don't
want it like that so we'll be adding
some of the class name we'll be adding
some of the background BG Das orange
suggestions uh we'll be using orange
like this and we'll be saying text-
black and text-
3X
3XL text Dash three come on suggestions
3x no suggestions
yeah text 3 Excel and we'll be saying
text Center just to make sure things are
all good and okay at least they are
visible we can even add a petting on y
AIS of five yeah better okay so so far
we are all good and we understand this
part is there but there will be cases in
your uh situation where the user will be
dynamic uh so Dynamic routing is a very
common scenario so for example the user
ID is why cannot write it here uh
something like 1 2 3 or maybe username
with a username of AES so I want to grab
this path and this URL so that Dynamic
capturing is one of the Core Essence of
how you'll be using the route the way
how we use it is actually simply go
ahead and simply write something here
which is Slash and then the colon is
important this is how you capture
anything out uh after the user slash
whatever comes next to it you'll be able
to capture that and then carefully name
this parameter this is a placeholder
user ID this could be just ID this is
could be product ID whatever you want
this could be anything like that but
this is not job done because if you go
back up here user definitely uh that's
all good but if I go back so notice here
the user now we are saying hey this is
not happening because I don't know what
to do with this uh this obviously will
give us error now we need to go into the
user and figure out a way that we accept
all these things now in order to make
sure that we have defined that this path
is actually accepting the parameters and
whatnot we have to use use the pams and
yes this is literally the name and we
call this one as use
pams no
suggestions use params no no suggestions
yeah that's bad and that actually comes
from react router
Dom okay and why are you having issues
because I wrote const import there we go
now all you have to do in this case is
this used peram is actually a hook we
studed hook quite a lot and this is a
hook that means it's a function nothing
more than that but what this function
gives us back that is important for us
so it gives us a lot of things we can
extract some information out of it what
information to extract yes exactly user
ID why user ID because we called this as
a user ID in this place and after the
colon the colon is a symbol that hey
this will be going into use param and
you'll be able to extract this with a
key ID of user ID just right here now
let's just go back what happens if I go
ahead and get back uh it says Hey prop
on Route error
boundary okay looks like this one is
okay but my main. GSX is having some of
the issues let's go back onto main. jsx
this one user path element is all
okay should be all
okay and let's also check the user I'll
be exporting that export
default user we are exporting that let
me quickly check that why this is
yelling at me
all right so found the bug a pretty easy
one uh probably because it's late night
sometimes these things happens so again
uh we are actually good uh in this case
already uh the issue that we are facing
is pretty easy actually if I go ahead
and refresh this this page works but if
I go onto the slash user or uh this one
this doesn't works because we never
defined the route that what happens when
the slash user only comes we are only
defining and are talking about what
happens when the user slash and some
parameters comes into that piure picture
so the easy way to fix it is actually to
remove this let's cut this out and let's
not make this one as self- closing use
the sandwich of uh concept that we
studied about so we'll be saying that
hey let's just go ahead and close this
route now we can use the sandwiching
concept and then I can use the inside
the sandwich route which obviously will
make it as slash everything is inside
slash then we have user on the user will
load the element user and after that if
there is a colon which technically makes
user slon user ID we will load again the
user element so very basic uh but again
sometimes these things uh do take some
time to debugging uh so there we go we
have this user and what additionally
what we did is inside the user one since
we extracted this user ID I just placed
it here it just a variable I am
displaying a variable in JavaScript I'm
not doing any magic here so when I go
back here the advantage of this is now
anything that comes up here in the URL
after this whatever the dynamic route I
will be able to catch this Dynamic route
for example if I just have something
like hes here I can grab this maybe uh
this is something on the user page where
you have some clickable elements and why
clickable elements you are coming onto
some GitHub user ID some a blog or
anything so I can grab elements from the
URL itself make a fetch request and get
the data so this is the whole idea of uh
doing everything that we are doing up
here all right so now let's go ahead and
work on with some more stuff which is
also pretty interesting and A New
Concept in this one and actually uh
nextjs also uses this same concept so
we'll be working on with this one I hope
the center element of this one how the
routers and the dynamic parameter comes
up this is all clear to you and by the
way even if you don't put this one and
directly put up this then the user route
will not work but user slash whatever
something will also work okay uh going
back we need one more route to work on
with this one so we'll go out of the
sandwiching we are not interested in
this one first let's create a new
component that component will be again
very basic uh but very interesting one
actually let's go ahead and call this
one as GitHub and inside this we'll be
creating a component known as GitHub jsx
of course.
jsx again RFC that is it now in this uh
GitHub and all of this what we want to
do this here is just simply show some
data into this one first let's go ahead
and create this route that would be
super beneficial for us so we'll be
having a route
route and there we go and we don't want
this path estri this simply means when
you have estri that means all the 404
found just load this element up here so
now if we have this element make sure
this is at the very end of it because
they are evaluated on Case by case basis
now if we reach out to something like uh
something like
contact uh which we don't have defined
it just says not found GitHub which is
not yet defined so it says not found so
this is a classic example of if nothing
cases so have you studied switch in
cases yeah this is almost like that uh
but before that make sure it is always
at the end we also want to have this
GitHub so we'll be having a route uh
path will be GitHub and the element that
we'll be loading is going to be
GitHub yep bring this one in here and
now we have this GitHub and let's uh
modify this a little bit not too much
but at least bearable so we'll have some
of the class name let's graph first of
all text to the the center uh will be
having a margin of four on all the sides
background will be gray how much gray
600 is good enough text can be white and
what else uh padding would be four on
all the side and text would be large so
3XL would be good and there we go we
have decent stuff coming up in here okay
now we have this one now I want to fetch
some data from the API itself and if you
remember fetching the data data is not
that hard and I can just visit this URL
and grab some of the data and it's an
object that is being thrown at me it's a
public URL you can also go ahead and
make a uh fetch request there so as soon
as this component mounts I want this
request to be come to be fetched up to
me and I want to use that so one easy
way of doing that is uh have a simple
data as my state so set data and we'll
be using react. user state by default it
will be an empty array object
uh whatever you like to have we'll just
have an empty null we'll have an array
or maybe an object we we'll figure it
out okay now I can use a use effect hook
so use effect in this and there we go we
have a use effect it has no dependency
array so there we go and now what will I
do here I'll fetch so I'll say
fetch okay this is a nice spoiler plate
but I'll write my own I'll simply say we
want to fetch this URL if this URL gets
a success so we'll say do then it will
give me a call back I'll say let's call
this one as response but response is in
the string format I need to convert it
into Json so let's have the response.
Json okay then chain on one more then
because that will actually extract the
data and we'll be having again a call
back let's call this one as data there
we go call back just like this and we
can console log the data as well as set
the data into the data so there we go
now the data is being set into this one
and now we can extract some of the data
out of this one okay uh let's first
console log and see if this is all
coming up when we hit this particular
route right click inspect and console
okay too much and we will expand this a
little
bit there we go so if I go back to
contact and load the GitHub it gets
nothing uh as of now because we are not
using it technically okay uh time to
actually use this data itself H
interesting how we can use this uh once
the data is actually being set as soon
as the component mounts save this go
back and now I can see I have this
object H let's reload this one more time
probably I didn't save that okay uh fill
rule did you mean fill rule no all these
okay uh these are just the CSS and Dom
properties not interested in them
contact GitHub there we go now I have
this object which has a lot of data and
probably out of this data because I'm
console logging the data and I am
console logging this so let's extract
some values out of it so what values can
I grab first of all the followers count
maybe
followers there we go and let's inject
the variables since I have access to
this data and if you have studied this
you know that I've actually gone through
many times you can just extract what do
you want I want just the followers count
here so that's why I just mentioned this
and there we go I get the followers
count so notice here we can grab the
image as well should be yeah let's grab
the
image and I'll say I'll be needing an
image there we go what is the
source source will come up from data if
the data has
aore URL and we'll also need to give a
width of
300 all right so we have this image as
well as all this data now here comes the
interesting part where things will get a
little bit more interesting towards the
router I go into about I go into contact
when I go on to GitHub that is where the
request is being sent uh we cannot
simulate this one as to come up after a
few seconds but what you'll notice that
use effect will only take place when
this component particularly uh loads up
on the page so contact when I go up here
so this will make a fetch request now
what if we could have done this a little
bit better uh can we optimize this this
is already very optimized but what if uh
there could be Advanced stage of this
one like for example I'm going into
contact before clicking on this I keep
my mouse over for probably a fraction of
second milliseconds but then I click on
it the same thing can be used for the
advantage nextjs does exactly same when
you actually pull your mouse over over
this one it automatically sends a
network request to load all the
resources that you require and then when
you click on it the things are already
available for you now how can we do this
in this scenario with the react router
Dom in the next years it happens
automatically behind the scene but how
we can actually do this one up here now
doing this all of this thing is actually
super super easy let me show you how
this is done first of all we don't need
this data and all of that this was just
to show you that how regularly we do
this again a good example EX size we'll
just comment this one out and we'll
write this thing again you can usually
there's a uh case where people write
these kinds of methods in the component
itself but if you wish you can separate
that out as well all you have to do is
export a a a kind of a method we'll call
this one as GitHub info
loader uh and this one is going to be a
simple call back just like this but the
only method only Advantage we want to
take care here is we want to make this
request as a sync previously we were
using uh the fetch in the then syntax
you can use that as well but I want a
Sync here as well uh so what we'll do is
we'll obviously await and we'll do the
fetch because I don't want to continue
if this is not there and the fetch is
going to fetch the same URL no changes
there we know that this works and let's
hold the response into a variable so
let's call this one as
resonse so there we go and now all we
have to do is return
return this response we don't need to
await this here response.
Json okay now uh notice here we are not
we are just responsing returning this
response we are not having this data and
whatever that is the good thing is I can
return this as it is now once you are
returning this then the next step
actually is almost in this file but we
don't do this here because this is not
the data flow understanding the data
flow is important once you done with
this this method actually first gets
loaded into main. jsx where you're
actually having this routing so this
method needs to come up here let's go
ahead and since the method actually
exist in the same component that is why
a lot of people prefer to have this here
we can just go ahead and say uh this one
is going to be GitHub infol loader
whatever the name is and then once we
are done with this we don't actually
load the GitHub just like this we
actually provide additional property no
we don't need to use the sandwiching but
we need to provide additional the path
will be same the element will be same
but there is one more element or prop
which is known as loader this loader
actually takes a method that whatever
the information you need to fetch
calculate whatever you need to do just
get me that method first so that if
somebody is trying to load this route I
can do some of my advanc pre-processing
on it once you're done with this the
next question in your mind would be okay
we created a method in this file we
exported gave this method to this guy
but how can I get the data from this
whole method I have return turn the
response but I need this uh this is a
common mistake that a lot of people do
this hey since you have exported this
here let's use this method and grab the
data no no you don't do that that's not
a proper way of doing the things in this
case when you want to have this you
actually use a hook which is given to by
to you by react router Dom so let's go
ahead and use this and this one is
coming going to come up from react
router Dom the name of the hook is
pretty simple uh you can guess that use
loader data yeah the property name there
is loader and here is the use loader
data since this is a hook you obviously
know how to use the hook so it's a
simple use uh use loader just like this
it's a method there we go and you can
extract data from it so call this one as
data since all the variables that we
named them as a data. follower so this
will have that object and you can
extract the information so now uh
technically it looks same that hey we
have contact about now if I go to GitHub
it technically looks same but it's
actually doing uh a lot of
pre-processing for you in the smaller
application like this it is little bit
difficult to find that it is adding some
value for us but trust me it is adding a
lot lots of value and this exact same
pattern you don't have to use that much
of hooks and stuff is used in the nextjs
as well they also do a lot of
pre-loading and pre-processing of data
uh a lot of fun stuff is there but by
the way this whole thing is actually
available in case you want to use
classic react in some of the
applications uh you can actually go
ahead and use that by the way there's a
lot of things you can go ahead and work
on with this one there's so much of
routes available a one that we studied
is use params so user ID use params this
is exactly what we studied uh we have so
much more use submit user route there's
there's so much of advancement in fact
there could be a separate course on this
in itself I'll try probably in the
future to create one such if you have if
you really want this one to happen let
me know in the comment section I would
love to do this as as a course in itself
so uh this is pretty good of one crash
course on the react router all the
advanced things which you probably are
going to need are covered up yes there
are still more uh something like
forcefully pushing the user onto some
page once we have logged in and all of
this will be covered up later on when
we'll do some of the mega project but I
think that is enough that is more than
enough for you as a react router crash
course uh that's it for this one make
sure you leave a comment in the comment
section I would be really really
appreciating that that's it for this
video and let's catch up in the next one
hey there everyone AES here back again
with another video and Welcome to our
ongoing react series I hope you're
enjoying this series because I'm
enjoying it so much teaching this series
uh first of all a very basic Target for
you to hit that uh comment section uh
we're expecting just 100 uh comments if
you can uh that would be great uh so
just hit that comment section first uh
just do the comment some appreciation or
maybe I'm just watching it on this date
and let's continue the journey of react
and now we'll take our journey now we
are pretty much comfortable with the
loops uh with the hooks uh pretty much
looping the things variable fetch uh API
fetching and all of these things uh it's
time that we explore a more advanced
feature in the react now one of that
feature is how do we handle the data now
one of the primary job of the react is
to handle the reactions and that's why
we called it as react the reactions
happens basically on two major factor
the first one is the props and the
second one is a state and you will be
passing on this data into various of
these component let me show you we have
already seen that by creating a card
component that you provide some data to
that card component whether fetching it
from an API or just generating that data
however you pass that data that data uh
passing is very common and let me show
you one such example uh that is pretty
common so let me share the screen first
so this is the diagram let's just say
this is our dashboard main component and
inside this we have divided the pages
just like previously we have divided uh
into navigation bar Footers and whatnot
uh this time let's just say this is our
home dashboard inside the dashboard
there is some another second component
then inside that there is one more
component and finally this is the
component which is showing some of the
data like displaying how many people
have watched your video and if you look
at the current perspective this is very
Troublesome because uh this inner
component is actually called inside this
component and this component is getting
called inside this component this
component gets called to this component
right now we have no way absolute zero
way that we can actually pass on data
from this outer component to this
component in order to do so that hey if
I want to pass on this I have to first
from this element or is this from this
component I have to pass on data to this
component this component will further on
pass on data to this component and
finally this component will pass on data
to this component so you can see here
that we are passing props into these
component and all of this is not really
bad but one thing that is bad here is
this component is not using any data
still it has to just access the data
just to pass it on and for one level
it's okay but if you can see here the
moment it goes onto second level or
third level you can see where the
problem comes up some of the components
which don't need this data also have to
access this unnecessary data and based
on this have to evaluate whether should
I render reender and what not but they
are not using this data ultimately this
inner component is using that data so
how can we resolve this problem this
problem can be resolved by just one
simple solution which is also termed
known as State Management now there are
lots of State Management libraries some
are inbuilt into react some only one and
there are other thirdparty libraries
which you can study and we will study
them so one uh easiest of the solution
is let's just say we have this uh Global
variable uh that would be a good name
and somehow we start a mechanism that if
anybody wants to access the data all he
has to do every single time is just go
up and ask this guy that hey I want to
access this data if anybody else wants
to access any data let's just say this
element then he has to go and just go
for this guy and ask data to this guy
there is no other way if you want to
update anything if you want to uh want
to access any information you ask this
guy if this is the central source of
truth that's what it is happening here
and this Global uh variable is known as
a store in some languages or some
Frameworks not languages in some
Frameworks every single framework we
call it as a different one the one that
we are going to study is known as
context API So This Global is known as
context I'll show you more of that the
idea is really simple we will have a
separate strategy and the only thing is
that all of these components are aware
of this global state that is all that is
all it is now this concept can be a
little bit tricky to understand because
of the code issues not the concept issue
the concept is this much that we have a
central place from where we can access
the data whenever we want we can update
any data in that Central repository from
whatever the component we want this is
the centralized concept but just because
there are so many ways of writing this
exact same code there are multiple
iterations of that that makes people
confused that okay what is the syntax so
understanding the data flow is easy but
writing the syntax is a little bit
tricky and that's why I'll walk you
through with a couple of syntaxes so
that you can know okay this one is
exactly same this one is exactly same
and this one is also exactly same so
we'll be working on with that so I have
a small flow diagram for you so what
we'll be doing is we'll starting uh
we'll start the project and we'll create
a react app why V or whatever however we
do that then we are going to create a
context the context nothing this is the
context this separate thing then we
simply create a provide the context or
also known as context provider what do I
mean by context provider making sure
that all of my components that I have is
aware of it they are not going to be
aware of them automatically there is a
mechanism there is a flow of the data
that hey all the components now are
aware that there is a global state so
that I can access my data so the next
step is this one provide the context and
the third step is consume it wherever
you want however you want you just
consume it so this is exactly what we
are going to do in this video and in the
next video itself I'll walk you through
one more iteration of this exact same
process but with a different minor
tweaking in the code itself so you get
the multiple idea of how the code is
being written so we'll just close this
one and we'll just get started with this
one this is absolutely easy nothing to
be worried I'll just open up my oh
there's something already running all
right so we'll close this and let's go
ahead and start this one so this one
will be our new project uh probably
eight uh so we'll just call this one as
create no not create my bad npm create
V and we'll be going with the latest yep
and we will be starting project name so
this one is 08 and we are talking about
mini context so let's just call this one
as mini context context API that's
exactly what we are studying and the
best part about the context API is you
don't need to install anything else
that's the best part about it uh let me
just dump this open this up an
integrated terminal and we'll just say
npm install should be fairly faster uh
the best thing which I love about it is
we don't need any third-party resources
the context API is directly cooked in
inside the react it was not there in the
earlier version but as the react evoled
as a library it it got this one and then
we can say npm run Dev that should be
easy and this is how the basic looks
like we won't be even installing
anything into it no Tailwind nothing we
we just want to go absolute Basics now
first let's try to create a problem that
is the major thing that how we are going
to create this a problem first so let's
just say inside the source we'll right
click and we'll create a new folder
first let's Place everything inside the
components and this is a legit problem
that we'll have and new file the first
file is going to be simple login uh we
won't be doing too much into the login
so R fce react oh nothing oh my bad it
should not be login uh it should be
login jsx rename login.
jsx and now we can see
RFC come on
RFC there we go we can close this down
so this one is not going to be too much
of a problematic uh I'll just be writing
the basic boilerplate code uh you can
also write along with me that would be
really really helpful so first of all
what I'm trying to create this is a
basic login so login has a username and
a password it it doesn't connect any
with any database it's absolute basic
raw one here so let's go ahead and say
that I will have a username and that
will be a set username by default it's
empty we will also have a password field
let's just say the password field
nothing else it's not doing anything now
uh once we have this we will we'll need
that something that needs to handle that
we'll obviously have a login field the
password field and a button so let's
just go ahead and call this one as
handle submit that's okay for me and
inside this we are not going to do
anything so we'll just write empty
slashes uh prevent the page from
refreshing yeah whatever that is and not
really bothered or much worried about
this one in this one let's go ahead and
add those fields so first of all we'll
have a simple H2 which says login this
is my login component so that I know and
aware about it then we are going to have
an input with the type of
text text there we go uh we don't need
this name or ID so I'll be just removing
this
and there we go let's move it to the
next line we'll be adding couple of
fields onto this one not too many just
the basic however we do that all the
time so on change is going to be uh
first of all we need the value one but
yeah on change is also good that at the
time of changing this is the input field
for username so let's go ahead and add
the value as well that you get the value
from the username once you have all of
this let's also add a placeholder the
value of username and what else I think
that's it okay uh another input field
that we are going to need is first I'll
add some of the spaces so line break
there space and then we'll be having an
input of type
password there we go and there we go my
bad what is happening there okay so this
is input type password this one okay we
don't need this ID or this
stuff let's move it to the next line
This one is all also going to move the
next line and again really basic first
of all the value the value will be
derived by password let me scroll this
and then we have on
change on change the value is going to
be governed by the set password that we
have let's add a placeholder and that
will say password and after this we will
be having a button let's add a simple
Button as
well button there we go this button is
going to say simp please
submit and we'll be having an onclick
event on this one since we didn't
created any form so we're going to say
onclick and on the on click this is
handled by the handle submit so this
kind of a component you have always
built now we have a simple value how it
is handling we'll talk about that first
let's create what the problem what we
have now similar to this component you
will also be dealing with this in the
real world application as well which is
going to be
profile profile if I can write that
jsx and let's go out of CE very basic
and in the profile all what I want to do
is let's put a space is I want to
display a username right now I don't
have a username but somehow I want to
display the username so how can I do it
and I am pretty sure you are not
understanding the gravity of the
situation right now this is so much of a
big problem and you might be saying hey
what's the deal with that why is it so
much of problematic I can go simply into
my app.jsx or main. jsx or any place at
all and I can just go ahead and load
this up like for example in the app.jsx
I can go and remove all of this content
that I have so let's just go ahead and
remove all of this and I can load these
component here for example I'll just say
H1 here and I'll say react course or
react video would be good react video
for context
API and then here at this place I can
load the login component just like this
and I can go ahead and load the user
component not user
profile profile here you go and the
profile component is there any issue
with that if I reload this there
shouldn't be any issue let's go ahead
and inspect this this should be loading
up uh use state is not defined my bad uh
we're using State here so this one is
going to give us use state
I don't like to edit out these problems
because these problems are something
which teach you stuff so as we can see
there is nothing wrong with this one we
are able to load this one now your first
initial reaction would be that if I can
load all of this probably I can just
pass on data of the login and all in the
app.js and from here I can pass on this
but imagine the situation that from the
profile this data actually goes to other
third component which are loaded inside
the profile just like here I can add
more things just like I was able to load
in my app.js this profile thing I can
also go ahead and load more stuff so I
can just go ahead and literally say uh
more component so what's stopping you to
have more component here uh maybe you
are having a dashboard if I can write
that component it's hard to type and
talk at the same time so imagine that
this is a dashboard on the dashboard you
have left pan and right pan you want to
display the data on the right pane but
right pane is not alone further that
there is a top section and bottom
section so twoo two more component in
the top section you want to display this
data profile username but the top
section is also composed of smaller
components so how long you're going to
be passing these components back and
forth you get the idea now you get the
point that we need some better solution
and this is exactly why we have the
solution up here that we want to create
a simple Global state where we can add
all of these thing and this is known as
context in the context API and the
context provider but in the case of
Redux I I have that video as well we
will we'll be talking about that you'll
find that video in the playlist as well
so you can see that there we call it as
store so call it store call it context
the concept is exactly same we need a
centralized repository centralized uh
store where we can have all of this data
this is exactly what we're doing so now
it's time that we understand that how we
can actually implement the context no
extra Library needed the step one is to
create a context and then to create a
provider so first of all let's
understand that how we create this
context it's a simple step if you're
taking the notes you can take them as
well all right so we'll come back onto
these logins and profile in a minute
first of all let's close this one inside
this let's create a new folder and let's
call this one as context creation of the
context has two parts some people do
that these two parts into separate files
some people do that in one file doesn't
really matter I'll walk you through with
both scenarios first one here the basic
the second one will be a little bit more
advanc not Advanced but yeah easier so
let's create a new file and first we're
going to call this one as user cont
context uh by the way you can have
multiple contexts since this is not
going to return any jsx I'll just call
this one as just the JS now this context
uh could be M for multiple reasons or
multiple resources this one is for user
context uh another thing could be for
product cont uh context another thing
could be tweets context so uh just like
everything needs a context in the real
world this is exactly where it comes
from for example fan you don't
understand anything with the fan it
could be a ceiling fan it could be a
table fan it could be a fan in terms of
a Bollywood fan Hollywood fan a YouTuber
fan it has a context it needs a context
that's exactly what we have so we're
going to go ahead and say hey react
let's come react and react uh directly
gives you this context so all we have to
do is user context react. create context
just like you import use State and all
of that we have the create context as
well and after that you all you do is
export user context so your question
might be okay we have that empty repo
the store which will be holding all of
this is related to the user but where is
the data there is no data you are
absolutely correct there is no data when
you create the context that's the step
one now once the context is created the
step two is actually to create a
provider or the context provider because
right now it is not usable so something
needs to uh be a central man which can
allow me to access the data as well as
feed the data ins in into that so let's
go ahead right click and create a new
file and we'll be calling this one as
user context uh
provider and this one is actually jsx
because this is a wrapper as I told you
uh we need a wrapper this whole thing
everybody should be aware of it the way
how we do it in react is we create a
rapper just like for example in this
case if I go into main. GSX you can see
that this react strict mode is a wrapper
for all of my component that I'm
creating because the app further down
the road Road app actually loads these
guys so all these guys are actually also
loading in the strict mode why just
because of this one this one is wrapping
the entire application so we need to
create a context provider and we need to
learn that how these sandwiching rule
actually applies so it's actually not
really that bad it's actually simple so
we'll be having first let's just say
react and we'll be using are we going to
use uh use State probably not okay uh
but we'll see that in a minute and we
need to import the context
that is the most important part so now
you have access to the context which you
just created and now we'll be using that
so the first thing that we are going to
do in this case is how to create this
context uh we have this and this now
let's go ahead and create the user
context provider yeah that that's a good
name user context provider this is
nothing just a simple method just like
that a simple arrow method just like
that okay so far it's good now the next
step is to export this so go ahead and
and Export default user context provider
now this is where the functionality goes
the first thing that you should know or
you should be aware of this is that
there will be more components which will
be coming inside you just like we use
the outlet yeah exactly same concept
almost exactly so first thing is as a
prop what you'll be getting you'll be
getting childrens's so just write
children if I can write that correct uh
you have to actually return that
children back but before that we need to
actually say that what is the data that
you'll be using or something like that
so I'll be saying that hey I'm having a
state so I'll be just calling this one
as user and then I'll be having a set
user this is right now an empty object
that is also good but right now we don't
have any user so rather having an empty
object I'll just say null I have nothing
a as of now after that I'll just go
ahead and use the return with the
parenthesis and what I'll do is I'll be
using this user uh context. provider and
yes this is a syntax we cannot not do
anything for that come on user context
do provider and this is how it looks
like user context provider this is
something which is given to you by
default the moment you use the user
context it automatically gives you the
access to provider uh the reason for
that is react gives us this create
context the moment you have used this
this was given to you by the react
itself now inside this you actually do
nothing and you just add a children this
is the syntax but alone this is not
useful because now your entire
application will be aware after 1 second
we will use it exactly just like we used
this rest strict mode we will be using
it exactly almost that uh but right now
it is having the access of it but the
reason why we created this user state so
that this data should be accessible to
all the children that's the goal if you
have more data add more things here add
more calculation maybe you want to have
a fetch request and whatever comes back
from the fetch you want to give that
access of it to all the con all the
components you do exactly like this but
right now I have a variable which
through which I can access the data I
have a method through which I can set
any data into this user so I have access
to all of this now I want to pass on
this so the way how you do it is simply
add a value and you simply say as an
object that I want to give you access of
this user I also want to give you access
of the set user so that you can read the
data as well as write the data in this
state all right so that's the next step
or the step two of having all of this
but now I know that my entire app.jsx is
actually loading all of this so somehow
whole of the things which are inside the
app. JX should be aware of this how
that's going to happen very very simple
instead of wrapping it into this uh
fragments I can just go ahead and say
hey user context provider and it
actually Imports it from the perfect
place I'm happy with this a user context
provider and We R wrap this up just like
that here and there we go the moment you
added this that is it now all of these
components which are wrapped inside it
are aware of that data now you could
have technically uh you could have gone
into app this main.js and could have
added here that's okay now your app is
aware of it inside any component of the
app he's also aware of it he or she
whatever you want to term it as so this
is really nice now we have actually set
up the boiler plate code and this is
exactly the same syntax that you'll be
using your data might be tremendous
amount in the smaller amount doesn't
really matter but now you have set up
the stage so this is a boiler plate
every single time you have to do now
what's important is how do we actually
send data into this state and retrieve
that State uh data from back from it so
obviously we have already set up the
stage for it login will be responsible
for setting the data into this one so
how do we use it that's where hooks
comes up and hooks obviously comes from
uh this one just like we have user State
we have a hook known as use context so
far all the hooks that we have used uh
they don't have this much of boiler
plate work but this one has and it has a
tone Advantage you can say now we have
this use context so what can I do with
the use context is you can actually
extract values from it remember the
values yeah these values these are props
you can extract this data so in the
login I don't need whole of data I just
need a Selective data because I'll be
just adding value to this state so I'll
be saying give me that set user uh set
user that you have thrown it and how you
have thrown it just by saying use
context and inside this use context you
cannot just go ahead and use it you have
to provide a context that what context
I'm talking about I'm talking about the
user context or the product context I
have to for this I have to bring in this
so I'll be just saying user context
bring it that in and provide that
because you can have multiple context
context for authentication for user for
products different context for different
things once I have this one then all I
have to do here in the handle submit
once the submit button is clicked I'll
just update the user with that data so
first of all just take this event and
prevent default once you have done this
just use the set user and inside this
the set user will be uh adding an object
no which will have the access to
username and password whatever you're
entering it has that now inside this
Central store I literally have the
access to this so this one is now
finally having this value and we have
the username and the password access
here once I have access of this variable
and all these things in here any of my
component can go and ask for this data
how can it ask yeah it's really exactly
same process if you have noticed here
the way how we extract the set user
which is a method responsible for
setting the data I can extract the other
thing as well so let's go ahead and do
this I'm pretty sure now you can do this
as well so const we'll be saying hey
let's grab the user because don't want
to access set user I want to access the
user and use context provide the use
context again this is not how you should
write it because it didn't imported that
so I would love to grab it there we go
and now write it use context user
context basically now since I have
access to this I have to do nothing I
have to just say hey this is going to be
a user but there might be a case that uh
there is no value into this one so I can
just do some kind of a optional
rendering as well conditional rendering
as well so I can say if there is nothing
in inside the user basically it's null
then go ahead and return a simple
H1 uh that says not logged in and why
are you having this issue not logged in
oh my
bad yeah there we go so if we have the
user there we go so very basic very
basic code so if we go back here and hit
a Reload and it might be uh that I have
missed some of this stuff okay uh use
context is not okay uh here we are using
use context we don't have it really
basic we can go ahead and say use
context there we go should be all happy
there we go uh just for the sake let's
reload it says not logged in as soon as
I do uh hes here the password field is
just a dummy field doesn't really bother
us much so if I submit this okay we have
some of the issues let's say where we
are having this issue uh it says objects
are not valid react child find object
with the keys username and password ah
yeah my bad uh this needs to be fixed
let me go ahead and fix
this so the error says not a valid react
child username so I'm pretty sure I know
where the error is uh this is actually
in the profile this user is an object
because that's what we actually added if
you remember in the this one we actually
added an entire object and we cannot
display the entire object just like this
hey dump all the object we need to
extract the properties out of it so user
do username in this case uh that should
fix the error let's go back and I think
it should uh let's see no worries I just
go ahead and say again H not logged in
submit okay it works uh but the more
component should be much smaller and the
profile hes should be bigger okay uh no
big deal uh we can actually just cut
this
out and just replace it here that is
better yeah there we go so we have this
one and by the way if I go ahead and
remove everything up
here and there we go and submit it it
says profile because hey we are still
submitting the data it's like empty
strings are getting submitted it's not
null yet but if I refresh there it's not
logged in so again we have to do uh much
more check but the idea is not about
checking we'll do that in the later on
videos the idea is that how any of the
component was right now the components
were in the same page doesn't really
matter but every single component can
now access without actually doing a prop
drilling which is considered as a pretty
bad practice in react my login component
is not aware of the profile I don't
really care about it it just can set the
data into this Global store or the
global context from wherever it likes it
just needs those methods to set the data
the profile on the other hand it doesn't
really care who's passing the data we
are literally passing nothing it can
extract the data from that Global store
directly and all I have to do is set up
those boilerplate codes and after that
all I have to do is make sure all of my
components are aware of it either you
can do it in app.js if it makes sense
otherwise you can take literally this
exact same code take it into the main.js
and WP your app with it that's exactly
all the components uh should be aware of
it that is the whole idea so I told you
it's really not that of a bad situation
or a bad issue itself uh it's just like
it takes a little bit time to adjust
with these like I have to create a
context then the context needs a context
provider and all of that so basically
the step is simple create context create
provider make sure all all of the people
are aware of that there is a context so
I can take the data and send the data
that is it that is your introduction to
the context I'm pretty sure I have
dumbed it down enough so that anybody
and everybody can understand it if you
enjoy these videos definitely do leave a
subscribe to my Channel or hit that uh
like button uh that really means a lot
if you drop a comment taking out of your
valuable time it really really motivates
me to make more such video it really
takes a lot of effort all right so
that's it for this video let's go ahead
and catch up in the next
one hey there everyone hes here welcome
to another video in our Rea journey I
hope you're following this journey along
and if you're watching this in a long
one short video that's cool even uh but
don't forget to leave a comment in the
comment section it's my motivation
driving Factor so hit that subscribe if
you haven't already and it's a humble
request leave a comment just a hurt
Emoji anything will do just leave a
comment so let's continue our our
journey of the react in the same format
the context API I'm pretty sure after
watching the video probably more than
once you now have a particular idea of
how the context API work it's pretty
simple create a context create a
provider and that's it and make sure all
of your components are aware of it we
will take this journey into a little bit
different perspective so that you get
the idea okay these are this is how
things are designed and in this one
we'll follow another way of writing the
context which is by using a custom hook
this custom Hook is nothing just like we
were always is uh using the the thing
use context every single time at every
single place and we have to every single
time provide that okay I'm talking about
this context I'm talking about this
context uh we'll just do everything all
in one place this is also another style
of writing code and since people use
these different style of writing code
that is exactly the reason why the
context APL looks a little bit difficult
but now we have gone through the
previous video this one is going to make
so much sense again you don't have to
worry about the CSS part yes we have the
Tailwind yes we have have couple of good
nice looking stuff but you can just grab
them from my GitHub repository copy
paste nothing to be worried there we'll
only talk about the code part itself so
this is what we'll be designing a simple
theme Toggler it looks simple but it
will be a good exercise to practice the
stuff so notice we have a theme Toggler
which toggles the theme only for the
card that's what we are going to be
designing because this component will be
aware of what the theme Toggler value is
it is off or is it on based on this
we'll be changing this now we're not
going to be writing too much of the CSS
we are dependent on the Tailwind because
Tailwind allows us to have these dark
mode classes directly cooked in from the
CSS team itself the way how they do it
actually is if you check out their
playground they actually mention this on
their playground there's a right button
here which says this toggle if you right
click and inspect this uh the way how
they do it is actually if you toggle
this one uh this one is here let me just
go back at the body
so this is here so notice notice here in
the uh not in the HTML actually this is
a part of the header itself so let me
just search this if I can search it here
somewhere search this and I'll just
say dark it should be dark so there we
go so in the top here in the HTML
portion itself we can see in the top
HTML uh they are actually naming this
class itself the moment I do a toggle uh
this dark actually goes away it's
actually light by default and when I
toggle this on they actually manually
inject this dark once I have this dark
theme now you can notice here that the
dark glasses are written and baked in so
if I go ahead and zoom into this one
notice here this is the dark so the dark
glass automatically takes in place when
the HTML automatically marks you as a
dark so this is exactly what we'll be
doing this is our working functionality
inspired by the tail V itself so let's
go back and try to have a simple
Tailwind we'll create a fresh new
project and with this project we'll
install the tail elent so let's go back
and close this one wheat is our way to
go so let's just copy this and we'll be
installing the V into a fresh new
project so let's go ahead and first
let's just stop
this okay let's Okay open this up contrl
C stop this remove this and we need one
fresh one and we'll be seeing first of
all let's remove all of this because we
don't need all of this data context I
can right click and close to the right
yep now we just need to create a fresh
new project so for that npm create V and
we'll be using the latest and yeah
that's it let's name this one as 09 and
this one is uh theme switcher project
that we have this one uh totally depends
on you what do you want to call it I'm
going to call it as theme
switcher theme switcher and we'll be
saying we'll be using react for this one
one again JavaScript and let's open this
theme switcher into my
terminal and remove the old one we have
to say npm
install this is probably going to take
some time depends on how much my
internet is doing and then we have to
actually install the
tailwind and let's install this after
this we have to change the content just
like this copy and open this up inside
the Tailwind config we'll change the
content there we go the next step is to
bring in the CSS uh we can copy this go
back Source index. CSS remove everything
paste it up here save that and probably
we don't need into app.jsx as well app.
CSS my bad app.css we probably don't
need anything inside this anyways we are
not much worried about how things are
going on we just want to have these
things and practice our context API npm
run Dev should actually run the project
and there we go very basic nothing to be
worried all right so let's close
everything and now let's talk about them
one by one the first step is to grab our
basic boiler plate card and how does it
look and all of that so first of all
I'll just remove I'll add a folder and
I'll call this one as
components components and the components
will have basically two component in
itself the first one being uh new file
this one is just basic card so let's
call this one as card.
jsx and all we have to do into this one
I'll just directly bring the card from
my uh notes itself uh nothing just the
basic boiler plate card as you can see
there is nothing reacti about it plain
vanilla uh react or not react even just
the Tailwind too much of the classes
some images that we are borrowing from
pixels some of the Apple watch and stuff
so that is it that is your card now let
me go ahead and create another component
which is the top part of of it in case
you saw this this top theme Toggler you
can also have your own input button for
this one nothing is going to bother you
but we are just making it little bit
stylish so that it looks good right
click new file and we'll be calling this
one as theme
button.
jsx and again our fce react functional
component for theme button and all I'm
going to do is just replace this return
with whatever the return I have in my
notes and let's replace this there we go
as you can see this is nothing more than
input button which has some of these
values like value is nothing onchange we
need an onchange button here as well we
don't have that so let's go ahead and
create that that is all now theme mode
and everything we will uh work onto this
one first let's have just the onchange
button so that it doesn't crash and in
fact the theme mode we'll be just
removing this this checked and entirely
we'll be removing this so that we can
later on work on this one uh right now
this is all good and okay the only thing
that's bothering is this onchange button
so let's go ahead and have it and we'll
be saying onchange button does nothing
but we are having this one okay so both
of our components are ready now the idea
is these components are not aware of
each other I want to create a
centralized repo a store or a context so
that both can be aware of this so for
this we already are aware of this that
how we create the context so in the last
video I showed you that we simply go
ahead and create a new folder you want
to keep it in the folder or not that's
your choice I'll just say
context context yeah that's good or
context there might be other context as
well now what you'll notice is in the
last video we worked through with the
context almost similar to this one so we
have this context we have two files here
first one is user context but
technically we didn't do anything inside
this it was just creating a user context
the Meat part of the information was
this user provider uh where we created
the provider so we have this provider
now this provider should be available to
every single place that's why we call
this one here
but another thing we saw that that every
single time we have to do this inside
the component like for example in the
login I have to do this kind of a stuff
use context and then have to provide the
context inside it here also in the
profile we have to repeat this use
context and provide the context to it so
how about if we actually cumulate all of
this stuff is that possible yes it will
save us a lot of time in later on so we
can actually improve our boilerplate
code and this is exactly what we'll be
doing so in this case what we're going
to do is uh we'll be just simply saying
that okay we will be saying context
create a new file and we'll be calling
this one as uh
theme. JS all right so how we actually
use this one this is pretty interesting
first of all let's go ahead and import
two major things which we'll be using
the first one is create context that we
use there as well as well as we were all
the time using this use context two
things in the components use context was
getting used the create context for
creating the context so these two things
now we bringing them all together the
first step was to create a context uh
where we were having all these things so
previously if you remember I'll just
open this and compare it again and again
so that you don't get confused with this
we actually it's a good comparison here
so if I open up this context so this
part has nothing at all this thing is
having some of the interesting stuff so
if you remember this was our state and
technically what we were doing is we
were providing uh this data inside this
there is another way of doing this much
more easier than this uh because
ultimately everything is going inside
this so when you're creating this
context while creating this you can make
it aware that what are the default
option or what are the data which is
available to you so you'll see the
syntax almost similar to this where
somebody says hey uh theme context and
create context while creating the
context you can actually provide an
object in here directly with the
information uh
previously we were actually providing
this into a later stage when we were
creating the context and provider and
all of that but this create context is
also perfectly capable of taking the
data now we don't Define the data here
we actually uh provide just a general
information about it what do you mean by
general information uh let's just say we
have this theme mode so by default this
is just a variable whose uh value is
light but I also want this ability to
toggle the theme as well uh I can just
go ahead and work on with this one uh
toggle theme but I'll show you what
happens when there are multiple uh
values like there is a dark theme which
is just a method I don't know what this
method does or how it function or how it
works it just is a method similarly we
have a light theme which is also a
method how does it function work I have
no idea at all okay now we also saw that
uh every single time we were using uh in
the main.js like uh theme provider is
the context so theme provider. provider
so this was going a lot and in the
previous one we saw in the app.jsx we
have to use this user context provider
and if you remember this one yeah we
have to use this like this user context.
provider how about we don't do it like
this we actually change the syntax and
again this is the reason why people
sometimes don't understand because there
are different ways of writing a
different version if you're comfortable
with that version that's okay if you're
comfortable with this version that's
okay too so in this one we go ahead and
say export const and and we simply go
ahead and say this is my uh theme
provider and instead of saying all this
children and stuff I'm just saying that
hey this
is theme context. provider so that I
don't have to say literally I'm actually
literally exporting a variable whose
ultimately value is theme provider.
provider and that is it that is all what
we are doing okay so anywhere instead of
using theme uh Pro uh like theme
provider. provider or theme. provider I
can just simply say now theme provider
that is it that's the meaning of it now
we will also create a hook so that we
can use it in all of that so let me go
ahead and work on with this so export
default and in this one we'll be
creating a function and that will be use
theme and what we're doing in this is
use context theme context so theme
context is already available to me so I
don't have to import or export it I can
just directly use this now anybody who
uses this hook which is use theme uh he
don't have to pass on this context like
previously we were saying use context
then bring in the context and add value
to it and literally what that was doing
is when we do this uh this create
context get all of that value that is
what how the store is being created
internally so this is also alternative
version Let Me summarize this because I
know this can be a little bit confusing
previously we were creating a context
that context was doing nothing nothing
at all we were just having this user
context okay step two we were using this
user context now if you remember from
this we were creating a
provider which was wrapping and the
reason why we were having this so that
wherever we use this uh use user context
provider ultimately what the code runs
is user context. provider which actually
accepts the children so all prop goes
inside it now in the newer version what
we are doing is we are actually merging
them together so that we don't have to
create this context separately and have
this one separately and provide the
values what we can do is just simply
create the context and whatever the
value functionality whatever you want to
incorporate you just directly give it
directly inside the uh create context
definitely we don't incorporate the
functionality in this one because that
needs to go separately and what we do is
theme provider directly gets a variable
uh we don't have to extract this every
single time just like we do it here user
context and children rapping no we are
aware of it uh we simply directly use it
like this and again one more hook which
actually helps us each of the component
to uh not have the import statement and
all of that just use the hook directly
Hook is aware of it and I know which one
I'm using so one file consist of
everything okay yeah little bit
different but how the usage of this
works and most of the tutorials and
everything that you're are going to see
this is the way how they use it the way
how I showed you to you in the previous
one is so that you understand okay these
are the pieces that I need to do in this
one also these are the exact pieces I'm
doing creating a context and making
everyone aware that the context exists
that's all and this portion is literally
for everybody so that every every
component can directly use my store so
three parts first the second one and the
third one that's exactly still uh onto
the same page okay now we are actually
on to this one uh how we can actually
use this one now we'll be using theme
provider previously what we were using
uh previously we were using this user
context provider if you don't remember
this in the app.jsx user context
provider ultimately it's a theme
provider so that's what we'll be using
let's close all of this and enough of
the previous discussion now let's go
ahead and continue with the newer one so
now I'll go into app.jsx and this
app.jsx has a couple of values and stuff
that we have to actually work on with
this one now what I can do here is
inside this app.js uh I can have couple
of states and their modes and stuff like
that but first and foremost what we have
to do is remove everything from here
this is our app.jsx let's just go ahead
and remove this and I do have some of
the values up here so let me just go
ahead and grab those
values and we'll be just copying and
pasting so this is my div and what I'm
doing is I'm bringing in the theme
button and the card which it didn't Auto
Import it so let's go ahead and write
this
again so theme button did we wrot that
in the lower
case no theme button should be
there theme
button no no
suggestion okay anyways let's go ahead
and bring them up manually in case it
doesn't
import card from component card and
import theme button from components
there we go we should have used the
index file here let's see how does it
look and there we go we can have this
but it has no effect or impact on this
one because they are not linked together
now comes up the advantage is we only
need one file to be there which is just
the theme provider remember theme
provider is not an export default so you
cannot just go ahead and say we have to
say in the curly braces and then we have
to say this one
is theme provider there we go and it
comes from the context theme now wrap
this up so every component is aware of
it you wrap this up in app.js or
wherever you like you can just wrap this
up okay now everybody is aware of it but
not like this uh everybody is not aware
of this uh the way how we were
extracting the value this is exactly how
you extract the value from it so in this
theme provider previously we were saying
just one word now we have a parameter
known as value and this can grab all the
values that you have mentioned in your
theme the values like this theme mode
Dark theme light theme this is all so I
will actually bring this one here so
I'll just say hey give me the object
of theme theme mode actually and and
then we have dark mode I'll just copy
this otherwise I'll miake it's a dark
theme copy that and paste it and the
first one is actually theme mode copy
that paste it dark theme and we do have
a light
theme okay so all the functionality is
here now right now they are empty they
have no idea how this functionality will
work and all of that uh but we'll
actually work with the state here a
little bit so let me show you how the
functionality now we are writing the
functionality part so it's super easy
and nothing to be worried on first of
all let's go ahead and have a simple uh
theme mode set theme mode and we'll be
setting this as a light by default
remember this is exactly the theme mode
now we have a value of it so previously
it was just empty it could have been
empty right now it's default value but
it could be empty it's a variable these
two are functions so what this function
actually does is these are
functionalities so what I can say is
let's declare these functionalities so
these are function Dark theme just like
this and we'll be having an arrow
function just like this all it does is
when you call it it changes Dark theme
uh we'll check the values to the dark
similarly we have a light theme which go
ahead and set the theme to light that is
it all we are doing is changing the
state value but changing just the state
value is not enough uh first of all you
are just changing the state uh this has
no effect into your web page so how does
it work work if you want any event in
the web page then you have to either
make it happen on some events like
clicks or on change or all of that if
you want to happen it based on some
State change then you have to use use
effect a simple uh hook here and the way
how it works is really simple you
provide a dependency array to this one
and in this case the dependency of the
theme mode the use effect hook simply
says that if any value in the dependency
array change I will reender this
component and when you render this
component I will actually want to change
that I want to run some piece of code
what that piece of code this is where
your classic JavaScript comes into the
picture I'll just go ahead and say hey
uh I want the document this document
will be able to run a query selector I
want to find an element which is known
as HTML and inside this I do have the
classes a lot of class list and first of
all I want to remove so remove
everything that's there uh not just the
dark even if you have light just remove
everything
and again this needs to go into double
codes otherwise it will not able to find
this or single codes it needs to be a
string once that is being done then I
want to again run the same uh query but
this time I want to add a theme to it
which is theme mode whatever is the
theme mode value just add this so based
on this so we have defined the
functionality yet so functionality
recites in app.js but since this
functionality I was able to set inside
this remember theme mode is the value so
now my card actually can grab this theme
mode value and this theme mode value can
be manipulated by the theme button and
the value can be grabbed by the card
itself so first of all let's take down
that the how the card is actually going
to grab it do you really think card need
to grab the value no not at all not at
all this was a trick question your card
don't need to grab the value because in
the app.js the whole thing is actually
being governed by the HTML Tailwind
feature not to us I hope you understand
that okay so the functionality part of
grabbing the values Al taken care of for
me by the Tailwind uh does my theme
button need some work uh yes your theme
button needs some work because this
theme button first of all need to grab
some value from the context and then
based on this it will be able to change
that value so first of all what you have
to do is grab the value so how we can go
ahead and do this we can go ahead and
have some values and this time I'll be
directly grabbing the value from use
theme remember use theme is my custom
hook that I've have designed what all
the values you have inside it you can
just go ahead and grab those values so
for example I have this theme mode I
have this light theme and I have this
dark theme whatever the name of your
function I have all the access to this
one now the next step is that I have to
just based on some onchange button so if
there's a change in the button I have to
do all of this uh so let's go ahead and
work on with
this and I'll just go ahead and say if
the value is checked what should happen
if the value is checked then the theme
mode means it's dark so if it is if it
is checked it it means it is on the dark
now what happens when the onchange
button so on change you just toggle the
value into it so really couldn't be much
more simpler than this so oh we have
already written the onchange button all
we have to do is now just get the value
so if the theme mode is uh dark it's
change it to uh light theme or dark
theme or what whatever it is I think we
can actually write a better code than
this one although this will also work I
hope so first of all let's grab the
value so uh we'll just go ahead and say
dark mode
status I'll grab the status uh from E
and we haven't got the E yet so this
will give us the event and the event
from that we can just go ahead and grab
the current Target
dot checked this is how you grab the
value from the checked whatever is your
value so right now the value is empty
yes there could be a chance the value
could be empty uh but we'll set the
value so we'll check
it and we're going to go ahead and say
now if the dark mode status then run the
Dark theme else just run the light theme
so light theme methods will actually uh
grab we have grabbed these methods from
here and now what will happen this dark
theme will be going up here and we will
be able to set the theme mode into the
dark and then that's it and similarly
here else just go ahead and use the
light theme we brought the light theme
the functionality will come from here
and then the value will be uh rerun via
the use effect and we'll be able to
change the value so I think that is it
we need to just save the value and let's
see now we have a toggle it still
doesn't work let me just check what
happened happened and console it says
the value prop is required for the
context provider did you miss a spell
forget to pass it okay I didn't forget
it I actually passed the value yes it
looks like I have passed the value and
should be all good theme provider value
let's check our provider theme as well
so if we missed out some value into our
theme as well no it looks like all good
let me quickly check that where I'm
missing that value
oh my bad I actually forgot this in the
previous uh teaching class as well uh
this is not an issue I didn't forgot the
value I just needed to refresh it but it
doesn't work still uh the reason for not
working is actually not based on some of
our mistake it's actually a
configuration we forgot to do so go into
the Tailwind config and in the Tailwind
config you have to actually mention that
how the dark mode is actually getting
used so here the dark mode is actually
based on the class itself uh yes
literally you have to say that uh once
you actually do this now your theme
Toggler will work so there we go uh so
really great great example but again I
find it uh first of all when I studied
about this I found it little bit
difficult to grab my head that how this
is all is working again remember there
are always three steps onto this one no
matter what or how the code is being
written because you'll be working with
other programmers as well in your
company some of them use this syntax
some have used that syntax but the
process always remains same first of all
you create the context then you make
sure everybody's aware of the context
and then if any component want to
consume the state add values get the
values whatever that's where you use the
use context now some people use the use
context within the component itself it's
good for them and they always always
have to provide the context to it Some
people prefer that all of the things the
logic should be written in one file so
this portion should be now very clear to
you that hey we have the use context
let's have it let's create a customized
hook so that people can grab directly
whatever the values are are there and
the next step is this one is pretty easy
uh you have this don't have this doesn't
really bother you because instead of
writing theme context. provider here you
could have just written it uh into our
app.jsx as well that theme provider.
provider doesn't really add any
additional value but you'll see this
happening quite a lot so I don't think
so this is bothering you uh write it
here or write it into the awareness file
I call it as app.js totally okay uh what
bothers some people is this portion that
hey uh how we are doing all of this
because this is the create context now
since we have the ability that create
context can directly have the context
whatever the data and everything you
want to pass it some people find it much
more easier that I don't have to bother
about childrens and whatnot I just add
my data here that's it it's purely a JS
file not the GSX file that's why some
people love it coming back onto the
previous example now you'll be able to
understand it much more better in this
example this file is a pure JS but it
doesn't do anything it doesn't take any
context it just is literally you are
exporting the user context that is it
and in this file uh we create the
separation of the jsx because literally
you are passing some jsx the thing which
should be done like value of the user
and stuff which which can also be done
in the appjs or main JS we are actually
doing this here itself that is the whole
reason for the confusion and again
previously we were exporting this user
context provider this user context.
provider goes here in that file we are
just exporting it directly so again uh
it's up to the choice if you ask me what
is my choice and what do I use
professionally I use this one where I
have just one file because in this
portion I think Clarity is much more I
don't have to worry too much it's a pure
GS file not jsx I can write all my data
in the context as well I can create a
simple hook which actually is aware of
it so one file for one context much much
simpler and as your application grows
you have much more of the context
uh then it this approach is much much
better and to be honest in most of the
complex project that I work context
doesn't make it up I most of the time
use Redux these days Redux toolkit uh so
I have to use some kind of a bigger
Library uh for handling these kinds of
state but yes for the interview persp
perspective or the purposes of mini
projects internal company projects yes
the awareness and the knowledge of
context API is much much needed so I've
shown you both of the ways and I'm
pretty sure sure this will take a little
bit time to digest so don't be in a
hurry take your time go through the vi
vid videos both of the sections again
and once you'll write the code manually
uh then it will make much more sense
much more clarity I've tried my best to
slow down the pace each line should make
sense to you yes it takes a lot of
effort that's why saying one comment in
the comment section just a heart would
mean a lot so that's it for this video
and let's catch up in the next
one hey there everyone hes here back
again with another video and yes I was
gone for a little while I hope you
missed me if you're watching it one go
then it doesn't make sense but anyways
uh finally I'm back and I'm trying to
put as much as content as I can possibly
uh with a given free time apart from my
job uh in this video I'll be continuing
the Journey of our react uh we have been
into the course of the react which is a
Project based course we have built so
many projects and now we are kind of
brushing up our skills on the context
API the context API is pretty nice to
have and it gives you a great Foundation
to even further understand other State
Management libraries like Redux zustan
and whatnot uh so I thought let's give
one more shot of understanding it by
building another cool project and then
we can move on to our Mega project which
is building up a Blog I'll talk about
that one in the next video or probably
next next video whatever that video is
uh but in this one we will be walking
you through with the context API and how
you can build a full-fledged project not
only just context API I'll also walk you
through with how you can use the context
API to uh store something into the local
storage of your browser as well now
these context API or Redux they are just
State managers and they just allow you
to perform certain actions or task in a
certain way it doesn't really care what
you are performing or how you are
performing it just allows you to give a
streamline part that this is only how
things should go and come back it's a
kind of a data streamline for us it
doesn't really care if you are putting
things into the local storage or a
database online or however you are
dealing with the things this this is
just pure functionality part so without
a further Ado let me walk you through
that what we are about to build let me
share the screen so this is where we are
so this is what we'll be building so
this is just a simple Todo it looks
simple but there is so much of
intricacies in that and so much of the
knowledge about how the code base or the
code structure should look like how a
program flow Works through we'll be
walking it through so in this one what
we'll be doing is uh uh we'll be Simply
Having this right too which will be a
component on its own itself and we'll be
walking it through apart from this we
have this uh simple thing which can be
toggled on and off uh that's nice and as
we toggled on uh now you cannot edit it
because it's done so what's what's the
point of having it and apart from this
you can actually click on this edit
button and as soon as you click on the
edit button uh this gets as editable so
this actually uh this whole text thing
if I save this this is a texting if I
click on this one it loads an input
field in the input field we loads a
value and then it makes it more of a
editable on its own place itself and
thus after that you can save that once
it's in the edit mode we give the save
button otherwise we get the edit button
we can delete that we can add more
to-dos obviously uh the most interesting
part is if I right click and inspect
onto this one I need to go into
application and in the application I can
see the local storage there's a lot of
things here session storage and whatnot
in the local storage I can see all of my
applications are or whatever my to-dos
are actually stored in this one this
whole applications looks simple but it
will give you a rock solid foundation of
how applications are being built using
the context API what thought process
goes into that an entire cred operation
this will be super helpful for you for
later on as we build our Mega project
this will be a good practice for you so
again uh let's go ahead and get started
and try to build this project I think
that would be a pretty pretty cool
exercise for all of us we'll be using
Tailwind we are not worried about the
CSS part this is not a CSS tutorial uh
we'll be skipping that part I'll be
giving you the copy paste class names
just add that otherwise if you don't
even give any class name that's fine too
we are more focused on the functionality
part and for this we'll be using the
Tailwind CSS our trusty old friend for
always that let's go into the docs part
of it and we will be framework guides
and we'll be going through the V guide
all right so let's go ahead and create a
fresh project so let me go ahead and
open up my vs code this is where we'll
be creating a fresh new project uh let
me open this up and we'll be creating
our new project so npm uh create
V and we'll be going for the latest so
let's go with the latest and uh what
should be the name of this project
that's an interesting question so we'll
be going with a 10 and then with the
name of too uh to do
context context and we are also using
local so I'll just say local for the
local storage so I'll just hit that
package name is same we'll be obviously
using react and we'll be going with the
JavaScript not the typescript at least
in this one so let's go there and there
we go we have this application up and
running now what I'll do is I'll close
this one I'll open this up in my
integrated terminal so that we are
directly into the folder itself and
we'll be saying npm install to install
all the dependencies what we have just
like the boiler basic play uh boiler
Basics all right now in the meantime
let's go into the Tailwind CSS and we
need this whole thing so let's just go
ahead and copy this and there we go uh
your cache folder previous version since
addressed oh there's so much of the bugs
uh CIS call oh seems like there are some
issues into this one I didn't expected
that but let me just go ahead and remove
this try it one more time shouldn't be
happening in the in this phase at least
but let's just go npm
install oh let me first do a quick LS if
I'm able to see that yes package.json is
here npm
install oh there is some issues your
cash folder contains root oh I need to
fix this one so just give me a second
I'll quickly go ahead and fix this one
weird error don't know
why all right so fixed it uh usually
these kinds of things happen when you
update your system and yes I moved on to
the latest Mac and that's why things
happen uh nothing much of a big fix that
I did actually I just run this simple
command which was suggested to me here
that hey you need to change the
permission of the npm packages here so I
did the exactly same asked for my
password gave it the password then I run
the npm install and it works fine so
that's basic uh nothing too much things
happen all the time okay now we have to
run simply npm run Dev at least let's
see if we are able to run the things
properly or not yep things looks good
things looks good now we can just go
ahead and copy this and let's stop this
paste this should be giving us a package
file for Tailwind hopefully config file
for Tailwind there we go this is our
config file let's go ahead and copy the
context for the V let's get this one
copy that this should be very common to
you by now we have been doing this for
so long and we need to have directives
so copy this and for the
Tailwind
CSS source and in the app. CSS not app
index. CSS we'll just remove everything
paste it up here save that that looks
good also go into your app.css and go
ahead and remove everything that's
exactly what we want we don't want
anything thing okay rest is all good we
should be able to get a Hello World with
the class names and stuff so let's go
into
app.jsx and let's run this npm run Dev
let's close this and inside this let's
go ahead and use the Tailwind CSS up
here so remove everything and paste this
H1 save that let's see and yep it's a
Tailwind it's a Tailwind one all right
so this looks good now let's see let's
prepare the plan of action that how we
are going to take this one the first
good thing is that I don't have to worry
too much because context API comes up as
a default one so I can just go with that
but first thing is always if you're
planning to use the context API or maybe
Redux toolkit or something just for just
first go ahead and Target that one
that's always and always a good idea
we'll come back onto app.jsx and all
these functionality but first is always
a good idea that you simply go ahead and
have a context for this one so let's go
go ahead and work with that so I'll go
into my source and I'll create a new
folder I want to keep my context
separate so I'll just go ahead and hey
why are you not allowing me to
write right click new folder yep now
it's good context again uh we'll be
calling it as context because you might
have more than one context a context for
login which does all the functionality
for login I'm having just one context
which is my to-do context so I'll show
you how it is being done professionally
in you in such kind of application I'll
create a new file inside the context and
I'll call this one as too uh
context uh context. JS not only that
usually you'll find that there is a new
file known as index.js this is nothing
much more than you have multiple context
and you pick all those context bring
them up in index so that you can import
all of them via the index file that is
it that is the goal okay uh let's see
how we can work with the context uh
pretty pretty easy if you have done this
uh any time and especially the to-dos
are pretty easy to work on with that so
I'll just go ahead and say first of all
let's import some stuff and we'll be
importing them from react so that's
obvious let's go up here what do we need
we need a create context and a use
context create context to create the
context and use context for using that
created context too many context but
yeah we need that so we'll be having a
create context and we'll be needing a
use context which is a hook itself all
right now we have these two uh the first
thing is to create the context so we're
going to go ahead and directly export
this and let's call this one as to-do uh
context this to-do context will be
created using the create context that's
it it's nothing it's just a function
this function takes an object and within
the object you can pass on all the
things which you want to have the
context of all the data all the fields
that you requir you can just directly
pass on in here uh we saw another method
in which I showed you we can create them
at separate places and and all of that
but this is more of a professional
approach you'll find this again again
that first approach I told you gives you
more clarity but in the real world
application you'll be using this much
more so in this one my context I'll call
this one as to-dos which is going to be
an array and how does each of my to-dos
looks like so I'll just give it a sample
here as an example so that we can
understand it more as we write code
otherwise it's not required yet this is
just for an exercise so that we
understand how each of my to-do looks
like
so I'll say that ID will be one we can
use later on ID as a date date. now or
we can use some kind of a nano ID to
give a unique ID totally up to us and
then we are going to give a to-do this
to-do is going to be a to-do message so
we'll be just saying to-do message and
then finally we'll be having a complete
this completed is nothing it's just a
Boolean value so I'll just save false so
this is how my to-do looks like okay not
only that to-do it's not going to be
just to-do there there needs to be a
functionality as well so first part is
ADD to-do so there needs to be a
functionality which adds the to-do I'll
be just writing its vague definition not
the functionality or the working part in
this one okay so how does the add to-do
Works looks like uh it is just a method
like this that is it but add to-do
doesn't work alone it requires a to-do
to be passed on so just go ahead and
give me that to-do and we now know this
as awareness that to-do will look like
this and that is why a lot of people
like use typ script because it gives you
awareness about how your data looks like
uh types of the data but again this
already makes sense so there's nothing
more to discuss with that okay similarly
we have added the to-do now obviously
there will be a method to update the
to-do how does the update to-do looks
like again it's going to be a simple
method just like this but another
essential thing to update an existing
to-do is give me what to do should I
update so that's going to be an ID and
what should I update the updated to-do
give me that so it needs to give that to
do so that's all how it will update I'm
not worried on that because how can
change depends on how you're making the
application for us this application is
based on local storage for you this
might be an application based on mongodb
or MySQL so there could be a lot of use
cases in that
example so we have added it to do
updated it to do uh what next we can
have a delete to do uh what do I need to
delete that first of all it's going to
be a method that's obvious uh what do we
need just an ID give me that ID and I'll
I'll simply go ahead and delete that so
that's one thing uh I also need to
toggle the to-do to mark it as false
true is it done not done based on that
so I'll just go ahead and call this one
as toggle toggle yeah that that sounds
toggle complete toggle
complete not a good naming in this case
but I'll just go with
that okay what do I need for that just
give me the ID and I'll work with that
so this is my vague functionality it
doesn't work and that's exactly our
context uh that based on this I can add
the functionality so I can not only add
data into this array but also I can
actually Define the functionality based
on that that is exactly your context so
now your context is all done but every
single time in the earlier videos if you
remember that we saw that it's not like
just defining the context isy somebody
needs to use that and whoever is using
need to use this use context as well as
say all these things that hey I need to
be aware of the context to-do context uh
login context or something this is such
a common thing that we later on realize
that doing this in the same file
actually makes sense and actually saves
us a lot of time so we we simply go
ahead and say let's create our own
custom hook let's call this one as used
to do hook is nothing more than a
function so let's go ahead and Define
function like this and in this function
what we go ahead and do directly return
another hook which is a used context
which is aware of the context since this
context is defined in the same file so
that's it so this hook returns another
hook yeah but the advantage is that I
don't have to again and again call two
files use context needs to be imported
but also this to-do context needs to be
imported here I don't need to import
this this is already available to me
that is why we Define that into same
file now also uh we saw that we can
export one one more line This is not
really that meaningful but makes our
other files much more easy to read so
let's go ahead and go ahead and do that
export const and we simply go ahead and
work on with to-do
provider so that we can directly provide
that so to-do
context uh simply can go ahead and work
on with
provider all right so this is the basics
that we have as of
now all right so my uh to-do provider or
the context for this application is
almost ready if I have more context then
obviously I'll do exactly same like this
maybe if I have login so what does the
login information consist if I want to
have any what are all the methods I'm
looking up for like create account login
log out anything more so I'll just do
exactly almost similar kind of a stuff
there now in addition to that actually
what I did is I should be writing all
this in to-do context I accidentally
wrote it an index so I'll just go ahead
and cut this out this should all go into
too context so nothing much that's not
going to bother us so we'll just go
ahead and copy paste it into the to-do
context which is a right place for it
now the reason why we created this index
is because you might have multiple of
these things and importing them from
separate separate files uh it's really a
nightmare kind of a thing so the best
practice is to go ahead and Export it
from here uh after importing it from
here uh so what we can do is we can
directly export all of this uh this is a
nice uh sneaky little syntax and we can
import it from uh let's just go ahead
and to-do context what all the things
you want to export from it the first
thing obviously a to-do context if we
need it most of the time we'll be using
the used to-do but maybe we want to get
some data in that case uh to-do context
is required uh we'll be also needing
to-do provider and we'll be needing the
hook which is used to- do so as you can
see this makes life so much easier
similarly we can export more of the
things by importing from other files and
that's actually uh is something which
streamlines the thing so uh that's
really nice one thing is sorted that our
context all the work that we wanted to
do is all being done okay so step one is
all done now next up is to create these
components so if you remember there was
a top component which was a form in
which we were writing the to-dos and
there was another thing which was uh the
bottom which is a listing of all the
to-do so that's one task that we have in
our hand uh so let me just close this
another task is in the to-do context we
have not defined any of these methods so
another task in front of us is uh simply
to define the functionality of all all
of this so let's go ahead and whichever
you want to take down the first it's
totally up to you I think let's go ahead
and take down the functionality part
first and then we'll bu will be building
the components first okay so the first
thing that we have to do is simply go
ahead and have a to-do provider in here
and the way how we are going to do is
let's wrap this up at the top so we'll
be just going ahead and say to-do
provider no no suggestions so I need to
bring this manually probably save this
let's go ahead and reload this reload
window so probably now it will give me
uh let's go ahead and too proide no
suggest okay uh so we need to bring this
to-do provider so let's go at the very
top and try to bring bring the to-do
provider all right so we'll go ahead and
say import
too
provider and that will be coming up from
and we'll be saying
context do/
contexts okay now that the to-do
provider is accessible to me I can go up
in here and can add this uh to-do
provider the easiest thing to do is just
go ahead and say to-do provider once you
have this obviously you need to have the
closing one as well so let's go ahead
and have it here and there we go so this
is happy now everything which is going
to be inside this is going to be aware
of the context some people you'll see
that they also give it to the main
itself that's also fine but I am pretty
sure that there will be no component
outside of this main which will be
requiring this context so I'll just go
ahead and wrap it up here so wherever
you need it needs to be the outermost
layer of this thing so that's the basic
of it so one part is done but another
thing that you are going to require in
order to do this is to uh bring in all
the methods and whatnot and all these
things from this one here so how we can
actually bring the rest of the things
that is the question that is the most
important question the easiest way to do
is is come back here and just say hey
there is a property being given to this
to-do provider automatically by the
context known as value via this value
you can actually go ahead and import the
objects that are there so for example if
I go ahead and do one more curly braces
here I can just go ahead and say Hey I
want to-dos it will give me the to-dos
that same array and you can also bring
in all the methods there so for example
we have this add to do we have update to
do uh what else we have delete delete to
do and one more was toggle something
toggle complete so I have brought in all
the data as well as all the
functionality here so you might be
wondering why we have brought in the
data also because we will be passing on
this data exactly to one component that
will eventually build to Loop through
all the values inside it so it's an
array so we will bring that and we'll
Loop through it uh currently I'm not
focused on this one exactly at this
moment I'm more of focused on the add
Todo update to-do because I want to
write functionality in them so let's go
ahead and work on with the functionality
from the very top first of all we need a
state for its management uh because
to-dos will be added and removed and
whatnot there will be a lot of
functionality going on so we need to
keep a track of all the todos inside a
state itself to update our UI let's go
ahead and call this one as to-do to-dos
to-dos would be good and this will be
set
to-dos and that will be all done by our
classic friendly user State the default
state will be an empty array so that
that functionality is all done
okay uh right now uh this is all good
but now let's add one by one the things
that how this is going to be done the
first functionality we are going to take
here is ADD Todo so how this
functionality will go and work on with I
can just directly go ahead and Mark this
as ADD too and then this is going to be
a simple method just like this the great
thing is that since I have this exact
same data that data will automatically
map to the method because remember in
the context we created just a method
just the defin not the definition just
the uh blueprint of it but not the
definition here's the point where we
going to go ahead and write the
definition it could have been done into
a separate file but all we need to do is
wherever you are importing these values
and these all things it needs to be in
the same file so you can Define it into
other file bring it in here and then can
map it that's also totally fine okay how
you're going to add to add the to-do you
need the to-do so let's go ahead and say
that okay we need the to-do what else we
can do uh it's really really simple now
all you have to do here in this case is
use this set todos so how does set todos
will work obviously it requires a call
back here so we'll need to have all the
access to previous to-dos that it have
it might have and then we will be
working to added adding the more of that
so where do you want to add that I want
to add the new Todo at the very top of
my array and rest of them I'll spread
this so I'll just go ahead and say that
uh this will be an array and inside this
we'll be spreading this so previous all
values we are spreading this out and my
to-do will go at the very first of it so
this is the place where my to-do will go
just like that it's an object it
requires three things uh my ID the
actual to-do uh title of it and the
completed which is by default false so I
don't need to give it much so I'll just
go ahead and work with that so ID how
can I get the unique ID the easiest
cheapest trick in the JavaScript book is
date do now uh but totally up to you
maybe you want to use Nano ID or
something else that's totally on you
okay uh now that we have this one uh we
have added the IDS and what else we can
do we can just get this exact too so
what we'll do is we'll be spreading this
to-do uh because the way how this to-do
will work uh the reason for spreading
this one is because this to-do might
have more of the functionalities or more
whatever it is I just want to have it
spread it out that's why it is in case
you're working with just the string
itself then you don't need to spread it
out but since ours is an object so we
are actually updating one property of it
and then we are working on it so really
simple basic classic JavaScript that's
it okay so this part is all done now
let's see how we can update the to-do
again classic way of updating is really
simple so we're going to go ahead and
say I need to update this update too
update too okay update too again a
method nothing more than that and I'll
say for updating I need a ID as well as
I needed to do okay how can I update
this for updating obviously the best
part is to Loop through all the arrays
totally depends on you how you want to
Loop through the values I'll just use
maybe a map for this one so I'll just
first of all bring in all the to-dos we
will be requiring all the previous
values so we'll call this one as prev
okay uh there we go now with this I'll
just take this all the previous values
inside my arrays I'll Loop through with
probably a map inside this map I get a
call back so I'll just go ahead and say
that I need each of these so prev to do
I'll call this one e each to-do as prev
to-do once I have this one then I'll
simply go ahead and update to update
that I need to find a particular to-do
to work on with that so what I'll do is
I'll just wrap everything inside the
parenthesis again so that it doesn't
give me any error so I'll just go ahead
and say pre have to-do if its ID because
each to-do has an ID if it matches
equals to the ID of the to-do that is
provided to me in the function so too.
ID
okay if that is the case if that is
working fine then let's go ahead and do
something in here otherwise we'll do
something in here okay just boiler plate
here this helps me always to write
things nicely so in this case if it
matches then I'll go ahead and say to do
so I'll just update the entire object if
it doesn't match with that then go ahead
and keep it as it is so prev to do
whatever that to do is we'll keep it as
it is so We're looping through each of
the value couldn't be much more simpler
than that the explanation line by line I
hope you have understood that if not
rewind the video okay next up we'll just
go with the delete delete is the easiest
one const delete too and the delete
works with just give me the ID and I'll
work with that all right how does the
delete functionality Works simple set
todos let's grab that we need all of the
access of that so we'll just go ahead
and say prev and we'll work with that
okay how we're going to work that first
let's uh let's go ahead and filter this
out uh looping through in this doesn't
make sense we can have a operation on
filter so that we can create a new array
based on the filtering operation so we
need to provide a condition so we'll say
hey prev let's go ahead and use a filter
method on that by the way I do have a
YouTube videos on these filter map
reduce really nicely explained step by
step bro broken down if you don't know
about in depth of that check out that
one okay how does that work so the
filter method requires a call back back
okay in each of the call back you'll
have the each individual to-do item call
it as pre to-do to-do doesn't really
matter it just is a filler word once it
is there then we we need to require to
pass on a condition to that so if that
to do uh we are looping through that
each one of them if its ID matches with
my ID then uh uh we need to delete that
so we have to go through with the
reverse logic of it I want all the
to-dos uh which doesn't match the ID so
which
doesn't
match the ID so now because if you don't
know this filter always works for the
true condition so we need to somehow
give the true condition that's why the
reverse logic always works here so what
I'm saying here is really simple that go
through with each one of them and I want
to create a new array based on some true
conditions that true condition is ID
should not match so whose ID is matching
we need to remove that whose ID is not
matching we need to create a new Arrow
out of it so that's what we are doing in
this delete to do okay uh pretty cool uh
now let's go ahead and work on with the
uh togle as well toggle is also fairly
simple nothing too much on that a little
bit but not too much okay uh let's call
this one as togle complete okay how do
you work it requires an ID and once it
has the ID obviously we need to go
inside this one here okay moving further
how does it work first of all let's grab
all the to-dos this is where we get it
and we need to go through with each one
of them so let's go ahead and have the
prev just like this okay now we have
this one uh I'll just go ahead and break
it down into separate lines so it's much
more easier for you to understand okay
now here what I'll do is I'll Loop
through with each one of them so prev do
map there we go We're looping through
the values inside the map we need a call
back so we'll call this one as prev to
do call it to do pre to do doesn't
really matter and inside this we need a
call back so this is my call back and
what I'll do is I'll again go into the
new line so it's much more easier for
you to understand now inside this each
one of this I want to toggle this one so
I want to go
inside the object like we have an array
in these array we have a lot of objects
I don't want to go every object I want
to go into a object whose ID matches
once I go inside this I want to update
that entire object not all the
properties just one property which is
the complete part okay so how we're
going to do this uh really simple let's
have this pre to do and first of all
let's see that if the ID of this pre to
do matches with the ID that you have
provided me if that is the case then
we're going to go ahead and do something
otherwise we'll do something okay boiler
boiler plate code here if uh it matches
with the ID then I want to update it so
I'll just go ahead and spread this out
so spread this prev to do first of all
once I spread this now I have access to
all of this once I have spreaded this
then I have to update only one field
which is
completed and that completed I need to
toggle that so I'll just change the
previous values so I'll just go ahead
and say whatever uh just use an
exclamatory so that it reverse the true
to false false to true so really basic
so I'll just say prev too prev to do and
you have a property known as
dot come
completed okay we are flexing this nice
really and on the else part what we need
to do just keep it as it is so just your
preer to do will remain as it is so
there we go okay uh one thing remember a
lot of people kind of uh get in
confusion with this one that hey you are
spreading this first and then updating
this is an object it doesn't really
matter once you spread this out that is
it then you can update the existing
field this is how the object spreading
works if if you spread this out either
first or end uh then if you update any
field that exactly that particular field
will get updated so really nice okay so
that's the functionality part we have
taken this down now this is the
functionality part we haven't talked
about how the things will actually go in
the local storage so we need to work on
with the local storage as well uh there
are two ways how the things are going
inside the local storage and coming out
of the local storage first thing any
changes in this to-dos or the set to-dos
if we are adding any field or updating
removing whatever we are happing we need
to update that into the local storage
and any given time when the page loads
itself we want to query the local
storage that if you have any data give
me that data otherwise what's the point
of having local storage so for this
whenever the component loads one good
thing that we can actually go ahead and
use is use effect this is a hook that we
want to use so use effect and this is it
and it requires a call back so let's go
ahead and give it a call back just like
this uh the second property is your
dependency array we don't have any
dependency array because this is the
hook where we are talking about as soon
as the component loads query the local
storage get me all the data and let's
push all that data into the state which
is set to do that's exactly what we'll
be doing uh so what we'll be doing is uh
we need to query the local storage and
we can just get the item just with this
one and we'll be calling this one as to
do right now we haven't called them
anything so let's just call this one as
toos all over storage okay we have got
all of this now let's go ahead and kind
of a this is a string this string needs
to convert it into Json first that's
local storage always works with a string
so there we go and we have multiple ways
of doing this the easiest way is to
json. par once we have this let's store
that into a variable const
toos okay we have brought in the local
uh we have brought in data from local
storage now we need to do is uh we need
to push this data into the state so
that's really simple but I want to I can
actually go ahead and directly do this
set to-dos and kind of uh use this one
and to-dos uh but what I'm thinking is
uh there might be no data into the
to-dos so uh that might be the case so
let's handle this as an optional
otherwise I don't want to do this so if
Let's test the condition if there is
to-dos first of all if there is no
to-dos then there might be a potential
of my application being crashed down so
let's not do that and what we're going
to do is uh let's go ahead and use
another condition that to-dos is there
but there might be nothing inside it so
to-dos uh do
length since this is an array I can use
that should be greater than zero
anything greater than zero then I'll go
ahead and use the todu and I'll just go
ahead and todu again this is little bit
optional but good to have so this is the
uh this is the place where I'm using the
use effect hook where there is no
dependency array as soon as the
component will Mount this hook will be
rent endered or this hook will be
activated and all this functionality
will work uh now I want another case
that if there is any update in the
to-dos then also this whole thing should
uh update so we should grab the data
from it and uh use and work on with all
of them but this time I don't want to
actually grab the data I don't want to
get the item I want to set the item
newer value should be set it so if you
have added anything updated newer whole
value should be added uh this whole
thing this new set Tod do all the arrays
should go into this one but the problem
is uh you might be wondering that hey
the easy solution could be just add a
dependency arrays or todos but that will
be a problem the problem is that if you
add this one this whole thing will run
again I don't want to run it I want to
run it once at the first start but not
after that so this is the classic case
where you use more than one hook so use
effect let's use it one more time and
yes you can have as many use effect hook
in your application as you like in this
case I'll just again have my uh call
back just like this and I'll have a
dependency array but this time in my
dependency array it is dependent on
to-dos anything that happens to to-dos
run this piece of code what piece of
code again we need to query the local
storage this time we'll set the item so
just update the value keep on setting
them keep on setting them set item uh
what do you want to set them this
requires two part the key and the value
the key is pretty simple just use the
exact same keys that you are using to
the values as well so set to-dos and
then uh we can directly use to-dos but
local storage doesn't really accept
arrays or anything it just accepts
strings so easy way is to just use
json.
stringify yep there we go and just go
ahead and take to-dos here there we go
uh really simple uh fun functionality
that we have added uh so the
functionality part is over now the next
part that's in front of us is to create
some components uh let's dive in and and
create some components uh the top form
as well as the bottom one here as
well all right so the next thing that in
that is in front of us is to build the
components that is it we have worked on
the functionality part we have worked on
a lot of Logics and stuff now let's go
ahead and talk about the components we
have two major components the first one
being the form itself where I write the
data click on the button it adds into
the context that's why the context is
for that's why the add method is for
that's one thing the another component
that we'll be creating is give it an
array of to-dos it will be looping
through and displaying it that's it uh
not only displaying it it will add some
more functionality it but we won't be
working on the functionality part
because we've already done that in the
app.js we'll be just bringing that
functionality and injecting at the right
place that is it that is it all we have
to do uh let's go ahead and work on with
this one so I'll just say that I need
one more folder yep so I'll just go into
Source new folder and we'll call this
one as
components looks good so again the
components will have majorly three files
the first one will be obvious the
index.js so that we can just get all the
components at one place and can Import
and Export that so uh that's majorly
it's being done in almost all places if
you want to do it that's okay if you
don't want to do it that's okay too not
going to force you anything on that okay
so first one that we will be working on
is going to be simply to-do form to-do
form form. jsx of course because this is
an X component uh jsx component and
we'll be to do items as well so let's go
ahead and say components new file this
one will be
to-do item. jsx okay uh let's take down
the easiest one which is the to-do form
first uh that is the easiest one I'll
close all the other files as well we
don't need them as of now okay uh how
does the to-do form looks like uh basic
react functional components so RFC
C uh react functional component uh what
we can do
is let's hit enter okay uh looks good
looks good react function to do uh does
this nicely okay uh one by one first of
all what do we need for this to do first
of all we need to track what the user is
writing in the form so I need a state
for that so let's go ahead and do that
uh this will be a single to-do so I'll
just call this one to-do set too and
that will be bringing up from use state
so bring me the user State and we'll
just say initially you are empty okay
apart from this do you need anything
else uh yes you need to add this to do
the add functionality is in my context
and the method if you remember it we
actually worked on the functionality in
app.js but the beauty is it doesn't
really matter where you worked on it I
can just bring in that functionality and
if somebody has done that functionality
I can just bring it here so the best
thing to do here is uh just use the hook
used to do oh no it doesn't why is it
not suggesting me anything I really
don't like it okay we need to work on
with used too and how we're going to
grab it we'll be grabbing it from we
need to go One Directory back inside the
context and from this one we need to
grab the to-do context so we'll just
grab this hook used to-do uh from there
or can I bring it directly from the
index probably but anyways uh you get
the idea use to do now we have this used
to do directly a hook which internally
if you remember is a hook is giving us
an axis of the hook use context which is
already having the to-do context uh
pretty nice okay and we can bring in
functionality from this one so I can
just go ahead and say hey give me
something whatever you like so in this
case I just need add to-do I don't need
to have access of all the to-dos I don't
need to have access of add delete no
need at all I can just work with that
okay uh this is good now we need to have
a functionality when the form is going
to get submitted or the add button is
going to click uh we need to add it into
uh this one so we'll just first of all
we'll say okay let me just show you one
by one so we'll call this method as
simply add not the add too so what this
will do is there will be an event that
will be fired first of all prevent that
default so e.
prevent
default so they doesn't submit it
anywhere okay that's the step one now if
there is no Todo like it is empty then
we'll just don't do anything so we'll
just go ahead and say if uh there is no
to do then just go ahead and return so
we'll just remove this remove this it
could be a oneliner so return if it is
not the case there is something inside
the to-do is there is a string or
something inside the to-do uh then we
can simply go ahead and call this one as
ADD to-do okay uh first of all let's
push this one here so add to-do and what
this add to-do uh method will do uh it
requires a to-do to be passed on on to
this one so this is to-do is an object
and we'll just give you this to-do that
is a string and we can optionally give
it uh completed as one as although there
is a default value there but hey any any
case we'll just give it a false we don't
need to give it an ID because if you
remember correctly in the app.jsx when
we were working on this add to-do
whatever the to-do you pass me on which
is an object obviously I am adding the
date here if you want to remove it
completely you can just save yourself
some step you can spread this or not
even spread this you can just have it to
do here which is an object and spread
this previous here so it's totally up to
you that what kind of uh data flow or
what kind of application flow you are
going in my case I'm passing this the
text of the to-do as well as completed
here and the date I'm adding there but
you can add do everything here you can
do not everything there you cannot do
that okay uh so this is the basic and
one as side note that I'll be doing is
once everything is all done this is all
what we need to do as a functionality I
want to reset the to-do as well so that
the state actually that to-do just gets
off so I'll just empty it out so I'll
just go ahead and say set to-do and I'll
just empty it out that's it uh little
bit Basics so there we go so this is all
it takes to have your to-do form now
comes to the visual part uh for the
visual part what we'll be having is a
simple form so let's go ahead and remove
this and just have a
form so there we go we'll be having a
form uh there will be no action required
on this we'll be having just one method
which is on submit and in this we'll be
calling this add method and we'll be
having some class name onto this one as
well so we'll be having class name of
flex this is just a visual aesthetic
aspect not bothered much on that uh we
are having this input which is a type of
text okay uh we don't need
this okay let's go there and and first
of all we'll be having a placeholder
placeholder we are saying right to do
with couple of
dots and after that we have some class
names that I'll be bringing in from my
notes file I do have a lot of notes okay
so I'll be just bringing them up so that
it looks decent so there we go okay this
is copy paste stuff Tailwind CSS okay
now interesting part how does the value
in this one governs the value is going
to be governed by the to-do so that's
managed by state what happens when
something changes so anytime you change
something so on change uh what happens
is there will be an event that will be
firing up so call back and we'll be
calling the set too and inside this set
too we'll be saying e. Target do value
so we'll be adding the targeted value in
here okay that's my first part of it and
the next part is the button so that's
not really bad so button which will be
of type submit there we go and we'll be
calling this one as ADD and obviously
without any doubt we do have some
classes here as well class name and I do
have it in my notes as well by the way
you'll be grabbing all these classes
from my GitHub itself if you want to add
it on your own give it on your own look
that's also fine no big deal there okay
so this part is all done we have
exported the to-do form as well so all
looks great now moving on let's go ahead
and work on with the to-do item again
RFC looks great so we have react
functional component everything
uh the looping part and all of this
will'll be working through all of that
and all these things in a minute I'll
just directly give you majority of the
part as well but first let's work on the
functionality part
because here also you need some kind of
State Management why because in our
application we are having some of the
state control as soon as somebody checks
on that so it's is it editable or not we
are governing that if it is marked as
complete then we are not allowing that
to be editable so that's one thing and
then obviously we we need to have all
these to-do messages as well we'll be
using the state as well and apart from
this we also have the update
functionality as well so first of all in
this to-do item somebody will give us a
prop which will be a to-do and this
to-do is having all the to-dos it's a
major gigantic array which has all the
functionality in it let's go ahead and
import One By One The functionalities
that we need first of all we need to
check is to do
editable okay and we'll be needing set
is to do edit table and that will be
governed by use
State user State and by default
everything will be false uh okay and
what else we need uh we need the to-do
messages as well so we'll be saying
const and we'll call this one as to-do
message set
too
message and we'll be saying that you
will be governed by US state but in the
US State uh we will be not passing on
directly to-do because that will be bad
we'll be just passing it all the to-dos
here okay so that's my one message of
the to-do okay and updation as well
we'll be governing the updation part as
well so we'll just say update
too update too and uh we don't need
updation for the State Management we
don't need this one okay uh another
thing that we need since we are
controlling couple of functionalities
here for example update the delete as
well the toggle as well we need to bring
these functionality and how we can bring
that uh simply with the hook itself the
used to do the use context hook actually
gives us that access uh but we are not
using use context we have actually
crafted our own hook that gives us
access to all the functionality so let's
go ahead at the very top and bring this
one here I'll say first of all let's
give give me Ed to do and I'll just
bring it from Auto Import that's nice
okay so use to do there we go this is a
hook and this hook gives you access to
all the features that you need uh what
all do you need in this one I'll need
update to-do I need delete to- do and I
also need uh toggle
complete there we go okay so all the
to-dos and everything are uh with me uh
now we need to Define some of the
functionality as well uh functionality
wise we have already taken care of most
of the things but we need to take care
of some visual aspect as well uh
especially what happens when we do the
edit because notice here if it is
editable then we are enabling some
fields for example if you remember when
I clicked on the edit there was a input
field that came in and that input field
was conditionally rendered if input
field like if it was edit was editable
then the input field came in the value
got into it and now now you're allowed
to edit into that so based on this this
is the whole thing this true or false
functionality is allowing us to
conditionally render that that is why we
need to write some piece of code to
conditionally do that so I'll just call
this one as edit Todo and what does this
edit to-do does it's a simple function
like this and all it does is it allows
us to update that because once somebody
clicks on edit we need to run the
functionality of update whether he has
edited or not that's up to him but we'll
just go with that in order to update
anything we need to pass on two things
the first one is the ID so we'll just
grab the to-do and ID from there and we
need to pass on the entire to-do that
needs to be updated so we'll just give
it an object we'll spread that to-do and
what we'll be doing is the only thing
that usually we are allowing to update
via this method is just the string part
so let's go ahead and spread this out
and the only thing only property that's
getting updated is the to-do which is
now getting updated with the to-do
message there we go now it's making much
more sense to you uh once this is all
done then obviously we need to uh say
that hey this edit is all done so this
operation is being performed now let's
set editable again back to false so set
to do
editable uh we'll be going it as false
okay uh right now you might be wondering
hey nobody has made it update that will
be done editable nobody's making it as
true yes we'll do that but that will be
toggled by another click not this this
is a pure functionality part okay uh now
another thing that we'll be going
through is um this one uh let's create
another method we'll be using that in a
second uh this will be a simple toggle
complete so in the toggle complete what
we are doing is uh this togle
complete let's go ahead and do it like
this there we
go okay uh toggle completed actually
this is uh not the toggle complete
toggle complete is something that we are
bringing from the context toggle
completed is something that we'll be
using for visual aspect only just for
the strike through line that is it so
how we're going to do that uh simply
just have this one
as uh
tole complete inside this we'll be
calling this one and passing on the
to-do do ID okay so we are not directly
using this method uh we are actually
created our own method inside this and
this method technically will be running
this method so that's it okay so the
functionality part is almost all done
whatever the code we wanted to write now
what's remaining is how we actually
render that we have used a lot of fancy
things inside this so we'll just do it
uh things one by one so first of all
what we are going to do is this is uh my
div this is for each of the to-do itself
uh the first thing that I'll do is add
some class names here so let me walk you
through how we are doing it so remember
this this is not all the to-dos this is
one to-do itself okay in the app.js we
will be looping through the values this
is just one okay so the first thing that
we have is the class name name and we'll
be removing the class name like this
we'll be starting our JavaScript use the
back ticks here the reason for using the
backtick is because I have some of the
CSS classes which looks as a default so
this is just a string but I want to add
more based on I want to do some
conditional rendering so if the to-do is
completed I want to just add another
color based on that so I'll just do that
okay so what I'll do is first of all
let's add the JavaScript functionality
and then ask if the to-do is uh
completed to do
is it has a functionality I know that
this is an object I added this uh
property into this one which is a
completed if that is the case we'll do
something otherwise we'll do something
so based on this we'll be rendering the
color and by the way I do have these
colors so I'll just copy and paste this
one so this color if it is completed uh
we'll use that and if it is not
completed we'll be using this color so I
do have different colors based on that
okay so this is easy part uh we have
gone through with this one now let's go
ahead and remove this too item and go up
here now we have couple of things that
are conditionally rendering first of all
the checkbox is always there so let's go
ahead and have this one so input this is
a type of uh
checkbox checkbox we don't need this
name and
ID okay so this checkbox we have a class
name for this one really easy which is
cursor no such suggestion cursor pointer
okay and is it checked or not this
checked or not is going to be based on
to-do so too will tell me literally
completed or not and what happens when
something changes so on change we'll run
on that and in this we will be running
the to-do completed the method that we
created to-do I'll just copy and paste
this one otherwise it will confuse me a
lot okay this one toggle completed copy
that and paste it here so this is this
is the reason why I didn't use it
directly because I did because if I use
it directly toggle complete I have to
pass an ID so I have to run a call back
here if you don't want to do that just
use it like this exactly same thing so
exactly same thing nothing too much to
be discussed okay next part is my input
field and based the input field is
editable or not uh that we'll decide
based on this one is to do editable okay
let's move on to the next part uh next
part is again this one is the input type
of text so we'll be saying input text
there we go we don't need any of this
remove this remove this okay first of
all the class again the class name will
go like this this this is a common
practice you'll see quite a lot of
things being done just like this so
these are basic classes but rest of the
classes will be conditionally rendered
so again fire up your JavaScript fillers
up here and is to do editable based on
this condition either do
something or do something else I do have
again uh these things so if it is
editable we are showing the borders
otherwise we are not showing the borders
and that is it I know very very sneaky
but this is how it's being done okay uh
so command
Z so we are showing the borders let me
just copy this so we are showing the
Border if it is editable
if it is not editable then we are making
the border is transparent that is it so
it gives the feeling that it's not an
input field that is it very sneaky I
know uh but this is all what we have so
in the class name now the rest of the
thing in this is pretty easy to add in
so we need to add the value what value
pretty simple value is a to-do message
uh to-do message we got the value we are
displaying it uh is it readable or not
so let's go ahead and so this is a
readon field based on some field so
we'll be using exclamate
and the thing is
is is to do editable so if the to-do uh
really basic logic we have already
discussed that too much uh is to do we
are giving it as a false so is it
readable only or user can edit it based
on the edit functionality we giving that
so really basic don't want to explain it
too much explanation of that and one
more field is on change what happens on
change so again we have an event that is
going to call back and that's going to
make it is is set
set
too set too message as e do target.
value there we go all right so this is
done and again very very sneakingly we
are adding these input fields and all of
that uh last but not the least now we
have buttons and actually we have couple
of them there's a save button which
actually conditionally trender render to
save or edit uh we have a delete button
as well so let's go ahead and do that as
well okay one by one first of all this
is a button so this button is just a
classic button nothing too much onto
this one what goes into the button is
actually uh dependent on uh the value
itself so I'll just go ahead and start
my JavaScript again and depend on is to
do
editable so for that we'll be giving it
something otherwise we'll be giving it
something so you can go ahead and say if
too is editable go ahead and give give
it a save if it is not give it a edit
message but we do have the icons for it
so I have actually copied the icons so
we'll be using the icons but again you
can use the text if you wish and I do
have a pencil icon for that as well in
the case of edit so we'll be using that
fancy but yeah I like that okay uh so
again we'll be adding some of the
classes and all these things so let's go
up here first of all let's add a class
name lots of classes in this one okay
okay copy that and paste it no worries
that part okay classes is all done but
what happens on click that is the
important part on click so on click
we'll be firing up a call back because
we need to check some conditionally
rendering here or conditionally so we'll
be checking uh if based on some
condition so if too is
completed if to-do is completed then we
don't want to do anything at all we
don't want to give any functionality on
click should do nothing at all if it's
already completed why do you want to
save or edit it so we'll just go ahead
and say return okay that's one check but
if to do is editable let's go ahead and
do some more stuff so we'll check again
if uh is to do editable in that case
we'll just go ahead and say edit too and
in this one we'll just run this method
and in the L part if to do is not
editable uh then we'll just keep it as
it is so we'll just say set
is to do editable and we'll take the
previous value and we'll say as it is
just flip
that prev okay uh so I hope you remember
is to do editable this is just a Boolean
value so this is just true and false and
if to do is editable then we perform the
edit operation if it is not then just go
ahead and keep it as it is we don't want
to do anything in that case Okay so this
is the first part and also what we can
do is in this case we can actually check
for you want to give that button so you
can actually optionally we can make it
as disabled button or not again disabled
will be based on if to-do is completed
or not so to-do dot
is uh not to-do completed there we go
okay that's my first button that I have
I do have another button which is a
delete button so let's go ahead and have
a button and this one is delete but just
like always we do have some icon for for
it so I'll copy and paste this one so
yes we have this icon and again apart
from this we'll be having a class name
in this class name lots of classes yes
literally lots of classes goes into this
one doesn't really B uh the most
important thing in here is what happens
when somebody clicks on this button so
if somebody clicks on this button then
obviously we'll run on click and on this
fire this callback and just simply run
the delete to-do and for this we need to
pass on ID so will say to- do. ID there
we go okay quite a lot of stuff uh but I
think it's all understandable probably
it's going to take one more iteration to
understand this it looks a lot but
because we are doing some sneaky stuff
like uh removing the borders of input
field and all not if you don't want to
do all of this you can just always go
with the classic simple add Tod do
remove delete that's it we don't want to
if somebody wants to edit it there are
lots of ways of editing that okay now
next thing is let's go ahead and import
all of this and export import them via
the index file that's always a good idea
so we'll just go ahead and say I want to
import the to-do form and I want to
import this to do item and end of the
day we'll be exporting them so export
all of them remember we are not
exporting them as a default so be
careful of that and to do item there we
go exported all of that now it's time
that we go into app.js and actually work
on with this one so
app.jsx now this is the part where we
work on with this one okay now as you
can see uh we need a little bit more of
the CSS part and whatnot but I'll walk
you through directly that uh all we have
to do is I'll be adding the CSS we'll be
giving you directly but in this one I
can just go ahead and remove this H1
first and can import my form directly
here so I'll just go ahead and say too
form and that will do the job it will
not look the best of the one which I'll
give you that but it will do the job in
the case where I want to Loop through
the values then also it will super super
easy I'll give you the copy paste
version of it but first let me walk you
through with the functionality part in
here when you to Loop through the values
you have to fire up your JavaScript just
like this now I can use the to-dos
remember this to-dos yes this is all the
time getting updated in the context and
everything from the local storage
everything you can use it directly so in
the to-dos just go ahead and first Loop
through it so we'll just go ahead and
say map once I'm looping through this
obviously I have access to this call
back just like this I have access to
each of the to-do just like this to-do
and in here what I'll do is I'll
directly fire up a parenthesis so that I
don't have to use the return keyword in
here and I can just go ahead and add a
simple div just like this the reason for
using the div is so that I can pass on
my key keys are really important when
you're iterating through the values and
I can say that to-do do ID is I'm pretty
sure that's a unique one so I can use
that and in here I can just go ahead and
call my component so that is my my to-do
item there we go this requires just one
thing to be passed on which is a prop
known as to-do and I can directly pass
on this too now this is all this is all
the functionality parts so now I'll go
ahead and actually bring the nicer
version of it which includes the classes
and whatnot so I'll just go ahead and
bring that in so from my notes but this
is it the functionality part is it rest
of it is just the classes and all of
that so I'll paste this one and if you
remember this is nothing we have the
to-do provider exactly same with calling
this to-do form but little bit nicer in
the div with some classes and some Flex
box going around and this is exactly the
same thing that we just discussed the
only thing which is different is the
width full and all of that so as I save
this and hopefully things if are working
or probably not I'll just kill it and
start it
again now if I go back there we go we
have this test and all of that so
probably it's working let's go back and
see in the context first in the context
to do context and this is to do message
and this is so what this is doing is
actually this is bringing all of this uh
from the local storage so I'll just
right click
inspect and go to my
application and we need to go into this
one and we'll just clear this one okay
now let's try to reload this now we have
everything gone okay let's go ahead and
add this one as test and add this so
there we go we see the test is there
let's also see if it is able to grab
this from or inject it inside my local
storage application and local storage
there we go it is we saw that test is
here with the ID nice nice and easy and
apart from this we are having the edit
functionality so the Border comes around
and I'm able to add the test one save
functionality working nicely can I
remove this yes this is also working so
let me just summarize this one more time
because I think this can be too much of
overwhelming situation for a lot of you
let me go ahead and walk through with
this one although I tried my best to
explain you line by line and I'm pretty
sure you'll leave a comment for that
that hey we we enjoyed this lecture the
first thing that we understood about
this kind of application is that we need
to attack the context first because
that's where majority of the things goes
so in the context of to-do it was pretty
simple we have the create context and
use context create context for creating
the context use context is the hook for
using that context and use context
doesn't work alone it requires the
context which you created by create
context so we use the create context to
do context we added our data will go
here functionality will go here we don't
write the functionality but the
boilerplate blueprint of the
functionality then we simply use the use
context hook and provide the to-do
context don't need to import anything
since it's available directly we created
our own hook known as used too to
actually go ahead and do all of this
pass on as a hook once that is all being
done now now there are two cases in
front of me work either on the
components or the functionality part
first I chose to work on the
functionality first first I always go
with that so we went into
app.jsx wrapped everything into the
to-do provider uh that's the easiest
thing and by the way if you remember we
are having this to-do provider also
being exported so we need this one
otherwise we have to say too context.
provider don't want to do that so I went
into app.jsx and work on with this
wrapped everything with the to-do
provider either do it here or do it in
the main.js jsx totally up to you uh
wherever we are importing these values
and things we have to import these
functionality as well so we know that
to-dos don't need anything but add to-do
update to-do delete to-do and toggle we
need to write the functionality
somewhere so we chose app.jsx for that
one add to-do pretty simple we just
added uh to-dos from the set todos very
basic update is very basic we discussed
on that uh Delete and toggle as well the
important part was the use effect we
used two use effect in this one this use
effect will run as soon as the component
will mount since there is no dependency
array inside this one this will never
run again if to-dos has a dependency
array then it always run again if
there's a change in that dependency
array or any value inside the dependency
array so this one use effect we want
that I want to add or inject the to-dos
as soon as there's a change in this uh
state which is a to-dos so that's why
use to use effect common thing you'll
see this quite a lot after that we
started to build our components and the
first we take down is a to-do form very
easy all we had to do is work on just
one functionality which is ADD too
pretty simple we brought it in from the
context and we simply says Hey when the
add method is being called somebody
clicks on that just run this add to-do
which is context and pass on the data
that's it uh then we worked on the to-do
item which is a singular item we spend a
lot of time in understanding the
contextual part of it uh the conditional
rendering of the elements uh this one
was basic because we want to control
that whether the to-do is editable or
not what's the to-do message and what
happens with the functionality as well
so functionality we brought in from used
too rest of the things is just managing
the visual aspect and the UI aspect of
it so we worked on the edit to-do
functionality and toggle complete
nothing much you could have done the
toggle complete inside there as well but
I chose to do it here again uh random
choice and in here we worked on simple
things for example should everything be
will be stried off or not based on
conditional rendering of the CSS input
box so this input box is checked should
it be checked or not to will tell me
I'll just ask the too to-do do completed
are you completed or not based on that
we'll get that then we have this nice
thing which is having a lot of
conditional rendering uh majorly the
outline around it so if there is no
outline the input field looks like a
text itself so we actually use that
value we'll get from the state on change
will be governed by the set to-do
message and is it read only or not
that's also after that we have a couple
of buttons the button will be a save
button or the edit button depends on is
is it to do edit editable or not and
then a delete button so that is it a lot
of functionality don't worry about the
CSS part of it if yours doesn't look
exactly mine just look at the GitHub
repository I'll be pushing that in fact
that would be a good thing to do I'll
just go ahead and add everything in here
and we'll say added
another add
another H app with
context and local
storage okay and this is app 10 so I'll
just mention that app 10 oh too much uh
I'll just remove this okay uh so let's
just go ahead and comit this so you can
find everything on my GitHub repository
okay pushed it so there we go so now I
hope that you are pretty much more aware
of the flow of the application as well
as how the context part of the
application works through that I hope
that has given you great great Insight
of the react appc application some inner
working of the react especially the use
effect hook and whatnot uh in the next
video from the next video itself we'll
be starting our Mega project which will
give you a lot of ton of insight of how
to build a full stack application uh
we'll be using obviously the app right
for it so let me walk you through about
that in the next
video all right hey there everyone he
here back again with another video and
welcome to the continuation of our react
Series so far we have studied quite a
lot about the react quite an In-Depth
series about how we can build
applications with the react how the
react internal works and pretty much a
lot of things now from this video
onwards we are moving into a journey
where we actually utilize all the things
that we have grabbed so far and put this
into a use of building a software
building or using the development skills
this is exactly what a lot of people
miss that how to actually transform your
learnings and knowledge into the
development skills and this is known as
development in this video I'll watch you
through what we are about to build and
what all skills you are going to be
learning throughout this one by the way
we are building a full stack application
using react and for the backend we are
using everybody's favorite and
open-source app right so I'll walk you
through what the idea behind this
application and I'm I will be focusing
more on the generalized knowledge this
means after watching this entire few
videos and the entire project you'll be
able to build any kind of social media
app you don't need to watch any other
videos after this you'll have full
knowledge by the way just imagine what
is Facebook just some text and images
that's basically it what is a Twitter
just some text and images so it doesn't
really matter how the website looks like
end of the day it's just a social media
which is empowering you with some kind
of text and some images the same goes
for the blog article so if you know the
ins and outs of how to build a Blog
application with some text and some
images uh you pretty much can build any
kind of social media app as well
definitely on top of that there could be
so much more that you can do but at
least a basic building block could be
ready and that's exactly what we'll be
learning in this video so let me first
show you what we are going to do so let
me share my screen so this is where
we'll be building by the way in case you
haven't noticed we are already on the
10th app so we have done with that this
one is going to be technically our 11th
app but I want to show you something
more uh first thing uh although you have
completed this series I expect that you
have completed this series in all the
playlist manner that I have uploaded so
quite a lot of long playlist that we
have gone through with a long videos uh
26 minutes to 40 minutes there's a lot
of uh range in that only recommendation
is if you're watching it in the
continuation uh I'm not sure that
whether you have seen this video at the
very end or at the very last wherever
you're watching it after finishing up
your context API go and watch my Redux
toolkit in 1 hour this is a crash course
on Redux where I've talked quite an
in-depth about how Redux toolkit works
and the setup of it different ways of
handling the situation uh this is going
to be a little bit requirement so in
case you haven't yet watched it go ahead
watch it in the playlist if you're
watching this entire video in just one
go go ahead and watch this one as well
and then you can move on to this video
which is obviously the next in the
playlist so what we'll be building up uh
we'll be building up this small
application and again our focus is not
on the UI part but rather more on the
functionality part in your UI there
might be two cards in one row in our UI
it might be four cards doesn't really
matter this is exactly the function fun
ality we are looking up for this is our
homepage where there will be a display
of the card which displays the title as
well as a preview of the images not the
actual images this is something which is
given to you by aight as a kind of a
easier way to handle images so that not
the entire image is being transferred to
you but a preview version of it which is
little bit of a lesser quality uh once
you click on this any of this AI or
anything wherever you want to visit this
this gives you a full-blown image which
is larger and that's why the bigger one
because I wanted to show this
exaggerated that this is a larger one
and you can see this is where we our
have our text Data our Text data is very
very small I just wanted to show you
that you can actually store the way how
this is being bowled out so yes this is
also done not only that this project has
some of the issues which are
intentionally left in this one so that
you can actually work on them and work
on that so that you saw that briefly log
to read post so this there's a
intentional error being uh shown there
and I by the way I will give you the
entire list of where the bugs are and
how you can fix them entire walkth
through will be given to you but these
are the things that you have to walk
through and you have to learn through
I've seen that when I recorded this
entire Series in different language and
people actually appreciated that okay
now we have some work to do and they got
excited and if I click on this latest
one you can see this is uploaded by me
so obviously I get the edit and delete
control over it not for the other people
so that's a great idea of how things are
done here we can see we are storing more
information like there's a color control
there's all of that so we have a
full-fledged editor that we are going to
be using uh along with the react of
course we have the log out and sign up
functionality and signin functionality
powered by app right I'll walk you
through with that as well when I click
on the ad post we can see that we have
this ad post that we have uh we have the
full control of viig editor what you see
what you get kind of editor we can store
that we have a slug which works
automatically uh we can have a nice slug
which automatically converts uh whatever
the URL or our title is into a URL
format with the dashes so there's a
little bit of logic writing that you'll
be learning in this one so quite a lot
of uh intriguing details are there uh
for this entire one we are using app
right end to endend this entire things
are stored in the database like this
I'll walk you through how the database
are being created how you can use them
authentication features end to end the
full back end is powered by the app
right it's free and we will be using
that so if I click on this uh this is
where we have entire authentication
details uh we are having all these four
five random names of the users but if we
wish we can go ahead and use other
services for this for example in the
settings we have lot more options just
have to click and enable uh small pieces
of code that I have to inject and that's
it it supports so many crazy how much it
supports and we will be using
authentication we'll be using database
Services we'll be using the storage
Services as well so this will give you
enough of idea that how to use storage
how to use authentication and how to use
databases uh rest of them I don't think
so there is too much of tutorial
required once you know how to do a b and
c in one format you can figure out how
to do the D1 so that's the that's the
goal of this series so again I'm super
super excited that we are going to get
started and we are going to build this
one again my recommendation is we will
be focusing more on the functionality
part the UI part it's purely purely
based on the Tailwind I highly recommend
you to give it a different look that
what I have given you a lot of other
students have done that and they have
found that it's a great result they have
learned so much more just by modifying
the UI it gives them so much of
confidence of course I'll be giving you
assignments as well but I'm super
excited to get started with this one so
in the next video we'll set up a simple
boiler plate react template we'll
connect our app right with that we'll
start everything from the scratch and
the fresh and I'm pretty excited that
you are also following this up so far
and I'm pretty sure you'll be following
in the next one as well in case you are
enjoying these series please share them
on LinkedIn and also do hit me in the
comment section as well just a model
support a heart would be really nice so
that's it for this video let's catch up
in the next one
hey there everyone a here back again
with another video and welcome to the
continuation of our react Series so in
this video we'll just create a fresh app
we'll uh peek into a little bit of the
documentation of app right and it's
actually surprisingly good that their
documentation was already good but they
have still Rewritten the entire one and
I'm loving the new one so we'll go
through with that and the entire
documentation study that we are going to
do and with the code that we'll be
writing is going to be 100% reusable so
whether you are building any app in
flutter or maybe in react native or
anything else that you're going through
the concepts will remain same if the
programming language changes then
obviously you can find the things
equivalent in your language as well but
in most of the case anything related to
JavaScript type script they are going to
be very very same so let's go with that
and let me share the screen and walk you
through with that so first let's go
ahead and create a new app so obviously
we are using V so npm create V at latest
that is what we have been using and
that's exactly what you're using by the
way with this one I'm targeting the
people who probably might have not
watched my previous videos that's also
fine if you're just starting from here
that's also fine there will be a few
Concepts which I'll Point towards sayy
this was covered in previous video or
something you can watch it at that time
otherwise it would be a fantastic
experience in working together and
building a full-fledged application a
full stack application so let's call
this one as 11th app uh that's basically
our 11th app tab but hey let's go ahead
and uh start my uh terminal here uh we
have a lot of one here uh we'll be just
going with the create vat latest I think
that's good one and let's call this one
as 11 blog app blog app yeah fine good
name we'll be using of course react and
yes no we are not going to be typescript
in this one yes I know I do have a
series on typescript on this channel it
got really popular on the free code Camp
as well but we'll be going with
JavaScript in this one and what I want
to do is I just want to kill this
terminal and I want to open this up
right click and open an integrated
terminal that way I don't have to do CD
and all those stuff and I'm into this I
can just do an LS and I can just say npm
install this is going to obviously
install everything for us and we need uh
we need Tailwind for this one as well so
let's go into uh tailin
CSS quickly go into the dogs that's how
I always recommend everybody to just go
look into into the docs figure out how
things Works in this one we have already
done this kind of a thing so we'll be
going with this command now so let's go
ahead and copy this so that we have the
Tailwind setup being done so this is the
part one of Tailwind setup the part two
is to have the configuration file and
set up so that it knows where probably
you'll be writing your tail vent files
or tail Vin commands utilities wherever
you see that all right so in this one I
have the Tailwind config go ahead and
change the content part don't forget the
trailing comma this is pretty important
so go ahead and do that once you're done
with this then in the index.css we need
these uh directives being placed yes
with the adorate they are called as
directives so we'll go into the main
file where all of my CSS is there in my
case it's inside the source and I do
have index.css we'll replace everything
and place our directives there save that
and that's it now I'm technically
allowed to run npm run Dev to have my
application up and running we'll be
doing that but uh that's the basic
configuration the next step is to have
aight being installed now installing
aight is pretty straightforward there is
nothing too much to discuss on that it
just says npm install app right and
that's it that is the easiest part now
you might be wondering that we are into
react which is pure front end so what do
this app right is going to do this app
right package in itself will allow you
to talk to the backend part backend as a
service which is app right this is a
very common thing in case you used any
backend as a service in which we focus
majorly on the front end part not on the
backend side so backend part is handled
by the app right but in order to talk to
that we need the app right so that's
what we have let's quickly check our
package.json so that we can verify
things are doing good and we are okay
with that all right so in the
dependencies we have aight that's
exactly what we want and in the dev
dependencies we have tailwind and all
all of that we are happy with that so
aight is the only thing that we require
right now now we'll be needing a couple
of things here so inside the blog uh
I'll be just creating couple of new
files let me go ahead and first create
that first is going to be EnV that's my
environment variable I'll walk you
through that how you can deploy this
application on worel or netlify what
whichever works for you uh I'll show
with the warell so these environment
variables are very important at that
point of time so that sensitive
information or data is not exposed in
the GitHub and all of that I will also
create another new file because I want
to give all this data to use so I'll be
saying
thatv and I'll be creating a do sample
so this is a sample file which is meant
to be given to you uh so that you
actually work with that and what I'll do
is I'll just actually uh go up into this
one and this environment variable I can
just right click and add this to G
ignore so that that file never goes out
to any GitHub repository because this
includes some of the sensitive data that
I'm about to add in here okay
uh what kind of sensitive data you'll be
requiring that will come from the aight
itself so go ahead create an account on
aight if you haven't yet it's cloud.
aight. pretty straightforward pretty
basic and if you just scroll at the
bottom you'll find the docs one here uh
by the way you can just get through
their docs simply by app.io dos however
you want and let me walk you through how
to study these docs that's an important
aspect so on the left hand side you'll
see that what products they offer and
they have authentication database
functions and Storage is these are four
major Services there's a lot under these
categories but these are major four
categories that they work on in this
project we'll work on Au we'll work on
database and we'll work on storage so
that at least three of them are
completely understandable by you and you
can explore further things more in the
database I'm not just talking about
touching the database I'll also walk you
through how you can make queries in the
database so that whatever the
application you are building you have
the knowledge so that you can explore
things on your own so we'll be going
through with that now if you go on any
of these product like for example if I
go into the Au now we can see that there
are journeys and there are references
now Journeys is something that what do
you want to implement in your
application and the apis are what all
the things I can do in that for example
in the email and login if I just click
on this it gives me the entire that hey
what do you going to need the entire
project is itself there so entire source
code is there and you can just see that
so here we can see that what we get is a
promise but what we are using is an
account which gets to us by this account
from the app right just like this and
further this we can actually provide a
user ID if we don't uh aight will give
us one and we can provide an email and
password uh to create an account of the
user so this is all it requires and
further if you want to do the login the
same kind of a guide is provided to you
but if you want to do more with this
account API uh you can just click on the
account API and can see that I can get
an account I can create an account up
dat an email I can create a JWT token
update a username pretty much whatever I
want to do delete the sessions list the
sessions uh there is an endpoint given
to me so that I don't have to worry too
much for example uh if I just want to
see that how to delete sessions all the
sessions I can click on this and this
gives me the method that okay you can
use simply delete sessions s with the
end so that it deletes everything and
that's it that is going to delete so it
saves me so much of the time if I know
how to navigate properly it doesn't
really matter if you're using using a
react native react or you're using
something else it just it just is the
same so that's your brief overview of
how to actually study the newer
documentation and I find myself I can
find exactly what I need in a much
quicker time with this pretty much
fantastic documentation here okay once
now that we know that how the
documentation and how we can Traverse
through them I can go into organization
uh which it gives to everyone the first
time we create the account this is what
they call account as an organization
I am supposed to create a new project so
let's go ahead and create an empty
project I can import a project as well
but that's experimental they are always
very fast in doing the things they
always keep on doing some stuff I'll
create an empty project and let's call
this one as YouTube blog I think that's
a pretty good name it also gives you a
project ID we need this project ID but I
don't want to edit it although you can
if you wish you can add your own custom
IDs I don't want to do that I'll just
simply click on create and this is going
to create a project for
me and in a few seconds hopefully my
internet is oh some of the things are
actually uh getting uploaded so I'll
just copy that stop that for a minute
and this is what I need so I can just
click on the copy and this is something
that I'll be needing okay where do I
need this all of these things go ahead
and follow along with me these are some
required stuff from your site so okay
Postman No I don't want to do any of
that okay in the environment variable we
need some variables to be put on so I'll
be just adding a reactor app and then
I'll say underscore app right if I wrote
that correctly appcore URL and that's
going to be my first variable name and
similarly we will be having couple of
others like app right project ID as
well projector ID and this is my project
ID so the what we get as a project
that's exactly my project ID that I have
now once I have the project ID the next
thing is we have uh not worked on one
thing which is the project
URL now the project URL is actually
constant for all the app right because
the app right is hosted up here in the
cloud by the way in case you want to do
and find it out properly then click on
the uh web this is where you add your
project you can add multiple of your
project so my project name is uh we
called it what uh we called it as let
let me just go into package.json we
called it as 11 blog app let's use the
same otherwise it's not really
compulsory uh this is really important
right now we want to use a local host
here uh but as you upload this exact
project on verell netlify wherever I use
something similar to this so any
subdomain which is coming up from Vell
any subdomain that's come from netlify
if you're not going to put this properly
then there are 100% chances that you'll
find yourself messing up with the course
error so this is something which
resolves it 100% necessary please pay
special attention to this one uh for the
Local Host it doesn't require any port
or something you just need to get Local
Host notice here uh it actually gives
you a suggestion I hope it's visible in
the screen recording yeah it is it is so
just add a local host so just go ahead
and add a local host that's all it is
required once you're done with this now
any request coming from Local Host will
be accepted in the server and it takes
time not too much but I have noticed it
takes two 2 to 3 minutes to propagate
these changes sometimes when I'm back
toback recording it sometimes takes time
so 2 to 3 minutes is usually the things
to propagate these changes let's click
on the next now npm install app right we
have already done that uh this importing
of the client in the web sdks and stuff
we will do that but not right now let's
go ahead and click on the next uh this
is the end points and set project so
notice here project is 736 this is
exactly the same ID that we have got in
this one uh so 76 uh 763 that's the same
ID we have already got and there is the
end point being mentioned here as well
that is exactly your app right URL you
might want to copy this and by the way
this is exactly same for all the
projects yes I worked with a lot of
projects of app right and this is
exactly what you needed here okay uh
once we have this now we can click on
the next and it says hey go to your
dashboard and stuff yes I'll go ahead
and do that this is one of the most
important thing please do not skip that
otherwise I've seen people struggling
into the course error so these are the
two things that you need and your
project now now you have a unique ID you
can talk to that and that's where the
app right SDK comes into the picture but
there are a couple of more things that
we are going to require so project ID is
great uh I'll just remove this one but
apart from the project ID we need the
database ID as
well database ID we'll work with the
database as well once you're into the
database that's a generalized database
in each database you'll find a lot of
collections as well so I'll just go
ahead and have a collection ID as
well and by the way from where to get
I'll walk you through with that as well
don't worry and we need the bucket ID as
well so I'll just go ahead and add a
bucket what do you mean by
bucket bucket simply means uh the
storage that will be using so let me
walk you through how we can grab that so
I'll simply go ahead and have this one
so what I'll do is uh simply go into the
database so our app is completely up
here now here we have the databases just
go ahead and create a new database and
enter the database name let's call this
one as YouTube whatever you want to call
you can uh go ahead and call that I
won't be giving any ID it will be given
to me uh automatically so I'll just go
ahead and click on create so that's what
this is so this is your database ID so
go ahead and copy that that's exactly
what we need so this is our database ID
that's it and once we are into the
database ID then obviously we need to
create a collection so that's the next
step I'll create a collection let's call
this one as
blogs articles whatever you like I'll
just go ahead and click on
Create and this is my collection ID so
blogs notice here how easy it is to just
go ahead and go with the flow and copy
The Collection ID so that's all what we
need now in here we are going to need to
add some of the attributes what kind of
data is going to come up in the
collection since we are here already
let's go ahead and add those attributes
so let's go ahead and click on ADD
attributes and click on create
attributes and you can create attributes
of type string integer float Boolean
there's a lot of types I'll be most of
the time we'll be using the strings once
I click on the string uh what is the key
that you want to use I want to go with
title if I can write that properly there
we go uh what is the size totally up to
you I'll go with 255 go ahead and use
whatever the type that you want to go
with that so I'll just go ahead and add
255 so use that or use the scroll ones
you can add a default string value if
you wish I'll be requiring this so I'll
just say hey this is a required string
I'll just go ahead and click on create
that that's it so you need to provide a
structure of your data that how this
data is going to come up in the
collection so that anything uh which is
required can be treated like that uh
let's go ahead and add a few more which
are going to be useful for us so we'll
be saying
content this is where this is how my
content will come up I'll go with the
string again 255 if you wish more then
obviously add more numbers here these
are character sizes so go ahead and use
more I'll say the content is also
required for me I'll just go ahead and
click on create for this
one all right so we have content uh
title let's go ahead and create one more
and that is going to be my featured
image featured image now this featured
image is going to be a string size I
think 255 is good enough I'm not storing
the actual image into this one rather
I'm keeping the long string URL that
I'll be uploading cling in the DAT in
the storage service of aite once I store
an image in that it returns me back as a
promise of a long string URL that is
what I'll be keeping here and I'll say
this is also required so give me this
image this is pretty important for our
application let's go ahead and create
that uh now I hope it gives you an idea
that how these things can be done uh you
can work with that so I'll just go ahead
and create uh more attributes one more
string so I'll just say hey I need one
more which is status now it's up to you
you can keep this as a string or you can
keep this as a Boolean value I'll not
keep this one as required because that's
the status of my blog whether it is
active or inactive I can just do that on
the go uh but if you wish to have it as
an enam Boolean it's totally up to you
I'll have one more which I'll talk in a
minute uh but this one is actually user
ID so I'll be adding a couple of not
couple just one user ID for each of the
blog that we have so this is exactly for
that uh 255 is good enough that we saw
while building the demo of this
application uh but this is required
field when we create a collection of
this one let's go ahead and create this
one okay so there we go we have now the
basics being done uh pretty good now
what we'll do is we will learn how we
can make some queries with the databases
as well in order to make some queries we
need to have some queries other than
these basic Fields like title or
something uh what you'll study is when
you have an indexes being placed based
on any collection it's much more
optimized for the searching purpose I'll
probably talk about more of the database
optimization stuff uh probably in some
another video right now let's go ahead
and learn how we can create an index so
all you have to do is create an index is
provide a key for that one so I'll just
go ahead and say that hey the key we are
going to call this one as status that's
my key uh the key type is you can have
multiple keys I'll just go with the keys
uh what is the data attribute which will
be responsible for this one I'll just go
ahead and use the status for this one
and that's it I'll just create this that
is how simple it is to have a key uh
being assigned so there we go now we'll
be able to make queries by the way we
can make queries just based on
attributes as well but it gives us a
little bit more Advantage we'll study
about them and I'll walk you through
give you some resources more on that so
there we go we have now all the values
being added up here uh since we were
already here we set this up now coming
more on to this one so we have the Au
service we have the database service we
studied about them we have one more
thing which is the bucket ID
now in the documents uh if you'll just
come up onto the documents and we were
in the attribute section go into the
settings section this is where you can
see that who can actually have the
permission to add these documents this
is the most important thing not anybody
can come up and write into your uh
documentation you need to give a role to
that that who is allowed to that anyone
is allowed all the guests are allowed
all the users are allowed uh any guest
anybody who will like to that I'll say
that any user is allowed any user is
somebody who is already uh using my
application already logged in or
something so all the users are allowed
of this application so it will
automatically wire these things up with
your links I'll say that all of my users
have the ability to create a read update
and delete my application whatever the
role you want to give you can have the
RO based access uh within this database
as a service I'll just go ahead and
update this so there we go our
permissions are updated this is the most
crucial one I have seen people people
struggling with this quite a lot so make
sure you are worried about your settings
and who can access the application now
we'll not talk about the functions in
this video probably some another video
let's go into the storage so this is
where you set up your buckets and
everybody calls their storage as buckets
let's go ahead and click on the create
button and what do you want to call this
bucket I'll call this one as images
doesn't really matter we never actually
uh we never reach it out using the name
we always reach it out using the ID so
that's what we need so let's goad ah and
create this and we'll see the bucket ID
go ahead and copy this and that's what
so there we go our setting is all done
now I want to copy this and I want to
give this you into environment variable
as well uh obviously these things will
be changed by the time you'll be
watching the video so I'll be obviously
rewriting them it's important for me to
rewrite I'll be giving you all of that
but you know what values and what
variables to look up for so that's the
step one of how to grab all the
environment variables and what the
settings we need from uh this this one
now let's go ahead and set up a little
bit of our application as well and show
you some of the best practices that
probably will help you to optimize these
application so first thing that we're
going to do is inside the source I'll
create a new folder and we're going to
call this one as uh conf uh this is for
configuration and we'll be creating one
more file into this one known as conf
JS conf.js now what we are going to do
in this configuration what we're going
to do majorly and you'll see this as a
common production grade setting and
practices being used is you simply go
ahead and create a
conf or conf just like this and this is
usually an object and you simply go
ahead and Export
that export default conf now why we are
doing this this is being done because
sometimes what you'll notice is
accessing the environment variable could
actually potentially throw up an error
or sometimes there is no guarantee that
what data type is getting returned this
is not the case when obviously you're
using typescript or something but this
is a common practice being used for
example I can just go ahead and say that
hey I'll export a app right uh URL just
like this and the value of this will be
wrapped up in the string so that I'm
100% sure the value that's coming up is
actually the string and I'll just go
ahead and say I'm accessing that by
process. EnV that's by default in the
react and then I'll just name this one
as whatever I use there so in the
environment variable if I go ahead and
say app right URL copy this and I go
ahead and paste this up here so a common
practice that you'll see quite a lot and
similarly we have the project IDs and
whatnot so let's go ahead and finish
this one up app
write project ID just like this and
again same
string and yes this one takes time
process. EnV do and we need to grab uh
the project ID so copy that paste that
that's the project ID ID we need the
database ID
Now app right data
database ID and again string uh this is
just to make sure that we don't fall
into the case or the data type issues
again nothing much process oops
process.env dot and we need to grab the
database
ID this simple export will help you to
save so much of the problem trust me
I've been into that
phase app right collection
ID and again that's going to be a string
and again process. EnV this looks so
much work right now but it saves so much
of the troubles good practice again we
have the collection ID one more bucket
ID almost
done app
right and bucket
ID there there we go again last one
string and we'll be
saying process. env. and last
one bucket
ID all right so there we go so now that
we are exporting this Con now we can
import this at any place and wherever we
import this we have uh conf. aight URL
app right project ID in case you wish
you can directly go ahead and import
this but the idea is that if you face
any error or the environment variables
are not being able to load we see all of
that at one place so this makes life a
little bit easier it was not compulsory
to do but in the good uh major scale
projects and high scale High scale
companies you'll find that this is a
common practice so just wanted to
introduce you that that yes things like
that happens and things that like works
all right so this is our Basics the
setups and everything are done now let's
close all of this you have the idea how
this is being done now let's uh set up
the things for the next video that we
are about to work so for this one we'll
create a new folder inside the source
and this is the most important thing in
here let's go ahead and name this one as
app right and inside the app right we'll
start with just one file and then
eventually you'll see that why the other
file or how the other file will work
we're going to call this one as .js and
I'll walk you through what is our plan
with this .js so right now we have uh
just got the idea that how things are
going to work we have studied the app
right a little bit I highly recommend
you to go ahead and explore a little bit
more of the document of app right the
idea behind that is I want to create
these Services why Services what's the
services whenever you work with these
kinds of applications especially backend
as a service you want to create a
service file which actually a kind of a
encapsulate all the hard details like
how the registration work somebody who
is using our application should not
worry about that he should see this as
just a method that I provide you an
email and password or probably a photo
and you register me as a user what you
do in the internal details should be uh
hidden from me should be abstracted for
me and another advantage of doing this
same approach is maybe you are working
with react native or maybe you're
working some other uh application as
well you can reuse this exact same code
yes literally you can copy and paste
this exact code and it makes it so much
highly reusable of a code so that's a
good practice that we are learning how
to write the reusable code so that's one
of the advantage we are going to learn
and once you see and understand that how
we can use auth iation service and the
database Service as well as uh the
storage service that's it you are Master
about the three services in app Rite and
you can explore things on the go we'll
be learning everything from the
documentation itself so that gives you
more confidence that yes you can do the
things on your own as well all right so
that's at all uh we'll be doing keeping
it short and in the next video I'll be
changing some of my IDs because I've
exposed this to all of you uh so I'll be
changing them and then we'll be working
on the next file together all right so
that's it for this video let's catch up
in into the next
one hey there everyone Hees here back
again with another video and let's
continue our journey with the react just
to give you a brief context in the last
video we saw that how we can build a
full stack application using react and
aite I walked you through with the setup
of aight and integrate it with the react
just a quick uh sidebar or as a
interesting note uh make sure that you
in your aight app your app is properly
configured you have added the web app
and there's a local host string being
added if we not going to add this this
might lead up into a lot of course error
which are nasty in itself but the easy
fix is watch out if you have added the
web app inside the app right that's it
in this video I will walk you through
everything that you need to know about
how to read the app right documentation
and integrate the O section of it I'm
taking one section at a time and we'll
walk you through how you can make your
code robust as well as highly reusable
whether you're using aight in nextjs
react react native flutter whatever
you're using you will be creating
exactly same file in fact you can
actually copy paste this exact same file
in all of your project and not only that
I'll walk you through how the best what
is the best way to read the
documentation and all that you need
quite interesting isn't it so this is
all that you need to know about handling
the O in the app right let's go ahead
and get started let me share my screen
first and then we'll work you through so
this is our app right documentation and
this is our react app that we have been
going through for while and in this I
showed you that we have installed the
app right so if I just open up my
package.json we can see in the
dependency we have app right pretty cool
so far now after that with the basic
configuration and having all of our
environment variables which we discussed
in the last video I asked you that
create an aight folder and create an
ar.js file into this one in this video
I'll walk you through that how we are
going to use this file but first let's
read the documentation so when you go to
the aight. iocs this is where you see
all the docks and the organization of
the dock the hierarchy of it the
structure is pretty nice to go ahead and
work on with this one uh so in this
video I'll walk you through with this
that how you can actually use this one
so just give me a second I'll arrange
these things uh some of the my elements
are moving on the screens just like that
okay so as you can see the products that
they're offering is O database function
and storage in this video I'll cover the
O in the next video I'll cover the
database as well as the storage part of
it so that's pretty nice uh let's go
into the O section of it in inside this
Au section uh you'll see that on the
left hand side we have some of the
concepts the journey and the references
uh most probably the way how you're
going to handle is first a look at the
journey for example in this one we want
to see how we can add a user based on
email and password maybe you want to go
with au logins or magic URL the same
strategies are followed there as well I
click on this and this is the first step
that how I can sign up a user similarly
I can just read the docs for login and
something more but what if I need a
little bit more so here first of all
just go ahead and read one thing uh
which is if you go onto this Au section
if you go onto the Au homepage uh there
is nothing to much to explore into this
one just go onto this one this is my
journey and after this journey let me
just move this a little bit here so that
you can see it all now what we are going
to do majorly is this account API user
API is uh you have a user and you want
to modify some things about user maybe
its name email and its record but this
is the account API there's a difference
between them so if I click on the
account API you'll see there are two
dots here uh just go ahead and click on
this and this is where you see all the
methods how to create an account how to
update an email so all these things are
mentioned here for example if I want to
delete a sessions or list all the
sessions I can just click on this and
this gives me the source code this is a
little bit shrinked up so this gives me
the entire source code that hey you have
to use a method which is known as a list
sessions and I'll give you a response
and in the response I'll give you a
promise and you can extract data from
this promise and you'll get all the
sessions exactly like that if I want to
work on the delete session I can just
use the method which is delete sessions
uh similarly if I want to create an
email verification or I want to have
something else whatever I want to get
the account preferences or I want to
update the name uh create a JWT token
whatever I wish I can go ahead and do
that now uh apart from this I would like
to bring you back onto the account not
here into the Au section so in the Au
section the very first thing if I go
into the Journey of email and password
login notice here this source code just
walk through with this every single time
I have to import client account and ID
ID for creating the unique IDs there is
no big deal then I have two options here
client and account now with this you'll
see a similar pattern that is getting
repeated again and again for example you
create a new object out of this client
okay I understand this point I
understand this part now I have to set
an endpoint and set a project the
endpoint almost always remains same
until unless if you have added your own
custom domains or something like that
but in most cases it will remain same
and you have to give a project ID this
project ID we have already seen in the
last video that you can just go ahead
and copy this project ID this is very
repeatable code okay after this I have
to create an account and I get this
variable account after using the account
that was given to me by aight and
injecting this client variable to it so
this is almost like giving a context to
the account that here is your context
and now give me this object account and
this account is you can say a facade it
has so many things insided into it for
example uh you can use a method like
create this create method is actually
associated with this account that's why
I'm able to call it account. create
similarly now if you go into the login
you'll see exact same portion being
repeated okay there's a client there's a
account there's a endpoint blah blah
stuff again repeatable but what I see is
account. create email session what
parameters I pass on I can study it here
but I can see this whole top point is
very very repeatable now with this I
would like to bring your attention that
if these all things are very repeatable
can I write a code in such a way that I
don't need to repeat it again and one
such example is create a class because
in the class I can create a Constructor
which can do all of this code repeatably
for me and when I extract an object out
of this class maybe all things are
already done and this is exactly the
approach that is used for creating uh
the services yes this is what we call in
the programmatically jargon word as
services so what I'll do is I'll create
a service and I'll use almost exactly
same kind of a stuff like this so I'll
just go ahead and copy this much from
wherever you you want to borrow it this
is exactly same code sign up login
doesn't really matter borrow this code
and we'll what we'll do is we'll just
paste this code here uh doesn't really
matter these are for my references only
now uh first of all I obviously need
this project ID and stuff so I know that
I have actually added them up inside my
config so I'll just go ahead and say
import uh conf and that conf will come
up from uh we need to go One Directory
back inside the conf and there we have
got conf
uh. JS I guess yep that's exactly the
file I'm looking up for now I have this
conf data and with this conf data I can
actually go ahead and use this app right
URL project ID all these things are
being exported so just with the doxis I
can have this so this problem is solved
all right uh what is the next problem
this thing is very very repeatable so
it's better that if I go ahead and just
use this so I'll just go ahead and move
this line above because I'm going to use
this one let's create create a simple
class and Export that as well so I'll go
ahead and say hey export class and let's
name this one as Au service we will
export the class maybe we want to use it
but my goal is to create an object out
of this class and Export that object so
that you can just import it and start
using it if you want to use it anywhere
else so I'll go ahead and use service if
I can write that correctly that would be
great uh service all right so there we
go this is our classic uh class in the
JavaScript world okay uh the next thing
is we need couple of uh these things so
we need these uh client and we need this
account as well so these are my goal to
create so let's go ahead and do that so
client is pretty obvious I can go ahead
and say hey client uh you'll be coming
up from new and client just like that
okay happy with this one uh but account
not so happy because because I cannot
create the account directly right now
account can only be created by passing
the context of the client and in order
to create a proper client context I need
to run these methods do set endpoint uh
do set project and I cannot just do that
right now because otherwise just by
creating the class I'm running I want to
run these methods as soon as somebody
creates an object out of this class and
that's a great way uh to bring up the
concept of Constructor so this is my
Constructor and as soon as this
Constructor is being called that means
as soon as somebody creates an object
out of this class I'll say that this do
client now we'll use the two method the
first one is set endpoint I'll pass you
the variables in a minute and I'll also
go ahead and use the Set uh project yep
that's the one set project and these are
the ones I'll pass you the variables in
a minute but once this is done now I can
create an object not object the account
this is exactly what we studied create
an account by passing the context so
I'll just go ahead and say this do
account now you can have the value so
what value you get you'll get obviously
a new keyword and we'll get an account
we'll pass on the context uh which in
this case is this do client there we go
so no more uh repeatable code in every
single time I have to do this this is uh
the best thing that you can do now let's
go ahead and pass on the variables into
this one so this one will come up from
uh conf. aite URL yep that's what we
used and into this one we'll say conf do
uh aight project ID there we go problem
solved and this is highly highly
repeatable code now
uh what we're going to do is we're going
to create couple of methods and again
these are aight methods so your request
is going to the app right coming back
onto this one this might take some time
uh so obviously Ayn await is your best
friend in this case uh maybe you don't
like them but these are the your best
friends so what we're going to do is
we're going to create a sync method and
let's just call this one as create
account and this method has no idea how
it works it just works so this is my
first method create an account uh how to
work with that we'll walk through with
with that but I'll create couple of
methods like this so this is my create
account uh this is my login method what
else uh do you need so anything that you
want to use so two things we already
studied sign up and login uh maybe more
things you are going to require maybe
you are going to require give me the
current logged in user or whoever has
the current session so we can just use
that so I'll just use this one uh get
current user just like this and after
that oh log out will be one so obviously
we need to delete all the sessions we
just saw the code for that so that will
be log out so if you have anything more
you can go ahead and use more such
things now it's time that we write
Logics for that so for that let's refer
the documentation for the signup uh we
have gone through with this much part so
I'm not worried on this part now all I'm
worried about is do create method that I
have to go through I'll be giving the
user ID so I can give my own unique ID
or I can use the ID which I borrowed
from the ight just here and I have to
pass on email and whatever else field
you have you just pass on them and it
will create an account all right let's
see how we can do that so anybody who
will be using this method will be
passing me uh what email um and we'll be
getting password and we'll be grabbing
the name as well maybe you have more
field go ahead and grab more field
nothing to be wored now in this one
obviously this might fail so your try
catch is again a good friend uh feel
free to use try catch or promises that's
up to you I leave that as a simple
exercise for you but I'll go with a
classic try catch because I think that's
easy and in this case I'll just go ahead
and say Throw error that's it should
have handled better but uh in this case
just want to walk you through with that
okay now uh we have seen that we have to
use this method account. create okay I
can use that uh this is going to be
awaited because this is a promise that
we are getting so if we are not using
promise then obviously we have to await
uh so in this one I have to access this
account I have to call this dot account
they don't because they're directly
using it I have created an object I I
have created a Constructor so that's why
I'm using this so This do account and it
has a method do create that's it and all
the values need to be passed on the
first method is the user ID uh so the
first method I can grab with the ID that
I borrowed notice here this ID exactly
same uh if you'll study the
documentation of this this has couple of
methods and as soon as you put up a DOT
uh you can see that there is a thing
known as unique no suggestions bad luck
so you can just provide a unique and it
gives you a string uh which you can
store as a unique ID but uh there are a
lot of other ways to generate unique IDs
maybe you want to use Nano ID or
something totally up to you I'll go
ahead and give email and I'll give a
password and I'll also give a name if
you have more parameters go ahead and
pass on this now this is going to create
an account so let's store that into a
variable and call this one as user
account there we go now we have the user
account now I can check it whether the
user account was successfully created or
not so I can just run a simple if else
condition and I'll check if the user
account exist or not so if user account
exists do something if it doesn't exist
then uh
return uh whatever the value is maybe
there's a null inside it or whatever
that is it's up to you how you handle
that maybe you want to return a proper
error object that hey throw this error
whatever you want to do it's up to you
but if the account was created I want to
log in the user probably that's my
workflow probably that's the flow I want
to go with the application so I can just
go ahead and say return and I can call
another method login and I can just log
in the user using this method obviously
this login is not going to work directly
this requires some parameter I can log
in with email and password now I can
just simply go ahead and say return
whatever is coming up back from this do
login calling another method from the
same class how easy it is and for this
one let's pass on email and password
done that's it now whatever is your flow
totally go with that but I just wanted
to show you how life is going to become
easier in the future with just this
class that we have now similarly with
the login we know that we just studied
it to login we know we want to just work
with this create email session I'll copy
this so that I don't make a mistake and
I can just use it so let's go ahead and
try the exact same method so again try
catch catch not going to do too much
apart from throw the error and in the
try part uh let's go ahead and turn
await obviously we have to await this do
account and we have to use the method of
create email session pass on the email
and password that you have
grabbed and that's it so easy to work on
with and this is why I like so much this
file is so much reusable this file is
not opiniated you can use this in react
native you can use this in react I have
used this in my lots of other tutorials
as well and that's why I love to create
this and maybe right now uh this create
account as well as this login is not
good enough feature for you maybe you
want to add more just go ahead and add
more methods into class that's great now
let me show you how you can get the
current user this is little bit hidden
in the darks but super easy again
there's just one line here so I'll just
go ahead and try catch and if the catch
is there you are not able to grab the
user then I want to do a little bit of
the more console log but anyways I'll
just go ahead and say return a wait is
must have this do account and the method
to get the current user is do get yeah
super simple that's all I have to do uh
no variables nothing is required it just
since this account has an access to the
end points and all of this so that's how
I can grab it super super easy but if
I'm not able to do this then obviously
I'll want to do a console log in this
case because sometimes this has happened
to me that while working with this
application things might have gone a
little bit wrong wrong so I'll just copy
paste a little bit of the error so I'll
just say app
write service there is error in the
service two colons and then the problem
is in get current oops get current user
uh this is the method which is creating
me the problem two colons and then I'll
just go ahead and would like to stack
the entire error which is coming to
meain again it's up to you how you
handle the error it's totally up to you
uh but if I'm not able to run any of the
try catch and of that I would love to
gracefully end this method by returning
a simple null so I'll check whether what
I'm getting if I'm getting null I can
handle the situation based on that now
another one is how to do the log out the
log out is super easy if you want to do
anything just go hit account API look
for what all that you want to do you
have to study this obviously uh list the
identities delete the identities update
the phone numbers list the sessions
delete the sessions yes this is exactly
how you uh Delete all the currently
logged in sessions or known as logged
out uh you can get the sessions as well
just like this you can go ahead and get
all these
sessions and there's a lot more here
some things you require a little bit
more of the studies and discussion the
Discord forum is also Discord section
entirely is pretty great anyways uh so
let's go ahead and work with I want to
delete the sessions so all I have to do
is use this delete sessions copy this
and we'll come back onto the logout we
don't need anything as a parameter we'll
just go with the try catch in the catch
uh we'll just do a same kind of a thing
so let's go ahead
and copy this paste this and this time
the error is inside the log out there we
go in the try what do you want to do I
want to await this do account uh dot
delete sessions make sure there's a S at
the end of it because it deletes every
session that you have so there we go uh
this is the way how we actually were
able to just simply create some of the
methods uh that helped us to do all of
this but this is not all uh because
right now this is a great class that we
have built up and let me just minimize
this this is going to work nicely and
I'll not forget to remove all of this
this was just to show you uh usually
every programmer does that bring some
things keep them in the file eventually
remove that uh this class is great but
this class needs an object so that this
Constructor is invoked at the time of
creation of the object obviously so what
we can do is we can can simply go ahead
and say const and let's just call this
one as Au
service service and that service will be
created obviously new o service just
like this so we have created an object
now we are going to go ahead and Export
default uh this OD service this object
OD service so this lower one is an
object this upper class is the class
itself so now the advantage of exporting
this object is that at any point of time
time the Constructor is invoked so my
endpoints are properly created and since
it's an object it can access all those
methods so life is much more easier to
this way so this is all that you need to
know about these services and in case
you want to add more methods maybe uh in
your application it makes sense to
update the status as well so you can
update the status as well that whatever
however you want to do does it make
sense or not status of anything so you
can make more things maybe you want to
create a JWT so you can go ahead and
request create JW W it will give you a
JWT so just go ahead and add more of
these methods in your class highly
reusable code and I'll obviously go
ahead and push all of this code you can
find them all in the GitHub section in
the description section uh so this is
really nice I enjoy this quite a lot
this is really a high quality code that
you have written highly reusable in any
application and is fun as well so in the
next video we'll go through with the
same process but this time uh we have
already done with the odd section next
time uh in our application it makes
sense to to have an interaction with
database as well as storage you can keep
them in separate files as well we don't
have that much of the application or the
methods being called so we'll keep them
in just one file and it's your choice
your decision totally uh so in the next
video I'll walk you through how we can
interact with the database as well as
the storage section and the storage apis
of that right I hope you're excited if
you are do let me know in the comment
section I would be super super pumped up
to get some of your support maybe on
tweet on LinkedIn or wherever if these
videos are making a little bit help uh
some motivation is required for me I
really really need that that's it for
this video thank you so much I'll catch
you up in the next
one hey there everyone a here back again
with another video and welcome to
another episode where we are trying to
learn react and we are trying to finish
up our Mega project in this video you
will learn everything that you probably
will need to learn about app right's
database how to make queries with the
database as well as how the storage
facility of the app right works works
the code that we are going to write in
this video is of course highly highly
reusable you can use it with the react
application nextjs application probably
with the mobile application as well like
react native letter whatever you're
using we'll just keep it absolutely
independent of whatever the platform
you're using that's the goal and we are
going with that and of course it's a
little winter time so probably one of my
first video in in the uh Winter Wear so
that's what we are going for okay so let
me share the screen and first uh let me
just remind a little bit jog of the
memory of what we are about to do in
this one so in case you remember uh in
the last video we worked through with
the OJs and I gave you a simple walkthr
of how these things actually work and we
created a simple o service which is
having all the constructors and methods
and we are using the client account we
created methods like create account
login current user log out and probably
you can add more we also went up with
the documentation so we studied the bit
and pieces of the documentation of how
the account API Works how you can add
and learn about more methods in the
documentation like creating jws or maybe
creating password recovery whatever you
want this is exactly the same thing that
we are going to work through with I'll
just scroll this a little bit so that we
can see it nicely all right looks good
decent uh yep I think yeah that's okay
now the next thing that we are going to
do is almost similar kind of approach
that we are going to use but this time
we'll be taking care of the different of
the apis that are available so let's go
here and this time we are first curious
about database and then we obviously are
curious about storage as well let's
explore the database so when you look on
the database here uh what do we actually
go with that uh first of all you can see
there are concept of database collection
document relationship all these and then
there are journeys about the queries
that you can make of course you can do
order pagination that's also available
but the first of all let's understand
the concept of databases and then we'll
also learn about how the queries are
being done and used if I click on the
databases this is how you create an sdks
and servers and whatnot the most
important thing with the database as
well is that you need some of the
constant uh fields that are required now
this one is actually uh node aight we
are not interested in that because uh
that's something you want to interact if
you're making a backend as a application
and which is interacting with that uh we
are moreover worried about creating and
getting through with the collections and
bu and all that but one common thing you
will notice here this is here it says
SDK database but if I go ahead and look
for uh let's just say database
apis notice here the exact same thing uh
we get the app right from the and we
extract client and database out of it
let me Zoom this a little bit and we
exactly create a client just like in the
O service we created uh o from this this
time exactly we'll be using databases
we'll be passing on a reference of the
client and the end points are exactly
same the endpoints is first of all the
URL and then we need a project one now
out of this just like you were able to
extract o database I think this gives us
enough idea that exactly same way we can
actually extract the services for
storage as well and that's exactly what
we'll be doing in this one so let me go
ahead and copy this piece of code so
that we can work on it together and
we'll be using exactly same approach
that we used in the O that let's create
a class and set up all these things and
we'll be exporting this class as well
now it's up to you what do you name this
class uh since there is not too much of
the things that we are doing usually I
would love to keep my storage into
separate class and my database related
all stuff in a separate class or a file
at least but in this case this is not
too much going on so I'll just wrap them
up in save same uh file here I'm going
to call this one as config not too
confused with the conf conf is for app
right's URL only and config is for all
the configuration remaining all the
configuration that I require let's go
ahead and work on with that first of all
I'll paste whatever I copied so this is
the stuff that is required for myself
now let's go ahead and move it at the
bottom and just go ahead and explore
them one by one so first of all the most
important thing is to grab all the conf
which is the
URLs so let's go ahead and grab the
URLs uh URL I mean to say all the end
points like uh the environment variables
basically so I'll just go ahead and say
give me uh conf and that will be coming
up from let's go One Directory back
inside the conf and we have conf.js or
conf that's the first thing uh after
that we obviously are going to need the
client and database and I'm pretty sure
you by this point you have learned that
uh you can also extract all the services
that you require maybe Au and other
things in this case I need storage and
we'll also discuss a little bit about
the queries how to make queries this is
the the most important part of learning
uh the app ride all right so most of the
things are done and we'll be using exact
same approach so let me also open up our
o so that we can refer it back we
created a class known as o service and
we created client an account out of it
great approach we'll be using exactly
same so let's go ahead and simply go
ahead and say export class uh service in
this one we'll be exporting the class as
well but the most important part is
we'll be creating an object and we'll be
exporting that so that object at the
time of creation of an object we create
or we use the Constructor that's already
spinned off and also uh all the methods
are directly available so that's the
goal uh let's call this one as service
directly and in this one first of all we
need a client so let's go ahead and
create a client and we'll be creating a
client just like that so we have a
client apart from this we will be
needing uh databases so let's call this
one as databases and we'll be needing a
bucket as well now bucket might be a
little bit unfamiliar to you but if you
have watched the previous video we know
that the folders in the app right are
called as bu the same terminology is
being used by AWS and all the other
folks as well so we got the client and
we got the database but in order to
actually properly create a database uh
we need couple of more things to be done
uh so let's go ahead and do that uh
first of all uh let's check on the
documentation so database can be created
by new database uh but the issue is it
needs a client to be passed on so we
need to actually do that and client uh
also needs these endpoints and all these
things to be created so that's also
interesting uh let me show you how that
needs to be done first of all let's go
ahead and create a Constructor in the
Constructor as soon as somebody creates
an object we'll spin off this
Constructor so this do client uh will
set an endpoint so let's go ahead and
set an endpoint in this we'll be
grabbing the Endo from conf so C
dot API aight URL that's the one we need
all right once this is done then we
obviously need to set a project so set
project that's the step one so we need
to provide the project ID in this one
let's go ahead and say
conf. project app right project ID
that's the one we need and once with
this is done that means properly a
client has all the variables and points
that are required for us to pass on so
these two things are done and now based
on this I can take a utilization and can
actually create the database and the
bucket so it's super super easy uh all
you have to do is pass on the reference
of this client and use it so this.
database databases will be created by
new oops not like that new database and
inside databases and we'll be passing on
this do client so I hope you can see the
pattern and the consistency in the
documentation of aight that is pretty
useful exactly like this we'll be simply
creating this Dot and this time let's
create a bucket and bucket will be
created for from Storage service so we
have the storage just like that and
we'll be passing on this do client all
right so this means now I have two
variables with me database and bucket
which has access to pretty much anything
that you want to work with for example
if you want to just list all the
documents now databases is capable of
doing so so now we can use the methods
like list documents and pass on the
document ID collection ID and whatever
you want to ask for it this is exactly
the point where you first time learned
that what all you can do with with the
database so in our case we want to ask
database and grab some of the values out
of it okay so let me show you uh first
of all let's create a couple of methods
and see what they will be able to do
obviously these methods will be a sync
and the very first method is get post so
I want to grab a single post out of it
now obviously when you're grabbing a
single post uh you need to provide that
based on what you want to actually grab
this so if I go back into aight Cloud
which is here here so this is my uh blog
which is previous one I'm not using it I
have removed all the apis keys out of it
this is my new one but exactly same copy
so if I go ahead and check it out and
let's take a look onto the databases
here and inside this one uh we do have a
database uh we were having the database
so uh just to give you a brief idea that
how this actually works or let me just
walk you through directly okay so how
can I grab a post post out of it okay
let's study a little bit of the
documentation okay get the document so
this is the one that I'm looking up for
Again by the way all the cred operations
are listed here create get update and
delete so this is my get document in
order to get a document notice here I
need to pass on the database ID
obviously I have that I need to pass on
collection ID obviously that makes
hierarchy and then I have to provide a
document ID and in case you remember uh
we created each document ID as a slug uh
obviously you can pass on the
autogenerated IDS but we actually
replaced it with the slug if you
remember in the earlier earlier videos
we actually did that so now somebody
will be passing me on this slug uh of
the blog post so that's a unique one for
me and I need to grab the ID from it
okay now how do we do it of course it's
a database operation so it needs to be
wrapped up in the TR catch first of all
let's do that and let's do a console log
as an error so in the error part uh
we'll do exactly same we'll refer it as
app oops not like that app right service
and we'll just mark it where the problem
actually comes and we'll say problem is
in the get post so that we can again
come back and look at which what is the
exact point where I'm facing the issues
uh once this is done then I'll obviously
go ahead and um print the error as well
I think that's good enough and we are
going to return a false so that in the
front end part we can handle that now
what's inside the triod now you'll be
surprised to know that how easy it is to
actually grab from the aight database
notice here this. databases this is our
service that we use and all I have to
use is a method I hope you can see that
already get document yes uh list
document is to grab all the documents
get document is where you pass on that
this is exactly what I need you need to
pass on an ID here so again the step one
is to pass on the database ID so let's
go ahead and say this is my uh app right
database ID that's the step one the next
step is to provide The Collection ID so
I'll grab that from conf do uh app right
collection ID that's the next step and
once after that I have to provide this
slug which whoever is using will use
this method will pass me up here and
will give me that uh once this is there
obviously this operation will take some
time so let's go ahead and wrap it or
prefix it with the AIT and let's
directly return that so whatever the
value is coming in uh coming out of this
query we'll directly just send it to the
user so I hope you can see it's not
really that difficult whatever the
unique value is in our case slug is
there we will be just using it and when
we'll be taking uh actual usage of the
service you'll understand that how you
actually grab that slug that's really
easy from the URL we can grab it uh from
the title we can grab it there are so
many places but this is it this is it
now the next step is uh that okay I know
how to actually use this one like I can
update the document get the document
we'll create those methods as well but
let's just say now I want to query the
data database and only want to find out
uh all the values uh which are status as
active so there is some query in my case
uh I'll just show you that I think that
will help all of us in this one instead
of worrying about the IDS and all of
that so let's go into the databases and
in the databases we can see this is our
collection and inside this we have a
Blog so all the attributes when I check
this I have this user ID so uh user ID
is there there's a title here as well
and we do have a slug here as well so
inside the user ID we'll be passing on
the Slugs and all these not in the user
ID but the title anyways I'll just see
this one now my goal is that I want to
find out all the status which are marked
as active so there's a query status need
to be active so this time find me all
the documents uh in this database ID in
this collection ID but not just I'll
pass on one thing and give me all of
that or that one particular value give
me all the values based on my query so
this is the point where we need to study
that hey there is a key and the value is
that only give me those documents so
I'll come back here and if you'll notice
that uh in the database I need to expand
this a little bit probably
not and uh let's go into this one
references and this time we'll be going
into database and I want to learn about
the queries so how do I make the queries
that's interesting so notice here it's
super easy all you have to do is query
uh do select or do equal whichever you
want to use this one says select which
attribute should be returned from a
document a return document if attribute
is equal to any value provided in the
array so this is one that looks okay to
me in this case because I'll be
providing you status and a value of the
status and you give me all the documents
uh that actually matches that so I'll
provide you a title in this case case it
says Iron Man but I'll give you a query.
equal which is status and the status
should be active so I'll just give you
by the way in the array you can pass on
all the parameter as a string if you
have multiple but I do have just one so
I'll just pass on the one so let's go
ahead and do that okay now let's go
ahead and write a method for this one
that I have uh let's go with this again
a sync we go with that get posts because
multiple will be coming up and then I
have to make a query
uh this is the parameter somebody will
be giving me if nobody gives me that
then by default I'll use that the way
how you actually grab the queries is you
write exactly as you are being told so
remember everything was inside the
square bracket you need to pass on an
array so this is the first step so you
want all the title to be whatever is
mentioned into this one or you can pass
on the key value pair as well the title
Iron Man and all of that so we'll be
using the second one I need the title to
be this one uh similar to this one so
this is my
query query.
equal there we go and this is the
parenthesis a method being used notice
here uh string and the value query types
whatever that is basically it's saying
is give me I want the status this is my
key that I want to find out what is the
value that you're looking up for if you
have multiple values you can provide an
array but here uh the type that I'm
looking up for is active all right there
we go uh not that difficult uh so now I
need to learn that how can I use it
usage is another another simplest thing
uh that you can do uh this is building
queries so if you look up for it notice
here I have to say is database ID then I
have to go with the collection ID then
in the array I can pass on as many query
as I wish I just have one that's why I
directly call this one in an array uh
but if you wish you can just uh convert
it like this I have already converted
that here notice here I've already
wrapped this up inside the square
brackets that is an array but if you
don't want to you can just make it one
by one I actually did a little bit help
to myself of wrapping this up now as a
third parameter I can directly pass on
that's the advantage great nicely done
okay let's go ahead and try this again
same we'll be using try catch the error
part will remain same so I'll just copy
and paste this one copy this paste this
and this time the problem is if it might
occur is in uh get posts so multiple one
okay next up is how can I try this up
really simple this dot
databases and this databases will list
all the documents based on what first of
all give me the database ID so let's say
conf
dot project ID I given not the project
ID my bad uh database ID we are
interacting with the database app right
database ID second is collection
ID so this one will be conf do
collection ID app right collection ID
and third part is directly my queries uh
this is the only part where you need to
be careful I have wrapped this remember
I have wrapped this queries directly in
the square bracket if you are not doing
that then make sure you're passing it
like this just a syntax issue all right
so obviously this is a database
operation it needs to be await so let's
go ahead and do that once this is is
done let's go ahead and return that
directly so I hope now you understand
it's not really that difficult to work
on with this so we have worked on two
database operations one is get post one
is get post based on queries it's very
repeatable very understandable and very
consistent code in the app right so
let's move and Shrink this up and let's
also shrink this up and let's talk about
other operations which is creating the
post creating the post is super super
easy if I go back into the documents
database uh
documents list documents create
documents let's see how do we create a
document and this is how you create the
document you simply say create document
you provide the database ID collection
ID something that is unique and all the
things that you want to store that is
already available in the attributes that
you are having all right so let's go
ahead and do that uh that will also help
you to understand that since this is
unique that's why we were able to go up
here
and mention that hey the slug is unique
so give me all the values based on the
slug hope this helps now let's go ahead
and move on to another one again this
one will be a sync and we'll be saying
create a
post and this should be super easy what
do we expect that how do we create a
post while creating the post I expect
that you pass me on a title you pass me
a slug
value slug is nothing just a title but
we remove all the spaces move them into
dashes just we saw in the demo and then
we also expect that you'll provide me a
Content you'll also provide me a
featured image you provide me a status
whatever the status value is and we'll
also grab a user
ID okay all the values are here once
these values are here again same try
catch operation very repeatable
code and that's the good thing once we
have a repeatable code that means uh
it's something good okay this one will
will be create post errors and
everything are good let's go ahead and
do the same thing now we know that let's
go ahead and return this this will be
await this do
databases this is going to work with the
method create document provide all these
things uh the first one is
conf. aight database ID the second one
will be conf do aight collection ID and
the third one is what is the unique ID
in our case the unique ID is not the ID
but the slug that we want uniquely we
want all the post to be unique so that's
the slug and the third parameter is
provide me all the objects yeah there we
go so let's go ahead and provide all
these objects so we'll go ahead and say
title then we have content we have
featured image we haven't uploaded the
image yet but we'll work on that status
and we have user ID there we go so all
the value that is being passed on to me
as a method I'll just use them to create
a post now uh going back this is for
creating the post okay uh how am I going
to do and update the post that's
interesting let's go ahead and say
collection databases let's go into
directly database apis that's always
easier and this time I want to update
the document okay so for updating the
document you have to use update document
notice here update document database ID
okay collection ID no big deal uh what
else do you
need and this is not proper this should
be a little bit more because you need uh
something to find out the update
document unique IDs so I think the
collection ID this is not scrolling
properly we definitely have more we
definitely have more update the document
here we can read about it collection ID
document ID
data to be updated and the permissions
anyways I'll walk you through with that
no worries okay so this is my create
post let's go ahead and create another
method which will be update I'll
sync update
post and while updating the post
uh update document you need to provide
that what is the unique value I am
looking up for for updating
that
and update document database ID this is
not proper I've worked with that I've
worked with this this is newly updated
document probably that's the reason so
while updating the post you will need a
slug which is uniquely identify your
document that needs to be updated that
needs to be passed on otherwise the
method of update document doesn't work
uh probably there's a mistake or I'll
send a pull request to them I worked
with these documents in the past so
probably that's that's the one issue and
then one we can do is provide me the
title the new updated title or the same
whatever that is you pass me content you
pass me featured image and you pass me
status these are the field which we are
allowing to change and once this is done
uh same stuff try
catch let's open this
up we'll copy this we'll paste it up and
this time if the problem appears it
might be an
update document tracking all of this and
of course we will be returning the wait
and this time this do databases and
update document now the way how update
document works is uh first of all you
provide the database ID and the
collection ID in which or in what one
what exactly the collection we are
looking for so conf. aight database ID
the second step is collection
ID so collection ID the third step is to
provide me the unique ID if you're
working with the unique IDs provide the
unique IDs if not not just provide
anything that's making your document
unique in my case that Slug and then
pass on all the objects that you have so
exactly same uh oops not like that uh we
do have I think I can copy paste Yep
this is all the data that we have so
I'll just copy and paste this
one so we have title content featured
image a status we are not passing on
user ID because we are not allowing to
change that and we are also not
accepting that so there we go all the
data is is done and that's it that's our
update post obviously we need to write
the delete one as well and to delete a
document uh what else do we have
database ID collection ID there is
something something that is missing
because we need a unique identifier
otherwise what document you are actually
deleting uh there is no way of finding
that out okay there's something probably
a bug or issue anyways this is you get
the point how this is being done so now
the best way is actually to actually
copy and paste this entire stuff because
that is much much much easier now now
that you understand the concept this one
is delete document or delete post uh we
be taking the slug but we don't need
these object because it doesn't really
matter what's inside we just want to
delete it no need of comma as well just
give me the slug and I'll try to delet
it and let's update this one this is if
the error occurs it might be delete
document good now we also don't need
this so that's great and obviously the
method gets updated instead of update we
want to use delete document two times
document delete document uh hopefully I
have copy pasted it correctly and we
provide the database ID we provide the
collection ID and we provide the slug
something that uniquely identifies this
one uh the only new thing is you cannot
just go ahead and return it because it
doesn't return anything the return type
data type is little bit questionable
here uh so we prefer to manually return
something here so we're going to go
ahead and say return true that yes it
was properly returned
return true oops my bad this should go
up here okay looks good let's indent
that properly there we go so this is
nice in the update one you don't need to
return that updated one actually returns
you the updated document that's good but
the delete actually if you'll see they
should actually go what the response is
going to be it just says Hey 204
application Jason uh so we don't have in
the update document if you check out uh
what is the response uh you can see it
gives you the document that's the good
one but but if you check the delete
document uh there is no document that is
returned there is no true false value
that is returned so yes nothing
magically is coming out of the box I'm
trying to teach you how to study the
docs and all of these okay so delete
post is done now let's work on one more
thing uh we can actually remove them we
don't need you uh just like that we have
created all these methods about update
post delete post create post get post
and pretty much anything all the queries
that you want to handle non queries you
want to handle we have worked through
with almost every possible case that can
happen in the database if there are more
you can obviously modify these existing
methods or can add more by reading the
docs next one is bucket so how do we
handle the bucket part let's go ahead
and study the docs so this time we want
to use a storage service now this is the
storage service and it has all the
methods how you can list all the files
create the files get files update files
delete file first for me is the create
file I want to upload a file so it
simply is a method which says create
file in my case notice here it gives you
do bucket ID which we have already then
you have to provide a unique ID for the
file and then you can simply say
document. getet element by ID or however
the way you want to grab it uh probably
there is something definitely wrong with
the scrolling because I can see there is
more content here but it's not visible
uh is it my browser just yeah we can see
that the scrolling probably my browser
is going that with this this reminds me
let's go back into databases and let's
see how the update document looks for
and collection ID and the document ID
notice here now it says and mention this
there is a unique document ID which is
required and that's exactly what we used
uh probably there is something in when
you scroll this ah now it's scrolling
but if I open this ah it doesn't scroll
probably I can repeat a report a bug to
them anyways we got the concept uh so
coming back onto the point which I was
saying that let's and talk about storage
we want to create a file the rest of the
stuff we have already take care now we
need to just run through the method of
create file uh whoever is going to use
this method will pass me a file uh just
like here they are passing the file just
like that let's go ahead and now in the
same file I'll just write it for it
maybe you want to use it this is where
we are using the storage
service okay so again a sync and we'll
be calling this one as upload file files
no we are just dealing with one upload
file and there we go now how we are
going to deal with this one exactly same
go with the TR catch borrow the catch
method copy that paste it up here and
this time if the problem occurs it is
coming up
from upload file uh what do you want to
do in the try part we obviously want to
return after awaiting and sending this
to bucket same Concepts uh this do
bucket do uh create file it takes couple
of parameter first one the bucket ID
which we can grab from
conf.
bucket app right bucket ID there we go
we need a unique ID so obviously we
don't have a unique ID but if I remember
uh in the O we actually no we didn't
actually worked on this one but in case
you don't know this we should have dealt
with us probably anyway uh you can see
that uh there is a way how you can grab
the unique ID so notice here there's a
file ID but app right all also gives you
something very interesting known as ID
so here uh inside the conf just like we
were able to grab this let's grab the ID
and you'll be able to provide unique IDs
with that although you can use Nano IDs
or something in case you wish to I don't
wish to I just want to use app right
Services if they're directly available
to me why to be bothered anyways so once
we have this ID now I have to give a
unique name to the file so I'll just say
ID do unique and that's a method so
there we go and then provide the file
that's it app right will take care rest
of the things that hey I'll upload the
files we'll provide a unique ID and
we'll return you all the path that you
require for this uh file so public path
will be given to you so that you can
display them so this is basic how you
upload a file uh can you assume how you
are going to delete the file let me go
ahead and copy this and we'll go up and
paste this let's move a method for
delete
file so so delete file obviously this
time you don't need a file you need just
an ID of the file so just provide me the
ID of the file and I'll just delete it
okay how can we modify this let's see
how to delete a file obviously give me
the unique ID so bucket ID you need to
give me file ID you need to give me
that's it two methods and it can do the
job so bucket ID I've already provided
you but the method is delete file so
let's go ahead and use that delete file
I'm giving you the bucket ID but I
cannot give you this file ID unique it
generates unique ID every single time
obviously and here I cannot give you
file but rather I have to give you file
ID so whoever is using this method need
to provide me this and this time if the
error comes up it comes up from delete
file all right so you have learned how
you can upload images by the way this
exact method works if you're uploading
PDFs anything else that you probably
want to deal with so delete file now one
more last thing I would like to discuss
before we sum up this entire lecture you
can see that aight has so many things
list files create files get files update
file delete file but what's interesting
is is you can also get file for the
preview what's interesting about this
file preview is uh file preview uh this
method supports preview of these images
so entire image doesn't uh gets onto
your network bandwidth but rather it's a
cutting and the resizing of your preview
image so for example preview ported only
for the image for sty smaller 10 MB so
let's just say you uploaded a file of 8
MB it's not 8 MB in the preview it's
just few KB so it saves so in our
application we also want to give this
feature that somebody who wants don't
want the entire file probably just want
a preview of it lower quality file we
can actually give that so let's call
this one method as well and the good
thing about this one is uh since there
is nothing too much of operation going
on uh you don't need to make it uh a syn
AIT although if you do that's great but
there is nothing being a sync await in
this one I'll show you why this is
because if you notice the method it's
just storage. getet file preview uh and
it's ridiculously fast again anyways it
might take some time so we'll see that
let's call this one as get
file preview and provide me the file
ID and what we're going to do is this is
like that and we can go ahead and simply
say return this dot bucket and we can
just work with the method get file
preview and provide you the detail the
first one is conf do bucket ID app right
bucket ID and the second one is uh file
ref file ID and once this is there uh
you don't want to return it like this
because if you notice it
carefully uh it's not mentioned
here let's see what's the return type
that we have response so response is
actually a big object file for View and
you need to actually do a console log of
this and once you do the console log of
this you will find out that uh this
whole thing actually needs to be worked
a little bit different so I'll just come
up here and once this is all done then I
go ahead and say
href this is the one you can get host
name and all these things yeah a little
bit sneaky but yeah this works nicely if
this doesn't Works uh we'll come back
here we'll make it a sync we'll just
insert a weight keyword here but I have
noticed while working a a previous
version of this application that this
works directly fine so if there is no
need of it buy to just add it
okay so this is all the method we have
studied in depth about how to upload the
files delete the files get the previews
if you have if you really want to work
with more methods you can definitely
work with that now you have the idea uh
last thing just like we did uh we'll
just go ahead and call this one as
service and this will be a new service
we create an object out of this class
and we export this one so export uh
default and let's
export service there we go this will
make our life so much easier of course
there might be chances that this might
have some bugs some issues we need to
fix them up uh these can be tested while
we actually work on the project in the
front end side of it but at least our
back end part is all done and this
really I'm super happy that now we are
actually able to write JavaScript using
app right we're building full stack
applications so this is my back end that
I have all written here
uh great work there in the backend part
let me go ahead and I'll just Commit
This one as well let me just go ahead
and add this
one add
service
for
database and
storage all right let's go ahead and do
a quick commit and I'll push this yeah
some people really say that hey you
should do it from command line no I feel
here it's nice and easy all right so so
this is all the knowledge that you
really need to have to interact with
aight uh databases and storage now
you're completely equipped with handling
any kind of thing all the queries
anything that you want to do this I hope
that this video has given you enough of
the knowledge to work things on your own
now that's it for this video from the
next video onwards we'll start working
on the front end side of the application
we'll walk you through all the caveats
how to build a full stack application
which is authenticated some pages are
protected and all these things hope all
right so that's it for this one if you
find this video interesting do leave a
comment section I really really need
some of your help and support your
comment just a like just a heart it
gives me so much of motivation I really
needed to continue do all of these
videos uh thank you so much let's catch
up in the next
video hey there everyone H here back
again with another video and it's been
quite a while in fact few good weeks and
if you're watching this video in just
one go then obviously we are meeting
back to back but if you're watching it
on my main Channel as the series is
progressing yes I was gone for a couple
of weeks a lot of health issues uh but
thank goodness I'm back it's winter here
and the best part is I do write my
strategies to record these videos
otherwise it would be so much difficult
probably I would have to re-record the
entire uh this segment uh but thank
goodness I write my strategies to teach
these topics and that makes life a
little bit easier so in this video we're
going to continue from where we have
left uh in the last videos which was
just handling the app right so far we
have handled the app right now we going
to see that how we can make those web
request and if we have any issues how we
can debug them and how the application
entire flow will work I don't expect
anybody to Simply go ahead and just
build these kinds of application in just
one go because simply that's not
possible so I'll walk you through what
is going to be the strategy how we are
going to deal with that first of all I
want to introduce the react Redux here
especially the Redux toolkit so that we
can manage the state of the application
on top of that we'll be needing couple
of pages what goes in inside those pages
we'll worry about that later but we'll
be needing few pages the reason for
introducing these pages is because we
obviously will have the routing in our
application so some page are going to be
protected that they cannot be visited if
you're not logged in but some pages are
available to everyone for example if you
are not logged in the signup page is
available but if you're logged in the
sign up page is not available for you so
there are certain pages which are
available to non-logged in user certain
pages are available which are for the
logged in user so we need to figure out
a way a mechanism a logic to do so it's
fairly simple logic I'll walk you
through with the two ways of
understanding the code so that you can
probably understand it at a very better
Pace all right so quite a lot of stuff
that we have to do uh let's go back and
try to share my screen so this is my
screen that we have first let's uh open
up the Redux part so I'll just go ahead
and work with that so I'll just go on to
Google and we'll go into Redux
toolkit that's the one we are looking up
for the getting started part it should
be fairly easy with that and we just
need two things uh the first one is
Redux toolkit and we of course need
react Redux so that it can act as a
binding agent between the Redux and the
react Redux is a is a independent
library in itself you can use it with
the vue.js probably anything else that
wherever you want to maintain the state
you can use that I'll copy that and
obviously we'll install this so quite
while and now let's go ahead and install
the toolkit first uh doesn't really
matter which one you install first but
since it was mentioned in the
documentation I'll just install that uh
we also need the router as well so let's
go ahead and since we are already here
let's install that so I'll just go ahead
and say react router Dom that's exactly
what we need and that's how we always
install them uh we simply go ahead and
say example tutorial now I just want to
install this uh what's new probably not
tutorial I think that's a better place
to install it h can you give me a point
where I can install it uh probably
not okay give me a step to install it
otherwise I have to do npm install react
router Dom I'll probably do that okay so
I'll just go ahead and say npm install
react router
Dom router dasd uh that's the easiest
way to install this
oh react oh my bad I mistyped it
react router
D okay that should be all so we have
couple of libraries being installed in
our system now we have Redux toolkit we
have react router Dom this is the basic
react Dom we are not interested in that
we are interested in the react router
Dom and we have the Redux react Redux
The Binding library for that uh yes we
will be needing couple of more but right
now let's handle what we have in it
right now okay uh one common thing that
we are going to do is in this
application in fact any application that
you'll be working through you will have
a lots of pages in them our application
also has a few good Pages what goes
inside that Pages we'll worry about that
later on in the component part but right
now I think it's a good idea that we
just create those pages and try to
figure out that how we can inject our
state management as well as how we can
protect some of these pages so let's go
ahead and practice that that's a good
idea so so I'll just do a quick LS and I
can see all of my files and everything
are here I will go inside uh the source
so let's go into the source and if I do
a quick LS I can see app right and all
these files and folders up here I think
let's create a new directory in here I
want to do this VI the command line
because it's much more easier and faster
this way uh feel free to use your mouse
I think this is faster approach and
better approach for me so I'll just go
ahead and say this is Pages uh now we
have pages I can go into the pages as
well
and I'll just open up these pages so
that I can show you what all the pages
that I want to create so obviously uh
this is uh all the pages that we have so
we'll have ADD post uh. jsx and by the
way touch is a utility which helps you
to create the files and since there are
so many files I don't want to just right
click new file new file I just want to
create them for here and we'll be having
one for all posts. jsx so add post is
going to be where I'll be giving a form
where user can add a new post and all
post is where all the posts are going to
be listed in the card format and then
we'll be having an edit uh post. jsx
this is where uh if you are owner of the
post you can hit the edit button and
we'll give you a form again the same
form will be utilized of the add post
but we'll be just pre-filling the data
into that that's how it is all done and
we'll be having one home. jsx uh this is
just a homepage for you uh for users and
and then we'll be having one login. jsx
of course for login we'll be having uh
one post page as well if you want to
read an individual post so jsx and one
last one which is sign up so we'll be
having sign up. jsx now if I go ahead
and do this this creates all these post
and everything for me uh that's what I
love about it uh you could have done
that right click as well but that's okay
as of now I'll just use a utility RFC uh
which is by the way a Rea add-on of a
VSS code that you can simply have so
I'll just have an react functional
component just like this so it
automatically detects the file name and
we'll be just having this one right now
no logic is there we'll be just uh
putting these uh basic templates here so
that we can Import and Export them RFC
all post same goes for edit post RFC
there we go I'm not doing anything at
all uh just providing these values what
goes inside them we'll definitely have a
a detailed we talk on them if we need
any more pages we'll obviously create
them RFC save that and one more RFC
there we go so now we have all the pages
so one task is done let's go ahead and
close that I can actually close others
just like that there we go so all the
pages are there right now all these
pages are available in fact if I just go
ahead and set up the router and
everything uh almost everything should
be immediately available to me now one
more thing that we are going to do here
is uh inside the source let's create one
more folder where we are going to handle
a couple of things I'll show you how to
do that but first let's create a new
folder and call this one as component or
components that would be better now
inside the components uh we'll just
create one uh only one file as of now
which will be uh simply the Au layout
how the authenticated layouts will be
there uh right now there is no logic
into them but we'll obviously we
creating them uh right click and a new
file inside the components let's call
this one as simply
O layout.
jsx Okay simply RFC nothing there uh
instead of au layout let's go ahead and
call this one as protected again it's up
to you if you want to call them
something else totally up to you I'm
calling it as protected as because if I
want to protect any of the page or
anything I'll just wrap all these things
around this component so this will be
serving just single purpose that
anything inside this layout uh is going
to be something which is authenticated
if you are authenticated I'll serve you
this will act as a rapper or by the the
rapper means I'll simply accept some of
the children here and all I'll do is uh
render these childrens that's that's the
whole idea so instead of returning this
kind of a thing I'll just say that hey
just return the the children up here so
I'll just go ahead and use it like this
and we'll go children definitely I'll go
ahead and modify this a little bit but
right now this is the goal you accept
some parameter you render them but right
now this of the component doesn't know
that which one to render which one to
doesn't render and in order to actually
have this we will accept a simple
authentication as a
parameter authentication and that
authentication by default will be true
if the authentication is true that means
render this page otherwise don't render
this page but right now we have no idea
from where this authentication is going
to come to us and how this will work so
obviously this is a little bit confusing
point at this point but these are very
common scenario when you work with any
react application you have some kind of
protected page or an O layout which
helps you to render conditionally
whether this component should be
rendered this page should be rendered or
should not be rendered so we'll work on
that we will also work on uh this will
be responsible for navigating the people
if you're not authenticated let's
redirect you on the login page if you're
trying to access any resource which
which you shouldn't be then let's
redirect you to login page if you're
already login page we will we will make
sure that you don't access the login
page or sign up page so that logic will
go in here uh but again this is just a
basic right now just to help you to
understand what is going on with the
flow of this application all right uh
this is all done uh we'll come back onto
this one right now let's go into another
part which is the Redux part of it a lot
of people are afraid of Redux you
shouldn't be we have played enough in
this entire series and I'll walk you
through how the Redux will work and
we'll just manage one thing and I'll
give you assignment to manage more
things that's how you learn when you
painfully you take some pain and you try
to work with these assignments so right
click on the source and create a new
folder and we're going to call this one
as simply store the name of this folder
is not important at all you can call
this one as Redux you can call it as
Superman Redux doesn't really matter uh
we'll create two files into this one the
next file is going to be store again
some people like to have this a store in
the root of the application nothing
wrong in that but I'll just keep it all
separated up here I'll also create a
slice in the Redux toolkit there is a
concept of creating slices we discussed
that in the previous video as well where
I showed you the crash course on the
Redux uh toolkit so please watch that in
case you feel a little bit uncomfortable
here and we'll be having this o slice.
JS of
course okay first of all let's manage
the store part because that's the
easiest of all in this one all we need
to do is configure the store so we're
going to Simply Say Hey I want to confy
confy store no suggestion configure
store and that will come
from Redux toolkit bothering me a little
bit yeah there we go once I have this
one then I have to create a store from
this configure store so I'll just say
that hey I created a store from
configure store this is a method which
takes object as parameter now what goes
inside this one this takes slices or you
can say reducers as well but we don't
actually make these reducers appear
That's exactly this o slice is being
made for you create all of your reducers
here uh the way how we create reducers
in this one here is pretty simple we
simply go ahead and first say that I
want to create a slice
so create slice there we go and this one
comes from the Redux toolkit then every
single slice needs to have an initial
state so that it knows when I get
started uh what should I do or how I
should behave so for this one we'll just
go ahead and say
initial
initial State uh feel free to name it
anything doesn't really matter uh
initial States the status is going to be
false we are using it to keep a track of
authentication of the user so if the
status is false we'll assume that the
user is not authenticated and we'll also
have the user data so if the user data
is there then obviously it will be
filled up otherwise by default it will
be null there is nothing inside the user
data user data is something which app
right will give us back uh for example
what's the username what's the email
what's the ID or any information you can
just add up here now this is the initial
state but the next point is to create
the slice just like we created the store
it's exactly same so we go ahead and say
Au slice and that o slice is being
created by create slice of course lower
create slice uh it's a method which
takes an object as a parameter so that's
what it does now this takes couple of
parameter not just one the initial State
couple of parameters first of all you
have to give it a name so that although
this is O slice it will be very unique
but it is a good idea to give all of
your slices a name so that you can refer
them back with this name then passed up
the initial state of what the initial
state of the slice is going to be and
then you create your reducers so this is
your reducers now reducer is an object
and inside this object you create all
the methods uh or whatever you are
tracking now good thing is uh you don't
have to worry about uh you might have
heard the thing in the in the reducers
and especially uh the Redux that hey
don't mutate your state or something you
don't have to worry Redux has taken care
of that behind the scene you just go all
crazy now Redux take cares of that
behind the scene that's a good thing so
inside this reducers uh the first
reducer or the method that I have is
login as soon as somebody creates a
login uh we'll give him an access of
state and action so as soon as you
create any method inside the reducer you
have already an access to the state and
the action state is that current state
of what the what this uh store is
actually depicting right now so that's
what it is action is something when
somebody wants to access the reducers
they use actions to reach you out so
that uh they can provide you the payload
they can invoke these actions and all
these things so pretty easy uh this is a
method now just go ahead and somebody
will pass Us in the state the status so
if he's logged in then obviously we need
to change the status to true and they
will also provide me a payload the
payload is accessible in the action so
I'll just go ahead and
say State
doaction actually not the action like
that state. user data somebody will be
providing me this user data inside this
and I'll just go ahead and say I'll
access it VI the action do payad do user
data all right so that is it so now
something uh really nice to remember
this is something that we are doing if
somebody is calling this login and is
providing me the status that means yes
after logging in once you hit that API
get the data back you are 100% sure that
okay you are logged in then you reach
out hit this reducer so I'll make the
status as login and via the payload
you'll give me the user data that I'll
fulfill into this one this will now
reach to the store inside this configure
store and it will be available to
anybody from any component you can
directly reach out to store and can
access that data that's why these are
super helpful uh similarly we'll be
having a log out reducer as well so
we'll just go ahead and say hey let's
have a log out same exactly same
repetitive stuff we'll have the state uh
you can optionally have the action as
well but in this case we don't require
because once somebody hits a log out
we'll just flush out everything uh but
still there is nothing which is stopping
you to have an access to the action here
and the payload here you can do
that I'll just go like this and I'll
just refresh the state so the status
will go to false and we'll just remove
everything from the data as well so
state
do user data by the way you can add more
in the initial State and have more data
if you wish but right now we'll just
keep it that much simplistic stuff okay
now once you done with that the job is
not done because you have created o
slice but there's a little bit more to
it by the way in case you missed this
take a screenshot pause it here uh this
is not enough we need to export this as
well uh the most important thing is what
people are looking up for uh is
definitely these methods login and log
out so that they can access that but
also uh some of the folks are looking
for this entire reducer who are those
some of the folks your store yes so we
need to export not only these methods
but also the reducer so let's go ahead
and do that first of all let's export
the reducer that's my default export
default o slice and just go ahead and
Export this reducer reducer reducers H
when did I name it as reducers
H let let me just quickly check this
this is seems like a small
bug all right welcome back yes I had to
look into the documentation and that's
how the real world developer works we
don't remember everything we always
consult the docs uh maybe stack Overflow
these days chat GPT to figure it out and
yes this is how it works so we can see
we are following almost exactly like
that so notice here here we are saying
reducers uh but at the time of export we
are actually saying counter slice.
reducer which does it so Redux in it
itself is kind of it's wrong to say
library it's more of a framework in
itself uh which has its own way of
dealing with the things so uh we just
export exactly like this like actions
reducers so yes it might be a little bit
confusing that hey here it is reducers
and there it is reducer only singular uh
but yeah this is how the documentation
works so we'll just follow that okay uh
that reduce removes my confusion as well
yes this is but it's a good one uh good
one I'll try to investigate it more to
study more about it that why this is the
case or how this is the case Okay so the
step one is done that we have exported
the reducer but as we know we have to
export these singular method so that any
file can actually uh use these methods
as well pretty easy we're going to go
ahead and say export const and then all
the methods that you want to export like
login log out and we simply go ahead and
say this one is going to be Au slice dot
actions there we go bothering bring me a
little bit we need to have a space
around there we go so this is what we
have as of now so both the things are
done now step one is to get onto the
store and first of all import these
reducers into into the store and make
sure your store is a aware of that not a
aware of that so we'll just go ahead and
say a slice from o slice now go into the
configure store this store uh need to
have the reducer just like this and all
the reducers that you have you have to
actually mention it here so my reducer
name is O that is my o slice if you have
more you can just put a comma and have
it like for example you're tracking a
Blog here so your blog
slice blog slice goes like that of
course with a space so you can just go
ahead and work on with that I don't have
it I have just one so I'll just save it
one I need to export that so that I can
use it wherever I like I'll just go
ahead and say
export
default and and
store not like that there we go so the
two things the major things are done and
we have this o slice we have store so at
least the preparation part of our uh
Redux is all done let's go ahead and
work on with how we can actually use
these stores and work with that now for
this we'll go into our H where is our
main. jsx this is where it is so inside
the main. jsx we can work with that if
you are working on something like index.
jsx that's also fine but what we are
looking up for is the main where our
application is loading this is where I
have to work on now I'll first and
foremost I don't want to wrap it like
this uh I'll just create a router for
this one and then we'll work on with
this one so first of all uh let's go
ahead and create a
router so I'll just come here okay this
is fine okay uh first of all let's go
ahead and uh create a router
router and router will be created by
create browser router
create browser
router and this is a method which takes
an
array and we need to import this right
now there is nothing which is importing
it
so
import
create browser router and that will be
coming up
from
react router Dom so this is the first
part uh we haven't worked on how this
will be taking care of the pages yet but
we have a create browser router and we
have a router provider as well router
provider okay so assuming that uh the
router is all done of course it is not
but assuming that this is all done uh
let's create this one first so the way
how it works is uh now instead of just
directly rendering the app we don't do
this uh we actually remove this part
this app will go inside the browser
router at the homepage that hey this is
how we load the app uh but for a minute
just remove this one part and all we're
going to do is have this uh router
provider self close it and now we'll say
that hey router will be this router that
we have just created right now there is
nothing but don't worry I'll walk you
through that how this is being done so
this is the step one how you configure
all of your router we'll go inside this
array provide the paths that home is
governed by app and what all components
basically we are loading or we can say
the pages that we are loading so that's
the basic of it but we also want that we
should have access to the store as well
that's the most important part for us so
how we can have the governing that all
of my components know that there is a
store so for this the major role is that
everything like all this router provider
at every single time they should be
wrapped by the store that is the problem
statement
so let's go ahead and first import that
so I'll just go ahead and say I need a
provider and that provider is not from
the react we need from react Redux there
we go now the next step is really simple
absolutely simple this browser router
this whole thing needs to be wrapped
with this
provider provider there we go close it
and this needs to go inside
this there we go but just put this
doesn't means that it is already
automatically aware of the store we need
to import the store as well so we'll
just first say that hey let's bring up
the store we can probably get it here
import
store from and the store is going to
come up from we'll go inside the store
and there we'll be having
store.js and now this provider can say
that what is your store uh just name the
store so simply go ahead and say uh the
store is going to be store
there we go now this is all done
properly configured that hey uh the
store since this is my store this is my
state of the application every page is
going to be governed by the state that
is why I'm wrapping provider first and
then everything is going to be governed
by this so I'm just governing it so I'll
just move it a tab so that it's easier
okay this is the first part of how this
is going to be done and by the way this
browser router that you're creating that
can be done by multiple ways there are
are kind of a sandwich method as well uh
in which you just create components
inside the components or you can also
provide an object into this one so we'll
go with the object one so here is our
object that goes like this and then I'll
just go ahead and say hey path what is
the path I want to have a path of Slash
who should be the element which should
be rendered when somebody visits this
path so obviously in this case now we
say the element which will be rendered
is going to be the app there we go self
closing there we go now the next step is
uh do we have sub paaths after this
application after this SL do we have SL
signup do we have SL login do we have/
poost yes we do have that all goes into
the children so as you can see children
right now it says object but no it is
not an object first of all uh this is
the proper syntax and this is further
down again an array okay what all the
children do you have okay so inside this
I'll have multiple of these children all
these are objects just like this first
of all what is the path that you want to
grab so the path of the children is
going to be first of all the Slash and
wherever that slash is by the way we
need an access to the pages yes we have
homepage on the slash we'll load the
homepage we'll just say element who is
the element you want to render here we
want to render home which is not yet
imported home is not yet imported so now
we need a lot of list of of these
Imports so import home and we'll be
importing now you guess the idea why I
created the pages so inside these Pages
we have home. jsx there we go you get
this point that how this is all being
done so this is my slash where the home
component will be uh logged in and all
these things so that's fun that's basic
but what about the elements like/ login
uh we need to provide some kind of
mechanism to find out that uh should you
be able to access the login or not
because if you're logged in you should
not access the homepage the login page
but similarly you get the point you get
the point so I'll just go ahead and walk
you through that how this is being done
this is another of my sub route let's
just say the path is going to be uh SL
login okay we know what component we
want to mount onto this one so the
element is going to be you might be
wondering hey just go ahead and say you
want to go ahead and have login into
this
one just like this but no this is where
you are a little bit wrong not wrong we
haven't discussed these kinds of
approach so we'll just first go ahead
and say hey login nope this is not login
I
want I want it to be from Pages SL login
okay uh there's nothing wrong in this
approach but what do we want to do in
this one is instead of rendering this
login directly which doesn't gives me
control whether should I show it to you
or not I'll just go ahead and bring in
one more component which I created so if
you remember we created this component o
layout it was doing nothing but time to
bring it now let's go ahead and
say
import and this one is O layout I guess
yep o layout and that will be coming up
from do/ components and we have just one
o layout. GSX okay what's so unique that
you're going to do with this one o
layout now instead of rendering this
I'll just go ahead and say first of all
I'll wrap this up with parenthesis so
that it's easier for me to write and
I'll say hey load this element which is
au layout just like this and inside this
Au layout now let's go ahead and use
this
login it could be self closing but
what's the point what's the point of
having this now inside this o layout I
can provide a prop and I can define
whether this page requires
authentication or not so I can just go
ahead and say
false just like
this I can say that this component
doesn't require an authentication and I
can based on this logic I can work on
with my Au layout so you get the idea uh
similarly like login page exactly same
uh similarly signup page yes exact copy
of this one so let's go ahead and have a
copy of this one let's put up a comma we
need to import this
first
sign up
from
Pages SL pages and we have sign
up and we'll say no sign up also this
route sign
up also don't require any authentication
and you can load this one sign up there
we go uh right now what we're going to
do with those authentication is uh not
really important but let me just show
you uh now let's also Define one more
and you will understand the logic behind
it let's get one more copy that and now
the route that we want to go for is all
post posts maybe yes now the element
that I want to render for this obviously
is all post so first let's bring
this import and we're going to call this
one as all posts and that will be coming
up from pages and all
posts. jsx okay now for this one I want
that anybody who visits the all posts
should be accessible by all posts but
this time the authentication is going to
be true because only who are logged in
should be able to read all of my posts
that's the logic I'm going for now this
is having a shortcut so you can just
remove this one if you pass on
authentication just like this this also
converts as a true so that's a Shand a
lot of people use that but now I have
two situations here people who will be
coming up whose authentication is false
like login and sign up and people who
will also be coming up who the
authentication is true so how can I
handle this situation so there are a
couple of ways now we'll work on the
functionality part of how you're are
going to do that so notice carefully how
we are going to do this one so couple of
things are there first of all the page
is having a requirement that should you
be authenticated or not there is also
one more thing one more variable in the
picture which is saying are you truly
logged in or not page requires a login
is a different different thing but are
you logged in or not we can verify that
you are logged in or Not by just making
a query to the store that's where the
two variables actually come up and we
have to match the two conditions here
all right so uh what we're going to do
is let's go ahead and one by one so this
authentication part is all good we are
not going to touch that and uh just
below up here uh we'll make couple of uh
queries with the with the selectors here
so first of all uh let's bring up the
important part in case you have not seen
the Redux crash course please go ahead
and watch that we'll be using use
selector from the react Redux we need
the navigation as well because we will
be redirecting the people use
navigation or navigate yeah navigate is
good react rodom so these are the two
ones now let's make a query so we'll say
Au status and we can just query the O
status by using the use selector and
from the use selector we'll say that hey
there is a call back here just like this
and we can say you give me access to
State and inside this I can say state do
o do status that's how we worked on it
so this will give me a true or false
value what is your au status is it true
is it false whatever that is we'll also
go and create a simple
navigate nav naate oops navigate and
we'll create a navigate from use
navigate just like that uh now we have
access okay now I hope you can see we
have couple of variables to check for
the first one is authentication which is
also a Boolean value we also have o
status which is also a Boolean value So
based on this you have to figure out
that what do you want to do and how do
you want to do now since this is a
couple of queries are going back and
forth I would like to create a state for
myself which is probably a loader state
so let's go work with that so I'll just
go ahead and say I'll use
loader and I'll say
set loader and that will be coming up
from use
State use State and by default it will
be true so your loader is going on by
the way we yes we have use State okay
now comes the logic part how you're
going to deal with that so as soon as
this component loads you have to make
some query you have to run these Au
status and you have to figure out how
this is all going on so that based on
this you can render some of the things
because right now this is not this is a
simple children render right now but
this is going to be changed that whether
the things are good or what's the value
of this okay let me show you how this is
being done first of all let's fire up a
simple use State
here use effect sorry use
effect use effect there we go no suggest
no
problem okay first of all the call back
and then we obviously know there is a
dependency array on that so on based on
what this is depending so first of all
it is dependent on Au status this is
dependent on authentication as well and
this is also dependent on the navigate
as well so there we go these are our
dependency array okay coming back onto
this one how do you want to work with
that we want to run a simple if and else
condition in here based on I will be
navigating you to login or I'll
navigating you to the slash page okay
let's see simple if uh authentication is
required
and
your au status is not equals
to authentication okay very carefully
look at this if I require a page which
is authenticated maybe you are visiting
uh all post so I I'm saying that hey you
required an authentication there but
your authentication status is not as
true because required means this will be
converting as true okay listen to this
very carefully when I say you are
required that means I'm passing a true
in here but what I'm also checking
another side is the odd status that you
are providing me is not equals to
authentication or in terms in short your
authentication is not true in that case
where should I redirect you simple
question you are
supposed to be logged in when you want
to see all post but you're not logged in
so obviously I should redirect you to
the login page really simple so I'll
just go ahead and say I use the
navigate and redirect you to/ login this
will take care uh the another condition
that I'm checking is not a simple else
condition this is also another Checker
okay so I'll just go ahead and check
this one if I don't require an
authentication so this is my authen
authentication I don't require
authentication okay uh you can just
visit these pages
but uh you simply go ahead and say your
au status is not equals
to is not equals to the
authentication there we go what should I
do in this case okay this is the second
case where I'm saying hey you are not
supposed to be authenticated to see
these pages that means the login page
the sign up page but what I'm also
checking hey you are logged in
authentication is au status is not
equals to false so you you are truly
you're logged in and there are some
pages which don't require authentication
who are those pages the login and sign
up so if you want to visit the login and
sign up page and you already logged in
you're not supposed to see those pages
so in that case I'll just redirect you
to the simple navigate so navigate and
and you'll be redirected to uh the slash
uh this is the basic logic that we have
created now based on this we can
actually render onto this one once this
is all done uh let's go ahead and do one
more thing if we are done all these if
and else cases uh let's go ahead and use
a set loader and turn it into false so
all the drama that we wanted to check
and all of these this is all done now
here I'm changing the state of this
loader based on this I can do a simple
Turner operation into this one so I'll
just remove this part and I'll say first
Che check my loader okay if loader is
true then we're going to show maybe a
loading maybe a null I'll keep this as a
simple exercise for you to create a
simple loading component maybe a spinner
widget just add it up here simple I'll
just use a null not a good practice but
I'll just keep it here and if the loader
is false then go ahead and load the
component which in my case is just the
children children there we not like that
not like that ch run there we go so
really simple but this is a good mental
exercise to actually figure out that how
things are going on uh by the way it has
couple of more ways of how you can write
that let me walk you through probably it
will uh take couple of our more minutes
but it will help you to understand how
this is being done so for example if you
are checking something like this I'm
just rewriting the code to make it more
understandable so let's just say there
is a authentication if authentication is
true then I go ahead and I'm checking
another one if statement something like
this so in this I'm checking if your uh
Au status is not equals to not equals to
authentication so something like this so
if you are having a problem in
understanding two condition at the same
time using the this you can also apply
this one so in this case notice here
let's understand this authentication is
required okay where does the
authentication is required oh this kind
of pages means all post okay
authentication is required in this one
so it is true so this will be converted
into as true okay uh just for
explanation purpose and the O status
what is your o status it is not equals
to authentication that means
authentication was required but you are
not authenticated so where should I
redirect you if you're are not
authenticated but the page requires
authentication simply you understood
this part now we should navigate you to
which page SL login and this is exactly
what I have done in this one here so
hope this helps you to understand the
part I can understand this could be a
little bit more uh for the beginners and
fresher but this is exactly what I did
I'll just keep it here to make sure that
uh you you know that how I explained
this to you but I think now this gives
you a much more clarity of how things
are done and how things are done okay so
moving back you understood this part
that all posts are being there uh but
there we have more elements so for
example I'll just go ahead and copy and
paste this one so the page is like add
post let's go go ahead and have that one
as
well import
add post no suggestion
no pages and we have add post. jsx this
also requires authentication so it's
almost similar to that this one will be
add
post add post just like that uh requires
authentication yes and we'll just simply
say you are add post there we go so
that's the one uh we also need the edit
part as well edit also needs a slug to
be passed on uh let's do that so we have
edit post and we have a post individual
as well let's import them too
much import and this one will
be edit post that will be coming up
from pages and inside the pages we have
edit post we do have one more which is
just the post let me check that we have
just the post let's also import that we
have
post come on post and that will be
importing from pages and we do have
post. jsx uh both of them requires
authentication uh so let's go ahead and
work on with
this copy and paste it put up a comma
the path is going to be edit post but
you cannot just go ahead and edit post
just like this you need a slug value so/
colon and
slug uh this will give us which post you
want to go and this requires
authentication yes this requires and
this will be edit
post all right uh what else uh we just
need to work with One Singular post as
well uh this one also
requires uh a simple post so we'll just
remove the edit part from here we'll
just say this is a post and you'll
provide me a slug uh we're saying that
you also require Authentication it's
just personal approach I don't want
anybody to see my I'm kind of a medium
kind of a fan where if you're not logged
in you cannot read much of them anyways
it's up to you and I'll just simply say
hey this one is going to be post that's
it so at least our routing and pages are
done you have understood the concept of
course we might need to debug a little
bit but the concepts are now perfectly
fine with you that how the O layout and
all these things Works uh we now know
how to protect our pages with the help
of this o layout this is doing all the
magic U making the queries now nothing
is happening automatically or magically
but pretty good start and pretty good
stuff that we have done so in the pages
all the pages are done but our
components are not ready that in what
pages we'll be rendering login sign up
uh we'll do that uh nothing much deal
again I'll be providing you all the
details of that and we'll not be writing
any of the CSS for that I'll provide you
the CSS directly you can just copy and
paste them from my GitHub as well uh
this is not a Tailwind class we'll focus
more on the react part that's it for
this video and let's catch up in the
next one
hey there everyone a here back again
with another video and in this video I
just want to do the testing of what we
did in the last video it was a pretty
big video so I thought uh let's sip some
water and come back here I don't want to
do the testing behind the scene I want
to do all the testing that if it is
working if it is not working uh we'll
probably pause the video we'll debug
together however it goes we just want to
do it all together so let me just share
the screen and see this okay so now the
goal is if I just go ahead and I simply
run this application so I've just run
the command that's very basic so it's
npm run Dev and I go onto the page this
is the page what I see uh good enough
but in order to do the proper testing if
you watched the previous video where we
set the router and all these stuff uh
you know that first we need to go into
app.jsx and the step one is to just
remove all this gibberish not a big fan
of this we'll just go ahead and remove
this uh there's a small error we'll just
go say div oh just like this and there
should be a paragraph here or let's just
go ahead and call this one as inside the
main we need an outlet into this one so
otherwise if we don't have an outlet
from react rout Dom uh rest of the
components will not be able to render
inside this so we need the outlet so
make sure it's from the react rout Dom
and now technically we should be able to
see the home here that's good and if I
go ahead and see the login uh we see the
login if I go ahead and see all post
uh it still goes for the login uh one
more thing which I noticed is uh there's
a small inconsistency here uh inside the
O layout we actually called it as
protected uh but here in the main. jsx
we are calling it as o layout not a good
idea I'll just go ahead and say this one
should be protected that's a better one
I'm pretty sure you might have already
noticed it uh but I just noticed it not
a good idea okay o layout uh let's hit
uh let's select all the instances of O
layout by the way these are just vs code
shortcuts which I love and one more okay
multic cursor remove this uh have the
protected one uh it's not going to
bother you anything but I think that's
good one okay so now I think the testing
is all good we are logging in rendering
uh login too much white I know uh too
much light mode uh don't worry I'll get
rid of this one sign up is good but if I
go ahead and see let's just say edit
posts oh edit posts doesn't exist edit
post exist and it says edit post oh we
need to give some ID as well slug uh
let's give it a test text it says login
so we are not allowed to do so so there
we go uh as of now our testing goes good
that we have all these applications
routing States everything is working
fine uh we have no errors uh good
testing in between uh while recording
the videos it gives us rarely an
occasion that we can test in between but
wherever I do get a chance to test along
with you I try my best uh from the next
video onwards we'll work on the
components so that I can show you what
all the components we'll be needing how
they'll be working some of them are
really boring like footer there is
absolutely nothing inside that just copy
paste of the uh Tailwind classes uh
header could be a little bit interesting
because we are conditionally rendering
some of the elements like uh the logout
button the sign up button and all of
that so they can be little bit
interesting but Footers not really
something all right so that's it for
this one I hope you have enjoyed this
one uh really short video but really
something that helps to understand the
features of it let's catch up in the
next video and work on the components
part of
it hey there everyone ha here back again
with another video and from this video
onwards we are going to have a journey
about building the components now some
of these components are really great
because you understand a lot of Logics
behind it for example how and why do we
use forward reference a special hook in
the react and some of them like
conditional rendering but some of them
are really truly boring they does
doesn't teach you anything from the
react perspective they are just you can
say the logo component it just displays
the logo that's it it does nothing more
than that a container it's just a
wrapper it just displays the element
nothing much more than that the footer
component lots of Tailwind glasses good
for Tailwind practice nothing else
nothing else at all but what we can do
we have to work with both of them so uh
we'll start with some of the basic ones
which doesn't do much and as we move
forward we'll progressively work on some
of the components which are really good
and interesting and helps you to
understand the react part of it uh let's
go ahead and do that so we'll just go
into the screen sharing first all right
uh once we're in the screen sharing mode
uh then let's go ahead and go into
components the first is let's create a
new folder and keep it inside this so
this one is going to be
container and inside the container we'll
have this simple container.
jsx new file
container and it should be all
caps
container.
jsx okay uh what do we have in this
container. jsx uh to be honest there is
absolutely nothing it's just as it is
you can probably can do something like
export default uh just right here in
case you wish if you want to but that
one is also fine so what do we have in
this container we simply return a div uh
which is going to render the children so
let's go ahead and accept all the
children and we are going to display
these children just up
here why we are doing this uh what's the
point of because we want to add some
additional classes that is the whole
goal nothing more than this uh we want
to Simply have a width of full uh so
that we can have a uh we'll also have a
Max width so we'll just say Max width of
uh 7xl by the way you can hover this one
I didn't come up with them automatically
I also worked with tweaked a little bit
while we were designing this application
so it's not some magic number that I
came up with uh we'll just say Max Auto
uh simple and we'll just say px- 4 uh so
these are the classes we came up while
displaying a container that's it nothing
more uh nothing less onto this one okay
uh we'll keep this one in a folder so
that it's little bit separated out uh
now let's go ahead and move into let's
close this one first we'll go into
container First Source and then contain
container
components components and let's create
couple of files first so I'll just try
to create the files from here it's much
more easier otherwise right click it
sometimes create files in the wrong
place where I don't want it to be so
I'll just go with the logo.
jsx and there we go logo uh what do we
have in this logo honestly nothing I'll
just go with the RFC uh the logo is logo
I don't even have a logo otherwise
usually it's just the image uh but let's
just say if we can have some logo can we
have some of the logo in the public we
have V SVG we can probably use that or
can we have I'll just keep it as it is
uh but we need to have some of the
classes on this one otherwise it is
going to give
us uh some of the issues with this one
we'll figure out later one uh right now
let's just display it inside this one
and instead of a div itself let's use an
image I think that one would be
good I'll just remove I'll add an image
in the later on videos don't worry I'll
just say I want to have an image just
like this and this one is going to be an
SRC right now there's nothing so I'll
just keep it empty and inside this if
somebody doesn't pass me any parameter I
I'll make it little bit more robust so
that people can pass me some values I'll
just say 100% And whatever the width you
give me I'll just use it as a style I'll
make it a little bit fancy I'll just say
give me a width if somebody gives me 80%
we'll use 80% width otherwise that's it
uh let's use at least an El so that we
know this is a place for
logo
placeholder if I forget later on we can
just work with that that's it that's
your logo uh next up is little bit
interesting not too much but little bit
interesting we'll have a simple Button
as well so we'll have a button. jsx why
do we have a button uh no such big need
of having a button but I realize that if
you have a button you can customize it a
little bit easier in case you are
familiar with something like Shad CN or
something that is fantastic almost same
kind of approach we are using I'll just
have an RFC we have a button uh the
button is going to take some of the
parameters
oops there we go uh what all parameter
first of all you'll be taking children
so that you can render them uh you'll
also have a type uh the type Ty is going
to
be
button and BG
color BG
BG color uh that is going to be by
default this one is going to be uh
background is going to be blue 700 600
whatever you wish plain old Tailwind
colors nothing more than that uh we'll
also give it a text color and the text
color is going to be white so we'll say
text- white and we'll also have some of
the class
names class name and that by default is
going to be empty but you can pass me on
more and you can also pass me more props
so we'll spread them around if we have
props and one comma is required now the
advantage of taking these props is if
you wish to have or to do something more
you can just go ahead and do this I'll
just remove this one and I'll say I'll
return you a
button just like this
button is going to render the
children you can also rename this
actually to the button title if you wish
but I think I'm happy with this one okay
what else do you want inside this button
let's have the class name class name uh
we'll actually change this class name
into uh first of all back ticks actually
first of all curly braces then a back
tick uh so that if we give px- 4 padding
on xais to be four padding on y AIS to
be two so that it looks like button is
and we'll also go for rounded dlg for
rounded but if you have more properties
you can just use the dollar and
variables to have this one for example
the BG color if you want to change it
now you can easily change it uh more
variables uh text color maybe you want
to change the text color go ahead and
change it now and also some additional
classes if you want to pass on I'll just
respect that as well okay so right now
we have basic default button the another
advantage that we can have in this one
is if you have more props to be passed
on maybe active deactive whatever you
want to say I can just actually respect
that as well I'll destructure these uh
props as well here so all these props
actually goes directly here uh makes
life a little bit easier again a good
way of how we can have the button very
generic button but could be reused like
anything now let's close this one let's
study a little bit which is more
interesting and you'll repeat this quite
often uh which is input. jsx inputs are
little bit different and interesting
compared to the button because button
doesn't have too much it just register
one event which is on click uh nothing
much more than that but inputs have
great number of deals with that because
if you think it carefully input is going
to be used in some other component that
component will have state so you have to
somehow manage that somebody's writing
inside this component but that value
goes outside of that into up upper level
component I hope you're understanding
this this is complex uh but the solution
is not that complex but imagine this the
component let's just say this is your
form one level down is input now this
input needs to give information to its
parent that is where the magic comes and
that's why I found input to be really
amazing now inputs just like this I'll
just actually rewrite this entirely so
how do we actually manage this that we
can pass on some information to our
parent itself passing into child it's
prop but how can we pass on to the
parent that is interesting that's why I
found this one interesting while
teaching so we have input just like this
in order to do so you have to use one
Hook from this react which is forward
ref yep that's it that's it uh forward
ra if you have this one that's it it
just pass everything to the parent
component and now you can go ahead and
say export default input there we go now
how do we use this forward ref Now using
forward ref again is is fairly
straightforward uh you just wrap up your
component inside this and we also know
the component is nothing it's just a
function so function we call this one as
input and this is how we work with it if
you have anything to access uh you can
just go ahead and say I will access a
label for this one I'll also accept the
type of this one uh type is going to be
uh text by default otherwise you pass me
on this one we'll have the class name
just like this and by default it's going
to be empty so that same concept of the
buttons uh we'll also have the props so
let's just say props if you have more
props you can just give me uh also you
have to give me a ref otherwise I'll
just pass on this ref okay uh let's go
ahead and move it on to the next line so
that it's easier to read for
everyone there we
go moving up just like this you also go
like this you also go like this uh just
arranging them sometimes these things
bother me a little
bit
okay there we go now hopefully it makes
sense okay uh much easier to read in
this way now in this one all we have to
do is return just like we return in the
components so this one is going to be
returning just like this and I'll be
returning a simple div just like
that this div will have a class name we
are going to get width of full whatever
is available to us and then we simply go
ahead and use these labels and all these
inputs so let's start our JavaScript in
here and we'll say label label label
there we go if label is there then we're
going to display the label so use an ERS
sign and another component just like
this and in here we're going to start a
label component label tag would be
better name label tag just like this
inside the label tag we'll display this
label if the label is not there what's
the point of displaying the label and we
can have some of the HTML ID for it so
HTML 4 and we can actually give it an ID
and we can borrow the ID by the way from
the react itself so I can just provide
an ID just like this right now I don't
have an ID so I can just go ahead and
create this ID by use ID which is given
to me by react itself and I can actually
go ahead and before I return I can just
say const ID is going to be equal to use
ID there we go now we get from where
this ID is coming up from all right not
bad uh we'll also add some of the class
names don't really like them but we have
to uh this one is going to be in line
block and we'll have a margin bottom of
one we'll have a margin sorry padding
left of one okay if you wish to design
it a little bit more you can just go
ahead and do that really doesn't bother
us much so this whole thing is the label
portion of our input we also need to
give it an input because that's what
this is input not the label let's go
ahead and provide an input it could be a
self-closing one just like this now we
need to set up all the parameters here
like for example we are taking type from
the user let's respect that and provide
a type just like that uh we also need to
provide a ref uh because when any form
will be using it they will be providing
us this ref or
references there we go and we'll say
just add the ref here uh let's
restructure all the props and add them
here as well there we go and also let's
provide the ID so same ID can go up here
same variables same unique ID will go
here uh then after that we'll add some
of the classes so the classes concept is
exactly same there is nothing new that
you are learning uh we'll have the
classes but we'll wrap them in the curly
braces and in the back text so that if
any variable comes up we can actually
respect that so this is a New Concept
that you learn into to this input which
is how to pass on some data from a lower
component to Upper component or to from
a child component to a parent component
that's interesting uh similarly like the
input one we'll create one more which is
exact same replication uh select form or
select input select.
jsx uh we'll go with this so select uh
exactly same concept uh I think this
will be a good reputation for us so
let's go ahead and create a
function and this will be our function
just like this and this function is
going to be named as select there we go
and we'll also grab the react import
react we'll we know that we'll be using
use
ID use ID and that will be coming up
from
oops react okay uh the function is all
done now we just need to export that
again it's up to you how you create your
function within inside that just like we
created or you can do something like
this export
default
react. uh forward ref and here we can
just say
select this one okay uh both are same
exactly same uh it's just the way of
writing the code here we're doing
everything in line whichever you prefer
there is no right or wrong uh there is
no optimization in this one uh you can
actually just wrap this up and pass it
on directly here I created the function
first and then I'm passing it at the
export time uh in the forward ref uh the
reason for showing you two ways is so
that you can understand that yeah some
people write code this way understanding
the code is also really important so
this is what we have as of now all right
moving further uh we'll take some of the
parameters uh what all the parameter we
obviously need this is a select so we
need options we need the label exactly
same thing will happen to the label just
like we did uh class name just like this
and we'll also have props we'll
restructure them
and once we are done with this uh these
are all the first like objects that
you'll be passing me but you also have
to give me the ref okay uh once we are
here uh then obviously we need to First
handle the ID part we know that that's
easy use ID there we go unique ID
generated return and there we go and
inside this we'll just return a simple
div okay first of all class name simple
class we'll say with get the fill width
there we go no big deal uh in here uh
the label thing will be exactly same so
why don't we just copy and paste that
save us sometimes because it is exactly
same there is nothing new we are
learning here so we start our JavaScript
we simply say if you have label then
we'll display the label we'll use the
HTML ID or HTML 4 for this one we'll
have the label uh but right now here
this label is good uh but now the input
form is different so this is okay now
let's start the select field this is
where things gets a little bit
interesting so this is my select field
uh I'll keep it
as no not self- closing okay now one by
one what goes inside this first of all
inside this select field first of all
let's display all the props that you
have so let's get rid of this oh my my
bad dot dot
dot props okay one part is done scroll
this a little bit okay uh we need ID
okay easy part ID will be going like
this so ID easy part uh we also have ref
easy part we also grab it like this ref
okay this is easy part now the thing is
which is most important about this is a
lot of options will be given to you this
is how the select Field Works uh In Case
by the way uh you forgot it or maybe you
want to jog the memory we can go select
HTML and I'm pretty sure W3 schools can
help us to memorize jog the value if I
try this uh this is how it looks like
this is the select field a lot of
options are being passed on and as soon
as you select the option that option is
being selected that's what exactly what
we want to get these options will
obviously be an array somebody who is
using my component should be already
aware of this and now all I have to do
is start a JavaScript here and I have to
say hey options I want to Loop through
you so maybe you can use for each maybe
you can use map whatever is your
favorite you can use that
in each one of them you'll get a call
back just like this so we'll get an
option options option remember that and
then we can simply use a call back just
like this I'll start a parenthesis not
the curly braces so that I don't have to
explicitly return and then inside this
one I'll say I will start options here
not options option and I'll close this
one as well there we go inside this one
I'll display each of the these option
okay half part is done because if you
remember the code part here uh this is
the option so this part is done but we
need to also have the value being added
otherwise it's just displaying here so
we need to take care of the value part
so we'll go up here and we'll
say
value and the value is going to be
whatever the option is simple uh we also
need to do one more thing uh which is
not required from the HTML perspective
but from the react perspective it's
required since the value is looping
through by default react uh fiber has no
way to knowing that if it is repeating
different values or the same values so
we need to provide a key for it this is
performance optimization and I know that
these each options are different so I
can provide it option like this uh
really interesting uh but this is all
what we have now apart from this there
is just one more final thing uh which is
just a class so I'll just copy and paste
this doesn't really bother us much so
there we go we have our select options
being added this is something really
interesting I hope it gave you some
knowledge of forward ref if it does do
let me know in the comment section this
is really important okay uh this is all
done uh input part is all done now let's
also do one more thing uh actually two
more things we have to do in this video
uh but this one is going to be a little
bit interesting so what we're going to
do is let's open this up it's much
easier to actually create components
from here I want one more component
which is post card not really the
postcard like postcard but card for the
each of the post that we have this is
interesting because a lot of information
we need to grab and how we can actually
grab this one so let's go ahead and RFC
react functional component we have
postcard just like this now this
postcard takes couple of information uh
let me show you it takes a dollar ID uh
if you're using mongodb you might have
underscore ID in the case of app righted
dollar ID you also give me a title you
also give me a featured image image
featured image okay uh featured image
these all things are given to me now my
responsibility is to Simply have a card
on the homepage to take the user on the
longer post for that particular post
okay how we can do that first of all
let's remove this because we want this
entire card to be clickable so we need
to grab the link just like this so we'll
grab it like this but this link uh
obviously doesn't come directly we need
to have it from the react router
import uh give me a
link no suggestions nope from react
router Dom okay now anything inside this
will take us to this but again we have
to provide where do you want to take me
for this we have to use the two keyword
I'll use uh back text we'll go wherever
we are uh obviously on the homepage so
we'll go on SL poost and Slash the slug
ID which in this case is dollar uh just
like this and we'll provide dollar
id id yeah that one okay now we know the
link part is sorted now all we have to
do is grab a simple div which is going
to display the information so inside
this div obviously some of the class
names will go I'll just copy paste these
classes doesn't really bother us much
and we'll use class
names just like this so let me just copy
and paste these classes you can also
copy and paste them
from okay uh from the GitHub itself uh
so there we go and inside this we'll
have another div yeah that's how we
designed it okay uh this div also has an
image so this is the image now where the
interesting part lies is how you're
going to grab the source because you
have this featured image only now let me
jog a little bit of your memory if I go
onto the config part notice here we
created a simple
method uh where it is yeah get get
preview so this featured image is
nothing it's a file ID that you will
pass me so here in the postcard you'll
provide me this featured image this is
nothing this is the file ID so I can
actually use this get file preview
method and pass it on file ID and what
it gives you is directly a link of the
image notice here we send href so this
is a link of the image so I can actually
utilize these features and that's why I
say uh these Services actually helps you
to lot of work that is already that can
be reduced down so all I have to do is
import let's call this one as app right
Service app right service and that will
be coming up from
SLA H nope do do slash yeah there we go
app right SL config.js probably don't
need ajs but
anyways uh so we have the app right okay
now in this Source I can just use it
directly so I'll just remove this one
inject it like this and I'll say app
right Service uh I'll want to use a
method which is get file preview and in
order to run this method I have to
provide you the featured image that's it
automatically it will call this and do
everything that I want to do all right
in this one image itself I will inject
the title optionally but if you wish you
can just go ahead and do that now time
to add some classes and this one is
going to be rounded Das excl
and we do have some of the classes onto
this div as
well we'll have the class name just like
this and again these classes are nothing
too much to be worry
about basic Tailwind
classes okay uh next part is how we are
going to display the title uh totally up
to you what I want to do is just below
this div uh we'll have an simple H2 and
inside the H2 I'll display
it title there we go we do have some
classes for this one as well so we'll
have a class name and we'll have a text
Dash excl we also have font
bold all right uh so I hope you
understand a lot of things that are
learned from the react perspective as
well as good software engineering
perspective that creating a service it
helps us a lot we don't need to do
things thousand times it just works out
of the box okay now one more thing uh
final thing that we are going to do for
this video is we'll create a new
folder uh which will be a
footer again nothing much this is really
the most boring file it has nothing it
will be simple
footer.
jsx okay simple RFC react functional
component and all we're going to do is
just copy paste some of the HTML code
remember this is not an HTML tutorial
there is nothing much we are doing uh
just a lot of CSS classes logos and what
not uh only thing we have to do is
import a link because all these are
wrapped around the link link and that
link come from react router on that you
already know and that's it that's it
your footer is ready now all you have to
do is go into an app uh display the
footer see how it looks like and all of
that uh whatever the things we wanted to
study in this one we have studied most
of it uh still uh there are few more
left uh but we're going to do that in
the next video already the video is half
hour long uh so let's go ahead move on
to the next video and see that how we
can work on the rest of the components
they're pretty interesting let's catch
up in next
video hey there everyone Hees here back
again with another video and welcome to
continuing our journey for building a
full stack application which is our blog
app in this video we're going to take
down two approaches and in fact two
Pathways at the same time the first we
are going to take the tiny MCE which is
a viig editor what you see what you get
so you will get the ability to uh simply
uh have the Bold applications calics
underlines all that you see in a fancy
editor you're going to see all of that
and in the second part we're going to
take a uh take a lead into understanding
the react forms now react forms can be
directly handled uh there is nothing
wrong in that but there is the industry
standard way of handling the things so
I'll show you what is being used in
majority of the production grade
application at first it might look
little bit too much but as you move into
the production grade application or when
you will be working in the job you'll
notice that most of the people actually
prefer these kinds of form instead of
just handling every state manually again
there's nothing wrong in handling the
state manually but this is the industry
standard so I thought that let's
introduce that uh it might be a little
bit challenging at first but this is the
good way and good approach to get
started so that's what we'll be doing so
let me just walk you through uh let me
first share the screen so this is the
editor that we'll be using this is time
MCE this comes up in both free plans and
the plate plans of course we'll be using
the free ones and that's what we'll be
going through and then we'll be also
going through with the controllers as
well so we'll be going through with that
so let me walk you through so this is
the uh tiny MCE which is an editor uh it
of course can take a parameter of API
key which we not be giving it to one uh
we'll be using the free version a couple
of parameters that are important to pass
on are like what's in it value
initialized value uh then we can provide
what should be the in it then we have to
provide the plugin that what all do you
want to support in your editor like
autol links list uh visual blocks Code
full screen what mode you want to give
and in the toolbar what options you want
to give uh undo redo all of these so
these are the things and in the content
body we'll be actually using as it is so
uh what's what are all options available
so this is the editor uh which we'll be
using by installing after this tiny MC
as an editor that's the first step and
after that we'll also have a look on to
this one which is a a react hook form uh
pretty interesting library to work on
with this one uh all the things are
available in their docs that what all
things you avilable set errors
controllers forms in this couple of ones
we are going to use and I'll walk you
through how to read the docs and how to
work with them uh this could be a little
bit challenging and I think this
requires a standalone crash course or a
video in itself which I'll try to upload
on my channel if you haven't yet
subscribed go ahead and hit that
subscribe I'll get if I'll get enough
request I'll definitely L do a proper
crash course on the react hook forms as
well pretty interesting subject and I
love this quite a lot so we'll be using
that all right so uh now let's go one by
one and try to install them first so
installation is pretty straightforward
there is nothing too much going on with
that uh let me just go on to vs
code first let's go into tiny
MCE so installation react let's go there
and the installation that we need is
this one which which is atate Tiny MC
tiny MC react let's go back up here and
have the installation for this one so
npm install and this one is for the
editor part all right and we also need
the react uh form as well so let's go
back and let's go get
started and here is a react hook form so
let's copy this and install this one as
well
so I think these are the two which we
are going to need as of now I think
that's enough let's go ahead and get one
by one up and running with this one all
right so first let's go ahead and create
uh we'll create one by one uh let's
start with the simple nav bar which we
are going to have so we'll be having a
logout button and a navigation bar then
we'll work on the realtime editor and
then we'll be working on the post form
as well which is going to utilize all
the hooks and all of that so let's go
ahead and start one by one so so first
of all let's create a new folder inside
the component we're going to call this
one as simply Navar or let's call this
one as header so inside the header uh
we'll be having two files the first one
is going to be header jsx header. jsx
and another one is going to be a
standalone component itself which is
going to be
logout log out or log out button. jsx
uh the reason for creating a logout
button itself because it is going to
make a query uh and we'll be using some
services from Au service and all of that
that's why we are just keeping it
separate one here all right so what do
we need uh we need dispatch so we're
going to say I need use
dispatch no no
suggestions all right I use dispatch the
dispatch is going to come up from react
Redux there we go after after that we
need the Au Service as well Au
service and that's going to come up from
couple directories back inside the app
right inside this
aujs yep that's the one and we're going
to need a couple of services from store
as well so we need to
import log log
out and this log out will come up from
we need to go One Directory back and
inside the store and from that we are
going to need Au slice.
JS all right so now we have the log out
the reason why we are having this log
out functionality in itself alone uh so
that we can make a request using the
slice and that request can just clear
out everything that's what we designed
it so in case you forgot that let me jog
the memory again so this is what we have
imported after exporting this one so
once we actually hit this one it will
create the status as false and we can
have a simply user data as null that's
what the goal is okay first of all let's
create a dispatch otherwise we won't we
won't be able to access it we won't be
able to send a message that we are using
this method so const
dispatch and that will be designed or
created using use dispatch hook there we
go now we have access to this one let's
create a log out Handler anybody who
clicks on this button we will be
handling it with this
one log out
Handler Handler and using this a simple
method let's fire this up and we'll be
saying hey Au service give us a method
which is uh log out and once we are
having this log out method being called
which is in our service uh let's use a
promise and we'll simply get a then if
then happens then we are going to
successfully cater that one
and we're going to then dispatch an
event which is going to be a log out
event there we go and since this is a
method let's run this and that's it in
case you wish you can handle the catch
part as well but I don't think it's
required in this case but that's it
that's how we are going to log out
notice here if I'm able to successfully
handle the log out then only I'm
dispatching an event of log out and
that's what we have designed in our
store as well that as soon as this is
being called up we're going to set the
state as null and the user data to set
status as to false and user data as to
null okay uh time to design a button uh
there is nothing much that we are doing
is let's go ahead and return a
button there we go inside the button we
just
say log
out and rest of the stuff is pretty
obvious only one thing is important that
is on
click on click and inside this one we
just simply say log out Handler please
don't say it like this we don't want to
execute it we just want to pass a
reference and then our basic class names
uh again I'll be just giving you these
class names if you want to design your
button your own way be my guest please
do that all right so now you understand
the logic behind it that how the logout
button is being designed uh let's go
into the header. jsx because that is the
file which will be having the entire
navigation items uh most of them are
just Tailwinds and Loops nothing but
there are some reacti is part of it so
I'll just say RFC so we have a header uh
we'll be requiring couple of import
statements in this one as well uh first
of all uh let's import uh container in
fact what we can do is since we need
couple of more things from this
component itself we can design an index
file and have an Import and Export
statement from there as well but in this
case let's go ahead and
do container
uh separately and we'll be bringing them
from slash oh we need to go inside One
Directory yeah do
slash
container H it's oh we need to go One
Directory back my bad One Directory back
container and inside that we have this
container do jsx we don't need that and
we also need a
logo and we don't have anything inside
the logo but still we'll get this one so
this one is from One Directory back and
we'll just say logo okay two of the
components that are required for
navigation bar are here since we'll be
redirecting a lot of stuff link is
required of course that comes from react
router
Dom and what else uh we need a log out
button that's why we designed
it log out button and that comes from a
log out button and we'll be uh forcing
people to use navigate here and there so
let's go ahead and do use that as well I
use navigate that comes from a react
router Dom okay how does we how do we
Design This header that's the important
part again uh this is going to be based
on something first of all we need o
status whether user is logged in or not
because based on that we are going to
display the signin or the log out button
so why not we create a simple const
which says o status and this status is
going to
from the use selector do we have use
selectors have we imported that um not
so we need use
selector import use selector there we go
and once we have this now I can use the
use selector and can make a query uh
give me the state and I'll just ask you
that State uh has this Au and has got a
status status this will fulfill a value
of true and false and also in the
meanwhile let's also use the use
navigate as well nothing
much
navigate and that will be coming up from
use navigate hook there we go okay uh
now we need to design a simple constant
of navigation items uh that is better
way once we have these navigation items
as an array we can Loop through them and
can simply generate our uh HTML from
that let's call this one as nav items uh
that's going to be a basic array and we
will have multiple objects into them if
you wish more you can have more I'll
have something like this name is going
to be
home not only that I'll also provide a
slug for
that and that slug is going to be where
you are so slash for that and we'll also
provide an active status for
that and active is going to be true in
this case
okay this active status right now looks
true but it's going to be based on the o
status uh so what's the art status and
all of that so let let me show you what
do I mean by that uh this will be
getting clear here so let's just say we
have a name and this time we have a
login login the slug is going to be I
can actually copy
this I can copy the slug which could be
slash login
come on there we go now interesting part
is it active or not that is going to be
based on not o status so what do I mean
by not o status so not o status simply
means if you're log in uh your
authentication status is true that is
you are logged in so the active status
will automatically become false so in
that case I don't want to display this
login to you that's the whole idea
that's the whole game of this situation
uh similarly we'll be having a sign up
exactly same so let's go ahead copy and
paste put up a comma we simply want to
say this one as sign
up sign up we'll copy and paste this so
smaller sign up same OD status will be
not that means if your authentication is
true I don't want to display this so
that means active will automatically
become false uh similar to this we have
couple of more pages for that
let's put up a comma and we'll have all
posts the slug is going to be all Dash
posts a routing will take care of that
but this time I want this all status to
be true if your OD status is true that
means you are logged in then only I want
to show you this uh all
post so otherwise you'll just see the
login and log out so that's it uh add
post post is similar one such thing so
you are able to see all post and you are
able to see add post that's how we are
designing our navigation bar this one is
going to be
simply add post this one is going to be
add post out status is true okay so now
I hope you understand that why and how
we are designing this nav items all we
have to do in this one is now simply
have couple of design items just like
there and then we can simply Loop
through the values the looping part is
important rest of this is fancy design
nothing more than that let's go ahead
and have a header this header will have
a class name uh simple classes pading on
y AIS is
three when we designed it we simply had
a shadow a shadow will just be like that
and we have a background of
gray 500 is good
enough okay inside this header we have
this container as a component so this
wraps up automatically and gives you the
space and then we have a couple of nav
items so so let's just have a nav and
this nav is going to have class again
couple of classes we have uh we'll be
getting a flex the first item inside the
nav is going to be a simple div which
will be for logo nothing more and for
this we will be having a class name
margin on right side will be four uh
while designing this this is what we
found it to be best let's wrap the logo
inside the link so we'll be having a
link just like
this where does it go to
nowhere so we'll be saying it like that
slash and inside the link let's place
the logo right now we don't have any
image for the logo but whenever we'll be
having uh we'll be happy with that okay
once we have this div item uh that means
the logo is all done and then we'll be
having a UL after this one so unordered
list and it will have couple of class
names and we'll be having a flex and
margin left off auto so that everything
is pushed onto the very right side okay
this is where the things get interesting
uh now we need to start our JavaScript
because we want to Loop through the
values so looping is not that much
difficult in this case I have these nav
items I can use any Loop my favorite one
is map and I'll go like this then again
we need a couple of values into this one
we have items so each object inside the
array we are calling it as an item and
based on this item we'll be looping p
through okay uh let's go ahead and work
on with this one so now we can directly
go ahead and start this but I don't want
to directly start this I want to display
the element only if its property active
is there so what can I do I can evaluate
this if item is
active there will be two cases item will
be active or might not be active if the
item is active uh let's do something
otherwise we'll do something okay okay
that's interesting so again this might
give you a little bit of the Turner
operat yeah that is this and in the
other case we are simply going to refer
it as null we don't want to do anything
you can just generate an empty component
as well that's fine too in this place
we'll just remove this and display a
component so let's place a curly braces
here now in this curly brace how do you
want to display the item obviously we
want to in an unordered list I want to
display a list item so I'll just go
ahead and grab Li list item since the
list item is the one that is getting
repeated it's good that we pass on the
key here item. name is the unique value
that we will be having okay inside this
list item we will be having a button
which can actually get these clicks so
we'll be having a button just like this
and in each of the button we'll be
having an on click which is going to
just navigate the value so I'll just say
on click there we go what do I want to
happen when the click is there first of
all a call back because I want to pass
the value just like this and then I will
use the
navigate so navigate where do we want to
navigate we have already taken care of
that by having the slug value so
navigate the
user to a place where it is item do
slug
slug item. slug so this is the place
where you will be navigating and after
that is just a class name to make it
look decently beautiful I have these
class names with me so I'll just copy
and paste this one I hope now you
understand it's not really difficult it
looks difficult but it is not uh the
button doesn't have any name right now
so let's go ahead and give it really
simple item.
name that's it so now that entire thing
is there and we are happy with that but
you might have noticed that we are not
actually giving any log out we have
designed a logout button but we are not
giving this log out to the user we have
only worked with this unordered list
which is nice now now what I want to do
is after this uh all the allies and
everything is being generated now I want
to have uh this one here I think this is
where I start my JavaScript I want to
have another Li but this Li is going to
be conditionally rendered only show the
logout button to the people who are
logged in so that means I can get the
access of that by a simple variable that
I've designed OD status if the OD status
is true then only do it so I can use
Turner operator if it is true do
something otherwise go ahead and do show
null that is also a good approach or I
can use another approach with the MERS
sign if it is true then only we are
going to render this just like this and
we can say let's grab an Li
Li yep there we go and inside this Li
let's load a simple
logout component just like that so I
hope you can see uh it was a little bit
lengthy but it's not really difficult
that's how we simply have our headers
and navigation bar uh don't worry we
will be assembling that in the app.js so
if you see this app.jsx uh just above
the outlet we will have the headers and
we'll have the Footers as well but right
now this is good enough for us to
understand that how things are going
already it's too much uh but that's it
so that's our part one the phase one we
we have handled the authentication part
and the logins and whatnot now let's
move on to something which is Tiny MCE
uh this could be a little bit difficult
at first uh but it's not it's really
really easy the first thing is that the
tiny MCE is a component which is not the
usual form it's a third-party form and
we're already using a third party form
which is the react hook form so react
hook form also knows that hey these
kinds of things are really really common
uh and if you look at their docs uh
you'll see that there is a hook that
they give you which is use controller if
you look at this it says react hook form
Embrace uncontrolled components in
Native input however it is hard to avoid
working with external controlled
component and we are into this exact
same situation A react select is one of
the selection Library which helps you to
get selection based components antd very
very popular so we are into one such
situation in that case we can actually
wrap everything using this component
controller and this controller gives
back the control of these thirdparty
forms to the react hook form that's
exactly what we want so let's go ahead
and see that how we are going to handle
that so let's close the header and let's
create a new file into this one and this
time we'll call this one as realtime
editor so
RTE do
jsx okay uh let's go ahead and do it one
by one react functional component export
just like that okay this is basic okay
now we need just the two things first is
our
controller controller and this
controller will come up from react hook
form and another one is we need to
import
editor this is
interesting
editor and that editor is going to come
up from the tiny library that we have
installed so tiny MCE react okay uh so
how do we how does this one work
component we know that we can wrap it
around uh but what's interesting is this
tiny MC so what you'll notice is there's
nothing too much to be worried about
this all you have to do is worried about
where you're going to load your editor
and pass on these initial values that's
all it takes so let me walk you through
and once you see this happening up here
uh you'll be pretty much comfortable so
whenever anybody is using an RTE he'll
be providing couple of values so what is
the name of this uh one name is good
enough uh we'll also get some of the
control from the user if it doesn't
provide we can also pass on default ones
it actually uses default one and then
we'll also say the label
oops label just like that and we'll also
have the default
values default value I'll show you what
these default values and everything are
okay uh now time to get into this one so
what we're going to do is first of all
our label logic will remain as it is
exactly same just like we have used in
the past as well so let's create a div
and have a couple of class name and this
one is going to be VD full that's it now
let's first display the label again
start your JavaScript like this if the
label is given by the user uh that's
great then only we are going to display
it
and if the label is present then we can
just simply go ahead and use a label
just like that okay uh this label will
have couple of classes
mainly
inline inline block there we go and
margin bottom of one and padding on the
left side of one that's it okay what is
the value that we want to add into this
one simply
label there we go so label part is done
we know that part we have done that
handled this one uh now comes up is the
wrapper first of all the wrapper so
controller there we go uh we can make it
self closing no bad nothing back uh
nothing bad into this one uh since it
doesn't take any values or something we
can just go ahead and make it a self
closing now this controller takes couple
of values if you wish to read more about
it you can read in the docs uh that's
why we passed it up uh name the unique
name of your input that's why we said it
name it also gives you the control here
the control object is from the invoking
user use form uh so again the exact same
thing I mentioned that control is uh to
make sure that if parent is invoking any
child form that child can again pass on
some data back to it uh then we have the
render which is what is that you want to
render into this one these values and
default values you want to study more uh
you can just go ahead and do this these
are the required ones nothing else you
have to worry okay let's doal with them
one by one so we'll say the name the
first prop now I will inject a
JavaScript here that I'll just keep it
as name if the name is there otherwise
we'll just say
content okay if somebody passes me this
name to make it this form reusable
that's great otherwise we'll call it as
content so control this is something
that you have to pass on when you
actually design a form like that uh
notice here this control is something
that is a control object from the
invoking use form right now there is
nothing which is using the hook use form
but if there is one this is where it or
this is how it takes the control of it
then the next one is
render uh render uh this render is
interesting one uh because it's actually
a call back so just goes like this and I
don't want to use the return keyword so
I'll just go like this inside this
render itself uh you need to provide
What fields you are interested in uh
working with so first of all I'll say
field just like that and the field that
we are interested in working is on
change okay uh little bit weird as of
now but don't worry it will be all good
in just a second now this is the field
that what do you want to control like on
change because we'll be having a state
in the state we'll be staring so this
all will come from who somebody who will
invoke the use hook form right now it's
not there so when we'll be designing the
major form that's where this will come
in okay uh now coming back in here here
I want to render the editor that's the
one and I it can be self closing as well
that's it now the editor right now it
looks like just one element uh but it
requires more fields and more properties
that's what we are going to provide to
it otherwise this is the only code so
notice here we are controlling the third
party forms just using the controller
with the a couple of fields only that's
it uh you'll understand the importance
of it as we create and we'll be using
this use forms and all of that so we
will be very soon using them as well uh
rest is all good so this part is all
done now we can go back to the tiny MCE
and provide all these values so all
these values like uh you have some
initial values provide that if you have
init uh just provide that uh if you have
plugins provide that uh toolbar provide
that content style provide that most of
them is exactly copy paste from the
documentation itself that's exactly what
I'll be doing but let me show you that
uh first of all the prop initial value
uh initial value I don't have anything
so I'll just pass on the default value
whoever is using just pass on that as it
is uh then we have this init this in it
uh we need to provide the object that
what do you want all to have like for
example you have option of branding as
false I don't want to show The Branding
uh but it still shows it because it's in
the free version otherwise if you pay to
them uh then it's just just like that
and then you can also provide couple of
more parameters like height and the menu
bar just like that uh then comes up is
the plugin so go ahead and grab as it is
whatever the plug-in values are again
it's up to you how you grab them do you
want to use all of them do you want to
not use all of them uh totally up to you
no Force there uh I'm just going to be
using all as it is so in the plug-in I'm
saying give me image plugin list plugin
everything so that's how you do that uh
next up is simply the tool bar so just
go ahead and uh grab everything that's
there in the toolbar and in fact grab
everything that's inside the content
body as well totally up to you totally
up to you that how you want to have it I
just want to have everything of it so
I'll just grab this one and let's grab
everything from here and we'll just
paste
this and this all
thing can actually
Oops why is it not moving
okay so toolbar looks good probably
there's something inside the copy paste
that I missed let me try that one more
time usually it's not that
bad oh it's bad
anyways yep
toolbar uh the value is too big it's
it's just a one long string I don't know
how they do it anyways and then after
that we have ending trailing comma and
we have this one come on where's my
cursor o
difficult okay let's move this
one okay decently adjustable I need to
change the setting of my vs code a
little bit to accomplish that okay uh
but anyways it's good enough and the
last thing that you want to do is once
you are outside of this one then we'll
be having an on edit change and this is
where we just say that I will pass on an
onchange so that anybody can control
this okay uh this is good and I think
that is all what we want so a little bit
difficult in the first run that hey why
we are doing this all of this why is it
all of that but remember this is a bit
of an advanced part of the tutorial I
think it helps you understand a lot here
okay uh now the preparation is done now
we'll be building one of the most
important form in itself which is the
post form so right click and create a
new folder and we'll be calling this one
as post- form uh this is our most
important form because it uses almost
everything that we have built so
far
post form. jsx all right a lot of logic
is also involved in this one uh but it's
good it's good you'll learn a lot of
things in this one have patience take a
break if you wish but I'll continue here
so first of all we'll be needing a react
and we'll also need some of the we can
actually use call back to make it a
little bit more optimized we'll be
needing now the hook that we have been
waiting to use which is use
form no suggestion okay no
worries and that will come up from react
hook form uh this is the most invocation
part and important part we need uh all
the things that we have designed so far
so we'll be needing a button and the
button that we have designed One
Directory
back and it's actually button we need to
go One Directory back oh my goodness I
actually
accidentally made this form outside of
the component it should be inside in
here let's drag and drop into the
components yes please move that post
form post form just like that hopefully
now it should be good One Directory back
yep that's my
button okay what else
input
from
input and we need RTE as
well and that's going to come up
from
RTE and select
also
and that's going to also come from o my
bad One Directory back and RTE this one
also oh sorry select my
bad select this one also One Directory
back
RTE One Directory back
input and this one is okay okay so these
are our components that we'll be using
we also need the service because this
one is a form it will be submitting some
data so we need the app right service
here as well let's use app
right
service and that service is going to
come from h a lot of back directories
yeah app right and inside that we need
config I think that will do the job uh
we'll be navigating and selecting some
of the information like we need we need
Redux so for that we'll be saying use
selector and this selector is going to
come up
from the react
Redux and we need navigation as well
import why navigation you might be
thinking uh once the form is actually
submitted we want to redirect user back
on the homepage that is why we need that
use
navigate and that's going to come up
from uh react router Dom all right quite
a lot of import that that we have done
here uh but I think that's good uh we
didn't actually started with the
template we should have done that but
anyways I'll just write that export
default and let's call this one as
function post
form and there we go should be good now
interesting part as soon as we have form
we might receive a post in that so we
are actually reusing the form in this
case so if somebody gives us the post uh
we use the same form in which we want to
edit our post and if it somebody doesn't
give me this post that's okay we'll
handle it accordingly and we'll use it
as for creating a new post that's how we
are going to use now most important
thing first of all we need to register
that what all values and everything that
you are going to use in the use form we
have this use form now this is a very
very powerful hook instead of managing
each of your input into its own
individual State uh it could be
nightmare maybe you have 20 input forms
and you want to maintain each one in the
State uh this could be challenging in
this one so that's why we use something
like this uh give all of your values and
then simply go ahead and use a hook
which is use form this use form can have
all the values so in here we can provide
all these values like what are my
default values so let's go ahead and
have uh let's provide these default
values as an object uh let's just say we
have a default value for the title oops
not like that I'll show you where the
title is uh so I have a default value
for title if you give me post then
optionally we'll extract it from the
post title if it is not there then we'll
just say hey it's empty similar to this
we'll just go like this similarly we
have a slug uh we'll say this one and
you'll be you'll be very fascinated
about how the Slugs values are being
handled in this one we'll say optionally
extract the slug from it if it is not
there then just go ahead and provide an
empty one similar to this we will be
having a
content if the content is there let's
optionally extract
that uh forgot a
DOT otherwise let's go ahead and keep it
empty as well and we have also have a
status as well
so
status if post is provided then
optionally unwrap that as a status if it
is not there then just
use active because that's the default
state of this one okay so we have
provided the default form but what all
the input fields that you are creating
are going to be managed up here so first
of all we'll have a register uh I'll
walk you through what these registers
and everything are uh another one is
handle a
submit uh sub submit uh this will
obviously be submit Handler we'll be
writing our code for this one there's
interesting one which is watch I'll walk
you through this is the most important
thing and very interesting thing in the
I use forms as well we'll be also having
a set value uh and we'll also have uh
control I'll walk you through all of
this don't worry and we'll have get
values okay quite a lot of stuff that we
have now let's learn and understand them
one by one how these things are being
managed or being done okay so this is
use hook
form okay this is where it ends all
right let's go one by one how things are
going to unwrap uh first let's focus on
writing the logic part and then one by
one we'll be focusing on building the UI
part of the app as well okay so first of
all uh let's grab
navigate from the hook use
navigate just like that right now it
does nothing but we have an option and
then we have user data how we are going
to grab the user data that's exactly why
we have used selector selector will give
me a state just like that and we can
just extract the data by saying state
do Au do user data all right so my user
data is now in the user data field uh
there are a couple of things I need uh
for example uh I need to have a submit
action as well so people will be
submitting the form uh we'll create an
async uh form for that uh and it will
give us the data right now we are not
doing anything in that we'll come back
onto this one and figure it out the most
important part is the slug so the way in
case you saw the application when I was
showing you the demo the slug is a very
interesting thing we actually are
transforming the title into the slug so
everything in the title is being
converted into the lowercase we are
trimming the spaces and spaces are being
converted into dashes rest everything
are ignored so the way how I did it is
let me show you that it's actually just
a method slug
transform and we'll be using a use call
back to optimize it otherwise it will
will be keep on wasting the
resource if in case you don't want to
use the use call back that's totally
fine by the way okay so I did a took a
help of little bit of the chat GPT I'll
show you where I took that first of all
uh the way how actually use that you
cannot directly actually go ahead and
monitor or get any values from it so uh
we have to actually grab a value out of
it so notice here I'll be controlling
these uh set values and get values I'll
walk you through through the that as
well in just a minute uh we'll be
holding that
part all right so we're designing this
slug transform and what's this doing is
anybody can call this method uh the only
thing is you have to pass me a value
what is this value uh it's nothing it's
just the value in the current form that
you're using uh just pass me on that and
I'll extract the value so uh I'll walk
you through don't worry in a minute
you'll understand everything of it I'll
say if the value is there and the type
of value we need is a specific one if
the type of value is string then only we
can proceed if that is the case if we
are having that uh then we can simply go
ahead and return a value out of it so
I'll just move it to the next line and
then I'll come back and put it into this
one later on so what we can do is we can
return a value and we can provide a
couple of methods on this one so this
value can have a method of dot trim
first of all let's do that once we are
done with that let's convert everything
to lowercase so we'll use to lowercase
all right and then we'll be using a
simple Rex to replace some of the stuff
and this is the Rex part where I took a
help of little bit of chat GPT otherwise
I used to use a website rexr but this
time I took a help from Chad GPT so
we'll say replace there we go and in
this replace I'll provide what value I'm
looking up for that's the Rex value and
the second parameter is what to replace
with and I'll just use the dash so what
to replace with this is something that I
grabbed actually directly from Chad G
Chad GPT put up a prompt that I want a
value that converts everything uh spaces
and everything that selects everything
so I'm just saying that hey this is a
negate by the way uh don't select lower
case uppercase uh any digits or any
spaces rest of everything are converted
into this one and then option what you
can do in case although it does the job
but I found in some of the edge cases it
was still bothering me so I didn't found
out any particular solution as of now so
I just went into replace and I wrote
another simple query which is a basic
Rex by the way it simply goes ahead and
say a little bit itchy throat so it
simply goes ahead and say that hey I
want to select all the spaces so slash S
is for the spaces and I want to look it
for the globally uh and
then just want to just double short be
it converted although most cases I found
that this alone works nicely uh but in
some cases this was problematic so I
just wanted to make sure that at the
Final End uh I'm just replacing all the
spaces with the dash and I'm ignoring
all these uh digits and lowercase A to Z
uppercase A to Z and slashes I'm not
really that great or good into to uh
these Rex I accept that but hey this
works fine so there we go so we are
returning the value and that's it that's
your slug transform that is all it takes
now we also need to pass on a dependency
array onto this one we don't have any
dependency but optimize this as much as
possible okay so this is my slug
transform that we have okay uh now you
might be wondering that hey uh that's
great we have slug transform but we want
it to run as soon as somebody types
something into that title form how can I
do that that's an interesting one
actually uh you cannot do that directly
if you're using any of the react or you
have to monitor a lot of things but if
you look at this one there is a
component being given to you that is
watch and what it says is this method
will watch specified inputs and return
their values so not only it can watch my
input in the name field it can also
return me that value so I can use this
and where can I use this or how can I
use this really really simple let me
walk you through with that as well I can
use actually it inside the use effect
hook oh that's interesting so I'll just
say react dot use effect there we go and
this is our call
back and looks like just use a call back
like this and we need a dependency
array okay first of all let's worry
about the dependency array on what
Fields this should be dependent first of
all we'll obviously use watch that's the
one uh also keep on watching on to the
slug transform if it changes a little
bit also I want to render reender the
things and also the set value now you
might be wondering what are these set
values can you explain that a little bit
because you're using this uh set values
get values and quite a number of things
these are actually coming up from the
use form itself when we are using use
form you don't need to create the states
uh that is the one advantage I'll show
you how these are useful when we'll be
designing the input field itself then it
will get much more clearer uh but the
whole idea is you don't want to create
thousand different states or variables
uh we can just use it directly like that
I'll show you that don't you worry okay
so the dependency array part is done now
let's go into the use effect uh this one
now here's the interesting thing how do
we use this watch uh really simple you
just simply go ahead and use a watch
just like this this watch uh gives you a
call back and you can provide the value
uh by the way these value are uh all the
values that you can have in the form
itself these are the values and out of
that I'm looking up for one value which
is name so watch out out of all these
values the fields that you have watch
out the name for me and once you are
here let's go ahead and have a call back
just like this and there we go now what
do we want to
do so
if the name is title I'll I haven't
created this yet but I'll do that very
soon if the name of the object because
as you can see uh the values are having
so many properties title Slug and all of
these ones if the value is name that
means the name of the post itself uh is
the title then only we want to run it so
what do you want to do in that case I
want to use a set value so again set
value can be used not just for setting
one value but in any field itself so set
value is here now in the set value what
do I want to use set value in what field
you have provided me number of fields
here I haven't given them yet but there
will be many as you can just have input
Fields all of them are governed by the
use form I just want to set one field
which is my slug so I'll provide you
slug like this there we go how do you
want to set it I want to set it by using
the slug transform method I'll provide
you the value do title okay once I give
you that title that means that will act
as a value for you and you can just use
that value then run all of this
operation and since you returned me that
I'll just use that to set the value a
couple of more uh fields and parameters
you want to provide in here is I should
validate because there are ways to give
provide validation inside the use form
using the Joey and other libraries we
are not doing that as of now it's
already too much uh we'll just use
should validate as true so all our basic
validations will kick in uh we don't
want to go too much in depth of that all
right uh why is it bothering title may
not exist yeah it's it doesn't exist as
as of now but it will very soon in the
future uh quite a lot of lot of intense
work that we have done and by the way we
haven't worked on submit yet we'll do
that but first I think uh now it's time
to get more clarity because these things
uh will keep on adding to the confusion
so let me just go ahead and render
provide a render here uh so that you can
understand that all right so we'll just
say okay let's minimize this uh post
form looks good here we should be
returning the r element return uh what
do you want to return I want to Simply
return a
form okay uh this form is not going to
have any action but rather on
submit what do you want to do I want to
use handle submit in that
case Okay uh handle submit uh should not
be used directly like this because if
you're using uh use form the handle
submit should be used from the use form
this is the handle submit but actually
it doesn't magically knows what to do
with the data so this is going to be the
method which is actually going to submit
the data the way how you do it is a
little bit weird but this is a method
and in this you pass on another method
so yeah higher order functions
JavaScript at it speak yeah uh this is
how the react hook form but don't worry
if you'll watch these videos couple of
times you will be used to with the react
hook forms very powerful very useful
okay let's go back and use some of the
class
names to make it beautiful
flex and this one is going to be Flex
wrap all right okay uh next up is the
most interesting part after the div of
course so we'll have a div uh we'll have
a class name uh nothing much we want to
use the width of
2x3 and we'll be using pedding on xaxis
of two that's it okay now comes the
interesting part is we'll be designing
our first input notice here I'm using
the input field that I designed earlier
that's it but how we are controlling
this input field that is the most
important part first of all let's pass
on a label which we designed as a prop
into this input uh we'll be calling this
one as simple
title all right
placeholder why are no suggestions
coming in oh these are props my
bad place oh suggestions are not coming
because this is not a regular J uh HTML
form this is my custom component that's
why suggestions are not coming in and
we'll say
title we will be having a class name of
margin bottom of
four there we
go okay now comes up the part where we
actually use the use uh forms let me
show you that let me take you onto the
website so this is the register
unregister and whatnot use form let's go
ahead and use that so if there there is
an
example of the forms that would help us
to understand this so much better
okay get started and here it
is okay so how oh this is the one that I
wanted to show you so whenever you're
using any input this is the one which we
discussed handle submit and onsubmit
exactly like that but when you are
actually using any input field this is
the way how you actually monitor or
govern that notice here register your
input into hooks so we have to
explicitly register these each input
inside the hooks so that they are
available as values by invoking the
register function so we have to actually
use this JavaScript then have to uh
extract or we can say destructure the
register and then provide that hey this
is the example that I'm using so Yep
this is the one let me go back onto the
code part so this is where we start our
JavaScript we simply say register there
we go uh this register is a method
that's how we register it we are going
to call this one as title now it is
registered as a title and we can provide
uh more Fields like required there's a
lot more that you can do but we'll just
go with the required as true this is the
part now notice here now this input
field is registered as title so I'll go
back and notice here when I say value
and the name is title because every
input field has a name and I gave it a
name of title now this will be monitored
here so whenever you pass on the value
inside this uh into this use effect it
will keep on watching the values if the
name is uh title which it is then only
the set value will here and again Watch
will be responsible for continuously
watching or monitoring this input field
ah very interesting uh so much difficult
to do with the core but this is much
much easier okay uh now let's have
another input field which is Slug
interesting one input self closing just
like that okay let's do one by one first
of all label that label is going to
be
Slug and the space colon something like
that and then we'll be having
placeholder placeholder is going to be
slug as
well and then we have class names
nothing much margin bottom of four good
enough okay now let's come up on to the
part where we registered it into the use
form how do we do that uh we first of
all start our JavaScript register just
like that inside the register we name it
as slug okay and what should happen how
this slug should actually work that
automatically is being taken care by the
watch itself so I just go ahead and say
uh this is
required as
true all right so this should be there
uh okay one more thing that we can do
here is that uh we can actually have
this input as slug transform as well so
let me just go ahead and work with that
so on in
put what do we want to do that's
interesting one okay let's start our
JavaScript first we will capture an
event onto this one and then we'll just
go like this curly braces just like that
so I'll just go ahead and use set values
because just because you have used the
slug remember this slug is just
returning the value it's not doing
anything it just says set values it's
just returning everything to set values
but there is nothing we have said that
what should be the value inside it this
is registering giving the values but we
haven't said how to take the values back
into this form and fill it up that's
what we are taking care right now so set
value now we'll say that hey I'll set
the value and my field name is Slug okay
and how do I get these values so use the
slug transform here and then we'll be in
order to use the select transform we
have to provide a value okay uh what
we'll do is we'll say e
do current
Target dot
value and uh that's
it and we'll simply
say should validate and we'll be saying
true let me walk you through one more
time okay uh notice here uh right now we
are not actually exporting the values
this is where we have done already this
part but now
this input field is going to set some
values into it and the setting of the
value is going to happen uh VI this on
input only that's the case in the on
input we are saying that hey as soon as
some inputs are being put into this
input field use the set value which is
given to us as a hook uh inside
this hook just a
second and here it is so this was given
to us so notice here we are not using
thousands of set values or set field set
input field set slug get slug no we just
use one thing which is set value and we
use get values to get any values out of
any field we just provide the name of
that to set any value in any of these
fields we just use one hook which is set
value that is the advantage just two of
these methods set values get me get
values and you can actually set and get
values from pretty much any field at all
that is what makes me like wow this is
too much how we are actually using this
all right so uh now we have the set
values we actually use the set values
here as well to provide that uh but here
we are actually using the set values on
this particular input field all right
quite an interesting one now let's use
another one which is our RTE so that is
easy one we have already worked onto
this one so RTE could be self closing
just like that H
interesting
oh we need to get out of
it RTE self closing just like that uh
pass on couple of values first of all
label the label is going to
be content colon just like that uh we
need to provide a name to this
one and the name is going to be just
like that and we'll say content and then
we have to provide a
control and we'll say control just like
that control again is given to us uh
from here notice here we got the control
this is exactly specifically designed uh
to take control of the input fields
which are outside or third party inputs
and then we simply have some of the
default values if you have give them uh
but right now the default value is only
for one thing which is get values
remember I told you get values so if you
want to get values from any field just
like that let's call this one as content
now imagine if you have to deal up with
these many forms how many states you
would be designing uh so easy okay this
value is all done so now we'll close
this div which is the first portion of
it now we need to go in the one third
part of this
one div and we'll go with the class name
on the right part of it so we'll just
say
1x3 and we'll
das2 all
right and in here we are having two
Fields one is the input field for the
images and another one
is simply the field which is just saying
uh is it active is it inactive something
like that so that's
basic okay uh let's start with the
input and inside the input it could be
self
closing okay
label
featured a
image and the type is going to be
changed to
file file selector and the class name is
going to be margin bottom Dash
4 class name margin
bottom-4 all right what do you want to
accept that's the idea we can pass on as
many props as we want uh so what do we
want to accept we want to accept image
which is PNG we also want to image which
is jpg or we also want to accept image
which is
jpeg if you have more you can just
provide more of these acceptance Fields
basic HTML nothing more in there uh then
we have to register this field as well
so let's go ahead and do that dot dot
dot
register and this field will be known as
image in the registration field again
basic required is
true
required that's going to be true I hope
you noticed the difference in here as
well all the fields are easily being
registered in here so this is just
register this is also just register only
difference is when we don't have a
control on that then we pass on the
control to get the values from it
automatically otherwise rest of the
fields are just very straightforward
register register just like that okay uh
we can actually have it as required as
true but we can just simply say
uh if the post is there then we don't
want it so if post is no post just like
that okay uh once we are done with this
then depends on the post whether we are
going to actually uh get a file preview
or not just like that so let's also try
that so we'll say if the post is there
then only we'll get a file preview so
we'll just go like that and we'll say
inside this
div we'll have a class name we'll say
width is going to be full inside in here
and margin bottom is going to be four
and inside the St we'll be having an
image the source of the image that is
where things gets interesting uh we'll
be using app right service get file
preview and pass on this post
dot featured image let's pass on that if
uh that will come up if post is there we
will obviously get the featured image
and in the alt let's use the
title post do title uh we should be
technically we don't need to uh use a
question mark here because we're already
checking it up here so that is good
enough uh I think that's good let's add
a class name
here and let's use a class name and that
should be
rounded
dlg
there we go all right uh so this is the
case when the post and featured image is
there now we need to have to work with
one more thing uh we need to select the
options for the user as well quite a lot
but this is what happens when you design
complex application so we have a select
field we can use it as self closing all
right move it up here uh let's provide
the options that's the first parameter
we have to pass on the options is going
to be an array so let's pass on an array
the first value is active the second
value is
inactive that's it that's your option
the label is going to be
status and the class
name we just need some margin from
bottom in all of these
cases and last but not the least is
register it into the react form react
hook form dot dot dot register and we
want to register it with the
status registered it and now let's
provide this is very optional required
is going to be
true there we go that's it so select
form is required now let's go ahead and
use a button to submit it
okay so inside the div let's keep it
inside the div itself uh we'll be using
a button we'll be using our own
button so there we
go
okay uh this is the button that we have
and inside this button we have we can
have children's that's how we designed
it so if the post is there then we'll
call this button as update if the post
is not there then we'll call it one as
create or submit whatever you
like all right so this is the
button and inside the button we can pass
on more values like type of the button
is going to be
submit and what else background color
BG color these are the properties which
we have given so let's also use
JavaScript here if the post is there
then we'll be using uh BG green so we'll
say BG Dash green suggestions
please no suggestion BG D green Dash uh
500 otherwise we'll just say
undefined all right we can use another
color as well by the way and one more
thing we can just provide in here is
class
name withd Das
full all right so this is the form that
we have again uh we have studied a lot
into this one I totally totally
understand that piece that part uh but
there is one more thing still remaining
which is the easy one by the way we
haven't yet submitted anything the
submission part is definitely easiest
among the all uh but definitely this is
something you need to understand
understand one by one how things are
going up now if the post is there then
obviously based on this we'll be getting
the value so first of all we have all
the data and by the way all the data now
we have as soon as you submit the form
uh the values are being called and we
have the data uh we need to extract the
data from couple of resources let me
show you that uh it's easier to actually
write the code than to explain that so
if uh the post is
there okay if post is there then we have
to do something otherwise we have to do
something else okay so post was there
already okay so first let's extract the
file let's get the file file be coming
up from the data everything is in stored
inside the data and we'll be having an
image and we'll be extracting this
okay now what we're going to do is we
are going to do something if we find the
file otherwise we'll be just uh putting
a null inside this one rest of the
checking automatically can be done by
the app right itself if it is there then
then we want to use an app right service
to upload the file so let's go ahead and
await this because this service takes
time and we're going to use app right
service we are going to use upload
file and in the upload file we just pass
on this
data do image and obviously the path
which is in the first
field okay so that's the part one and uh
this is the part now again we need to
continue further if the file is there uh
if the file is there uh then let's go
ahead and delete
this
if uh the file is
there then we are going to use app right
service dot delete file because we want
to delete the previous file previous
file is inside still in the post so
we'll say post dot featured image so
okay uh if file is there go ahead and
delete that you can also go ahead and
use an await here as well if if you wish
but I think it's good enough it can do
its job behind the scene as well uh
depends on when we do more thorough
checking we can actually go ahead and
work on with this okay uh now let's call
this one as uh DB
post and what we want to do is
AIT app right service and this one is
going to be responsible for updating the
post for updating the post provide me
the ID first so that can be extracted
from post. Dollar ID there we go and
then provide me all the data that you
have okay what data do you have I can
just extract everything from the data
itself and one thing that you have to
give me is the featured image to
overwrite that featured image because we
just uploaded that that will be coming
up from file if we have that if we have
the
file then give it
file do dollar ID otherwise if you don't
have it just give me undefined so that
if it is compulsory app right can throw
me an error okay now continuing further
in this case if the post was updated
successfully then let's redirect the
user so let's go ahead and work with
that if uh we have the DB
post if that's the case we have the DB
post then let's use the navigate which
we created from use nav
Navigate and we'll say Go to/ poost
slash the slug of it which we can get
from like this and we'll be having not
the post DB post the newer one DB post
and we'll get a dollar ID there we go
nice and easy keep on talking keep on
writing the code that makes life so much
easier okay this is the part where we
have the post what about when we don't
have the post in that case we'll go with
the else part that means we are creating
a fresh post so let's upload the file
first go like this file aade no quick
question like this await and then app
right service please help me to upload a
file okay how do we upload a file by
extracting it from data do data do image
and out of that image the first value
which is the path uh once you have
uploaded that then what should I do next
if I have the file uh let's get that
field uh properly set let's use this if
I have file then what I want to do is I
want to create a field ID uh file ID
sorry field ID file ID
as
file. doll
ID okay and then inside this data that I
have access I will create a new field
which is featured image uh which will
have this one file ID could have done
that in one line as well but I'm more
comfortable with this one okay now that
you have all the the data you have also
the access to featured image which you
uploaded first uh let's create a new
post so obviously I'll say await app
service dot create post uh provide me
all the data that you have so first of
all let's give it all the data by
destructuring it and then also give it a
user ID a user ID can be given to you by
simply user data remember we have access
to it in every component and we can
actually have a user data dot uh dollar
ID that's how you grab the ID okay now
once you have done that let's store that
into a variable let's call this one as
DB
post okay once this is done that means
DB post is created now inside this I
want to check for another condition if
by this time the DB post is being
created let's
navigate navigate where do you want to
navigate to uh we want to navigate to/
poost to the newer there's only one post
ID that we have which is DB DB post we
need to use
variables we need to have DB post and
we'll extract the ID out of it all right
uh so this is not too much but you need
to be very careful with what you are
doing that's why I always say uh don't
code uh with the mouth shut always uh
code uh by thinking of it you can do one
by one step by step all these process
this is almost kind of a standard
practice we always upload the files
first we usually create helpers for them
upload the file get back the URL of the
file set your object properly and then
use helper files to upload the file
create the files create the post
whatever you want to do uh quite an
intensive video in itself I would say
that and definitely it took us a little
bit while uh well over one hour onto
this video but I think it's good enough
and that's majorly it what we wanted to
do uh now it's time that we actually
assemble our all of our components and
start debugging them one by one
obviously there are mistakes in it uh
but we'll figure them out let's catch up
in the next
video hey there everyone AES here back
again with another video and in this
video we're going to continue our
journey we'll create two more components
which is sign up and the login now this
could be done either in the pages or in
the component uh both are absolutely
correct I prefer to do it in the
component so that in the page I just
have to load one component and that said
it brings all the functionality but it's
totally your choice maybe you want to
just keep the components as purely just
the UI part I want to keep it as both
the logic and the UI part totally your
decision now once we are done with the
login and sign up then we'll be working
on the post because there are many posts
which will be available in the post page
uh so basically we'll be making a query
we'll get the data and we'll be just
passing or on to another component so
that it can Loop through it uh let me
just share the screen it will be much
more easier hope you recovered well from
the last video it was quite intense and
that video requires you to spend at
least one or two day with the
documentation of react hook form
understand it better or probably repeat
that uh that always helps to understand
code more the more you see the code the
more you read the documentation it gets
much more clear with that over the time
uh things requires reputation so that's
why I highly highly recommend that once
you are done with this entire uh this
series uh go it again for one more time
that will surely help you all right
let me share the screen and let me walk
you through that how and where we are
going to work through so this is the
docs I still read it to this day and uh
there's always something more
interesting going on in here now one
thing that we are not going to focus in
this video is this part we have already
seen that how we can register any input
field with the react hook form by this
method and then everything is available
in the data and that's why we have this
data available so
register uh form States and watch and
handle submit and whatnot uh this is the
data so this is what we are having all
right so we'll not worry on that part
rest of the part we will walk through
again uh okay so first of all let's go
into components right click and new and
this will be our first uh let's start
with the sign
up come on write that sign up.
jsx okay so what goes into the sign up
first of all let's do RFC to get a react
functional component now in this one
since this is a sign up we definitely
100% requires the Au Service uh so let's
go ahead and grab the Au
service Au service and that obviously is
going to come from One Directory back
inside the app right and inside the O so
that's our app Service uh we'll also be
using some of the links in this one
we'll navigate the users forcefully once
this is done sign up we'll either
redirect him into the application or to
login page but that is is going to be
required let's go ahead and grab link
and navigate rather use
navigate use
navate come on
navigate and these are going to come
from react router Dom all right uh we
also will be using react that is obvious
we will be managing some of the states
as well uh I'll walk you through not too
much states because we'll be dependent
majorly on the react hook form but still
there's a place we'll be using it I'll
walk you through with that all right so
this is the all and obviously we'll be
needing some of the buttons and all
these basic component so let's go ahead
and grab a button and that button is
going to come up from uh we need to go
in the same and the button. jsx we need
input and Logo as
well so
import
input come on input from the same
current directory that we are just grab
input and the logo as well although
there's nothing in our logo but still
we'll we'll just import this logo
from SL logo all right so components are
there and obviously we'll be requesting
some of the features we'll be using use
form so let's bring them as well uh
first one use form because I'll be using
this left and right use
form and that is going to come up from
react hook form and little bit Redux
also is required uh mainly use dispatch
because I'll be dispatching some of the
actions
dispatch and that dispatch is
from react Redux all right quite a lot
of stuff that we have imported uh but
that's good uh we got this one now let's
see how we're going to do that first of
all uh the easiest part is to use the
use navigate so I think let's do that
easy part I always love to do first
naviate and that simply
says use navigate there we go that's it
easy part done uh let's create a state
for the errors and that's the reason why
we are using user State uh because right
now the form although form has the
capability to handle the errors as well
uh there are validations and what not
and all of that like there is a specific
dedicated how to handle the errors as
well uh but I think I'll handle them
better in the state so I'll just use the
state in this one error and that will be
set error and for this we'll be using
use State and by default there will be
nothing no errors at all uh we'll be
also using the dispatch so easy part
just like navigate uh let's go ahead and
use
dispatch and that will be coming up from
use dispatch so that whenever we want we
can just now use it all right now the
next thing is uh that we obviously will
be uh registering the user user so for
registering the user we need to use the
use form so I'll just go ahead and say
const and we'll be saying register and
then there is handle
submit and this will be use
form all right I hope now by this point
you understand the part that register is
something uh which is we what we use for
dot dot dot register yes that one and
handle submit is the method by which we
actually pass up so any times you use
something like this handle submit
anytime you use uh the form the react
hook form you cannot just directly pass
on on submit uh you have to have to go
through with the handle submit which
further takes a function of on submit
and that is why how and that's how
basically it controls the entire form so
keep that in mind uh really sometimes
when you create this it's easy to
actually forget that okay so this is the
basic now how we are going to create the
user because handle submit requires a
method to be passed on we'll call this
one as create uh you can call this one
as create user create user on aight
totally your choice how you do it I'm
going to call this one as simply
create create and this one will be a
sync operation and this one is going to
take data data obviously will come from
the react hook forms there we go now uh
first and foremost that what we're going
to do as soon as somebody clicks that we
are going to use set error to set the
error or to reset the error basically to
onto the initial state now let's go
ahead and use a try catch the catch part
is easy uh the catch part we can just go
ahead and say set error we can use the
state and we can say hey error give me
your
message that's it uh super easy to
handle in the tri part okay in the
triart we'll await obviously because
that takes time and we are going to use
a service from the app right so let's
call this one as Au service that's what
we called it and from this we are going
to use the create account and we'll be
passing on the data that's it now let's
hold this into a variable let's call
this one
as
const user
data okay once this is uh completed then
if we have the user data uh then we can
actually invoke uh dispatch to save all
of this data in our Redux otherwise the
error is there so let's validate this if
we have user
data then we can simply go ahead and say
uh let's go ahead and uh get the current
user how can we get the current User
it's pretty simple actually you can use
Au service again and from this you can
run the method of get current user just
like this and you'll be having the
access to whoever is the current user
this operation might take some time so
let's go ahead and use an await in fact
I missed a couple of places await and if
you find them just go ahead and add
await for that all of the upright
operations should be awaited okay uh
let's go ahead and say further down we
can call this one as user data no
problem we are inside the if block okay
now if we have user
data if we have user data at this point
which is our current user we'll go ahead
and fire up a dispatch I don't think we
need this one we'll just do it a single
line we'll say dispatch what event do
you want to dispatch I want to dispatch
a login event and the login event is
going to be uh coming up with the data
so I'll just go ahead and say user data
so that's it I'm fixing it Up all In the
user data uh did we brought in the
login
H I think we didn't brought the
login nope doesn't look like let's bring
the
login import and we want to bring in the
login come on write that
oh looks like this is
freezing nope oh now it's working
keyboards and we will bring this up uh
from let's go One Directory back inside
the store inside the O slice this is
where we want to bring the login and
this is exactly the login that we are
using in here once this is all done uh
let's Force the user to navigate on the
homepage maybe if you want to navigate
to some other place that that's up to
you I'll use
navigate where do you want to navigate
I'll just go ahead and say navigate to
slash all right uh not a big deal that's
all what we wanted to do uh for this
part now for this Return part I'll just
copy and paste and give you the entire
code because there is nothing more we
are learning in this one so I'll just go
ahead and copy paste all we are doing in
this one is uh some Flex box and classes
and all of that the important part we
have already discussed that whenever we
want to have these input Fields how to
actually link them up so notice here
this is how we are linking them up by
saying uh dot dot dot register and then
the name field is being uh registered
the email field is getting registered uh
the password field is getting registered
and then a simple button uh which just
says uh create account and once we have
this one this form actually has uh so
notice here we have the errors being
handled here at this point and notice
here the form is as soon as the form is
being submitted we are using handle
submit which comes from the react hook
form and we use the method create here
so that's what we and that's how we
designed it the login is exactly same
almost exactly same so that would be a
good exercise for you to repeat in case
if you wish you can pause the video
right here and try this out again it's
not about all the time writing the Live
code it's also about how you understand
the code which is already written that's
also a good practice uh so we'll we just
did that all right so sign up is ready
almost as component now we can go ahead
and work on with another one one which
is the login exactly same nothing much
to be differentiated there and let's
call this one as login.
jsx okay so RFC and again this Return
part will be copying and pasting so
nothing much more than that uh let's go
ahead and borrow some stuff from the
signup as well okay let's in fact borrow
everything because it's almost exactly
same and let's go ahead and work on with
this one okay uh instead of the login um
this one is is actually login so we're
using the login same dispatch we are
going to require we are going to require
Au Service as well button inputs pretty
much all of them are going to be using
uh just like this and we're going to use
login here but this login might create
some of the issues here so let's just
rename this one as Au
login okay makes a life a little bit
easier not much uh but I think rest of
them are pretty good good and pretty
okay all right uh let's see how we are
going to deal with that first the easy
parts let's go ahead and do that const
navigate
navigate that's going to become up from
use navigate there we go this is ready
uh we need dispatch as well so we're
going to say
dispatch and that's going to come up
from use dispatch just like that easy
part uh then we need use form so we'll
be needing register of course that
always goes and we need to have handle
submit and that's going to come up from
use form uh we have done that many times
now okay uh what else we will be
managing the errors so let's go ahead
and use a state for that error set error
and that's going to come up from use
State just like that by default the
errors are going to be empty uh now we
need to work on a method which says log
in how do we handle the login part
exactly same nothing much different or
difficult let's go ahead and say uh
const login we can say it login because
now we have renamed this one as o login
in case you wish to call something else
that's totally on you we'll say async
and this is going to say hey give me all
the data call back just like this and
first step is to set the error very
repetitive very repetitive let's go
ahead and fire up a try catch
the catch part is easy as you all know
we can just simply go ahead and set
error and we'll say error. message and
you might be thinking a pattern here
repetitive that's exactly what I want in
the course itself that hey things are
repeated and you can try them and once
you build enough application you'll
figure out I can build anything these
are exactly the same thing it's just the
way how we handle the data and how we
get that okay so what we're going to
call this one in this one uh first of
all let's go ahead and use a weit
and the aate is going to utilize an a
service there we go from the Au service
we are going to use a method of uh login
and we'll be providing all the data that
you have uh let's call this one as
session session there we go feel free to
call it anything it doesn't really mean
that you have to call it session I'm
just saying that hey this is session now
if we have the session or any data uh
session if we have the session now can I
get a current user uh from the OD
service because if there is a session
the login was successful technically
there should be a current user that I'm
able to grab so let's go ahead and say
await Au service come on not that art
service. get current user there we go if
I get that and I hold that into a
variable call this one as user data feel
free to call it whatever you like if I
have user data then I can dispatch a
login action so I can just go ahead and
say
if I have user data then we can dispatch
and I can do that in one
line I can go ahead and say dispatch
what do you want to dispatch uh you
might be thinking we'll be dispatched
login but remember we actually login is
now being known as o login so just go
ahead and call this one as o login and
Au login uh is a method which we are
going to pass on user data that's it and
user data is being passed on so that's
all good now let's redirect the user as
well uh navigate where do you want to
navigate probably on slash that's it so
there we go told you it's not really
difficult at first it looks difficult
but it is not very much and in the login
page uh since we are using some of the
Tailwinds and other features that's why
I'm just copy pasting otherwise if you
see that there is nothing big that we
are doing in here so this whole thing at
this point is nothing it's just
hard-coded values just HTML and CSS even
this portion till here uh till this
portion everything is just hardcoded CSS
nothing more here we are handling the
error if the error is present we are
displaying the error in some red
squiggly uh lines just like that and
this is the form this is the important
part which we discussed in the last
video quite a lot and we saw that how
input could be registered or could be
binded with the use form using this
speed of this piece of code which is
nothing do dot register and we name this
field as email required is true that is
it that is it this one is password field
required that's it and as soon as the
form is submitted uh we have this form
here we use handle submit which comes
from the react hook form we provide that
method who is handling it actually and
that's it that's it that is it our
component and everything is all done now
one more thing that we are going to do
in this video is now moving on to the
pages part because now almost all the
components we have discussed that what
we wanted to build now let's work with
the pages one by one and again uh for
the login and the signup page there is
nothing we'll be just importing the
values but there is one page which is
post uh this is something interesting in
the post what we're going to do is uh
we're going to grab some data and then
we are going to Simply uh kind of
iterate over the values and there's a
lot of stuff that needs to go into this
post as a page uh let me show you one by
one uh how we are do dealing with this
and how we are working with
this all right so the reason why this
one post page that you see up there yeah
there uh is important uh because this
requires a little bit more of knowledge
of how we are building this application
the way how we are building our
application is we upload an image no
problem at all then we use an editor
which we brought from Tiny MCE that
editor allows us to have unordered list
ordered list and both italics colors all
these things and save them in the
database now how it saves in the
database it actually writes simple HTML
with some inline elements and inline
stylesheets and just store that as a
text inside your database that's how it
works there in fact every uh single
element that you see around which
provides you Vis that's how they work
and they sa but the problem is that if
you bring in just the pure HTML you
cannot display the pure HTML in any
react component uh so we need some more
work to be done and in fact we need a
little bit of help from this so this is
the package that is going to help which
is HTML react parser uh it's published 3
days ago but it's pretty popular you can
see the weekly downloads it's pretty
crazy uh what it does is now you can
actually use a method parse once you
actually import that and install that
and this is going to allow you to have
HTML code and in fact inline CSS as well
and it works like this react. cre create
element in case you saw the previous
videos where we discussed how react
Works internally how GSX Works
internally so this actually breaks down
everything and helps you to just work
with that I found it really really
useful so that's why we are going to
install this let's go ahead and copy
this and work with this and this will be
super helpful for us in in the post as
well let me go back and first let's go
ahead and install this uh probably I'm
not in the proper folder let's go ahead
and open up
okay let's verify this one more time
that are we having installation properly
or not so we have react HTML react parer
that's exactly what we want now coming
back onto the post page because rest of
the things are pretty comparatively easy
the singular page how we display the
singular page and the concept that only
if you're author of the page then you
have the ability to edit it or to or to
Simply have a delete lead functionality
that is also little tricky not too much
but little bit something that we should
explore together uh so we'll be needing
uh react uh obviously we'll be using use
effect come on write
it use effect and we'll be using user
State all right uh we'll be needing some
of the elements from react router as
well so we'll be needing them from react
router
Dom
okay uh what do we need we need link uh
we need use navigate and we need use
params that is the most important what
is this use params uh it's really simple
anything that you see in the URL uh you
can actually grab the value of it by
using the Ed param it's super simple
super easy to work on with this one uh
we'll be needing app right
Service app right
service come
on app right sir if I can write that
service there we go and this one is
going to come up from One Directory back
we'll go into app right and we'll go
into
config okay what else uh we need couple
of components as well uh specifically
the button and the
container
import button from One Directory
back component and the button we be
needing container as
well
container and that container will come
from One Directory back inside the
components inside the container inside
that we have this container pretty long
name uh but we have that most
importantly let's have uh parts that is
going to come up from the newly
installed HTML react parser and let's
install let's also have the use
selector I usually like to have all of
them as I go as I need I just work with
them but I know these things are going
to come handy within a minute so I just
know let's have them so react Redux all
right uh if we need anything else we can
just work with that now how the post
actually work this post uh especially in
the page now if you are in the page
first of all let's create a state to
handle the post so let's go ahead and
say this is my post this one is going to
be set
post and that is going to come from use
State uh by default let's call it as
null there is nothing inside it uh then
what we need is we need to extract the
slug so we say the slug and the slug is
going to come up from use
params that's it uh one more thing you
need to understand the reason why we are
calling this one as slug that is
something really important and useful
for interview perspectives as well if
you go into main. jsx uh notice here we
are calling this one up here
as colon slug this colon slug is the
reason why I'm able to grab a slug from
the Ed param so keep that in mind super
important to know uh let's also grab the
navigate const
navigate
navate and that's going to come from use
navigate just like that super easy okay
now how can I grab the user data okay
because why do we need user data because
if you are a user and you are author uh
then we'll see that do you should you
get the delete and the edit button first
of all let's grab the user
data user data and that can come to me
by using the use selector simple react
Redux and we'll simply say
State state. o do user
data user data okay now I have the
access to to user data now how can I
verify uh that this post is written by
you or not because post is also storing
a user ID and we can extract the user ID
from the user data as well so we can
match both of them so let's just say if
we have the post uh because post might
be null if the post is there uh let's
and we have the user data as well user
data then we can do
something otherwise is we'll do
something okay uh we want to check if
you have post if you have user data uh
then we want to match it that will be a
true part and otherwise it will be a
false part so we'll say this as a
false all right uh how can we verify the
true part uh the true part can be
verified by simply comparing them so
let's say
post uh is going to have a field known
as user ID uh is it equals to the user
data
Al which also has a field of ID so do
dollar ID so if both of them match we'll
be getting a result of true otherwise
false let's store that into a variable
so let's call this one as is
author and there we go now we are
checking for the condition if post is
present if user data is present then if
they matches that's great that's true
otherwise it's just a false so now we
have an access of the field that hey
this is all it how it works and all of
that okay now uh we want to do something
a little bit more onto that uh we want
to work with how the delete post will
work because deleting is interesting
okay uh let's write a simple method for
that delete uh post it's actually super
simple that's why we are handling it
first so how does a post gets deleted uh
really simple you just query to app
right so app right service has a method
of uh Delete Del file not delete file
delete post yep uh you just have to
provide the post ID to it and I can
extract this from the post do doll ID so
once I actually pass it on uh I can use
an AIT here or if you wish I can use a
then just like this and if I receive a
status uh then I can go ahead and uh
Delete the file as well because remember
we are not keeping the file at the same
time if the post is deleted then let's
go ahead and delete this so I'll fire a
call back
so in this case if I receive that hey
the status is
there it gives me a status by the way if
you'll read the docs once anything is
deleted it gives you back a status so
let's check in here uh if the status is
there
um if status is present then I'll go
ahead and delete that so will use app
right service and we'll say delete file
and still you have access ACC to this
post uh Dot and this time extract
featured
image and now this image will be deleted
uh if you wish you can put an AIT on
this one uh but if it does it in the
behind the scene uh I'm really okay with
that and I can just
navigate totally up to you how you're
designing your application if this is
really important step you don't want to
move it before this you can put an AIT
onto this one that's also fine totally
up to you that how you want to design
your application
okay so so far it's good uh but there
one more thing uh we got this slug but
we are not using this slug because this
is a post page individual post should be
loaded as soon as the page or somebody
comes to this page or this page loads or
this component loads uh so yes you
guessed it right we'll be using
something known as use effect to
actually do the exact same job use
effect and there we go we'll be having
our call back and we need a dependency
array as well so so this will be
dependent on either the slug there's any
change or if somebody navigates here so
we'll be running it on the both side now
how do we grab a slug so if the slug is
present if we have
slug then go ahead and just query the
app right hey app right give me a post
so get post not posts only one and for
that you have to provide me a slug uh
let's use promises do then so if you get
the post let's go ahead and use a call
back if you get a
post uh what do you want to do uh so if
I get the post I'll set the post
if post is there uh then I'll go ahead
and say set
post and in the post we'll be posting a
post too many posts okay uh what in the
else case if we don't get the this one
so in the else part we can just go ahead
and say uh let's
navigate let's navigate back on on to
the home because I was not able to grabb
that so there is no point of loading
anything uh so that's it pretty easy now
we were able to grab it so delete post
is pretty nice uh nothing much we have
to do okay now let's go ahead and work
on with this one so return I don't want
to return anything uh just like this I
want to return only in the case of post
if the post is there then let's go ahead
and do something uh otherwise you can go
ahead and do something else uh what
something else do you want to do uh you
can put a message couldn't find the post
or something but I'll just go ahead and
do a null because rest of the things
will be taken care by my use effect uh
but totally up to you the reason why I'm
actually explaining this so much is so
that you understand the flow of the
application not just these memorized
thing that we have to always do this no
it's your application how you want to
design it how you want to handle the
edge cases this is how things are
designed so that's why I'm actually
mentioning all this in such a detail
okay let's go up here uh what do you
want to do in this this case uh I'll
first have a simple div which will be
having a class of
p-8 okay now inside this uh let's open
up a
container container there we go now
inside this container uh we'll be having
a simple div which just posts an image
so I'll just have a div and we'll be
having some of the class names onto this
one not really much interested in the
classes or writing in front of you I'll
just copy and paste my classes you get
that now
once you're into this div the first
thing that we want to do is display an
image now how do we display an image
that's a question again we can use our
JavaScript and use app right for getting
the image so we can use an app right
service and we can get a file preview to
get a file preview we can use the post
which I already have for this particular
page and from this I can use the
featured image there we go we got our
image now in the alt let's use post
title
maybe we can simply say post. title
there we go and it looks good uh we have
some of the class names as well into
this one and the class name is just
rounded Excel rounded D Exel all right
so the image part is all done and this
div looks great now we also need to
display the content so just below this
div I'll open another div with
also has a class of w- full and one more
class of margin
bottom-6 all right so this is my second
div and in this I'll just do two things
I'll display the title as well as the
content title is easy part there is
nothing big deal onto this uh again one
more uh div uh let's use an H1 directly
I'll not get a div H1 do text-
2XL uh anything else font
bold font bold now how can I display
this text super easy use your JavaScript
and simply say post. title okay no big
deal but how can I display the content
because content is something where we
have used uh editor and editor is
storing all of this so what we're going
to do is in this case uh what we're
going to do is let's use a div which
will be having a class of browser Das
CSS these are custom classes you can
write them as well but the most
important thing is use your JavaScript
but not ordinarily you have to use a
parse which comes from the HTML react
parser and in this I have to say post.
content there we go uh told you it's
super easy everything that we are
storing this is all thanks to this parse
which allows me to display the HTML
content and everything that's inside
there so all of your formatting like
bold italic your colors everything is
being pared properly now one more thing
that we have to do is okay uh this part
you understand nicely uh but there's one
more thing now on top of this image I
want to show the user that can you
actually delete uh
this this post or can you just have an
edit button something like this delete
post or edit post something like this so
for this we'll optionally render
something so here is my JavaScript and
is author will give us a true or false
and based on this
we will display this so let's use this
one just goes like this uh we'll simply
have a div which
has
absolute
Dash
right- 6 and these are classes to keep
it at the very right top that's it
top-6 so we have this div now inside
this div we'll have a simple link the
first one is going to allow the user to
update this post how can I update that
super easy nothing too much I'll have
the
link okay the most important part in
this link is two because this is
something which does all the magic so
I'll use a back text where I want to go
I want to go to
slash edit Dash poost and to edit any
post I have to provide the slug after
that that's it so I'll just use a slash
and we'll provide an ID just like that
so post. doll ID that's it now you'll be
redirected to/ edit post and edit post
we haven't yet handled uh but this will
be handled here in the post so that's it
all we have to do is just load all the
things in the data that's it so this is
the post that we have grabbed okay uh
the next thing is uh let's name this
button as something so let's call this
one as uh inside this let's give it a
button the button component that we have
designed and let's call this one as edit
we have some classes for this one as
well
all right uh actually not the classes we
have some of the properties onto this
one so I'll just paste this so we have
the background color green and the class
name just like this so one part is done
that how this is being actually done and
designed uh similar to this we also have
a button this time not the link but we
need just a button so I'll just copy
this move outside of the link and we'll
also keep this one uh this one is going
to be a delete button
and this button will have a simple
onclick this one is going to be red
that's fine margin right we don't need
this into this one margin right we just
need one thing
here on
click suggestions no
suggestions anyways on click just like
this and simply run delete post that's
it delete post already is handling
things up here so I think that is good
enough so this is something that is
worth discussing of how things are being
done how you are able to par these
things I hope that gives you a little
bit of extra knowledge of how these
professional applications are designed
and once you understand this you can now
build anything that you want basically
something that's storing the code part
or anything you can just store them in
using the editors and using the parts
you can just display them so that is it
uh quite a long journey about this one
still almost like half an hour but I
hope this has helped you to understand a
lot about how applications are designed
how the workflow of the application
works and you're building it along with
me I highly recommend that once you
watch these videos try to build them on
your own if you need help take help from
my GitHub uh not directly from the video
but if you feel uncomfortable even after
that then only take help from the videos
itself that's it for this one let's
catch up in the next
one hey there everyone hes here back
again with another video and in this
video we'll try to finish our app uh
it's almost done we don't have anything
major that we want to explain or we want
to go through along with this uh rest of
them is just importing the component
display them that's pretty much it only
couple of things are remaining which
I'll walk you through in this video so
let's go ahead and do that and probably
after that uh we might need some kind of
debugging maybe some CSS is here and
there just minor stuff nothing much to
be worried about so one final thing to
walk you through with the flow of the
code is something so let me share the
screen and walk you through with that so
this is our screen so in case you did
notice that we have this uh post and
inside this in the last video we created
this button which says edit which takes
you to sledit SL slug so in case you
want to know you forgot about how that
works uh we have this edit post SL slug
in which the edit post is going to be
the page uh that will be loaded so if I
just go ahead and click on this this is
something that we are importing from
here so so page is edit post so let's go
into the edit post and see how we can
actually manage that so as you reach to
the edit post the first thing that
should come to your mind is that I'm
getting a slug and I can extract that
slug using use perams and I can use use
effect to query the app right to bring
that post and that's exactly what you
should be doing so let's go ahead and
grab it uh I'll walk you through with
the usually what I do is I just go up
here and start writing so I need a post
obviously so let's go go ahead and work
with the post and that will be set post
and usually I rely too much on the
autoimport statements just like this uh
in some cases it doesn't work
automatically so I hate that part all
right uh next thing is we need to
extract the slug so let's go ahead and
grab a slug and that slug is going to
come up from uh use per
Rams it doesn't gives me I hate it why
it's not giving me suggestion in most
cases it does but today it's not really
happy with me okay so we need uh use
perams so how we're going to get the use
peram that's that's the question I think
that's from react rodom so
use Rams no
suggestions uh import from react router
Dom did I made a
mistake yes use per Rams yep now it
makes sense uh since we are here let's
also grab use
navigate use navigate and let's also
grab it so
navigate and that's going to come up
from use navigate just like that okay uh
so these are the things that I have now
the first thing that I would love to do
now is to use the slug and get something
from aight services so we need to get
aight Services first all right import
app write
service and that's going to come up from
One Directory back inside the app right
inside the
config let's now use use
effect and the use effect goes like this
it gives me a call back just like that
and we have a dependency array all right
so what's the dependency uh maybe if you
change anything into the slug or if you
navigate from here and there that these
are my two dependency now coming up onto
the part where we can go with that okay
so if I have a slug then make a request
so let's check this if you have a slug
then only make that request so app right
and we are going to say get post one
only not the posts and post can be taken
up by the slug uh we can use a wait here
or you can use do then for the promise
part and then we'll say inside this if
you get a post just like this let's go
here now if we have post let's set that
post into my state so
if I have a post let's go ahead and set
this into set post post there we go if I
don't have any post so in that case I'll
just go ahead and say
navigate navigate where do you want to
navigate totally up to you I'm happy
with the slash all right so this is the
part where it's easily now this part
here is even much more easy uh the
reason for that is uh I can just bring
in container and the post form which
I've already created as a component so
that makes my life much more easier
let's bring them so
import container and that's going to
come up from One Directory back inside
the component we have container and we
have container and we also need the post
form so import post form and that's
going to come from One Directory back
inside inside the components and we do
have
post form and inside that we have post
form post form there we go and all I
have to do is I can keep this Tiff as it
is if you wish and I'll say the padding
on y AIS let's be it six we don't need
this and we can say wrap everything
inside the
container just like that and inside this
we'll be having a post form and it could
be self- closing and we need to pass on
one peram which is post which is post
all right so post is coming up from my
state so that's it told you after this
point almost everything is super super
easy like let me tell you one more thing
what happens when you simply go ahead
and do add post now I don't have to do
too much of the things I can just go
ahead and say I want to import container
and that container is going to come from
One Directory back inside the components
container should have done an index.js
there I'll probably leave that as an
exercise for you uh there should be just
one index file inside the components and
I could have bring everything here make
my life much much easier uh but anyways
and we do have a post form and that's
going to come from One Directory back
inside the component
slash uh post form slash poost form and
in here I can just go and remove this
again same class name padding
Y6 and in here wrap everything inside
the container just like always and in
here you can just go ahead and say hey
I'll have a post
form post
form why did it brought it again no idea
but anyways we'll remove this
one okay so told you it's super easy now
because the post form component that we
created in case you forgot that it's
okay it's totally normal to understand
that you forgot that uh remember
everything is being done in here so
submit everything is there we're just
loading this component inside this one
so super super easy now what happens
when you actually work with the all post
okay in the all post uh we'll just grab
all the posts that are possible and
we'll be working with that like uh so
let's first import app
right
service
service and that's going to come from uh
One Directory back inside the app right
we need config and what else do we need
probably that's it I want to have all
the posts so const
posts set
posts that's going to be use uh
State and by default it's going to be an
empty array uh we want it to be tradable
because there are many post inside that
first thing is use
effect use
effect just like that have a call
back and there is probably nothing as a
dependency array when you put nothing
inside the dependency array that's also
a good thing that means it will run only
and only once when the component mounts
and that's it so let's go up here and as
soon as the component mounts we'll use
app right Service uh we'll say get post
this time s because we want to grab all
of it and we'll say that hey um we'll
get all the post we'll just take it in
the array and Dot then and if everything
goes right we'll be having the
posts and all we have to do that if we
have posts if we have posts just go
ahead and uh use set posts just like
that and we'll saying posts dot document
that's that's a little bit part on on
the app right side because the post in
itself has an object. document has
couple of more things by the way if you
wish to see more of it just do a console
log of the post and then once you have
the dot documents that actually gives
you an array and again by the way I
didn't vent it up on the very first go I
had to do a console log to understand
what kind of document is something that
I'm receiving back and then I worked on
this one by the way aite does a
fantastic job in showing you what is
something that you are receiving back
when you're making a query or something
like that uh so fantastic job there but
yes I needed to do a little bit of conso
log there now the interesting part is uh
we would be needing a postcard so if you
remember we created this post card in
which you pass on the ID title and
featured image and it displays that so
we'll be using this so let's go ahead
and bring that uh we'll bring container
to container oh nice suggestions finally
you are awake and and we'll be needing a
postcard post card no
suggestions uh it's just understanding
the things which are already being
designed hate this should have been done
Auto auto anyways not complaining too
much uh components and then we have
postcard okay uh moving back uh this is
going to require couple of classes uh we
are going to set the width of
full and padding on white
eight okay so now moving ahead let's
clean this uh first of all let's wrap
everything inside the container just
like that inside the container we'll
have a simple div and in fact this div
can have a class of flex and flex Dash
wrap so that everything becomes a card
and we can just easily shrink them up
okay now what we have to do start your
Java Script because now we want to Loop
through the posts remember this uh the
posts which is an array
so we'll be rendering this but
conditionally so we'll be saying that
hey uh what we can do is uh
post. map and inside this each post we
are going to call Post uh this is
individual one just goes like this and
I'm not going to use curly braces
otherwise I have to explicitly return so
I'll use parenthesis for that and I'll
say I'll be returning you a div uh with
a class of pedding
das2 and and a width of
1x4 width of 1x4 I don't think so it
automatically takes it as emit
abbreviation ah it takes it that's nice
by the way it's
Dash uh and since this is the one which
is iterating over so we will put a key
onto this one and key is super easy
post. dollar
it and once I'm in this the component
that I want to Loop through is my post
card self closing of of course it takes
one prop so what we're going to do is if
you notice it carefully I could have
given it like this so I can just go
ahead and say hey post is equals to post
but it's not accepting uh these kinds of
parameter in this way so remember the
way how you design these components and
what they expect the data make sure
you're careful about that in our case
the post is expecting an object which
has all these information so don't pause
it on directly uh in case you want to do
so so you have to pass on just an object
and we are going to destructure it
that's the important part and that's it
it's going to do the job so I told you
it's very minute details now uh we are
all happy with this edit post we have
worked on uh and home there is nothing
inside the home uh what we can do is um
home can also have the
card uh this is my all post same and on
the home Also let's grab all the cards
and do the same stuff okay so let's go
ahead and say all
post and we'll copy all of this home
will also display the same stuff so
we'll paste it all post what do we need
uh the same stuff copy this and in here
we'll just paste it so we have post and
all these stuff uh get post blah blah
stuff looks okay now in this
one uh what we can do is there are a
couple of more things that we should
have done okay h on the homepage if you
have like we haven't taken care of the
cases in the all poost when the array is
zero H we can actually do that in the
home and I can give that as a sample
exercise for you okay uh so this part is
all okay but what do you want to return
When the array is zero so let me just
handle that case if the posts do length
is actually zero that means there is
nothing inside the array uh then you can
simply go ahead and return uh that there
is nothing to read otherwise we can just
wrap up the container something like
that so let's go ahead and remove this
part return what do you want to return
uh no post to display but let's actually
do that in a better way let's grab
everything from the all post I'll grab
this copy this and I'll paste
it okay so container and we don't have
this one to actually load so we'll just
remove this and we probably will have a
simple H1 which says log to read posts
so probably there is nothing inside it
or we can say there's no post to read
better message is login to read so this
is all the case when the if statement is
working if the statement uh doesn't get
invoked that means there is something
inside the length so in that case we can
actually use the same all post copy that
and we can just paste it up here that
hey the container is there and we are
iterating through so post. map
everything postcard it's it's exactly
same so now that you know how to handle
the situation when the post is zero you
can do exactly same in the all post as
well just write a simple if statement at
line number 19 I can just mark it as to
do for
you to do add case
for U array
length zero yeah not really the best
sentence but I think you can do the job
okay uh so the home part is done uh what
about the login part this is the most
easy part but I think you will find a
couple of bugs in this one uh let me
show you why the reason for that is we
did everything inside this login so we
just need to import this component but
you will find it little bit difficult if
you don't know one simple thing which is
how to import this so you probably might
think that I'll just go ahead and say
I'll import login and that will come up
as One Directory back inside the
component we do have login the problem
is our page is also called as login uh
this is really bad so which one to use
which one not to use something like this
uh the easiest fix is just use an elas
sing and let's call this one as login
component and notice here this is what
is giving you problem that hey import
login this is not how it works so we
need to actually change this a little
bit and I think this is the reason why I
always say that it's always a good idea
that these kinds of situation might
happen with your component so it's
always a good idea to actually uh grab
things like this so let me show you an
easy fix of that because that's a common
scalability problem uh let me just show
you that we will just create a simple
index file inside the component new file
and call this one as
index.js and one by one we'll be just
importing everything and we'll be
exporting that that's all what we'll be
doing in this one this is much better of
an approach so if I go ahead and say
login and that login is going to come
from SL login now I can go ahead and say
export and I can export all of this is
like that and I can export login now
once you do this kind of a thing it's
much easier and you'll notice that uh
this import statement is not going to
work because it's not uh export default
so you can actually just wrap this up
inside the parenthesis and every time
you bring that uh it comes up like this
and this gives you the ability to call
it as login so you can rename uh the
structures like this or rename the page
as login page something like that so
that's also workable but I think you get
the idea that how to avoid these kinds
of problems good good stuff to discuss
uh we'll have a simple class name and
we'll say padding
Y8 and now in here I can just hit an
enter and can say I'll have a login
component self closing of course so
there we go much easier much easier fix
uh post uh page we have already worked
with that sign up exactly same so for
this sign up also we'll import the
signup import sign up from Pages nope
not from pages
sign up from current directory and sign
up all we have to do is comma and say
sign up now the advantage is I can
actually uh bring these sign up and can
rename them so I can just go ahead and
say
import sign
up from components that's nice and I can
just say Get it as sign up
component and in here we can just have a
class name which says is H padding
Y8 and this one can hit and
enter and we can
say sign up component self closing of
course it's all right a lot of stuff and
actually the better way of handling this
entire thing in the component would be
to grab everything that's there in the
component and export in this way so that
there is a consistency and I don't have
to name this because if you notice it
when we were bring some like in the edit
post uh when we were bringing these
things uh like post form container this
is coming up from different so there's a
missing piece of consistency here so at
least one thing would be consistent is
everything will come from do/ components
that's it uh so good stuff but I think
you get the perspective of how things
are being done and I am happy that I was
able to share all these details
production grade scalability issues with
you the only thing remaining is to test
the application and we're going to do
that in the next video let's catch up
there
there hey there everyone hes here back
again with another video and welcome to
the final video where I'll walk you
through how I debug this application
expecting that your application will
work on the very first go is absolutely
a wrong notion and especially when
somebody's teaching you he's more
focused on the teaching part and the
flow part so some mistakes are meant to
be there they are obviously going to be
there and yes it took me like really a
lot of time to debug this by a lot of
time I mean 1 hour a little bit more
than 1 hour uh so in this video I'll
walk you through what all I did how I
debugged the process how I read the
errors this will help you to understand
the entire flow or when you're done with
the application or in between if you
want to check it out what all the
processes you need to go through so
let's go it one by one and I'll walk you
through uh currently the application is
in the working form and I'll just give
you the entire source code as well but
the most important part is to understand
the the psychology behind solving these
bugs and most important is read those
damn errors that's that's the secret
ingredient okay uh let me share the
screen first and one by one let's go
there so what I did is I tried to run
the application so the first conflict
that I saw immediately was in my app.jsx
so uh this is the first part so in the
app.jsx there was nothing absolutely we
didn't had anything so we have to load
some stuff so in the return statement as
you can see I brought in my headers and
I brought in my footer so that in the
header I can load up the navigation bar
along with the logout button and the
outlet as well now not only that I also
wanted to figure out that whether the
user is logged in or not so how can I do
it as soon as this component loads yes
you guessed it right it was use effect
so I use the use effect hook along with
the app right Services just a simple
method get current user if the current
user is there uh then that's great
otherwise uh let's allow the user to
move on here and there so what I did is
I created a state uh loading and we used
the dispatch just like that and after
that we used a simple use effect and we
simply went up with the OD service get
current user if we get the user that's
great let's dispatch a login action that
user is logged in uh otherwise let's
dispatch the loading as false So based
on that uh we're just loading uh if the
loading is false otherwise we don't load
anything that's that's pretty much it I
did once I did it and I moved on to the
Chrome browser so let me just walk you
through with this one so uh this Chrome
browser so what we saw in this one is uh
we simply went up onto this one and try
to login in and we saw a whole lot of
Errors uh and I tried to inspect this
into the console and it gave me so many
of the error I looked into this one and
the most first one the error that I
found is uh that it was not able to load
the environment variable so when I was
teaching you in the react I actually
accidentally used all the react variable
not the V variable but but we actually
use the vit so uh here's The Simple
Solution all you have to do is you have
to say import meta env. vcore and then
whatever you want to say and that's how
it works so I looked up into this one uh
found a solution for this one and went
into my environment variable first and
changed everything to Vore Vore just
like this so I'll just copy all of this
and I'll also paste this into the sample
so that in case you are going through
with the re V or react whatever you are
going for you can just go with that I'll
obviously remove these ones because I
don't want to push it and of course by
the time you'll be watching the video I
would have removed uh these ones as well
so I'll just go ahead and uh paste it up
and let's go ahead and comment this in
fact uh in the sample we can keep it no
problem at all uh all right so I'll just
keep it in the sample once I did it in
the sample The Next Step was to change
that into the conf.js as well so this
also got changed to wheat. app right the
errors were pretty clear once you check
the console log it simply said hey I
don't know what this uh process. env. V
so I had to change this one import. met.
EnV so pretty first error uh that we
caught up uh after managing our app doj
app.jsx so this was the first problem
that I saw then after that I realized
that in a lot of places uh I have couple
of issues like into this input file I
somehow missed these parentheses so they
were little bit uh difficult to find at
first it just gave me an error on the
signup screen that ID was missing and
I'm pretty sure that I gave you the ID I
checked up first of all about my ar.js
saying that hey I'm providing you the ID
it's id. Unique uh turns out uh in the
signup component itself I was missing in
the input component I was missing the ID
just like this I tried it again gave me
hey ID is missing come on I'm giving you
the ID why are you doing this to me uh
then turns out I realized that in this
one I actually forgot to import the ID
from the app right yeah uh can't believe
I did that but yeah these are the errors
these are the bugs once I have this ID
in here then obviously id. unique works
and it started to do the sign up for me
uh so that's one thing and in the login
also if we are using in the login we
don't use ID so there's nothing much
more onto this part so this is a couple
of things not only that a couple of more
things needed to be fixed for example in
the footer I actually forgot to import
the logo that was giving me a bug so I
did that after that in the header. jsx I
actually uh imported these logo in a
different format so I Ed this one which
is a wrong if you're doing an uh export
default uh this is not how we do it but
somehow accidentally I did it so I
looked a little bit on what all the
things are missing it was pretty
straightforward errors so I started with
that uh once this is all done uh I went
up back into this that hey what all
these things couple of other components
also were having some issues that hey
this was not imported properly or
something I work with that another error
that I saw uh was here that it says add
post but in the URL Slug It says add
post so that is wrong obviously we
didn't take took care of this URL so I
went up and change this to post uh that
is what we are handling in the uh in the
app dot not in the app main. jsx so this
is the one that we are handling uh which
is edit post and slug not posts there is
no s so couple things just look out for
the flow of your application that always
works with how things are going on and
how things are doing for you so don't
panic read the errors one by one step by
step try to figure it out because what
I've noticed is that errors sometimes
are not in the place where you're
looking up for or are expecting them for
example in my case uh I was expecting
the ID might be something wrong in the
ar.js and obviously it was that ID was
missing here but this was also uh pretty
much un seen or I didn't expected that I
might have missed this parenthesis here
so in the ID so input file I didn't
expected that it would be there uh but
it was there so this is what we did and
apart from this uh I've also added a
couple of more CSS as well uh it's not
really required but I have added these
CSS up here these are browser CSS so
when the browser CSS if you see
something like output or summary or
details iframes and all of that uh by
the way they are available on online on
the website of framer uh the parsel of
the
uh the package that we used which one
I'll show you that uh HTML react parser
so the Cs is available on lot of
resources there uh so this is couple of
ways of how I fixed the application rest
of the things worked nicely uh but
expecting that application will work
immediately is is a bad idea one more
thing which I noticed that gave me an
error is this one so when I try to
upload an image at the very first it
gave me an error that hey uh you don't
have permission to upload uh turns out I
have the permission for the guest test
that we did together but we also need
need to give all the users the
permission to do crud in the images so
you can just click on ADD roles and
select individual users if you want to
give some users only the permission but
I wanted to give it to all users so I
just selected that and it just gave the
permission to all of them so this was
one of the issues so make sure you are
aware of that and now in the Au you can
see uh the user is being registered you
can work more on it if you want to build
this application a little bit more
complex which I highly highly recommend
uh we tried with that uh then in the
database we can just check out this is
one post I tried to have that uh this is
the post if I if I click on this YouTube
and the blog uh this is my first post uh
this is my first post title uh content I
told you that the content is being
stored in the HTML so all your CSS
colors everything is stored like this
that's why used we used the react parser
featured image only the ID is getting us
status is active and the user ID that we
are storing so pretty Basics how things
are being done make sure you are aware
of it make sure you try more of it in
the settings I'll also mention that hey
I actually said that the all the users
can actually do the crud operation with
this document so make sure this
permission is also enabled so in this
entire application we have seen that how
the authentication Works how the
database Works how the storage works
I'll try my best to actually have more
on functions as well uh but in case you
didn't notice that uh on the app right
channel one of my my friend Dennis uh
he's creating a couple of videos on the
official app right Channel about using
functions in the app right that are
pretty cool so go ahead and check them
out in case you have some time but this
was all the application that I had by
the way I will push the entire uh source
code of this application so that you can
match it you can try it on my GitHub as
well feel free to check out my GitHub
the entire code for the entire react
course plus this Mega project is
available for all of you if you still
find any issue uh reach me out on my
Discord or Twitter or Instagram wherever
you feel active I'm pretty active on all
social media reach me out I'll try my
best to create more videos if you find
something that this was not clear just
reach me out I will help you to
understand it much much uh easier way I
hope this video has this entire project
has given you some insight about how
complex a real world application can be
a couple of things which are still
missing in this application which I
think you can work on with this is uh if
I go ahead and say all post add post are
working fine in case when I click on ADD
post uh there is a little bit CSS issue
so this featured image active was
supposed to go here I'll try to fix this
up uh that's one thing and apart from
that if I go ahead and see all post uh
in this all post uh these edit and
delete buttons supposed to go over the
image uh probably I missed something
rest of them are pretty easy and okay so
we can see that it's it's working nice
let's try to log it out once I click on
the log out button it redirects me onto
the login page but it's up to you we
don't have still any logo I would highly
recommend you to try this out the reason
that I am actually leaving this
application in a position where you can
actually work a little bit more because
no matter how much you see me coding or
you follow along with me uh there will
be bugs there will be error and if you
add couple of more features from your
side that actually makes you a good
programmer so try to add a little bit
more or try to convert this application
into a social soci media because it's
also same images are there posts are
there so try to do build something like
that and this will give you a lot of
confidence if you face any trouble reach
me out on Twitter or on Discord I would
be super happy to help you out uh watch
out for more of my videos and courses
I'm constantly making more courses more
videos on cutting edge bleeding edge
Tech as well as uh rock solid teexs as
well like pythons and JavaScript as well
and if you have some suggestions do
reach me out I would love to have your
feedback uh that's it for this video uh
hope you have enjoyed it was a great
fantastic Journey with all of you I hope
you will share the entire Series so that
I get more eyes it would be really
really great if you can share on
LinkedIn uh but if you don't want to
that's okay that's fine too anyways
that's it for this video let's catch up
in the next
one